REFORM HOWEVER WOULD BE IN LINE
WITH THE LAND SHERMAN ACT IN
ITS CURRENT FORM. OR DOES THE
LEGISLATURE IN ADMINISTRATION
WANT TO CONSIDER AN ALTERNATIVE
PATH. IN THIS CASE WE RECOMMEND
THAT THE LEGISLATURE BEGIN TO
CONSIDER WAYS TO CHANGE THE
STRUCTURE OF THE SYSTEM BASED
ON ITS PER RIGHT PRIORITIES AND
WITHIN AVAILABLE RESOURCES. IN
LIGHT OF THE FACT THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION IS NOT PROPOSING
TO IMPLEMENT THE RATE STUDY IT
APPEARS TO BE CONSIDERING SUCH
AN ALTERNATIVE PATH. YOU
CONSIDERING ALL OF THE
PROPOSALS BEFORE YOU TODAY WE
RECOMMEND THAT THE LEGISLATURE
KEEP THIS KEY DECISION POINT IN
MIND. WE DO RECOGNIZE THAT
THESE WILL BE VERY DIFFICULT
DECISIONS- I CAN'T UNDERSCORE
THAT ENOUGH- AND WE WOULD LIKE
TO SAY THAT OUR OFFICE IS
ALWAYS AVAILABLE TO HELP IN ANY
WAY IS THE LEGISLATURE GRAPPLES
WITH THESE DECISIONS. WE
BELIEVE THE IMPORTANT TAKE AWAY
FOR TODAY HOWEVER IS THAT THE
SYSTEM IS AT A PIVOTAL MOMENT.
WHATEVER DIRECTION THE
LEGISLATURE AND ADMINISTRATION
CHOOSE TO TAKE IT SHOULD BE
DONE WITH EYES WIDE OPEN. IF
THE ADMINISTRATION DOES NOT
INTEND ON. IN OF THE RATE STUDY
AND INTENDS TO PROPOSE A
REDESIGN TO THE STRUCTURE OF
THE SYSTEM IT SHOULD BE
TRANSPARENT ABOUT THESE PLANS
OF THE LEGISLATURE AND OTHERS
CAN PROPERLY WAITING. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. AT THIS TIME WE WILL
TAKE PUBLIC COMMENT ON ISSUE
ONE. SEEING NONE WE WILL BRING
IT TO THE SUB COMMITTEE TO
DISCUSS AND WOULD LIKE TO OFFER
IT TO MY COLLEAGUES FIRST. NOT
THEN I WILL START. I KNOW THERE
IS A WORK GROUP THAT HAS. FORM
A- TASK FORCE IF YOU WILL
WHAT'S THE- WHAT'S THE
DISCUSSION CURRENTLY WITH THE
INADEQUACY OF. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR- NANCY BARGE MEN-
DIRECTOR- I WE HAVE JUST BY WAY
OF BACKGROUND THE DEVELOPMENTAL
SERVICES TASK FORCE- WAS
DEVELOPED- EARLY AND I'M TWO
THOUSAND TWELVE- WHEN WE WERE
LOOKING AT WHAT WAS THE FUTURE
FOR TO- THE DEVELOPMENTAL
CENTERS AND MOVED TO. THE
DEVELOPMENT SERVICES TASK FORCE
TO TAKE A LOOK AT HOW
REBUILDING THE COMMUNITY SYSTEM
SO RECENTLY WE DID A
RECONSTITUTING OF THE
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES TASK
FORCE FOR A NUMBER OF REASONS
ONE IS WHILE WE DID ADD SOME
MEMBERS OF THE CLASS- TASK
FORCE A MEMBERSHIP. IT REALLY
WASN'T REPRESENTATIVE OF KIND
OF WHERE WE ARE TODAY AND
LOOKING AT NOT ONLY THE
REPRESENTATION OF THE
INDIVIDUALS WERE SERVING- BUT
ALSO THAN TAKING A LOOK AT HOW
DO WE MOVE FORWARD SO ARE ABLE
TO RECONSTITUTE THAT. PLEASE TO
SAY THAT WE DO HAVE A
SIGNIFICANTLY MORE
REPRESENTATIVE GROUP THAT IS ON
THE DS TASK FORCE AND THEN THE-
FIVE RELATED WORK GROUPS- WE
STILL HAVE SOME WORK I THINK TO
GET FULL REPRESENTATION OF OUR
COMMUNITY AND THAT. THAT WILL
BE PART OF WHAT I WANT TO POINT
OUT LATER IN ANOTHER ISSUE- BUT
TO YOUR QUESTION AS FAR AS KIND
OF WHAT IS THAT FOCUS. SO WE DO
HAVE- A BIG TASK AT HAND YOU
KNOW WE HAVE A NUMBER OF THINGS
THAT WE'VE BEEN LOOKING AT AS
FAR AS THE SYSTEM AND HOW TO
MOVE FORWARD. CERTAINLY THE
PROVIDER RATES TAKING A LOOK AT
HOW DO WE WORK THROUGH THE-
SERVICE COORDINATORS BECAUSE WE
HEAR THAT- THE OPERATIONS OF
THE REGIONAL CENTER TO BE ABLE
TO SUPPORT THE INDIVIDUALS WERE
SIR. AND THE BEST A- CELL NOW
WHAT WE'RE DOING AND WE'VE GOT
AN INITIAL MEETING WITH THE
SYSTEM SCORE WORK. THAT WILL
FEED INFORMAION TO THE D. S.
TASK FORCE IT WAS A
FOUNDATIONAL CONVERSATION TO
SAY WHAT ARE THE THINGS THAT
WERE SEEN THAT'S WORKING IN THE
SYSTEM ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
ARE RECOGNIZING THAT ARE.
WORKING THERE THAT THEY WANTED
TO HAVE FOCUS ON. IS A SURPRISE
THAT SOME THINGS THAT WERE
BROUGHT UP OR THAT THEY WERE
DISCUSSING TODAY. I'M HOWEVER
THERE'S ALL THE AND THE VOTE
THE CONVERSATION THE DOESN'T.
HAPPEN BUT ONCE WE KNOW THAT WE
HAVE SERVICE CORPS ASIA AND HOW
DO WE DELIVER CARE COORDINATOR
FOR THE INDIVIDUALS THAT WE
IS THE WORK THAT THE RULES
DON'T DOES WITH WITH HOW TO
DELIVER THAT. THE. COORDINATION
SERVICE. I MEAN I REMEMBER WHEN
I STARTED. SO CORD I. YOU KNOW
IT'S GOING TO BE TELLING WHEN I
TELL YOU HOW MANY YEARS AGO IT
WAS A LITTLE FOR THIRTY FIVE
YEARS AGO. BUT WHEN WE TAKE A
LOOK AT YOU KNOW KIND OF THE
CHANGES THAT HAVE HAPPENED IN
OUR SYSTEM OVER TIME. WE ARE A
VERY DIFFERENT SYSTEM. THAN WE
WERE. YOU KNOW WHEN EVEN I
STARTED. SO WE THOSE ARE THE
DIFFICULT OR- COMPLEX
CONVERSATIONS THAT WE WANT TO
HAVE WITH OUR COMMUNITY TO GET
TO THE POINT OF TRANSPARENCY.
AS AN ADMINISTRATION THERE'S
SOME REALLY COR TENANTS IN
CORE- PHILOSOPHICAL THINGS
THAT. ARE REALLY IMPORTANT THAT
WE DO WE NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE HAVE AN ACCOUNTABILITY IN
OUR SYSTEM. THERE'S
TRANSPARENCY THAT WE'RE LOOKING
AT PERSON CENTERED. THAT WERE
REALLY VALUING WHAT IS
IMPORTANT TO THE INDIVIDUALS
THAT WERE SERVING. AND WE DO
HAVE A SYSTEM THAT'S GOING TO
BE SUSTAINABLE GOING FORWARD.
WE DON'T HAVE A DEFINED SYSTEM
OF WHAT THAT'S GOING TO LOOK
LIKE AS FAR AS RATE STRUCTURES
ARE RATE MODELS SIR I MEAN IN
THE SENSE OF THAT. THE
METHODOLOGY OF HOW WE'RE GOING
TO DO IT WE HAVE A GREAT
INFORMATION FROM THE RATE
STUDY. THAT'S GOING TO HELP AND
FORMER CONVERSATION. SO MOVING
TO THE NEXT COUPLE OF MONTHS AS
FAR AS WHERE WE'RE GOING TO BE
FOCUSING THE WORK OF OUR WORK.
GROUPS IS REALLY ON THE
INCENTIVE PROGRAM. BECAUSE WE
HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY RIGHT NOW
JUST TO TAKE A- LOOK AT. NOT IS
THAT SOMETHING THAT WE'RE
LOOKING AT. HELLO YEAH BUT
ASKED BE. FOR SIX. OF VERY TO
LOOK AT WHAT ARE WE PAYING.
WHAT'S THE VALUE TO IN OF THE
WHO'S- SIR. SO YOU STAY. SAYS
TAKE OFF AT WHAT IT VALUE BAY.
SINCE THAT ARE WERE. OR HOW CAN
BE HOW. STATE. THE STATE'S
LET'S START IN TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN WE JUST APPLIED FOR
THE NEXT ROUND I'M AND WE WERE
JUST SELECTED- SO WE JUST
RECEIVED NOTICE THAT CMS IS
GOING TO WORK WITH CALIFORNIA
TO HAVE THIS CONVERSATION WITH
THEN THE ID D. SPACE AND HOW DO
WE LOOK AT TAKING A LOOK AT
ALTERNATIVE SYSTEM KIND OF
STRUCTURES TO BEST SERVE THE
INDIVIDUALS THAT WE ALL HAVE- A
CONCERN FOR SO THE SYSTEM IN
FISCAL REFORM WORK GROUP IS
GOING TO FOCUS ON THE NEXT
COUPLE OF MONTHS LOOKING
BECAUSE WE'RE GOING TO DEFINE
THE GOALS AND THE PERFORMANCE
INCENTIVE PROGRAM. TAKE A LOOK
AT THOSE PERFORMANCE MEASURES
HOW WE'RE GOING TO MEASURE THEM
GETTING HAS A COMMON THEME
YOU'RE HEARING TODAY AS WE WANT
TO BE ABLE TO EASURE OUTCOMES.
WHAT ARE WE WHAT ARE WE MAKING
SURE THAT WE'RE DELIVERING AS
FAR AS THE EXPERIENCE FOR THE
INDIVIDUALS. I'M THAT ARE
INVOLVED WITH THE REGIONAL
CENTERS SO WE'RE GONNA FOCUS
THERE THE NEXT PART OF IT
THOUGH IS THAT AS PART OF THE
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE MAKING
SURE THAT WE'RE TAKING A LOOK
AT. WHERE THOSE ALTERNATIVE
APPROACHES. BUT MAKING SURE
THAT WE'RE NOT TAKING TIME THAT
IS GOING TO BE LONG WE
UNDERSTAND THE COMPLEXITY OF
THIS AND WE ABSOLUTELY
UNDERSTAND THE TIME SENSITIVITY
TO IT. THANK YOU FOR THE
RESPONSE OF. IF I MAY AT SOME
POINT WITH THE BUDGET
SUBCOMMITTEE WE TALK. DOLLARS
AND SENSE AS WELL AND SO. THE
RATE CITY WAS PRETTY CLEAR
ABOUT NEEDING ONE POINT EIGHT
BILLION DOLLARS FOR-
IMPLEMENTING THE RATE STUDY
LAST YEAR WE WERE ABLE TO PUT
IN FOUR HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS. THROUGH THE EIGHT
POINT 2% FOR CERTAIN RATES- MY-
CONCERN IS- WE ARE FAST
APPROACHING OUR NEXT BUDGET.
AND NEED TO. HAVE SOME TYPE OF
SIGN FROM THE ADMINISTRATION IF
THESE DISCUSSIONS RECENTLY CAN
EXPECT TO. HAVE A PROPOSAL FOR
THE MAY REVISION. IS THIS
SOMETHING THAT WE'RE GOING TO
SEE DO THESE DISCUSSIONS HAPPEN
BEFORE THEN. OR DO WE HAVE
ANOTHER YEAR OF RATES THAT
AREN'T. ADEQUATELY HELPING US
WHERE I THINK THEY SHOULD AND I
THINK WE CAN ALL AGREE ABOUT
ACCOUNTABILITY AND NEEDING. TO
MAKE SURE THERE'S QUALITY AND
DATA AND TRANSPARENCY WITH IT
AND WILL FOLLOW UP WITH THAT
BUT I JUST AM TRYING TO GET A
SENSE TO YOU. DO YOU THINK
SOMETHING WILL HAPPEN BY MAY
REVISIONS. WERE HAVING- AN-
INTERNAL CONVERSATIONS- AS FAR
AS ANYTHING THAT IS PART OF-
PROPOSALS GOING FORWARD IS A
DELIBERATIVE PROCESS THAT
SOMETHING THAT IS- INTERNAL AND
AT THIS POINT I CAN'T- PROVIDE
ANY ADDITIONAL DETAIL. ON. OUR
OUR HOPE AS A SUB COMMITTEE IS
TO PARTICIPATE IN THOSE
DISCUSSIONS AND SO I. MY
REQUEST WOULD BE TO HOPEFULLY
PROVIDE US AN UPDATE. ON THESE
PROPOSALS AND DISCUSSIONS.
ABOUT FISCAL REFORMS
SPECIFICALLY- AND ANYTHING
WE'RE GONNA DO WITH RATES ARE
FUNDING COMPLIANCE OR CASELOAD
RATIOS- WE HAVE A FOLLOW UP
HEARING ON APRIL TWENTY SECOND
TERM WOULD HOPE WE COULD- HERE
ABOUT IT BEFORE THAT.
FURTHERMORE WE ASK THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION MAKE SURE THAT
WE'RE VETTING ANYTHING THAT'S
COMING AND MAY REVISION AND
MAKE SURE THAT STAKEHOLDERS ARE
ADEQUATELY A PART OF THOSE
DISCUSSIONS THAT OCCUR BETWEEN
NOW AND THEN- THESE ARE VERY
CRITICAL FORUMS AND REPRESENT A
SIGNIFICANT PART OF OUR
COMMUNITIES THREE HUNDRED FIFTY
THOUSAND PEOPLE. IT'S WE
SHOULD. MAKE SURE THAT THEY'RE
HEARD FULLY. INTEND THAT- MAKES
IT VERY HARD FOR US TO ADOPT
THEM IF WE DON'T HEAR ENOUGH
ABOUT THE INFORMATION IN A
TIMELY FASHION SO- WE JUST
APPRECIATE AND MAKE THAT
REQUEST. WITH THAT WE WILL HOLD
ISSUE ONE OPEN AND MOVE ON TO
ISSUE TO. THE MASS THE
SERGEANTS TO- CONTACT ASSEMBLY
MEMBER HOLDEN. SINCE HE WILL BE
PRESENTING BUT PRIOR TO
PRESENTING ON ISSUE TOO I MAY
ASK TO ESTABLISH CORPS. DOCTOR
ARAMBULA PRESENT. FRAZIER
MATHIS. PATTERSON RAMOS RUBIO
HERE DOCTOR WOULD. WE HAVE
THREE. MR PATTERSON'S HERE HAVE
FOR. WE OKAY SERVICE. AND OKAY-
SORRY ABOUT THAT MISS CHAIRMAN-
I KNOW MR HOLD MAYBE COMING SO
IF IT COMES I WILL STOP. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS OF
THIS WONDERFUL COMMITTEE AND
STAFF- ALSO A QUICK THANK YOU
TO THE SERGEANTS AUDIO WAS IN
ON FOR THIS HEARING AT THE
BEGINNING BUT THEY QUICKLY GOT
IT ON THERE'S HUNDREDS IF NOT
THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE WATCH
AROUND THE STATE AS WELL SO
THANK YOU TO THEM- MY NAME IS
JORDAN LINDSAY I'M EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE ARC IN UNITED
CIVIL POSEY CALIFORNIA
COLLABORATION I'M ALSO CHAIR OF
THE LIMóN COALITION WHICH
REPRESENTS- MANY STATEWIDE
ORGANIZATIONS REPRESENT BOTH
INTELLECT. IT'S A BIT THESE
HEARD THROUGH THE LANHAM ACT
CALIFORNIA PROVIDE SERVICES AND
SUPPORTS TO MORE THAN THREE
HUNDRED SIXTY THOUSAND
INDIVIDUALS WITH INTELLECTUAL
AND DEVELOP A DISABILITIES IN
THIS YEAR ALONE MORE THAN
FIFTEEN THOUSAND NEW
INDIVIDUALS ARE EXPECTED TO
REQUIRE SUPPORT. SAME TIME
DIRECT SUPPORT STAFF TURNOVER.
HI DUE TO LOW WAGES ESSENTIAL
PROGRAMS ARE CLOSING ACROSS THE
STATE. AND REGIONAL CENTER
CASELOAD RATIOS ARE TOO HIGH.
AND EXCEED FEDERAL ASSURANCES.
ALL OF WHICH FORCE PEOPLE TO
LIVE WITH INADEQUATE OR NO
SUPPORTS. THINGS SUCH I'M SURE
ALL OF YOU ARE HAVE HEARD IN
YOUR DISTRICTS FROM FAMILIES.
CALIFORNIA RECENTLY AS YOU
NOTED COMPLETED A MULTI YEAR
RATE STUDY WHICH CONFIRMED THIS
WITH AN UNDER FUNDING
DETERMINED TO BE ONE POINT
EIGHT BILLION. INDIVIDUALS WITH
INTELLECTUAL DEVELOPS ITS
ABILITIES THEIR FAMILIES AND
THEIR DIRECT SUPPORT FOR
PROFESSIONALS ARE SUFFERING AS
A RESULT OF THIS UNDER FUNDING-
JUST A FEW HOURS AGO I WAS ON
THE PHONE WITH. IN A MOTHER OF
AN EIGHTEEN YEAR OLD WITH
AUTISM AND SH AS OF TWO DAYS
AGO SHE'S NOT EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS INTEREST ON ORANGE
COUNTY. AND THEY ARE TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT DESPERATELY WHAT TO
DO THE BIGGEST CONCERN OF
COURSE BEING FOR HER SON. AND
WE ARE TRYING DESPERATELY TO
TRY TO WRAP SOME SERVICES
AROUND FOR THEM. LAST YEAR THE
LEGISLATURE BUDGETED BUDGETED
INCREASE. AS YOU MENTION OF TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION IN THIS
COMMITTEE WAS AN ESSENTIAL PART
OF THAT THANK YOU. AN STILL
HOWEVER DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES
ARE GLARINGLY UNDEFINED UNDER
FUNDED BY MORE THAN ONE POINT
FOUR BILLION DOLLARS IN
CALIFORNIA. NOW THE APPROPRIATE
AND REQUIRED COURSE OF ACTION
IS TO IMPLEMENT A MULTI YEAR
STRATEGIC INVESTMENT PLAN WHICH
ENSURES THAT THE COMMUNITY AND
THE PROMISE OF THE LANHAM ACT
MOVES FROM A TIME OF CRISIS AND
INTO A TIME OF OPPORTUNITY.
ASSEMBLYMAN FRAZIER HAS PUT
TOGETHER THAT PLAN HE'S NOT
ABLE TO BE HERE TODAY- SO I
WILL QUICKLY. DESCRIBE THAT
PLAN IT IS LAID OUT VERY WELL
IN THE THOROUGH. AGENDA THE
PLAN HAS FIVE ELEMENTS TO IT
NUMBER ONE FIRST PHASE IN THE
DDS RATE MODELS OVER THREE
YEARS WITH AN INVESTMENT OF TWO
HUNDRED SEVENTY FIVE MILLION
GENERAL FUND EACH YEAR. THIS
WILL GET US T BE AMOUNT NEEDED
THE DETERMINED UNDER FUNDING
FOR DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES
SINCE THE RELEASE OF THE
UPDATED RATE MODELS. THE
LAMBING COALITION HAS BEEN
WORKING FEVERISHLY TO CREATE A
DETAILED AND STRATEGIC THREE
YEAR IMPLEMENTATION PLAN WHAT
YOU'VE BEEN ASKING FOR. AND WE
ARE ONLY A COUPLE DAYS AWAY
FROM FINALISING IT. WE ARE
EAGER TO SHARE IT WITH THE
COMMITTEE LA FINANCING THE
DEPARTMENT. THE PLAN INCLUDES
NOT ONLY FUNDING METHODOLOGIES.
BUT ALSO THE DATA COLLECTION
REQUIREMENTS INCENTIVES AND
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT. SECOND
PART O THE PLAN TAKE
CORRECTIVE ACTIONS FOR THE
SERVICES THAT WERE MISTAKENLY
OMITTED FROM LAST YEAR'S
PROVIDER SUPPLEMENTAL RATE
INCREASES THIS WAS INCLUDED AS
NOTING THE AGENDA IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET HOWEVER IT
NOT UNTIL JANUARY ONE TWENTY
TWENTY ONE START DATE. WOULD
YOU PROPOSE THAT FAIR IS FAIR
AND JANUARY ONE TWENTY TWENTY
RETROACTIVE START DATE IS THE
APPROPRIATE PATH FORWARD FOR
THOSE THREE SERVICES OF
INDEPENDENT LIVING INFANT
DEVELOPMENT PROGRAM AND EARLY
START SPECIALIZED THERAPEUTIC
SERVICES. THE THIRD PART OF THE
PLAN. IT'S COMPLY WITH FEDERAL
AND STATE REGIONAL CENTER
CASELOAD RATIOS BY HIRING EIGHT
HUNDRED SERVICE COORDINATOR
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. THIS IS
SOME YOU'LL HEAR MORE OF FROM
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MAIENSCHEIN
LATER IN THE AGENDA AND SO I
WILL LET HIM GO INTO FURTHER
DETAIL ABOUT THAT PART OF THE
PLAN- THE FOURTH PART IS SOLVE
THE MINIMUM WAGE QUIRK WHICH WE
HAVE BEEN TRYING TO SOLVE IN
THIS LEGISLATURE FOR QUITE
AWHILE. ENSURE THAT ALL DDS
FUNDED SERVICES AND SUPPORTS
RECEIVE ADJUSTMENTS FOR THE
STATE MINIMUM WAGE INCREASES BY
THREE POINT 3% INCREASE THE
RATE MODELS ARE ONLY UPDATED TO
JANUARY ONE TWENTY TWENTY JENNY
ONE TWENTY TWENTY ONE WE ARE
ALREADY EVEN IF WE DO NOTHING
THREE POINT 3% BEHIND IF WE
ENACT IN FULL RATE MODELS THIS
YEAR WE'RE STILL THREE POINT 3%
BEHIND BECAUSE OF THE MINIMUM
WAGE. INCREASE ON JERRY ONE
TWENTY TWENTY ONE THAT IT WILL
ALSO BE EXPLAINED FURTHER. BY
ASSEMBLYMAN HOLDEN. AND THE
FIFTH PART OF THE PLAN IS TO
SECURE A FOUNDATION FOR LONG
TERM PLANNING BY PERMANENTLY
REMOVING THE SUSPENSION DATE
THAT IS- CURRENTLY ENACTED IN
PROPOSING A JET IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGETS BEEP FURTHER
MOVE BACK FURTHER BUT STILL IT
ALL WE HEAR THAT THIS MAKES
LONG TERM PLANNING IMPOSSIBLE
FOR THE COMMUNITY THROUGHOUT
THE STATE. WITH THIS PLAN IN
PLACE THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
WILL RESTORE THE HEALTH AND
SAFETY OF PEOPLE WITH
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES AND
WE WILL ENTER A NEW ERA NOW
THAT WE ARE FINISHING AN ERROR
OF THE PAST FIFTY YEARS A NEW
ERA OF COMMUNITY INCLUSION
THANK YOU. THANK YOU AND-
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRAZIER IS
MESSED PARTICULARLY ON THIS
DAYS LONG. BEEN A CHAMPION AND-
REALLY HELD THE TORCH AND JUST
WANT TO RECOGNIZE THEM AND-
APPRECIATE. HIS ABSENCE OF
WITHOUT ASSEMBLYMEMBER HOLD.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF MY TO ACKNOWLEDGE-
STE ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRASIER'S.
CONSISTENT CONTRIBUTION TO
MOVING TE BALL DOWN THE FIELD
ON THE SUBJECT- AS NOTED THE LA
OWES ANALYSIS OF THE DDS TWENTY
TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY ONE BUDGET
THE CURRENT DDS RATE STRUCTURE
IS NOT ALIGNED WITH CURRENT
SERVICES. AND SERVICE NEEDS WHO
TREATS SIMILAR SERVICE
PROVIDERS IT DIFFERENTLY AND
ACCORDING TO THE RATE STUDY HAS
SIZABLE FUNDING GAPS. OF ONE
POINT EIGHT BILLION. MOREOVER
MINIMUM WAGE INCREASES
EXACERBATE FUNDING CHALLENGES
IN SEVERAL WAYS THE STATE HAS
NOT ADJUSTED PROVIDER RATES TO
ACCOUNT FOR COSTS ASSOCIATED
WITH LOCAL MINIMUM WAGE
ORDINANCES WHICH YOU'VE HEARD
THE RATE ADJUSTMENTS PROVIDED
TO COVER COSTS ASSOCIATED WITH
STATE MINIMUM WAGE INCREASES
HAS NOT. BEEN AVAILABLE TO
PROVIDERS IN AREAS WITH LOCAL
MINIMUM WAGES THAT EXCEED THE
STATE MINIMUM WAGE THEREFORE
MANY AREAS OF THE STATE WHICH
PROVIDERS WERE UNABLE TO ACCESS
FUNDING ASSOCIATED WITH THE
JANUARY FIRST TWENTY TWENTY.
STATE MINIMUM WAGE INCREASES
FROM TWELVE DOLLARS TO THIRTEEN
DOLLARS PER HOUR WE'RE
REQUESTING TWENTY NINE MILLION
IN GENERAL FUNDS FOR THE
PURPOSE OF CREATING A FAIR AND
EQUITABLE PROCESS FOR ADJUSTING
THE RATES OF COMMUNITY SERVICE
PROVIDERS IN CONJUNCTION WITH
INCREASES IN THE- STATE MINIMUM
WAGE. THE CURRENT PROCESS OF
MAKING THESE ADJUSTMENTS AS
PROVEN INADEQUATE AND HAS
RESULTED IN THE UNINTENDED
WITHHOLDING A VITAL NEEDS THIS
IS FROM STRUGGLING SERVICE
PROVIDERS IN MANY AREAS OF OUR
STATE WHERE SERVICES ARE
URGENTLY NEEDED THE LA- HAS
TAKEN NOTE OF THIS PROBLEM
DUBBING AT THE MINIMUM WAGE
QUIRK DUE IN LARGE MEASURE TO A
QUIRK AND THE IMPLEMENTATION OF
THESE RATE ADJUSTMENTS.
PROGRAMS IN HIGH COST AREAS
SUCH AS SAN FRANCISCO AND LOS
ANGELES ARE NOT ELIGIBLE FOR AN
INCREASE ONE STATE MINIMUM WAGE
RISES BUT PROGRAMS AND LOWER
COSTS AREAS ARE ELIGIBLE TO
RECEIVE AN INCREASE WITHOUT AN
ADULT ANY ADJUSTMENTS TO THEIR
RATES TO COVER WAGE INCREASES
PROVIDERS IN THESE AREAS OF HAD
TO MAKE SIGNIFICANT REDUCTIONS
IN ALL AREAS OF THEIR
OPERATIONS. DEFICIT SPEND AND
RELY MORE HEAVILY ON SOFT WIRED
IN IN SECURE FUNDING SOURCES
SUCH AS FUND RAISING AND
SPENDING DOWN ENDOWMENTS. THE
IMPACT OF SERVICES OF
INCREASING WAGE COSTS WITH NO
CORRESPONDING RATE ADJUSTMENTS
HAS BEEN CRUSHING SIR PROVIDERS
THROUGHOUT THE GREATER BAY AREA
LOS ANGELES ORANGE COUNTY AND
SAN DIEGO COUNTY REPORT GROWING
STAFF VACANCIES IN TURN OVER
RATES. APPROACHING 50% A
GROWING NUMBER OF AGENCIES
ACROSS THESE REGIONS AND REPORT
ARE REPORTING THAT THEY ARE
FORCED TO CANCEL SERVICES ON A
ROUTINE BASIS. DUE TO A LACK OF
AVAILABLE DIRECT SUPPORT STAFF.
I ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT TO FIND
A UNIFORM THREE POINT 33% RATE
ADJUSTMENT FOR EACH ONE DOLLAR
OF STATE MINIMUM WAGE. TO
ACCOMPLISH THIS ISSUE WE
REQUESTED APPROPRIATION OF
TWENTY NINE MILLION GENERAL
FUND. WHICH WILL BE JANET WHICH
WILL GENERATE TWENTY SEVEN
MILLION TO REACH THE TOTAL
COSTS OF THIS FISCAL YEAR OF
FIFTY SIX MILLION. I HAVE WITH
ME. THOSE WHO SPOKEN OF WHO ARE
JOINING IN TO- MAKE THE POINT
OF HOW IMPORTANT IT IS THAT WE
DEVELOP THIS CALCULATION. THANK
YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER HOLDEN IF-
YOU WOULD LIKE YOUR GUESTS TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT- I DID WANT TO
RECOGNIZE IT SHOULD BE DIRECTOR
PARCHMAN- WHO HAS A GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL AS WELL AND SO. WE
WILL MAKE SURE TO INCLUDE YOU.
HI THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK MY NAME'S
TOM HEINZ I'M EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF A NONPROFIT CALLED
THE SPAN OF A SINCE. WE SERVE
FOLKS IN ALAMEDA COUNTY TO HELP
THEM LIVE ON THEIR OWN. AND
FIND EMPLOYMENT. IN ALAMEDA
COUNTY RIGHT NOW THERE'S A TWO
POINT 5% UNEMPLOYMENT RATE.
AVERAGE RENTS IN OAKLAND FOR A
ONE BEDROOM APARTMENT AND 90%
OF THE WEIGHT OF A DIRECT
SUPPORT PROFESSIONAL IN MY
AGENCY. I AND ARE SUPPORTED
LIVING PROGRAM WE SERVE PEOPLE
WHO NEED TWENTY FOUR HOUR
SUPPORT WHO HAVE- SIGNIFICANT-
PHYSICAL AND BEHAVIORAL
DISABILITIES. OFTENTIMES ARE
NON VERBAL AND IN MANY OF THESE
SITUATIONS TO OUR STAFF THAT
SERVE THESE FOLKS WHO ARE ARE
VULNERABLE IN MAKING JUST THE
MINIMUM WAGE. AND THESE ARE IN
COMMUNITIES WHERE THE STATE
DOES NOT AUTOMATICALLY
REIMBURSES FOR THE MINIMUM
WAGE. I NEEDLESS TO SAY WERE
LOSING THE BATTLE IN COMPETING
FOR WORKERS LAST YEAR WE LOST
NINETY THREE WORKERS OUT OF A
HUNDRED NINETY POSITIONS SO
REALLY CRITICAL ISSUE FOR US.
THANKS HIGH HARY BRAWL WITH PAT%
POINT- THE STATE CURRENTLY USES
TWO WAYS TO DETERMINE HOW TO
ADJUST RATES WHEN MINUTES STATE
MINIMUM WAGE GOES UP FOR OUR
COMMUNICATOR FACILITIES THERE'S
N AUTOMATIC INCREASE BETWEEN
FOUR AND 5% FOR EVERYTHING
ELSE. IT'S A LABORIOUS PROCESS
pINDIVIDUAL STAFF MEMBERS WHO
EARN LESS THAN THE NEW MINIMUM
WAGE COMPILING ALL THAT DATA
CHURNING IT OUT AND COMING UP
WITH NEW INDIVIDUAL RATES FOR
EACH. PROGRAM SO BESIDES THIS
ADMINISTRATIVE HEAVY PROCESS IT
HAS A SEPARATE ISSUE WHICH IS
THAT IN AREAS WHERE WE CAN'T
PAY MINIMUM WAGE. IT'S NOT
THERE'S NO REIMBURSEMENT SO I'M
FROM SANTA BARBARA WE DON'T
HAVE A LOCAL MINIMUM WAGE BUT
OUR COST OF LIVING ARE SO HIGH
THAT WE CAN'T PAY WE PAY A
DOLLAR A DOLLAR FIFTY MORE THAN
MINIMUM WAGE MINIMUM WAGE GOES
UP AT THE STATE LEVEL WE HAVE
TO INCREASE OUR RATES. THERE'S
NO SUPPORT SO WE HAVE AS A
BACKWARD SYSTEM WHERE LOW COST
THERE IS THE STATE GET
INCREASES EVERY YEAR HIGH COST
AREAS THE LA THE BAY AREA SANTA
BARBARA SAN DIEGO GET NO
INCREASE. SO FORTUNATELY
THERE'S A PRETTY EASY SOLUTION
ASSEMBLY MEMBER HOLDEN HAS COME
UP WITH WHICH IS THE DO WHAT.
WE FOR COMMUNITY OFFICE FOR
THAN BUYERS WHICH IS JUST A SIM
OF THE IN WERE SHE'S CáC. BUT
THREE POINT THREE THREE PER FOR
A ONE DOLLAR. THAT BY. OUR
PROCESS THAT IS WERE ALL THE
BURKE. IT NEED IN TEN ALLEGEDLY
WHICH THE SUPPORT FOR HIS
WEAPON AB INCREASE K. AND OR
FAT AND EQUITABLE ACROSS THE
STATE SO WE APPRECIATE YOUR- IN
SUPPORT FOR THIS AWESOME FIX TO
A VEXING. THAT'S BEEN A FOR
AWHILE. THE THANK I'M NEXT WE
CAN DIRECTOR. THANK YOU ASK
NANCY PARCHMAN DIRECTOR DDS-
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED BUDGET
AND INCLUDES AS THAT THE CHAIR
HAD NOTED THAT LAST YEAR'S
BUDGET ACT INCLUDED THE FOUR
HUNDRED THIRTEEN MILLION- THAT
WOULD HAVE BEEN TOTAL FUND SO
IS A PARTIAL YEAR LAST YEAR
THAT WAS FUNDED FOR SIX- FOR
CURRENT YEARS SIX MONTHS. AND
SO THE- GOVERNOR'S- BUDGET HAS
THE- FULL IMPACT OF THE ACTION
LAST YEAR INTO- GOING INTO
BUDGET YEAR SO WE WOULD BE-
ADDING THAT THAT'S- INCLUDING
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED BUDGET.
IN ADDITION IT IS THAT AS IT'S
BEEN NOTED THAT THREE
ADDITIONAL SERVICE CODES- THAT
WE'RE PROPOSING- THAT WOULD BE
EFFECTIVE JANUARY FIRST TWENTY
TWENTY. ONE I HAVE SORRY HAVE
TO. GET THE CALENDAR IN MY
HEAD- AND THOSE THREE SERVICE
CODES AND THEY WERE INFORMED BY
OUR UPDATED RATE MODELS WE HAD-
WITH FEEDBACK FROM THE
COMMUNITY. THAT WE HAD UPDATED
THOSE RATE MODELS AS A BASED ON
THAT WE- PRIORITIZE AND
IDENTIFY THREE SERVICE CODES
THAT WE INCLUDED AND WAS INFANT
DEVELOPMENT EARLY START
THERAPEUTIC SERVICES AN
INDEPENDENT LIVING SERVICES.
AND SO FOR- BUDGET YEAR IT'S
EIGHTEEN MILLION TOTAL FUND TEN
MILLION GENERAL FUND- WHICH IS
AGAIN REFLECTIVE OF HALF YEAR-
TWO OF THOSE SERVICE CODE WOULD
BE AT A POINT 2% AND THEN THE
EARLY START THERAPEUTIC
SERVICES WOULD BE AT THE 5%
WHICH AGAIN WAS INFORMED BY
THE- UPDATED RATE STUDY. THANK
YOU DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. JUST
TO CLEAR FINE POINT ON WHY THE
BUDGET REFLECTS HALF YOUR COST
FOR THE THREE ADDITIONAL
SERVICE CODES IS DO THE
NECESSARY- FEDERAL CMS APPROVAL
SO THAT'S WHY WE HAVE A HAPPIER
COST CONSISTENT WITH WHAT WAS
PROVIDED IN THE BUDGET ACT AND
THE ANNUALIZED COST THOUGH FOR
THERE'S THREE THREE SERVICE
CODES IS ABOUT THIRTY SIX
MILLION TOTAL FUND AND TWENTY
ONE POINT SIX GENERAL FUND.
THANK YOU. HELLO. THANK YOU I'M
THERE ARE A NUMBER OF IMPORTANT
ISSUES DISCUSSED IN THIS IN
THIS SECTION OF THE HEARING SO
I'D LIKE TO JUST A COMMENT ON
FOUR DIFFERENT POINTS FIRST WE
I JUST WANT TO RECAP SOME OF
THE COMMENTS WE HAD MADE ABOUT
THE RATE STUDY ONE THAT THIS
WAS THE FIRST TIME WE HAVE.
SORT OF A QUANTIFIABLE MEASURE
OF THE FUNDING GAP IN THE
SYSTEM. TO THAT THE RATE STUDY
WAS A LEGISLATIVE PRIORITY. AND
THREE THAT THE- THIS IS THE
SECOND BUDGET THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION IS NOT PROPOSING
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE RATE
STUDY. THE SECOND POINT THAT
I'D LIKE TO MAKE TODAY IS THAT
OUR OFFICE RECOMMENDS APPROVAL
OF FUNDING FOR THE THREE- FOR
THE SUPPLEMENTAL RATES FOR
THREE ADDITIONAL SERVICES- THIS
REFLECTS LEGISLATIVE ACTIONS
THAT WERE TAKEN LAST YEAR TO
APPROVE SUPPLEMENTAL RATE
INCREASES. I WOULD NOTE THAT
OUR OFFICE STILL HAS CONCERNS
HOWEVER ABOUT THE FACT THAT
THESE ARE ONGOING SERVICES
SUBJECT TO A SUSPENSION- EVEN
THOUGH THAT SUSPENSION HAS BEEN
DELAYED BY EIGHTEEN MONTHS.
THIRD SOME COMMENTS ON THE
MINIMUM WAGE THE MINIMUM WAGE
HAS REALLY- CREATED A NUMBER OF
DIFFERENT CHALLENGES FOR THE
SYSTEM. ONE IS THE ISSUE OF
COMPACTION AND THAT'S LIKELY
AFFECTING OTHER SERVICES
ELSEWHERE TOO. IN OTHER
PROGRAMS. BUT A UNIQUE THE-
ISSUE THAT'S BEEN DISCUSSED
ALREADY IS THIS THIS CORK IN
LOST SO NOT ONLY DO THE
PROVIDERS IN THE HIGH COST
AREAS NOT ONLY ARE THEY UNABLE
TO GET A RATE ADJUSTMENT. TO
HELP COVER THE COSTS OF THE
LOCAL MINIMUM WAGE ORDINANCES
THEY ALSO ARE INELIGIBLE TO
REQUEST FUNDING ASSOCIATED WITH
STATE MINIMUM WAGES. THERE ARE
A COUPLE OPTIONS TO ADDRESS
THIS- WHAT WE DUBBED THE CORK
IN LAW- WHAT ONE WOULD BE TO-
SIMPLY DO SOME STATUTORY CLEAN
UP TO ALLOW THOSE PROVIDERS TO
ACCESS THE CURRENT ADJUSTMENTS
UNDER THE CURRENT PROCESS THE
SECOND WOULD BE A PROPOSAL
ALONG THE LINES OF MISTER
FRASIER'S AND MR HOLDINGS AND
THE ASSOCIATED ADVOCATES- WELL
OUR OFFICES NOT CONDUCTED AN
INDEPENDENT ASSESSMENT OF
WHETHER THREE POINT 3% IS- AT
THE RIGHT AMOUNT WE HAVE TAKEN
A LOOK AT THEIR OVERALL- COST
ESTIMATE WHICH IS WHICH SEEMS
ABOUT IN LINE WITH WHAT WE
WOULD HAVE CALCULATED. A AND
THEN FINALLY ONE OF THE POINTS
THAT WAS RAISED IN THE AGENDA
THAT WE DIDN'T TALK A LOT
ABOUT- BUT I'LL JUST MENTION IT
BRIEFLY IS THE FACT THAT THE
SYSTEM DOESN'T HAVE A-
SYSTEMATIC WAY OF COLLECTING
DATA. ABOUT CONSUMERS IN ABOUT
SERVICES- THIS MAKES IT VERY
DIFFICULT TO KNOW WHAT THE
UNMET SERVICE REQUIREMENTS ARE
WE DON'T KNOW IF CONSUMERS HAVE
THE CHOICES- OF SERVICE
PROVIDERS THAT THEY'D LIKE. A
WE DON'T KNOW MUCH ABOUT
QUALITY. AND WE DON'T KNOW IF
THINGS ARE BEING DONE
CONSISTENTLY ACROSS REGIONAL
CENTERS WHETHER THEY'RE
COLLECTING DATA IN THE SAME
WAY- EVEN CONSIDERING SERVICE
CODES IN THE SAME WAY. THANK
YOU I THINK YOU HIT THE NAIL ON
THE HEAD WITH THAT ISSUE AND
MORE TO DISCUSS LATER SO- WE
WILL NOW TAKE PUBLIC COMMENT ON
ISSUE TO. GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER
CHAIRMAN REVERSE- CARL LONDON
HERE REPRESENT THE ALLIANCE
SUPPORTING PEOPLE WITH ID DE.
HAS ONE MAKE A COUPLE COMMENTS-
FIRST FOUR ONE EXPRESS THEIR
SUPPORT FOR BOTH MR HOLDEN'S.
IN A LETTERMAN COALITIONS
PROPOSALS WE'VE BEEN WORKING
VERY CLOSELY WITH THEM AND
BELIEVE THOSE ARE BOTH-
EXCELLENT- APPROACHES TO
SOLVING SUMMER PROBLEMS. WANT
TO POINT OUT SOME OF THE AGAIN
JUST REMINDER SO SOME THE
STATISTICS WE KNOW ABOUT THE
IMPACT. OF WHAT'S BEEN
HAPPENING IN OUR SYSTEM. AND IT
STARTS IN THE SYSTEM WITH A
REAL FOCUS ON PEOPLE WHO ARE
STAFF. IF ALL YOU DID WAS A
SIMPLE PROBLEM. YOU LOOK TO THE
FACT WE HAVE ABOUT A HUNDRED
FORTY THOUSAND WORKERS IN THE
SYSTEM. AND YOU LOOK AT THE
FACT THAT THE STATE AFTER THE
RATE STUDY NOW SAYS THE- THE
SYSTEM ABOUT ONE POINT FOUR
BILLION. THE MAP ON THAT ALONE
IF ALL YOU DID WAS TELL EVERY
WORKER IN THE SYSTEM YOU'RE
GOING TO MAKE TEN THOUSAND
DOLLARS MORE PER PERSON. IN THE
NEXT- AHEAD WITH THE TURNOVER
RATES GO HIGHER BE EASIER YES
THE- ABSOLUTELY. SO YOU LOOK AT
WHAT IS MY GOES YOU'VE GOT A
SYSTEM ALREADY THAT HAS TO PAY
OUT. EIGHTY FIVE CENTS ON EVERY
DOLLAR. TO THE PEOPLE WHO STAFF
THE SYSTEM ANY DOLLARS YOU GIVE
GO STRAIGHT TO PEOPLE THAT WORK
IN THE SYSTEM. TODAY WHAT WE
KNOW ABOUT THE STAFF ALMOST 80%
OF THEM ARE WOMEN. MOST OF THEM
WORK TWO OR MORE JOBS MOST OF
THEM ARE A GOOD PORTION THAT
MORE ON PUBLIC ASSISTANCE. ALL
FORMS OF PUBLIC ASSISTANCE FOOD
MEDI CAL AND OTHER PROGRAMS.
IT'S A SERIOUS PROBLEM-
PROGRAMS THAT TODAY. ON THE
VERGE OF CLOSURE BECAUSE OF
RATESI'M AWARE OF SOME AND
MISS RUBIO'S DISTRICT FOR
EXAMPLE. THAT ARE RIGHT ON THE
EDGE OF CLOSURE. WHAT HAPPENS
WHEN THEY CLOSE. WELL WHAT
HAPPENS IS THOSE PEOPLE HAVE NO
WHERE TO GO ANY LONGER. THEY GO
RIGHT BACK TO THE REGIONAL
CENTER WHO THEN US TO FIND THEM
A PROGRAM AND GUESS WHAT. EVERY
PROGRAM WE FIND FOR THEM AFTER
THAT POINT IS MORE EXPENSIVE.
THAN THE ONE WE JUST CLOSED.
THAT IS TRUE INSANITY BUT
THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT'S GOING TO
HAPPEN IN MS RUBIO'S DISTRICT.
VERY SHORTLY UNDER THE CURRENT
RATE STRUCTURE- THE LAST THING
I'D LIKE TO SAY IS ON THE RATE
INCREASES. WOW WHAT AN UNFAIR
OUTCOME FOR THESE FOLKS THAT.
WHERE THE DEPARTMENT FOUND
THROUGH PUBLIC COMMENT THAT THE
RATES THEY HAD PUT OUT WERE TOO
SHORT. FOR THOSE THREE
PROGRAMS. THE BENEFIT IN THE
REWARD IN THE PENALTY THEY GET
ALL THE SAME FELL SWOOP IS. YES
WE DISCOVERED. THAT WOULD BE
WORK FUND YOU ENOUGH TO THIS
RAY STUDY PRO. BE THE PUBLIC
TOLD US. WE HADN'T DONE THIS
CORRECTLY. YOUR WORDS YOU HAVE
TO WAIT A WHOLE NOTHER YEAR.
GET THE BENEFIT OF OUR COPIES
THAT'S- REDUCE. HELLO THING I
SEE IT I BE YOUR LONG. NOW
FIFTEEN YOU'RE LOOKING ON THIS.
RUSHED WE NOW HAVE. SIX THANKS
FOR WILL GRAB APPROVED ALL.
WHAT WE BUILD IT AND WE WOULD
THIS. FEDERAL APPROVAL. WE WERE
BACK TO THE- ONE THE FED
GOVERNMENT IF. APPROVAL CAN. ON
JULY FIRST. HOUSE THIS IS A SHE
HIM TO CUT THESE RATE INCREASES
TO HALF YEAR THAT'S ALL THIS
DOES IS DELAY. A HALF YEAR
THESE RATE INCREASES. I I'D WE
WE'RE GOING DOWN THE WRONG PATH
IN THIS AND I JUST WANNA MAKE
THOSE POINTS AS YOU CONSIDER
THIS THANK YOU. THANK YOU SIR
AND THEN IF WE CAN TRYING KEEP
YOUR- COMMENTS. CONTENTS THERE
ARE A LOT OF PEOPLE AND I JUST-
DON'T WANT PEOPLE STANDING FOR
TOO LONG. MY NAME IS RENEE
PEARLS ARMONK A CLIENT OF THE
REGIONAL CENTER OF THE EAST.
BAY I'M ALSO A MEMBER OF THE
BOARD OF DIRECTORS OF THE
REGIONAL CENTER OF THE EAST
BAY. AND I ALSO SERVE BOTH IN
THE R. C. B.'S CONSUMER AB. SEE
MINDY. AFTER SIX YEARS WHAT THE
REALLY GOOD. CASE MANAGER I
LOST MY CASE MANAGER WHAT SHE
MOVED. WITH HER FAMILY TO
ARIZONA I AM NOW ON AN OPEN
CASE LOAD WITHOUT A CASE
MANAGER FOR MY OWN. THIS MEANS
ONE UPPER I NEED I REQUIRE SOME
HELP WITH SERVICES I MUST ASK A
SUPERVISOR TO HELP ME. HAVING
NO ONE IS SIGNED ME SINCE
JANUARY. MEANS THAT I HAVE NO I
HAVE HAD TO BE PERSISTENT IN
GETTING REFERRAL PACKAGE FROM
SUPERVISORS IN ORDER TO APPLY
FOR INTERNSHIPS. REGARD JOB
COACHING WITHOUT- REALLY. WELL
TRAINED JOB PROPOSAL BURN COACH
MY PARENTS HAVE HAD TO ACT OF
MIGHT BE HAPPY AS BOTH. JOB
DEVELOPER RIGHT JOB COACH THIS
YEAR AFTER FUTURES LOWER MY
PROVIDER CLOSE NIFTY THREAT I
SHOP IN LAFAYETTE WHERE I WAS
EMPLOYED FOR THREE YEARS I HAVE
NOT BEEN ABLE TO DO A
PROFESSIONAL JOB COACH IN THE
MEANTIME I OF THE SUB. BOLGER
JOBS WOULD TALK TO PINE ME
POWER TIME WHILE I AM PLUG FOR
INTERNSHIPS WITH LEAD ME TO
IMPLEMENT I AM ON A WAITING
LIST SINCE SEPTEMBER. TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN FOR JOB. FROM
COACH FROMEAST BAY INNOVATION
WHICH IS AN APPOINTMENT SERVICE
PROVIDER WITHOUT REALLY GOOD
TRAIN JOB DEVELOPERS AND JOB
COACHES I FOUND IT EXTREMELY
HARD TO FIND PAID WORK RATES
PAID TO THE SERVICE PROVIDERS
MUST ALLOW THEM TO PAY BETTER
WAGES. TO THEIR SERVICE STAFF
WHO LIVE WORK DIRECTLY WITH
INDIVIDUALS LIKE ME WHILE THE
DEPARTMENT OF DEVELOPMENT
SERVICES IS HOLDING BACK THE
RATE STUDY DONE AT THE
LEGISLATION. DIRECTOR
DIRECTIONS REGIONAL CENTERS I'M
SURE BRIDGE TO PROVIDE YOUR SIR
SUFFERING THANK YOU. FOR
LISTENING THANK YOU MA'AM. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS MARK
LANSON EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
THE CALIFORNIA SUPPORTED LIVING
NETWORK- SEE IF SOMEONE IN OUR
MEMBERSHIP APPRECIATE THE
RECOGNITION ON THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET THAT INDEPENDENT LIVING
SERVICES BE INCLUDED IN THE
SUPPLEMENTAL PROVIDER RATE
INCREASES. FOR NINETEEN
THOUSAND CALIFORNIANS WITH
INTELLECTUAL AND DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES THAT USE AYE ALAS
AT AN AVERAGE COST OF SEVEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS A YEAR THAT'S
FIVE HUNDRED. SIX HUNDRED
DOLLARS A MONTH- IT IS THE MOST
COST EFFECTIVE EFFICIENT
SERVICE WITH SIGNIFICANT
IMPACTS ON ACHIEVING QUALITY OF
LIFE FOR PEOPLE RECEIVING
SERVICES WHY WAIT SIX MONTHS WE
RIGHTED THE RATE NOW LET'S
WRITE THE DATE. PROVIDERS ARE
STRUGGLING RIGHT NOW. ON AND
SHOULD NOT BE TOLD TO WAIT FOR
THE SUPPLEMENTAL RATE INCREASES
WE HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
IMPLEMENTS. JULY FIRST I DON'T
KNOW WHAT IT'S LIKE TO DO
JANUARY FIRST IMPLEMENTED-
IMPACTING LAST YEAR'S BUDGET
BUT- THERE'S NO REASON TO WAIT-
SO WE ASK YOU TO SUPPORT-
MOVING THAT FORWARD THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SIR. HELLO I'M JACKI
DOLLARS AWESOME I'M THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE STEP
PROGRAM. AND I WANTED TO SAY TO
YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER ARAMBULA
AROUND YOU. CAN SEE THAT REALLY
WELL SO MY- SCHOOL ROLL OFF MY
TONGUE. THANK YOU FOR
RECOGNIZING THE CLOSER THE
DEVELOPMENTAL CENTERS IT'S BEEN
MIGHT WORK OF MY PASSION FOR
TWENTY FIVE YEARS. I DO WANT TO
SAY YOU KNOW IT'S KIND OF A SAD
ASSUMPTION THAT WE MADE IN OUR
SYSTEM. THE PROMISE THAT WE ARE
A WITH MINIMUM WAGE INDUSTRY
THEY'RE ALL FIGHTING TO BE
RECOGNIZED TO GET THE FUNDING
WE NEED TO PAY MINIMUM WAGE
WHAT EVERY PROVIDER IN THE ROOM
REALIZE IS. OUR DIRECT SUPPORT
PROFESSIONALS ARE WORTH SO MUCH
MORE THAN MINIMUM WAGE BUT
WE'RE SAYING WE'RE GOING TO
FIGHT FOR YOU TO MAKE SURE MY
LOCAL MINIMUM WAGES MATT. I
CURRENTLY HAVE TWO RATES IN MY
FOR MY SUPPORTIVE LIVING
SERVICES IN SACRAMENTO COUNTY
ONE FOR THEIR WICKS STAFF AND
ONE FOR THE ASLEEP STAFF. I GET
PAID THIRTY CENTS MORE AN HOUR.
ON MY A SLEEP RATE BECAUSE
ALTHOUGH STAFF ARE MINIMUM WAGE
BECAUSE THEY SLEEP. SO IT'S
KIND OF A- A BACKWARD
ASSUMPTION THAT WERE FIGHTING
ON AND IT FEELS REALLY-
CHALLENGE YOU TO EVEN THINK
THAT WE HAVE TO HAVE THIS
CONVERSATION. THE DRUG SUPPORT
PROFESSIONALS ARE MINIMUM WAGE
EMPLOYEES YOU'RE GOING TO WE'RE
LOSING SO MANY PEOPLE JUST ON
THAT VERY BASIC PREMISE. SO
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
HOLDEN FOR TAKE IT ON WE NEED
TO FIX IT- THE OTHER ONE IS
INDEPENDENT LIVING SERVICES
THAT'S HOW I STARTED MY CAREER.
IN NINETEEN NINETY TWO. IOS
SERVICES IT'S A PROGRESSIVE
INNOVATIVE SERVICE. THE AVERAGE
COST AS I LOOKED AT THE NUMBERS
YESTERDAY FIVE HUNDRED SEVENTY
ONE DOLLARS A MONTH. THEY
DIDN'T FIX THE RATE STUDY PER
SE BECAUSE THEY DIDN'T FIX THE
WAGE. THEY FIX THE PERCENTAGES.
I WOULD STILL TAKE A
SIGNIFICANT CUT IN MY RATE IF
THE RATE STUDY WAS IMPLEMENTED
BASED ON THAT NEW ASSUMPTION.
IF TALKING ABOUT THE MOST COST
EFFECTIVE MOST INCLUSIVE
SERVICE OF ALL. AND WE CAN'T
FIX IT. SEVENTY ONE HUNDRED
DOLLARS A YEAR. PEOPLE DON'T
GET THAT IN IN I'LL LESS
INSTRUCTOR IS VERY DIFFERENT
AND THE JOB THAT THEY DO IS
VERY DIFFERENT YOU NEED TO
RECOGNIZE THAT I HOPE WE FIX
THE RIGHT. CORRECT THE RAKE
COLLECT CORRECT THE DATE BUT
ALSO RECOGNIZE THE WORK OF
THOSE ISLANDS INSTRUCTORS
BECAUSE THEY WERE THE FIRST IN
THE NATION TO DO THIS REALLY
INCLUSIVE SERVICE AND I
HOPEFULLY YOU UNDERSTAND THAT
I'M LIKE WE'RE NOT A MINIMUM
WAGES INDUSTRY. PLEASE FIX WHAT
HE'S ASKED BUT THAT'S NOT WHO
WE ARE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MA'AM. IF ANYONE WITH THAT THE
ARE YOU CALIFORNIA AND SUPPORT
OF BOTH THE PROPOSAL FROM
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRAZIER AND
ASSEMBLY MEMBER HOLDEN I REALLY
APPRECIATE YOU BOTH BRING A
PHOTO. THANK YOU THANK YOU
MA'AM. IT MY NAME IS BONNIE
GALE I'M A PARENT OF A CHILD
WHO HAS IS THAT REGIONAL CENTER
CLIENTS FROM VALLEY MOUNTAIN
REGIONAL CENTER I AM HERE
REPRESENTING EDUCATE ADVOCATE
ESTATE A STATEWIDE GRASSROOTS
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATION THAT
SERVES FAMILIES WITH SPECIAL
NEEDS CHILDREN AT EDUCATE
ADVOCATE IS A MEMBER OF THE
LATCH MEN COALITION AND WE
SUPPORT ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRAZIER
AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER HOLDEN'S
BUDGET REQUESTS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MA'AM. GOOD AFTERNOON
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS VERY
JORDAN WITH THE CALIFORNIA
DISABILITY SERVICES
ASSOCIATION- FIRST I JUST WANT
TO THANK ASSEMBLY MEMBER HOLDEN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FRAZIER IS NOT
HERE TODAY FOR THEIR TREMENDOUS
WORK AND AT OBVIOUSLY I'M GOING
TO SUPPORT THEIR PROPOSALS BOTH
TO IMPLEMENT THE RATE MODELS.
AND TO FIX THE MINIMUM WAGE
COMPONENT AS AS WE HEAR FROM
OTHER CAN STAB PROVIDERS HERE
TODAY I SHOULD WE SHARE THE
RIGHTEOUS INDIGNATION THAT WE
ARE EVEN TALKING ABOUT OUR
INDUSTRY AND OUR DIRECT SUPPORT
PROFESSIONALS AS MINIMUM WAGE
PROFESSIONALS BUT THAT'S WHERE
WE ARE AND THAT'S WHAT THE RATE
STUDY SHOWS WE ARE ONE POINT
EIGHT BILLION DOLLARS
UNDERFUNDED WORKING HERE THAT
NUMBER A LOT TODAY I THINK-
BECAUSE- IT REALLY IS. A
PROBLEM AND WHEN WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT THE MINIMUM WAGE FIX THAT
ASSEMBLY MEMBER HOLDEN IS
PRESENTING THAT'S WHERE THAT'S
WHERE WE ARE BUT THAT'S NOT
WHERE WE WANT TO BE IF WE START%
TO IMPLEMENT THE THREE YEAR
PLAN THAT THE LAND WE COALITION
IS PUT TOGETHER WE WILL START
TO SEE PROFESSIONALS BEING PAID
WHAT THEY DESERVE. WE WILL SEE
A REDUCTION IN THE IMPACTS AND
THE STRESS OF GIVING THEM
POVERTY WAGES- TO DO
TREMENDOUSLY IMPORTANT WORK AND
WE SHOULD RESPECT IT AS SUCH I
WILL ALSO SEE THE OUTCOMES IN
THE THAT WE'RE LOOKING FOR
INDIVIDUALS WITH DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES AS WE START TO SEE
MORE STABLE WORK FORCE. AND WE
START TO DEVELOP THE SERVICES
AND FUND THEM APPROPRIATELY SO
THAT WE CAN GET THE OUTCOME SO
WE'D LIKE TO SEE. THANK YOU.
SIR MY NAME IS JAMIE DAVIS ON
THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR MORE
ADVENTURES A RELATIVELY SMALL
AGENCY IN MARIN COUNTY WHICH IS
A RELATIVELY SMALL COUNTY.
WHERE EDWARD CRITICAL
CROSSROADS A SONY SAID- I WAS
SO EXCITED THIS WINTER TO. WORK
ON RAISES FOR MY STAFF BASED ON
THE EIGHT POINT 2% THAT WE GOT
BUT I STILL FEEL LIKE WE'RE
BEHIND FOR WAGES IN MARIN
COUNTY. AND ADDED INTO THIS I
LEARNED A COUPLE OF WEEKS AGO A
TOLL HAS BEEN PROPOSED FIRST
HIGHWAY THIRTY SEVEN FROM
SOLANO COUNTY TEMERIN. AT LEAST
3240% OF MY EMPLOYEES COME FROM
SOLANO COUNTY TO MORAN SO THESE
LITTLE THINGS ARE PICKING AWAY.
AT OUR WORKERS NEEDLESS TO SAY
MOST OF OUR BUDGET GOES TO OUR
WORKERS EITHER FOR HEALTH
INSURANCE OR- WAGES AND OTHER
BENEFITS SO- WE HAVE TO MAKE A
CHANGE WHEN I STARTED THIRTY
TWO YEARS AGO I WAS MAKING A
COUPLE DOLLARS AN HOUR MORE
THAN MINIMUM WAGE AS A DIRECT
SUPPORT WORKER. SO I WANT TO
CONTINUE THAT OR OR IMPROVE ON
THAT FOR PEOPLE THAT WORK FOR
ME. THANKS. GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS AL MILAN I LIVE IN
SACRAMENTO- I COULD SPEAK ON A
NUMBER OF ISSUES- TODAY. THIS
IS MY DAUGHTER MOLLY WHO IS NOW
TWENTY EIGHT YEARS OLD. AND SHE
LIVES CURRENTLY WITH MY WIFE
SHERRY AND I HERE IN
CARMICHAEL- AS TO THE COULD
SPEAK ON MANY ISSUES. AROUND
OUR CARE FOR HER BUT TODAY I
WANT TO SPEAK SPECIFICALLY
ABOUT EARLY START I'M NOT GONNA
STOP TALK ABOUT THE DOLLARS AND
CENTS. BUT I'D LIKE TO REMIND
EVERYONE AND HOPEFULLY. THEY IN
BAD IN THEIR MINDS THAT WHEN WE
SERVE CHILDREN BIRTH TO THREE.
WHO COME INTO THE EARLY START
SYSTEM FOR WHATEVER DIAGNOSIS
THEY MIGHT HAVE IT'S NOT JUST
ABOUT THE CHILD. WE'RE PAYING
TO SERVE FAMILIES AND HELP
FAMILIES LIKE MINE OVERCOME OR
GET THROUGH WHATEVER THE
INITIAL EXPERIENCE BRINGS TO
OUR FAMILY. SO THAT TWENTY
EIGHT YEARS LATER WE'RE STILL
ABLE TO BE TOGETHER AND CARE
FOR HER. I SPENT TEN YEARS AS
THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
WARM LINE FAMILY RESOURCE
CENTER HERE IN SACRAMENTO WHICH
SERVE SIX COUNTIES ALL AROUND
HERE. AND ICE WORKED WITH MANY
MANY PARENTS FACILITATED A
FATHER'S GROUP FOR TEN YEARS
WHICH IS STILL IN EXISTENCE. SO
I MAINLY I'M HERE TO JUST TO
IMPRESS UPON YOU. THAT WHEN YOU
TALK ABOUT FUNDING INDIVIDUALS
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT FUNDING
FAMILIES MOTHERS FATHERS
GRANDPARENTS WHO OFTEN WIND UP
CARING FOR THEIR CHILDREN. AND
WITH OUT ADEQUATE STAFF AND AN
EARLY START. YOU HAVE A VERY
SPECIALIZED GROUP OF PEOPLE WHO
ARE PROVIDING FAMILIES WITH.
UNBELIEVABLE WRAPAROUND
SERVICES EVERYTHING FROM
EXTREME MEDICAL NEEDS TO
BEHAVIOR NEEDS. TO A SADLY
LACKING NEED FOR JUST HELPING
MOM AND DAD UNDERSTAND HOW TO
DEAL WITH AND MOVE FORWARD WITH
WHAT THEY ARE GOING THROUGH. SO
I APPRECIATE ALL ALL THE WORK
THAT IS DONE. I AM VERY
GRATEFUL TO LIVE IN CALIFORNIA
AND TO WORK WITH SO MANY GREAT
PEOPLE IN THIS AREA I ENCOURAGE
YOU TO DO EVERYTHING YOU CAN TO
SUPPORT. THE SYSTEM THE PEOPLE
IN THE SYSTEM THAT SUPPORT OUR
FAMILIES THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME. THANK YOU SIR. HELLO MY
NAME'S HELLO I'M SHORT. MY
NAME'S REBECCA LABORIEL- FROM
THE CALIFORNIA SUPPORTED LIVING
NETWORK AS WELL AS WORK I WORK
WITH STEP I'M AN I LS DIRECTOR
AND I BROUGHT MY POLICY TO LET
EVERYONE KNOW HOW THESE CUTS OF
IMPACTED OUR FOLKS SO. HERE WE
GO. HI MY NAME IS A RECOVERING-
AND I WAS ASKED TO GIVE YOU
GUYS A COUPLE OF LETTERS AND
ONE I WOULD LIKE TO READ TO YOU
FROM ONE OF THE I LS
INSTRUCTORS IS BEEN IN THE
FIELD FOR THIRTY YEARS. AND HE
SAYS HE'S BEEN WORKING WITH
DISABLED ADULTS FOR THIRTY
YEARS. AND HE ENJOYS WORKING
WITH THEM EVERY SO YOU CAN PUT
A SMILE ON THEIR FACE AND
OFTENTIMES THEY'RE WONDERING
HOW THEY CAN FUNCTION IN OUR
LIFE WITH OTHERS. I HELP THEM
OPEN IT OPEN MANY DOORS WITH
LIFE INCLUDING ATTAINING A PAID
JOB EDUCATION AS WELL AS VOTING
FOR THE POLITICS. BEEN INVOLVED
IN OBTAINING A COMMUNITY
RESOURCE IS GETTING BETTER
UNDERSTANDING OF EVERYDAY LIFE
AND MAKING GOOD LIFE CHOICES
ARE SIR. MAY BE ADDED. TO
DIFFERENT JOBS I TRAIN AND TO
DEVELOP AND MAINTAIN
INDEPENDENT SKILLS SO THEY CAN
LIVE THEIR LIVES IT TO THEIR
FULLEST. ONE ONE LIVE QUALITY
THAT I SHARE WITH MY EMPLOYERS
AND CLIENTS IS THAT I CAN
UNDERSTAND AND RELATE TO THEIR
CHALLENGES IN EVERYDAY
STRUGGLES LIVING IN A FINANCIAL
STABLE LIFESTYLE. AS A MATTER
IS A MAJOR BARRIER THAT THEY
HAVE TO DEAL WITH DAILY. LIVING
LIVING IN A SUNNY CALIFORNIA IS
A WONDERFUL ABOUT HIGH EXPENSE
AND IT TAKES A TOLL ON EVERYONE
FROM HIGH RANKING INCREASED TO
HIGH COST OF LIVING FOR MEDICAL
INSURANCE EXPENSES. AND BEING
VERY CHALLENGING TO THE-
FINANCIAL STABLE VACATION IN
PURCHASING GENERAL LIFE THINGS
HOME HOME IMPROVEMENTS BETTER
VEHICLES AND SOME OF THE
WONDERFUL THINGS THAT. I HAVE
GOALS WITH ACCOMPLISHED IN LIFE
UNFORTUNATELY I HAVE NOT BEEN
ABLE TO ACCOMPLISH THIS WITH A
VERY LOW RATE WITH THE LOWER
RATE PAY AND THE HIGH COST OF
LIVING IS NEXT TO IMPOSSIBLE TO
BE FINANCIAL STABLE. AND THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA I'M
DEMANDING THAT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA GRANT SAID BUDGET
INCREASE FOR THE IOS
INSTRUCTORS THAT WE CAN
CONTINUE TO GIVE THE BEST
QUALITY CARE RESPONSIBLE TO THE
DISABLED ADULTS. IF WE'RE
INSURING THAT THE DISTANCE ABLE
TO DOUBTS THAT ARE LIVING TO
THEIR LIKE VERY INDEPENDENTLY
THERE IS A SESSION. WITH THEIR
GOALS AND THEY'VE BEEN HOW
SPRING BUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA REDUCE TO THE HIGH
BUDGET IS. JUST BY CLOSING DOWN
MANY OF THIS STATE INSTITUTIONS
OVER THE YEARS WE'VE ALSO HELP
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
KNOWLEDGE AT THE DISABLED
DOUBTS ARE RECOGNIZED AND THE
ORDINARY CITIZENS. AND THEY'RE
JUST LIKE US AND THEY'RE NOT
TREATED IN A DIFFERENT. THEY
CAN DRIVE THEY CAN OWN A HEART
ON HOME AND THEY CAN ALSO VOTE
JUST LIKE US. I'M I'M NOT
ASKING TO BE PAID A MILLION
DOLLARS BUT WORKING WITH THE
BUDGET WITH INCREASED LATELY. I
HAVE A VERY DIFFICULT TIME
BEING FINANCIAL STABLE YET I'M
STILL WORKING WITH THE DAYS
DISABLED ADOPTION LIVING THEIR
LIFE INDEPENDENTLY. ANY
INCREASE IN THIS HOW. WOULD
HELP ME TREMENDOUSLY AGAIN I'M
DEMANDING A BUDGET INCREASE
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND
CONSIDERATION THERE'S A COUPLE
OTHER LETTERS. IF YOU GUYS
COULD PLEASE TAKE THEM YEAH IF
YOU GIVE A PRESCRIPTION SO.
THANK YOU THANK YOU. HI MY NAME
IS FRENCH OF BRUNDLE. I WORK
WITH A I'LL- WORK WITH IOS AND
I ALSO AM. TO MAKE A GREAT
INCREASE. AND I ALSO DO WORK
WITH LANDSCAPING PEOPLE THAT
ARE. THAT DO A LOT OF WORK
AROUND. A DIFFERENT HOUSES AND
WE DO A LOT OF LANDSCAPING WITH
HOUSES THEY HAVE DISABILITIES
AND STUFF. AND I WOULD LOVE
FOR. THE US TO GET A INCREASED
A GREAT INCREASE ON EVERYTHING
AND HELP GET MORE I LOST
WORKERS IN THE COMPANY TO HELP
US. AND I THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR YOUR PATIENCE IN MY NAME IS
FRANCES RANDALL. THANK YOU SIR.
I'M BONNIE. THIS IS SHE'S NEVER
DONE THAT BEFORE THIS IS BONNIE
HUGHES SHE DOES. THE MONEY
MONEY HADLEY AND SHE DOES THE
SAME THING SHE IS OUR- GREAT
INCREASE OF OUR IOS AND SHE
ALSO. IS WITH THE COMPANY SHE-
NUMBER OF YOU'RE NOT WORKING
BUT SHE WANTS TO WORK AS MUCH
AS SHE CAN AND HELP. PEOPLE GET
AROUND HELP- DO WORK LIKE
LANDSCAPING OR ANYTHING SHE CAN
DO. AND WE AGREE APPRECIATE
YOUR TIME AND WE WANT TO HELP
WE'LL BE LIKE TO HAVE YOUR
HELP. WITH THE IOS AND KEEP OUR
COMPANY GOING STRONG. THANK YOU
BOTH THANK YOU. YEAH. THE
TRAFFIC GEN. HELLO MY NAME IS
STEVEN I'M IS AT THE STATE
PROGRAM AND I HAVE AN IOS
WORKER WHO KINDA DEFEAT AND
ABOUT WHAT WHAT THE WEEK AND
PLEASE KEEP THE RATE THAT I AM
I THINK YOU'VE GOTTEN RATE
INCREASE THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS JERRY HADLEY
AND I'M A INDEPENDENT LIVES
DEAL WITH- STEP HAVE BEEN WITH
THEM FOR ALMOST TEN YEARS. AND
I APPRECIATE THEIR SERVICES AND
I LOVE TO. HAVE SOME MORE
SUPPORT ON THAT BECAUSE THEY DO
HAVE A LOT OF PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES THANK YOU THANK
YOU.
SORRY I GOT LOST HER SON
HI- RICK ROLLINS REPRESENT
ARKANSAS SHE'S THE REGIONAL
CENTER AGENCIES SO ONE OF FIRST
OF ALL THANK THIS COMMITTEE FOR
ITS GREAT WORKER LAST YEAR AND
A SISTINE. OUR SYSTEM- WITH THE
WONDERFUL APPROPRIATIONS OP
OPPORTUNITY AND- THE RESPONSE
TO THE ADVOCACY COMMUNITY-
WE'RE HERE TODAY TO SUPPORT THE
ADVOCACY OF PROPOSAL THAT'S
BEFORE YOU ON PAGES EIGHT
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN. END OF IS A
PROUD MEMBER THE LAMB AND
COALITION OF SUPPORT TO THAT
AFTERNOON THANK MISTER HOLDEN
MISTER FRAZIER AND ALL THE
OTHER CHAMPIONS OF OUR SYSTEM
FOR CONTINUED TO WORK TO.
SUPPORT OUR SYSTEM THANK YOU
THANK YOU SIR. HI I'M DEBBIE
LINK WITH UNITED CEREBRAL PALSY
AND STOCKTON AND I'M THE
DIRECTOR OF THE EARLY STAR
PROGRAMS THERE INTO CODE ONE
SIXTEEN. AND YOU GUYS HAVE
HEARD IT ALL HERE BEFORE BUT WE
ARE HERE I'M HERE IS TO-
STRONGLY URGE YOU TO SUPPORT
THE RATE INCREASE. YEAH WE
HAVE- A LOT OF STAFF A BEEN
THERE AT LEAST TEN YEARS. MOST
FOR MAKING THE TENTH PERCENTILE
SALARY FOR THEIR PROFESSIONAL
DISCIPLINE SO THEY'RE THERE
BECAUSE THEY LOVE THE JOB. BUT
IT'S GETTING HARDER AND HARDER
FOR THEM TO. MAKE ENDS MEET AND
FOR US TO MAKE ENDS MEET WITH
THE INCREASING RATE- INCREASE
IN OUR RENT THE INCREASING GAS
THE INCREASE IN OUR PROTOCOLS
FOR TESTING EQUIPMENT. SO I
WOULD JUST LIKE TO REALLY PUT
OUT THERE ARE STRONGLY URGE YOU
TO- DO THE RATE INCREASE AND
PREFERABLY AT THE BEGINNING OF
THE YEAR NOT HALFWAY THROUGH
THE YEAR. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MA'AM. HI HI MELODY MERRY FROM
PROFESSIONAL VALUATIONS AND
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES WERE A-
I'M COMPREHENSIVE PROGRAM IN
SAN JOAQUIN COUNTY THROUGH
VALEMOUNT REGIONAL CENTER. WE
SERVE ABOUT THREE HUNDRED
FIFTY. INFANTS AND TODDLERS AND
THEIR FAMILIES. AND WERE
STRONGLY AM ENCOURAGING
EVERYBODY TO PLEASE DO THE RATE
INCREASE DO NOT GO BY THE RATES
THAT ARE ON THE REVISED STUDY.
WERE RATE ONE ONE SIX CODE
EIGHT OH FIVE. AND AGAIN LIKE
DEBBIE JUST SAID WE HAVE REALLY
LOW WAGES FOR PEOPLE WE CAN'T
KEEP PEOPLE BECAUSE OF THE WAY
JUST BEING SO LOW. AND WHY 5%
FOR EARLY START AND 8% FOR
EVERYBODY ELSE. THANK YOU FOR
LISTENING THANK YOU. MY NAME IS
LISA DRAKE I'M ALSO WITH A
PROFESSIONAL VALUATIONS
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES ONE OF
THE OWNERS I'M ALSO A SPEECH
THERAPIST AMBER SERVICE
PROVIDER FOR INFANTS IN THEIR
HOMES I'VE DONE IT FOR OVER
THIRTY YEARS IT'S A PASSION AND
WE'RE ALL IN IT FOR PASSION AND
NOT FOR THE MONEY BUT- MONEY
DOESN'T WE NEED IT BECAUSE I
CAN'T KEEP GOOD ENOUGH PEOPLE
TO KNOW HOW TO WORK WITH
FAMILIES IN THEIR HOMES IT'S-
IT'S TRULY. A TALENT- IN A
UNIQUE GIFT AN OPPORTUNITY WE
HAVE TO IMPACT PEOPLE'S LIVES
AND IN TERMS OF THE RATE STUDY
I DON'T KNOW THAT IT ACCURATELY
REFLECTS WHAT I DO IN MY DAY
AND THE TRAVEL TIME THAT I
SPENT EVEN IN SAN JOAQUIN
COUNTY TRAVELING FROM MOUNTAIN
HOUSE TO A SCHOOL ON IN BACK TO
STOCKTON. IT'S A LOT MORE THAN
THE RATE SAID HE REFLECTED AND
SO I ENCOURAGE YOU TO PASS ON
THE PERCENTAGE INCREASE. THANK
YOU MA'AM. I'M KATHLEEN BOWMAN
I'M ALSO ONE OF THE OWNERS OF
PROFESSIONAL VALUATIONS IN
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES. I'M AN
EARLY INTERVENTION TEACHER AND
I WANT YOU TO HAVE A LOOK AT
THE RATE STUDY PLEASE INCREASE
WE I'VE BEEN AND- I'VE DONE
THIS FOR OVER FORTY YEARS. AND
BESIDES THE GREAT TEACHERS THAT
WE HAVE AND THERAPISTS AND-
NURSES- WHO WOULD HAVE TO TAKE
A CUT IN PAY- IT'S ALL ABOUT
THE FAMILIES. I WITH THIS
GENTLEMAN SAID BACK HERE. IT'S
ABOUT THE FAMILIES AND WHAT WE
GOINGAND DOING HOMES. AND IT
IS THE TOTAL FAMILY IT'S NOT
JUST THE TRIAL IT'S THE WHOLE
FAMILY AND SORRY FOR GETTING
EMOTIONAL. BUT I'VE NEVER. EVER
THOUGHT THAT I WOULD HAVE TO
COME HERE AND SPEAK IN FRONT OF.
US STATE SENATOR SENATE AND
HAVE TO FIGHT FOR THIS. JOB
WHICH WE ALL HAVE SO MUCH
PASSION FOR AND LOVE SO MUCH
AND IT'S ALL IN OUR HEART.
BELIEVE ME. WE ARE A COMPANY
THAT WE STARTED. OVER FIFTEEN
YEARS AGO START WITH FOUR OF US
AND WE ARE SO LUCKY TO GO IN
ANSWER SANDWICHING COUNTY. AND
IN GOING IN MEET THESE FAMILIES
THAT WE BEGIN TO GET TO KNOW
THEM WE BECOME PART OF THEIR
FAMILY GOING IN WEEKLY AND
SERVING THOSE CHILDREN AND
THANK YOU FOR LISTENING TO ME.
THANK YOU MA'AM. HI MY NAME'S
PATTY DIXON I CAME TODAY
SPECIFICALLY TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT. OF THE FUNDING FOR IOS
EYELESS SERVICES TO MEET OUR-
AS A SAFETY NET TO KEEP POPLE
FROM ENDING UP ON THE STREETS-
IF YOU THINK OF A TYPICAL
PERSON ON SSI GETS NINE HUNDRED
AND FORTY THREE DOLLARS A
MONTH. IF YOU CAN IMAGINE
TRYING TO LIVE ON NINE HUNDRED
FORTY THREE DOLLARS A MONTH
YOUR RENT YOUR UTILITIES YOUR
WIFI YOUR PHONE WHICH WE ALL
NEED IN THIS STATE AGE YOUR
FOOD YOU'RE CLEANING SUPPLIES.
ALL OF THAT OUT OF NINE HUNDRED
FORTY THREE DOLLARS A MONTH YOU
MIGHT NEED A LITTLE SUPPORT AND
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO
NAVIGATE WHEN YOU RUN SHORT ON
MONEY WHERE THE FOOD BANKS WHEN
YOU NEED HELP WITH MEDICAL.
APPOINTMENTS MAKING SURE YOU'RE
KEEPING UP WITH YOUR HEALTH
MAKING SURE THAT YOU'RE
CHOOSING HEALTHY FOODS AND
TEACHING YOU ABOUT HOW TO DO
THESE THINGS IN YOUR LIFE
HELPING YOU FIND A PLACE TO
RENT THAT YOU CAN AFFORD WHICH
IS A WHOLE NOTHER STORY RIGHT.
AND NAVIGATING MOVING AND
ROOMMATES AND IT'S JUST A LOT
AND I THINK THAT THAT LITTLE
FIVE TO TEN HOURS OF SUPPORT
THAT A PERSON GETS. IS HUGE IN
KEEPING PEOPLE FROM FALLING
THROUGH THE CRACKS OF IT JUST
IT IT JUST MAKES A WHOLE LOT OF
DIFFERENCE AND I FULLY SUPPORT
FUNDING AT I WAS JUST KINDA
CHUCKLING BECAUSE I SAW. A
GENTLEMAN HERE THAT I WAS AND I
LESS INSTRUCTOR FOR TWENTY TWO
YEARS AGO AND I WAS MAKING
ELEVEN DOLLARS AN HOUR TWENTY
TWO YEARS AGO. AND WORK WHAT
FIFTEEN MAYBE NOW SO IT
DEFINITELY NEEDS FUNDING IS A
VERY VERY VALUABLE- PROGRAM
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME STATUS IS ON
A NAME A PROGRAM DIRECTOR AT
STEP. AM AND THERE'S REALLY
NOTHING THAT I CAN SAY MANY
MORE ELOQUENTLY THAN ALL OF THE
OTHER PEOPLE THAT SPOKE BEFORE
ME. SO JUST SECOND WHAT THEY
SAID ABOUT THE RATES AND- HOW
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT IT IS TO
FIND THE SERVICES THAT WE
PROVIDE- IT'S NOT A MINIMUM
WAGE JOB IF YOU ALL THINK BACK
TO YOUR MINIMUM WAGE JOBS THAT
YOU HAD THOSE ARE YOUR STARTER
JOBS. YOU'RE BAGGING GROCERIES
OR FLIPPING BURGERS THE THINGS
THAT ARE EYELESS INSTRUCTORS
DO. ON OUR DIRECT SUPPORT
PROFESSIONALS DO ARE NOT
STARTER JOBS THEY REQUIRE
SKILLS THEY REQUIRE TRAINING.
AND THEY REQUIRE LEVEL
DEDICATION THAT. THAT OTHER
JOBS THAT ARE MINIMUM WAGE JOBS
DON'T REQUIRE SO WE DO NEED TO
FIX THE RATES BUT I WILL SAY I
AM. COLLEGE APPRECIATE THE
GOVERNOR'S RECOGNITION THAT
I'LL AS NEEDED TO BE INCLUDED
IN THE EIGHT POINT 2% INCREASE
WE JUST NEED. THAT DAY WAS THAT
THE MARK SAID FIX THE RATE SIX
TODAY WE NEED TO FIX THE DATE
IT NEEDS TO BE RETROACTIVE. TO
JANUARY OF TWENTY TWENTY NOT
UNITS TWENTY TWENTY ONE SO
THANK YOU. YOU HI MY NAME'S
MARGIE. A DIRECT SUPPORT
PROFESSIONAL AND I'VE BEEN ONE
FOR. APPROXIMATELY TWENTY
YEARS. BUT I STARTED- WHICH
STEP. TWELVE YEARS AGO APRIL
WILL BE TWELVE YEARS NAY APRIL.
I WAS MAKING TEN FIFTY THEN BUT
I DON'T REMEMBER BUT MINIMUM
WAGE WAS. BUT I KNEW I WAS
MAKING MORE THAN MINIMUM WAGE
SO I WAS REALLY EXCITED. WELL
HERE IT IS TWENTY TWENTY. AND I
MAKING THIRTEEN FIFTEEN AN
HOUR- I CAN GO TO MCDONALDS AND
FLIP BURGERS FOR THIRTEEN FIFTY
RIGHT AND I'VE ACTUALLY PART
SUPPORTING A PERSON. YOU KNOW
THAT'S IT FOR CULTURE OUR
SOCIETY HE- I JUST DON'T GET
WHY THEY DON'T RECOGNIZE THE
IMPORTANCE OF THE JOB THAT I DO
BECAUSE- LIKE AND IT'S MY
CAREER YOU KNOW SURE I COULD GO
WORK AT MCDONALDS BUT YOU KNOW
WHAT. IT I WOULD LOVE TO SAY
IT'S NOT ABOUT THE MONEY BUT
FACE IT WE ALL HAVE LIVES WILL
HAVE BILLS TO PAY SO IT IS
ABOUT THE MONEY. BUT IT'S
MOSTLY ABOUT THE LADY OVER
THERE IN THE RED SHIRT I'VE
WORKED WITH HER FOR A LEVY
YEARS AND- THAT'S WHAT IT'S ALL
ABOUT SO ANYWAY. DON'T FORGET
US PLEASE THANK YOU YOU MAY.
NOT RELATED TO THE WOMAN IN THE
RED SHIRT BUT I BELIEVE IT'S A
WONDER WOMAN SURE AND I'D LIKE
TO GIVE KUDOS TO THE. I
REPRESENT GATE PATH WE OPERATE
IN SAN MATEO AND SANTA CLARA
COUNTY WHERE THE HIGH COST OF
LIVING. AND LOCAL MINIMUM WITH
MINIMUM WAGE MANDATES MAKE IT
VERY CHALLENGING TO RECRUIT AND
RETAIN STAFF. WE HAVE WAITING
LISTS WE CAN EXPAND PROGRAMS.
WHERE ARE. THE SYSTEM IS IN
CRISIS AND THAT IS VALIDATED BY
A- GREAT STUDY THAT REFLECTED A
ONE POINT EIGHT BILLION DOLLAR
SHORTFALL IN FUNDING SO I WOULD
ENCOURAGE YOU TO. IMPLEMENT
THOSE RATE MODELS I SUPPORT
BILLION I'M IN COLLECTIONS
PROPOSAL FOR A YEAR. IS AN
THANK YOU. THANK. GOOD
AFTERNOON DOCTOR AMULET AND
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS MY NAME'S
LOWLANDS I'M THE CEO OF
EXCEPTIONAL PARENTS UNLIMITED.
AND FRESNO CALIFORNIA- WE SERVE
ABOUT THREE HUNDRED CHILDREN AT
ANY GIVEN TIME. IN THE INFANT
DEVELOPMENT PROGRAM- THAT IS
FUNDED WITH THREE TDS IN THE
REGIONAL CENTER. IN FRESNO
THERE- WE SERVE ABOUT FIVE TO
SIX HUNDRED CHILDREN- DURING
THE YEAR IN THAT PROGRAM. I
HAVE ONE PHYSICAL THERAPIST AT
ONE SPEECH THERAPIST. I HAVE
ONE OCCUPATIONAL THERAPIST HAT
WORKS PART TIME. AND THEY ARE
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT OUR SPEECH
THERAPIST. AS ATTEMPTING TO SEE
ABOUT 50% OF THE CHILDREN ARE
PROGAM BECAUSE ARE IDENTIFIED
THROUGH THAT PROGRAM. AS
NEEDING SPEECH SERVICES THIS IT
INCREASES REPAIR IMPORTANT TO
US IS SERVICE PROVIDERS. A
RETROACTIVE GETTING. VERY
HELPFUL. NOW WE ARE RUNNING AT-
IN THE RED OFTENTIMES AND SO
PLEASE PLEASE CONSIDER THAT
THANK YOU. SIR. MISTER CHAIR
GUY HOUSTON MISSION HOPE DAY
PROGRAM- WE SERVE THE EAST BAY
IN THE BAY AREA- THE- IT'S
EARLIER ABOUT TIPPING POINTS. I
THERE ARE PROGRAMS ON THAT ARE
CLOSING- PARTICULAR RESIDENTIAL
IN OUR AREA- BUT PROGRAM
DUNGARVAN IN HAYWARD CLOSING A
FACILITY FOR THIRTY FIVE
INDIVIDUALS SO THE TIPPING
POINT IS HAPPENING AND SO YOU
KNOW SOMETHING HAS TO BE DONE
TO IMPLEMENT THAT PROGRAM- PART
OF OUR COALITION WERE PUT
TOGETHER. WE'RE INVITING YOU
LEGISLATORS TO COME WORK IN OUR
PROGRAMS I THINK YOU PROBABLY
HAVE ALREADY SIGNED UP FOR
THAT- BUT BUT BE IN OUR SHOES
AND TWO HOURS OF YOUR TIME IN A
PROGRAM WORKING WITH OUR WITH
OUR CLASS IN OUR DIVISION.
THANK COURAGE YOUR THINGS TO DO
THAT I THINK A REALLY OPEN
THEIR EYES THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU SIR AND I DID SIGN UP
FOR THAT AND WELCOME BACK
ASSEMBLY MEMBER. HELLO MY NAME
IS STORK INTERESTS AND I'M
GRANDMOTHER TO A TWENTY SEVEN
YEAR OLD. YOUNG MAN WHO IS A
HAS AN INTELLECTUAL DISABILITY.
WHILE I AGREE GOOD TO GET THAT
GOOD PROVIDERS TO SERVE
SIGNIFICANT RATE INCREASES
INCREASES I ALSO BELIEVE THAT
IT SHOULD BE TIED TO
ACCOUNTABILITY. JUST LIKE IT
WAS MENTIONED HERE IN THE
COMMITTEE. ARE THEY HELPING OUR-
PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES REACH
THEIR GOALS. I'M ALSO PART OF
THE INTEGRATED CUT COMMUNITY
COLLABORATIVE IN AND WORKING
WITH OVER A HUNDRED FAMILIES
THIS YEAR. I NOTICED THAT SOME
OF THEM WOULD TALK ABOUT SOME
OF THE SERVICES THAT THEY
RECEIVE IN PARTICULAR ABA.
SERVICES AND SOME WOULD SAY
THAT THEY WERE GETTING GREAT
SERVICE AND OTHERS WOULD SAY
THAT THEIR PROVIDER WOULD NOT
SHOW UP OR WERE THEY WERE. NOT
AVAILABLE AT A CERTAIN DAY AT
THE LAST MINUTE SO I THINK
REALLY WE NEED TO LOOK AT. HOW
WILL ALRP PROVIDERS ARE DOING
BEFORE WE DECIDE THAT WE JUST
GOING TO DO RATE INCREASE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MA'AM. WHAT
DOES THAT IS ME NUMBER IS GOOD
HE SAID THIS BUT OTHER DILEMMAS
FROM ABOUT SAID FROM WHAT IT
DOES IT. FOR TRANSLATE FOR HER.
YOUR SECOND SEES THEM AS THE
ACCURACY AND THE WE KNOW THAT
THE SYSTEM IS GROWING BETTER SO
NOTING THE FECA BUT THAT DOES
NOT MEAN GET THE AND THEY GET
RENTALS THE LIST OF ECS THAT WE
NEED TO REDUCE THE SERVICES OUR
SERVICES. I CAN PUT ARE WE
SHOULD BETTER THE SERVICE LAW
FOUR MONTHS. THE FORM I THINK I
SAID THIS THREE WILL YET LARA
COURSE OF THE WAY THAT THE-
SERVICES ARE DISTRIBUTED TED
AND THE RESOURCES ARE
DISTRIBUTED. IN THIS BESSIE L.
AND ESPECIALLY LIKE ALI THAT
THE LIBERAL WITH ORDERS THE
QUALITY OF THE PROVIDERS. IT IS
THAT IDEA IN OUR AREA I PUT
OVER THE OTIS GUESS IN YET
ANOTHER SET OF FEATURES ON A
THREAT FROM MEDIA THERE ARE
SOME SERVICE PROVIDERS THAT DO
NOT- HAVE SERVICES FOR OUR
pFAMILIES. THAT WOULD NOT COMMIT
TO SERVICES TO OUR FAMILIES
WHAT GUESTS ON CASTLE WE SAY
THEY DON'T BECAUSE THEY MAY BE
SEVERE CASES OF AUTISM- BUT
GUESS SO GAS IS GOING TO THAT
OTHERS WHO LIVE WITH OR BECAUSE
THE THEY ARE CONSIDERED-
INDIVIDUALS THAT HAVE A LIGHT
DISABILITY. IT WAS GOOD
TROUBLED ADDRESS FROM YES I
HAVE FOUND I HAVE HEARD FROM
OTHER FAMILIES GET PORK A LAST
SECOND CS THAT BECAUSE THE
AGENCIES IS DONE WITH LOCALS
AND- LIBERAL LOS SERVICIOS THAT
THE AGENCIES. ARE TOO FAR FROM
THE SERVICE ARE. PROVIDED FOR
YOU THE FOOT HILLS WE HAVE
LEARNED A LITTLE ONE LINE YES
WHO ARE HAVE FROM FAT THAT THEY
HAVE NO. SO ADDITIONAL
INCENTIVES FOR THOSE PROVIDERS
WOULD BE GREAT THANK YOU. YOU
PROCESS. HI A I'M WENDY FOR
KIDS TIME THE CEO OF COMMITTEE
CALIPHS CALIFORNIA WE PROVIDE
SERVICES AND NOT VARIOUS AREAS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. AND I
WANTED TO STAND UP AND LET YOU
KNOW THAT WE COULDN'T WAIT
ANOTHER YEAR FOR THE EIGHT
POINT 2% AND WE HAD TO CLOSE
SERVICES AND ONE OF OUR SERVICE
AREAS. THAT WE HAVE BEEN
SERVING FOR EIGHT YEARS OUR IT
IMPACTED FIFTY PEOPLE NUTS.
TWENTY SIX EMPLOYEES. AND YOU
KNOW UNFORTUNATELY FOURTEEN
INDIVIDUALS THAT HAD TO. BE
TRANSITION TO ANOTHER SERVICE
PROVIDER- IN THE MAIN REASON
WAS WE COULD NOT. GET STAFFING
WE'RE AT A POINT WHERE WE COULD
NOT ENSURE WE HAD ADEQUATE
STAFFING. IT TO KEEP THEM IN
THEIR HOMES AND THE SAD TRUTH
IS AS MUCH AS I LOVE COSTA
PASTA. INTO TOWN. WE KNEW WE
COMPETE SELL. REAL SUPPORT
THREE POINT THREE MINIMUM WAGE
INCREASE OKAY ANY WAY TO
INCREASE RATE INCREASE THAT IS
GOING TO SUPPORT THE SYSTEM. TO
ENSURE WE CAN REALLY PROVIDE
THE STAFF. THAT IS NEEDED TO
PROVIDE ADEQUATE CARE AND
SUPPORT TO THE PEOPLE. OF THAT
WERE BEING. USE MUCH. MY NAME
IS CHRISTINE I ME TOLD SERVICES
DIRECTOR FOR STABILITY AND
CONTRA COSTA AIRS IN CONTRA
COSTA COUNTY FORMERLY CONTRA
COSTA AIR SEE- AND I'LL JUST BE
VERY BRIEF I JUST. ECHO
EVERYTHING EVERYBODY ELSE HAS
SAID ABOUT ALL THREE OF THE
SERVICES THAT NEED THE
INCREASED FUNDING- ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT I NEVER PLANNED ON
IN BEING IN THIS POSITION IT'S
HAVING TO STAND WITH PARENTS.
TELL THEM OF THE SERVER BECAUSE
THERE THAT THE COULD POSSIBLY
HAVE BUT THEN TELL THEM THAT
IT'S GOING TO BE A THREE OR
FOUR MONTH WAIT FOR THEIR YEAR
OLD TO GET SERVE. UP AS CANNOT
HIRE STAFF. YOU CAN. HI I'M IAN
TURNER I'M STEPPING AGENCY- I
ACTUALLY WANTED TO ADDRESS TO
THIS THE DIRTY WORK OF
HOMELESSNESS BUT NO ONE'S BRING
OUT I JUST GOT THREE REFERRALS
FROM ALL TO REGIONAL FROM THREE
INDIVIDUALS WITH THAT ARE ALL
TO REGIONAL CONSUMERS WHO ARE
HOMELESS- ONE OF THE THINGS I
ALLEGE CAN HELP AVOID IS PEOPLE
BECOMING HOMELESS- LEARNING HOW
TO PAY THE BILLS- LEARNING HOW
TO GET AFFORDABLE HOUSING IF
THAT EXIST ANYMORE SACRAMENTO-
BUT ONE OF THEM ENDED UP
GETTING HE'S IN A PSYCH WARD
AND WHY I HAVE AND I. OCCUR WHO
ACTIONS CAME OUT IN A BRIDGE.
AND WE JUST GOT A REFERRAL YES
HE'S LIVING UNDER THE BRIDGE-
OVER BY THE AIRPORT THREE TO BE
WORKING WITH HIM TRYING TO GET
HIM INTO SOME HOUSING. AND MY
THIRD ONE THE WOMAN WITH THREE
CHILDREN SHE HAS A SIX YEAR OLD
A FOUR YEAR OLD AND A TWO YEAR
OLD. TO THE CHILDREN ARE ALSO
ALTER REGIONAL PLANTS- I WASN'T
ABLE TO GET STAFF OUT. I'M A
LITTLE SHORT ON MANAGER I DROVE
UP BURKE AND I MET WITH HER AT
THE HOTELS. TRY TO GET HER
PORTABLE HOTELS VOUCHERS- WILL
NEED A CREDIT SCORE. OF FOOD SO.
REALLY WANT TO TALK ABOUT THAT
THE I'LL US SERVICES ARE SO
IMPORTANT BECAUSE THEY
ABSOLUTELY HELP WITH AVOIDING
HOPELESSNESS. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MA'AM SEEING NO FURTHER
PUBLIC COMMENT ON BRING IT UP
TO THE SUBCOMMITTEE AND SEE IF
WE HAVE ANY QUESTIONS. IF NOT A
HOLD CHANNEL MY INNER FRAZIER
IF I MAY. AND REALLY DO WANT TO
LOOK AT HIS PROPOSAL AND HEAR
FROM THE ADMINISTRATION NEXT
STEPS FOR RATES IS IT. THE
HOLISTIC APPROACH THAT YOU WERE
SPEAKING ABOUT EARLIER OR ARE
WE GOING TO LOOK AT A PHASED IN
APPROACH FOR RATES. THANK YOU-
MISTER TERRY AGAIN WHEN- WE'RE
LOOKING AT OUR OUR SYSTEM IN
FISCAL DISCUSSIONS AND TAKING A
LOOK AT THE RATES- WE ARE
HAVING AN INTERNAL DISCUSSIONS-
AS FAR AS BEING ABLE TO-
OUTLINE- SOMETHING THAT AREAS
SO MUCH I'D LIKE TO FOCUS ON.
IS THE SO A WOMAN'S ARE GOING
TO BE REALLY CRITICAL TO OUR
DISCUSSIONS AND THAT CONTINUES
TO BE ON ON THE AREAS THAT I
HAD RELEASED PREVIOUSLY STATED-
SO WILL WE'LL BE HAVING
CONVERSATIONS WITH OUR SYSTEM
IN FISCAL REFORM WORK GROUPS
AND THEN SO TAKING A LOOK AT
THE PERFORMANCE TO PROGRAM-
THAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT HERE
SHORTLY. I WAS HOPING YOU COULD
TALK ABOUT SOME OF THE BENEFITS
AND DRAWBACKS OF THE MEMBERS
PROPOSALS AND ADVOCATES
PROPOSALS- SPECIFICALLY IF I
COULD THE EARLIER START DATE
FOR THE THREE CODE. AS WELL AS
A MINIMUM WAGE PARK. SO
REGARDING THAT THE PROPOSAL'S
NOT OUR PROPOSALS YOU KNOW AND
CERTAINLY ANYANYTHING THAT THE
COMMITTEE WOULD LIKE US TO
PROVIDE TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE ON
WE'RE CERTAINLY HAPPY TO DO
THAT I KNOW THAT WE'VE BEEN
ABLE TO PROVIDE SOME OF THE
DETAIL TO PROVIDE INFORMATION
ON. PROTECTION OF COSTS BUT IF
THERE'S ANYTHING ADDITIONAL
THAT CAN BE INFORMATIVE- ARE
HELPFUL AND YOUR ANALYSIS THAT
THAT DATA THAT WE HAVE WE'D BE
HAPPY TO PROVIDE THAT. RATE
FROM. ANY FURTHER COMMENTS IF
NOT I HAVE A REQUEST- AND IT
WAS WHAT THE LA- HAD MENTIONED
AT THE CLOSE OF HER COMMENTS
REGARDING DAY- IT'S AN ITEM
THAT WE- SEE THROUGHOUT OUR
AGENDA HERE TODAY. BUT I REALLY
WOULD LIKE US TO TAKE A
MEANINGFUL STEP ON DATA IN THE
DVDS SOME. UNDERSTANDING THAT
IN A MORE UNIFORM WAY STATEWIDE.
WE NEED INFORMATION ABOUT THE
NUMBER OF PEOPLE WHO ARE
SERVED. AS WELL AS FAMILY
SATISFACTION ACCESS TO SERVICES
AND SUCCESS OR FAILURE OF
COMMUNITY INTEGRATION.
RECOGNIZING THAT THERE ARE
SIGNIFICANT DATA GAPS IN OUR
SYSTEM RIGHT NOW I'D LIKE US TO
THINK ABOUT HOW WE CAN MOVE
FORWARD THIS YEAR TO CREATE A
UNIFORM DATA WAREHOUSE THAT
WILL ASSIST WITH TRANSPARENCY.
AND OUTCOME ORIENTED SYSTEM
PROGRESSION CAN I ASK THE LA-
TO WORK WITH DDS AND THE
SUBCOMMITTEE STAFF TO AID US IN
CONSTRUCTING DRAFT SUPPLEMENTAL
REPORTING LANGUAGE TOWARDS THE
SCHOOL. I SEE TWO HEADS SHAKING
SO WITH THAT WE WILL HOLD ISSUE
TO OPEN AND MOVE ON TO ISSUE
THREE. OKAY. THANK YOU
ASSEMBLYMEMBER HOLD. WHEN
YOU'RE READY DIRECTOR A- THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR COMMITTEE
MEMBERS- I'LL GO AHEAD AND
PROVIDE AN OVERVIEW OF THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED PROPOSAL
THAT WE HAVE RELATED TO THE
PERFORMANCE INCENTIVE PROGRAM
AND ONE OF THE AREAS ALL TOUCH
ON- IN IN THE DISK AND WILL
ALSO BE RELATED TO DATA.
BECAUSE AN ELEMENT AN IMPORTANT
ELEMENT IS CERTAINLY GOING TO
BE THE DATE INTEGRITY- AND
WHICH WE WOULD RELY ON AN
IMPLEMENTATION AS PROGRAM SO AS
THE AGENDA IS DOES NOTES THAT
WE DO HAVE A READ STE. FOR A
SEVENTY EIGHT. DOLLARS TOTAL
FUND SIXTY IS- OF GENERAL FUND
TO IMPLEMENT A NEW- PROGRAM FOR
AN ENHANCE PERFORMANCE
INCENTIVE PROGRAM. THE PROGRAM
IS REALLY DESIGNED AND WAS
CONSTRUCTED WITH THE VISION OF
BEING ABLE TO IMPROVE OUTCOMES
FOR THE INDIVIDUALS THAT WERE
SERVING. AND IT WOULD BE FOR
THE REGIONAL CENTERS AND
WORKING- THAT WOULD BE DIRECTED
TO THE REGIONAL CENTERS AND
SERVICE COORDINATION AND BEING
ABLE TO MOVE FORWARD IN A VERY
INNOVATIVE FLEXIBLE. WAY
HOWEVER IT WOULD BE VERY TIED
TO ACCOUNTABILITY OVERSIGHT
AND- BE VERY PRESCRIPTIVE AS
FAR AS THE GOALS AND THE
PERFORMANCE OF OURS. DOES IT
TOO MAKE SOME SOME SIR
REGARDING A EMERALD DOES MOVE.
THEM FOR AND TAKE A LOOK AT HOW
DO WE STEPPED OUR CULTURE IT.
IS TO HELP BRING SERVICE AND
ONLY FOR THOSE SIR. NINE IT OUT.
MUCH ONLY THOSE ALSO ARE REALLY
COOL. SEVEN SO WE DID. I'M AND
WE STILL HAVE AN APP FOR
CONTRACT ON THAT PERFORMANCE
CONTRACT IS STILL VERY ON THE
HOW IT IS VERY TIGHT MORE CA
MEASURES AND SO AS WE MOVE
FORWARD TO A PERFORMANCE
INCENTIVE PROGRAM WE ARE REALLY
LOOKING TOO THIN AS IS TIED TO
COME AND- SURE I'M AT POSE I'M
JUST BUT AN CONNECT I KIND OF
THOUGHT IN CANADA
ACCOUNTABILITY PIZZAS SO THE
PROGRAM ON THE CALL THE OF THE
OUTCOME AND RESULTS WILL
ULTIMATELY BE. COME RIGHT TO
THAT I'M REALLY. ADDRESSING THE
SERVICE. AND DISPARITIES THAT
SYSTEM IS FACE A WE'RE GONNA
TALK SOME MORE ABOUT THAT LATER
IN THE AGENDA THE IMPORTANCE
OF. ADDRESSING THE ISSUES THAT
WE HAVE AS FAR AS PROVIDING
SERVICES TO OUR COMMUNITIES ARE
AND CERTAINLY SEEN THOSE ACCESS
ISSUE. ON THE OTHER ELEMENT AS
AS WAS NOTED AS FAR AS THE DATA
SO WE TAKE A LOOK AT THE DATA
AND HELPING THE REACHED CENTER
ALSO SAYS THE STATE. IS IT
WHITE RICE THE THAT IS BE ABLE
TO. SO WE- SURE THAT WHATEVER
PER FROM MEASURES THAT ARE
GOING TO PURSUE. IN GOING
FORWARD THAT WE CAN REALLY RELY
ON THAT DATA TO BE ABLE TO DO
THE MEASUREMENT AND TIE IT TO
INCENTIVES. SO THE STRATEGIES
THAT THAT WE'RE LOOKING AT THAT
WE'VE BEEN WORKING ON BECAUSE
WE'VE WE CERTAINLY HAVE BEEN A
NUMBER OF CONVERSATIONS ARE
STAKEHOLDER. AS A CHAIR HAD NOT
HAD OF THE- THING ABOUT OUR
SYSTEM IS REALLY BRING GAUGE
METAL ARE STAKEHOLDER. DE AND
CREATING AN N. AS IN THE VALUE.
A BRING TO THAT WELL IN AND
HELPED US IDENTIFY THOSE
PRIORITIES. SO IN THOSE COPS
ASIAN ENDS IT DID COME FORWARD
AT. TAKEN HOW TO HELP. MAKE
THAT WE HAVE SOME IN. IS ABLE
TO A COMES AND THOSE X. ALL
GIVING EXAMPLE. WHEN WE TAKE A
LOOK IT TAKE UP AND CROSS THE
STATE AND MAKE SURE WE HAVE HI
MY ACCESS TO TAKE. AND THAT
WERE ABLE TO BE ABLE NOT ONLY
DOES YOUR- IN ONE. THAT THEY
HAVE A VERY HARD TIME HAVING
THE SAME INFORMATION IF THEY GO
FROM ONE REGIONAL CENTER TO THE
NEXT REGIONAL CENTER. SO THESE
INFORMATION PACKETS IF YOU WILL
REALLY DO TO CUT A TOUCH ON
THAT MAKING SURE THAT EVER GOES
THROUGH THAT FRONT DOOR. IS
GOING TO BE ABLE TO HAVE THE
SAME INFORMATION AND THE
CONTINUITY. THEN TOOK A- STEP
IS THAT WE'VE BEEN WORKING ON.
A REAL TIME SURVEY. I COULD
DELIVER TO DO THE FAMILIES THAT
ARE GOING THROUGH AND TAKE THAT
CAN GO AHEAD AND IN REAL TIME
NBA. TO INDICATE IN SAY FIVE TO
EIGHT DIFFERENT QUESTIONS WHAT
NEXT AND DID YOU GET YOUR
QUESTIONS ANSWERED. OUTSTANDING
QUESTION DO YOU UNDER THE
OUTCOME IN YOUR- ABILITY- SO
THOSE ARE THE THINGS THAT WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT ARE
DEFINITELY LINKED WE'VE BEEN
VERY FORTUNATE TO BE ABLE TO
INVEST IN BEER. TO START THE-
PROCESS BE ABLE TO HAVE THIS-
THAT WOULD BE ABLE TO. SECURE
THE SUCCESS OF THIS CONCEPT. SO
A COUPLE OF OTHER THINGS THAT
ARE REALLY IMPORTANT IN THIS
PROGRAM. IS WE'RE GONNA BE ABLE
TO TAKE A LOOK HOW DO WE
SUPPORT INDIVIDUALS- WE DO
RECORD. OBVIOUSLY ARE. THOSE
THAT WE WANT- FOR CASELOADS
WERE IN TALK ABOUT THAT FIRST
CHILDREN THAT ARE THREE. OR AND-
SOLD. TRACKING BRITAIN'S THE-
REYES ARE PROPOSED FOR. LITTLE
LATER YOU IS ONE TO FOUR. FIVE
BUT WE- NEED TO DECIDE SAID
EARLIER WE HAVE A- DIFFERENT.
SO YOU MIGHT THAT EXPERTISE TO
NAVIGATE THE DIFFERENT SYSTEMS.
SO AGAIN TO KIND OF. TAKE YOU
INTO THE SYSTEM AND THE CHANGES
THAT WE'VE HAD PARTICULARLY FOR
OUR YOUNGER FAMILIES. IS THAT
OVER THE MANY YEARS THE LAST
SEVERAL YEARS WE HAVE SHIFTED
ABA SERVICES FOR INDIVIDUALS
WITH AUTISM TOO MANY CAL OR TO
THEIR HEALTH PLANS IT IS NOT AN
EASY SYSTEM TO NAVIGATE SO WHEN
YOU TAKE A LOOK AT YOUR DO YOU
HAVE EXPERTISE. FOR THIS COURT
ERRORS THAT HAVE EXPERTISE TO-
WORK AND HELP AND SUPPORT IN
OUR- MEETINGS OR SOMEBODY THAT
HAS THE EXPERTISE TO BE ABLE TO
HELP A FAMILY CONNECT TO A
HEALTH PLAN OR TO BE ABLE TO
CONNECT TO. THOSE SERVICES
THOSE CHEN SOURCES OF DEPEND ON
AND MAKE SURE THAT THAT PERSON
IS HURRY THE CONCEPT IS THAT
MAKE SURE WE HAVE A BASE FUND.
THERE WERE ALSO WOULD. THERE'S
JEEZ EIGHT NAY TO MOVE. AND HOW
THEY'RE GOING TO ACHIEVE THAT
PRESCRIBE PERFORMANCE MEASURES
AND THEIR STRATEGY DEPENDING ON
THE RESULTS OF. RED COAST
CENTER IS V. ROLE RURAL FOR
HOUSE INDIVIDUALS DE SER. TO IT
PAGE ON YOU HAVE ABOUT FOUR
THOUSAND AND- OR. TO IN OUR
CASE LOAD SO WE COULD APPROACH
CASELOADS A LITTLE DIFFERENTLY
AND RECOGNIZE THE DIFFERENCE OF
THE NEEDS OF THE PERSONS THAT
THEY'RE SERVING. SO THIS WOULD
GIVE THE OPPORTUNITY FOR THE
REGIONAL CENTERS TO MOVE
FORWARD IN A WAY THAT ALSO
WOULD STILL BE H. CBS
COMPLAINTS BECAUSE WE'RE GOING
TO BE MEASURING COMPLIANCE WITH
THE FEDERAL RULE. BASED ON WHAT
IS THE EXPERIENCE IN THOSE AT
ARMS SO THOSE ARE THE ELEMENTS
THAT WE SEE NO OVER THE NEXT.
FOUR MONTHS AS I IT SAID THAT
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT WE'RE
GOING TO DO. WE'RE GONNA BE
IDENTIFIED THAT THEY CAN HELP
US IDENTIFY THOSE PRIORITIES.
AND THEN THOSE PER- PERFORMANCE
MEASURES THAT WE WOULD BE USING
TO BE ABLE TO ACHIEVE THOSE
GOALS. AND THEN WORK THROUGH
THOSE METRICS AYE WE'RE GOING
TO BE ABLE TO TIE THOSE
INCENTIVES. AND SO TO JUST TO
HELP YOU SEE THE PICTURE OF
THIS WE WOULD SEE THAT ACROSS
THE STATE THAT WE WOULD HAVE
THE SEVENTY EIGHT MILLION. AND
AT THE NEXT FOR THE BASE FOR
THAT READ. CAN TO ANSWER THAT
THEY- THE SERVER COORDINATOR
CLOSE SELECT. HELP NAVIGATE
THROUGH THE PORT MERRY. IS IT
OUT THERE. AND DEAN OF. WENT
SAID. YES 70% AT AND HAVING THE
TWO FIVE SIGNED THAT WOULD BE
TÁI. THOSE A- IT WOULD BE
ABLE TO MAKE EVERY RESULTS AND
IS ON BEING ABLE TO MEASURE TO
THEIR STAY BECAUSE WE DON'T
WANT TO BE ABLE TO WE DON'T
WANT TO PUT AND TO PROBLEM
WHERE A REGIONAL CENTER IS
GOING TO HAVE TO COMPARED TO AN
THE RESULT AND IT'S A EXPLAINED
AND THEY DON'T OPPORTUNITY TO
IMPROVE SO SURE IT'S NUMBER
FIVE RESOURCE CENTER HELP
EXPECTATION OF BE HELD ON THE
A. K. FORTY THAT. TO BE AT TO
READ THOSE. CITED A- DATE DO
SOMETHING THAT IS DIFFERENT BUT
STILL ACKNOWLEDGE THE
IMPORTANCE OF MAKING SURE THAT
THE REGIONAL CENTERS HAVE THE
RESOURCES- WHERE IT'S NEEDED TO
PROVIDE SERVICES AND ALSO
INVEST IN AND DOING THE THINGS
THAT HAVE DONE IT I'D AS FAR AS
THE DATA INTEGRITY SURE THAT
THOSE RESOURCES APPROPRIATELY
AND THIS PROGRAM. THANK YOU
DEPARTMENT FIND. FOR AT FURTHER
TETANUS RICHARD THANK YOU HELLO.
THANK YOU SONYA PADDICK
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE-
WE ACTUALLY DO RECOMMEND
REJECTING THIS PROPOSAL. WE
RECOMMEND INSTEAD THINKING
ABOUT THE FUTURE VISION OF THE
SYSTEM AS WE TALKED ABOUT
SEVERAL ISSUES AGO. THE REASON
WE RECOMMEND REJECTION IS NOT
BECAUSE THE IDEA DOESN'T HAVE
MERIT BUT WE FEEL THAT RIGHT
NOW IS NOT THE RIGHT TIME TO BE
THINKING ABOUT INCENTIVE
PAYMENTS- IN LIGHT OF THE
SIGNIFICANT FUND UP THAT WE
JUST DISCUSSED I'M IT ALSO
MEANS THAT INCENTIVE PAYMENTS
MADE THAT. WE NOT RATE QUESTION
AT THIS PIVOTAL MOMENT- AND
THAT INSTEAD TALKING ABOUT
FISCAL REFORM A IT MAY BE THE
TOP PRIORITY AT THIS TIME
HOWEVER WE ALSO DON'T THINK
THERE SHOULD BE A FALSE CHOICE
BETWEEN TALKING ABOUT QUALITY
WE TALKING ABOUT QUALITY OR
OPENLY TALKING ABOUT FISCAL
REFORM. THERE REALLY TWO
DIFFERENT DISCUSSIONS THAT YOU
CAN HAVE ONE IS ABOUT QUALITY
AND ACCOUNTABILITY AND
TRANSPARENCY. AND ANOTHER IS
ABOUT USING INCENTIVES TO TRY
TO ACHIEVE THOSE GOALS THAT'S
JUST ONE WAY TO TRY TO ACHIEVE
QUALITY IN THE SYSTEM INCENTIVE
PAYMENTS YOU CAN STILL. TRY TO
ACHIEVE QUALITY WITHOUT
INCENTIVE PAYMENTS. I'M SO IN
FACT I'LL JUST GIVE YOU A
COUPLE OF EXAMPLES FOR HOW YOU
MIGHT PURSUE QUALITY AND
ACCOUNTABILITY GOALS IN OTHER
WAYS RIGHT NOW. ONE IS BETTER
OVERSIGHT OF THE SYSTEM AND IN
A COLLABORATIVE WAY- IRAN TO
FACILITATE CONTINUOUS
IMPROVEMENT IMPROVEMENTS IN THE
SYSTEM. ANOTHER IS TO REVISE
THE REGIONAL CENTER PERFORMANCE
CONTRACTS WHICH IS PART OF THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL WE
RECOMMEND APPROVING THAT ASPECT
OF THE PROPOSAL. ANOTHER
POSSIBILITY IS TO RESTRUCTURE
SOME OF THE CURRENT
APPROPRIATIONS THAT CURRENTLY
EXIST IN THE SYSTEM SO FOR
EXAMPLE. THE DEPARTMENT
CURRENTLY HAS AN INCENTIVE
PROGRAM- THAT THE THAT THE IN
THE SYSTEM FOR A COMPETITIVE
INTEGRATED EMPLOYMENT. HOWEVER
THAT PROGRAM HAS NOT. REALLY
TAKEN OFF THE WAY I THINK
EVERYBODY WOULD LIKE IT TO YOU.
IT MAY BE POSSIBLE TO
RESTRUCTURE THAT PROGRAM AND
ALMOST USE IT AS A PILOT TEST
OF INCENTIVE PAYMENTS TO
IMPROVE QUALITY. I'M YOU COULD
CONSIDER DOING ANOTHER TYPE OF
PILOT TEST OF INCENTIVE
PAYMENTS RATHER THAN APPROVING
A OF A SEVENTY EIGHT MILLION TO
DO THIS- ON A NON PILOT TEST
BASIS. I WOULD ALSO SAY THAT
IT'S NOT CLEAR THAT MANY IN THE
FORM OF INCENTIVE PAYMENTS WILL
BE THE PRIMARY MOTIVATOR FOR
MANY REGIONAL CENTER AND
SERVICE PROVIDER EMPLOYEES.
THERE MAY BE OTHER WAYS TO
IMPROVE QUALITY. SUIT TO
IMPROVE THE QUALITY WORK OF
THOSE INDIVIDUALS- WITHOUT. AT
USING INCENTIVE PAYMENTS WE
HEARD FROM A NUMBER OF FOLKS
DURING THE PUBLIC COMMENT THAT.
YOU JUST. MAKING A DECENT WAGE
FOR EXAMPLE MIGHT BE ONE WAY TO
IMPROVE QUALITY. SO I WOULD
ALSO MENTION THAT FROM OUR
OFFICES INITIAL REVIEW OF THE
LITERATURE APPEARS MIXED ON
WHETHER PERFORMANCE INCENTIVE
PROGRAMS IN THE PUBLIC CONTEXT
ARE ALWAYS SUCCESSFUL THERE ARE
MANY WAYS THAT THEY CAN GO
WRONG. AND THE DESIGN OF THE
PROGRAM IS REALLY REALLY
IMPORTANT. FINALLY I WOULD NOTE
THAT THERE'S CURRENTLY NOT TOO
MUCH DETAIL ABOUT THE ACTUAL
PROPOSAL THAT THE DEPARTMENT
HAS PUT FORWARD AND TO AVOID
POTENTIAL PITFALLS THE DESIGN
AND THE ABILITY TO MAKE
CONTINUOUS IMPROVEMENTS TO THE
TO THE DESIGN OF THE PROGRAM
WILL BE PARAMOUNT AND THE
LEGISLATURE TO TIED TO PROCEED
AND APPROVED THIS PROPOSAL WE
WRECKED THEY REQUIRE MORE
DETAIL THE DEPARTMENT ABOUT
ENVISIONS THE PRO I'M ACTUALLY
WORKING ABOUT THE PLAN FOR
IMPLEMENTATION AND ABOUT HALF
BUT APART. WELL YOU A PROBLEM
IN SO MAKE PREVENTS ON LIVE
BASIS. THANK YOU NEXT WE WILL
HILL HERE FROM KATIE HORNBERGER.
HI THANK YOU UP SO I'M GETTING
REFER BURGER FROM DISABILITY
RIGHTS CALIFORNIA AND THE
DIRECTOR OF THE OFFICE OF
CLIENTS RATES ADVOCACY AND WE
PROVIDE SERVICES TO REGIONAL
CENTER CLIENTS THROUGH A
CONTRACT WITH THE DEPARTMENT.
AND OF YOUR WE ACTUALLY- OR-
REALLY SORT OF BELIEVE THAT
THERE ARE A LOT OF POSITIVE
ASPECTS TO THE PERFORMANCE
INCENTIVE PLAN AND- BUT WE ALL
SORT OF KNOW THE DEVIL'S IN THE
DETAILS AND DOES SO AND YOU
SAID NOT A LOT OF DETAILS TO
DATE. AND SO I THINK WE NEED TO
REALLY THINK ABOUT WHAT THOSE
DETAILS MIGHT BE AND I THINK
SOME OF THE MOST IMPORTANT
THINGS ON IT REALLY WANT OF
ROPE STE PERFORMANCE INCENTIVE
PROGRAM FOR THE RICH CENTERS WE
NEED TO THINK ABOUT FIRST THAT
THERE ARE SO. SYSTEM I PREFER
COMMENCEMENT THAT UP TO THE
REGION CENTERS AND THERE'S
DEPENDING ON MEASURE OF PROGRAM
CAN'T BE. IT WOULD HAVE TO ALL
TWENTY ONE REGIONAL CENTERS
THAT WOULD HAVE TO BE THAT THAT
ALL PARTICIPATE. ON THEY WOULD
HAVE TO BE HAVE PERFORMANCE
TARGETS ARE MEASURE. THEY WOULD
HAVE TO MOVE OUR SYSTEM FORWARD
AND NOT AND THEY WOULD ALSO
HAVE TO BE TRANSPARENT- I THINK
WE'VE HEARD A NUMBER OF TIMES
TODAY THAT ONE OF THE
DIFFICULTIES IN OUR SYSTEM AND
ONE THAT I WOULD AGREE WITH
THIS THAT WE OFTEN. THE
TRANSPARENCY IS LACKING IN IT'S
HARD SEE WHERE WE'VE MADE
IMPROVEMENTS. WE SHOULD BE ABLE
TO REALLY READ THESE HAVE A
COMMON UNDERSTANDING- WHEN I
READ IT I SHOULD KNOW WHAT'S
EXPECTED OF MY REGIONAL CENTER.
UP WE ALSO. HAVE AS NANCY SAID
THAT THE EXACT MEASUREMENT
SHOULD BE DIFFERENT FROM ONE
CENTER TO THE NEXT BECAUSE WE
DON'T WANT ONE CENTER TO COME
IN ALREADY MEETING THE GOAL.
AND ANOTHER REALLY HAVE IT BE
AN UNATTAINABLE GOAL. SO THE
EXACT MEASURE WOULD BE
DIFFERENT WITH DIFFERENT AND
THOSE DIFFERENCES WOULD BE
BASED ON- BASS LINES THAT ARE
CLEARLY ESTABLISHED AT THE
START OF THE PROGRAM. THIS
PROGRAM ALSO NEEDS TO BE BASED
ON WHAT I CONSIDER TO BE THE
CORE VALUES OF OUR PROGRAM-
WE'VE- HAVE REALLY ESTABLISHED
CORE VALUES WITHIN THE LAN
TURMAN ACT. ON IT OUT THINGS-
YOU KNOW ERIC SEGMENT TALKED
EARLIER ABOUT SOCIAL JUSTICE
AND THAT THIS REALLY IS A
PROGRAM. TO IMPROVE PEOPLE'S
LIVES AND FOR PEOPLE TO LIVE
EQUAL LIVES AND SO WHEN WE
THINK ABOUT THAT. LOOKING AT
BIG PICTURE TOPICS LIKE
EMPLOYMENT COMMUNITY
INTEGRATION REDUCTION OF
SERVICE DISPARITIES CHOICE. ON
AND OF COURSE BECAUSE IT IS
COMING H. CBS COMPLIANCE. UP
OUR RECOMMENDATION IS THAT WE
FOCUS ON MAYBE THREE OF THESE
IN THE FIRST TWO YEARS AND
PARTICULAR I'M AS THE PROGRAM
IS GETTING UP AND RUNNING AND
WE'RE LEARNING HOW TO- ASSESS
THE DATA. COULD EVEN PICK THREE
WHERE THE DATA IS MORE EASILY
OBTAINABLE FOR EXAMPLE H. CBS
COMPLIANCE WHERE WERE GATHERING
THAT DATA ANYWAY. ALL YOU KNOW
THE SAME MAY BE TRUE WITH-
COMPETITIVE INTEGRATED
EMPLOYMENT ON AND EVEN WITHIN
POS DISPARITIES AND I KNOW WE
HAVE A WHOLE SECTION LATER ON
THAT. UP BUT WE ALSO NEED TO
NOT O THIS IN A VACUUM IT HAS
TO BE PART OF A COORDINATED
INITIATIVE WITH ALL OF THE-
THINGS WERE GOING IN OUR SYSTEM.
TO BE EFFECTIVE. UP WE ALSO
WHEN WE THINK ABOUT ON THE DATA
AND I WAS GLAD TO HEAR YOU-
ASKING THAT THEY REALLY WORK ON
COMING UP WITH THAT AT DATA
SYSTEM BECAUSE I THINK
ESTABLISHING THAT THAT BASELINE
DATA IS GOING TO BE INTEGRAL TO
THE SUCCESS OF THIS PROGRAM. UP
AND THEN WE THINK ABOUT
REPORTING IT REALLY SHOULD BE
AN EASY TO UNDERSTAND WAY.
BECAUSE IF WE WANT TO
COMMUNICATE SUCCESS TO THE
PEOPLE RECEIVING THE SERVICES
THEY HAVE TO BE UNDERSTOOD.
UNDERSTAND WHAT THAT MEANS. UP
AND OF. PART OF THAT IS
DEVELOPING IT IN CONSULTATION
WITH STAKEHOLDERS- I WILL SAY I
WAS PLEASED TO SEE OVER THE
PAST COUPLE OF DAYS- THAT THE
DEPARTMENT IS CAN BE USING THE
SYSTEM IN FISCAL REFORM GROUP
AND THEN ALSO THE OVERSIGHT AND
TRANSPARENCY GROUP WITHIN THE-
DS TASK. FORCE TO THAT SOME OF
THESE IDEAS AND WAS EVEN MORE
PLEASED TO HEAR YOU SAY TODAY
THAT THERE WILL BE ACTUAL GOALS
TO RESPOND TO BECAUSE I THINK
SOMETIMES THESE LARGE TOPICS
ARE BROACHED AND PEOPLE DON'T
REALLY KNOW HOW TO RESPOND. BUT
IF YOU GIVE THEM SOMETHING
CONCRETE TO RESPOND TO YOU
ACTUALLY CAN HEAR WHAT
STAKEHOLDERS THANK. SO ONCE
AGAIN I'M WE APPRECIATE THAT
MINISTRATIONS EFFORTS AND THE
DEPARTMENT'S EFFORTS TO BRING
OUT COMES TO OUR SYSTEM- AS WE
THINK THAT THOSE ARE REALLY
VITAL TO OUR SUCCESS. THANK YOU.
NEXT WE HAVE ALISON MARIN'S. MY
NAME IS ALLISON RANTS- MY
FOURTEEN YEAR OLD SON MIKE A IS
A CLIENT OF SAN ANDREAS
REGIONAL CENTER AND I'M
SPEAKING ON THIS ISSUE AS A
BOARD MEMBER OF DISABILITY
VOICES UNITED SO WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT THE USE OF PERFORMANCE
INCENTIVES I'M ONE OF THE MOST
COMMON FRUSTRATIONS THAT WE
HEAR FROM FAMILIES AND SELF
ADVOCATES. IS IT REGIONAL
CENTERS DON'T PRIORITIZE
ACTIVITIES THAT IMPROVE THEIR
WELL BEING. INSTEAD WE OFTEN
HEAR THAT REGIONAL CENTERS
PRIOR TO HIS ACTIVITIES THAT
IMPROVE THE WELL BEING OF
REGIONAL CENTERS- BUT OF COURSE
THIS IS EXACTLY WHAT ONE WOULD
EXPECT FROM A SYSTEM THAT DOES
NOT COMPENSATE REGIONAL CENTERS
BASED ON HOW WELL THEY IMPROVE
OUTCOMES. FOR THE CONSUMERS
THEY SERVE. THE ONLY WAY TO
CHANGE THE STATUS QUO IS FOR
NEW FISCAL INCENTIVES TO BE
EXPLICITLY TIED TO CONSUMER
CENTERED PERFORMANCE MEASURES.
THAT BEING SAID. WE SHARE IT
DRC'S CONCERNS WITH THE TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE IS CURRENTLY
WRITTEN. FIRST WE FEEL THAT
MAKING PARTICIPATION VOLUNTARY
DEFEATS THE PURPOSE OF THE
PROGRAM AND IN FACT COULD EVEN
MAGNIFIED DISPARITIES BY
ALLOWING LOW PERFORMING
REGIONAL CENTERS. TO OPT OUT
AND ESSENTIALLY SETTLE FOR
MEDIOCRITY AND THOSE THAT DID
CHOOSE TO PARTICIPATE- THAT
WOULD MOST LIKELY CHOOSE THE
LOW HANGING FRUIT- SO WE THINK
CONSUMERS DESERVE MORE AND THE
PROGRAM MUST BE MANDATORY FOR
ALL REGIONAL CENTERS. A IN A
BIND SOME OF THE COMMENTS THE
GRAB BAG APPROACH TOWARDS GOAL
SETTING IN WHICH EACH REGIONAL
CENTER GETS TO PICK AND CHOOSE
WHICH GOALS THAT WANTS TO WORK
TOWARDS IS COUNTERPRODUCTIVE IF
YOU TAKE A LOOK AT REGIONAL
CENTERS ANNUAL PERFORMANCE
CONTRACTS IN YEAR AND REPORTS
ALL OF WHICH ARE ON DDS IS
WEBSITE THAT IS EXACTLY WHAT
YOU'LL FIND IT'S ESSENTIALLY A
HODGE PODGE OF BENCHMARKS THE
VERY TERM REGIONAL CENTER TO
REGIONAL CENTER SOMETIMES EVEN
FROM TWO YEAR AND OR NOT
CONSISTENTLY MEASURED OVER TIME
WE KNOW OF THIS APPROACH IS NOT
CONDUCIVE TO ACCOUNTABILITY.
PERFECT OUTCOMES MUST BUILD ON
CURRENT POLICY INITIATIVES
POINT PICKING UP AND YOUR SEATS
COMMENTS AND MUST BE UNIFORM
ACROSS THE SYSTEM NOW TO BE
CLEAR AND THIS PICKS UP A
DOCTOR BARGES COMMENTS
DIFFERENT REGIONAL CENTER NOT
ALL DECIDE TO MOVE FORWARD IN
THE SAME WAY EVEN THOUGH IT BE
WORKING TOWARDS THE SAME GOAL
FOR EXAMPLE ONE REGIONAL CENTER
MAY DECIDE TO IMPROVE
COMPETITOR GRATED POINT. I HAVE
DURING ADICIONAL IN HOUSE
EMPLOYMENT SPECIALIST ANOTHER
MAY PARTNER WITH CA BASED
ORGANIZATION OR LOCAL
BUSINESSES WE ARE ALL IN A VERY
SERVICE VERY FACT I THINK THE
THING WE WANT ENCOURAGE THAT
KIND OF IN A- HOWEVER. WE DON'T
CENTERS THESE. FOR THE SAME SET
OF GOALS AND THEY SHOULD BE
MEASURED IN THE SAME WAYS AND I
REALLY CAN'T UNDERSCORE ENOUGH
THE IMPORTANCE OF THE DATA
COLLECTION ISSUES THAT I'M NOT
GOING TO. YOU KNOW SAY IT
AGAIN. BUT YOU KNOW THE ENTIRE
IDEAS ESSENTIALLY A NON STARTER
AND LESS WE CAN AT LEAST TO
FIND A SET OF METRICS WE REALLY
BELIEVE WE UNDERSTAND ARE
TRANSPARENT. YOU KNOW I WANT TO
ECHO ALL THOSE COMMENTS BUT WE
ALSO AGREE WITH SEVERAL OF THE
CONCERNS EXPRESSED BY ALEJO. ON
FIRST AND THIS IS A- HAS TO DO
WITH THE DATA COLLECTION SYSTEM
OUTCOMES HAVE TO BE MEASURED
WITH CLEAR OBSERVABLE MEANT
METRICS. BUT WE THINK IT'S
BETTER TO PRIORITIZE ONE OR TWO
REALLY RELIABLE BENCHMARKS THIS
YEAR. THAN TO POSTPONE ALL
ACCOUNTABILITY MEASURES UNTIL
THE SYSTEM IS FULLY FUNDED.
AFTER ALL THAT DAY MAY NEVER
COME. SO WE BELIEVE WE SHOULD
START SMALL AND BUILD FROM
THERE. SECONDLY THE REGIONAL IT
REGIONAL CENTER STAFF WHOSE
BEHAVIOR MOST DIRECTLY AFFECTS
OUTCOMES ARE THE ONES WHO NEED
TO BE INCENTIVIZE. THAT WAS ONE
OF THE THEMES THAT ELLIE-
PICKED UP FROM THE RAND STUDY
ON KIND OF WHAT HOW WITH THE
PROGRAMS THAT WORK IN THOSE
THAT DON'T. AGAIN WE COULDN'T
AGREE MORE WITH THAT. SO FOR
EXAMPLE WE WOULD NOT SUPPORT
REWARDING EXECUTIVE MANAGEMENT
TEAMS OF REGIONAL CENTERS THE
REWARDS NEED TO GO TO THE
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE DOING THE
HANDS ON WORK ESPECIALLY
COORDINATORS BECAUSE THAT'S
WHERE THE RUBBER MEETS THE ROAD.
WE BELIEVE THESE CONCERNS CAN
AND SHOULD BE ADDRESSED THROUGH
A STAKEHOLDER PROCESS. SO WE
LOOK FORWARD TO COLLABORATING
WITH OTHER ORGANIZATIONS TO
DEVELOP A MEANINGFUL
PERFORMANCE INCENTIVE PLAN.
THAT MOVES THE SYSTEM FORWARD
TOWARDS ACCOUNTABILITY AND THE
CONVEYS TO CONSUMERS AND
FAMILIES THAT THE OUTCOMES THAT
MATTER TO THEM. ARE THE
OUTCOMES THAT REGIONAL CENTERS
WILL BE REWARDED FOR HELPING TO
BRING ABOUT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU AND I MAY I ASK IF WE CAN
HAVE SOME ROOM FOR IN THE WEST
WING. PLEASE. WE WILL FOLLOW
HER WITH PUBLIC COMMENTERS SO
IF YOU HAVE PUBLIC COMMENT WITH
ISSUE THREE PREPARED COME UP
SAN. GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
AMY WESTLING I'M THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE ASSOCIATION OF
REGIONAL CENTER AGENCIES AND I
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PROVIDE. SOME COMMENTS ON THIS
PROPOSAL. AS WE'VE HEARD THE
GOALS OF CALIFORNIANS REGIONAL
CENTER SYSTEM OVER THE LAST
FIFTY YEARS WORD TO SERVE
PEOPLE WITH DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES IN COMMUNITY
SETTINGS. AND TO KEEP FAMILIES
TOGETHER WE HAVE MODIFIED
THOSE OVER TIME AND THINK OF IT
IS HELPING YOUNG CHILDREN MAKE
DEVELOPMENTAL PROGRESS
SUPPORTING FAMILIES TO MAINTAIN
THEIR CHILDREN AT HOME AND
PROMOTING THE INDEPENDENCE OF
ADULTS. AND IN THAT ROOM WE ARE
STRIVING FOR BIGGER GOALS THAN
WE EVER IMAGINE FIFTY YEARS AGO
WE'RE LOOKING AT EMPLOYMENT
HOUSING TRANSPORTATION. AND THE
FUNDAMENTAL MOVEMENT OF PEOPLE
FROM INSTITUTIONS TO
SEGREGATION TO IMMIGRATION AND
FINALLY TO THE ULTIMATE GOAL OF
INCLUSION. RECENTLY AS THE
SYSTEM WAS MOVING TOWARDS A
WORLD AFTER DEVELOPMENTAL
CENTERS WE STARTED IMPLEMENTING
SEVERAL POLICIES IN OUR WORLD
WITH KIND OF A COMMON THEME TO
THEM BUT THESE EFFORTS HAVEN'T
BEEN FULLY ALIGNED. SO WE HAVE
THE COMMUNITY RESOURCE
DEVELOPMENT PROGRAM WHICH
PROVIDES FUNDING SO THAT
REGIONAL CENTERS CAN WORK WITH
COMMUNITY PARTNERS TO DEVELOP
NEEDED SERVICES IN THEIR AREA.
WE HAVE THE HOME AND COMMUNITY
BASED SERVICES TRANSITION
GRANTS WHICH HELP MOVE SERVICES
GROUP CLOSER TO- COMPLIANCE
WITH FEDERAL STANDARDS AROUND
INTEGRATION. WE HAVE THE PAID
INTERNSHIP PROGRAM THE
COMMUNITY- THE C. I. A.
INCENTIVE PROGRAM AND THE
DISPARITY GRANTS PROGRAMS SO
ALL OF THESE THINGS ARE
OPERATING IN THE SAME SPACE
WITHOUT A COMMON THREAD. SO
WHERE DO WE GO FROM HERE AS
WE'VE HEARD FROM THE ADVOCATES
AS WELL AS FROM THE DEPARTMENT
AS WELL AS FROM THE LA JOH THE
FIRST STEP IS REALLY TO.
CLEARLY IDENTIFY LONG TERM
GOALS AND THOSE GOALS NEED TO
BE IN THE AREAS OF QUALITY
ACCESS AND UTILIZATION ENSURING
EQUITY. RECOGNIZING THE VALUE
OF CARE COORDINATION. PERSON
CENTERED PLANNING AND
INTEGRATION. A SECOND WE NEED
TO COME TO AGREEMENT ON THE
SYSTEMIC MEASUREMENT OF
OUTCOMES NOT JUST FOR REGIONAL
CENTERS BUT FOR THE SYSTEM AS A
WHOLE WE HAVE LOTS OF TOOLS AT
OUR DISPOSAL AND WE NEED TO
LOOK AT THERE ARE THE NATIONAL
CORE INDICATORS THE RIGHT
ANSWER THE CEDAR WHICH IS A
SYSTEM THAT WE USE HERE IN
CALIFORNIA OR THEIR DATA
ELEMENTS THAT WE AREN'T
COLLECTING AT. THIRD AS HAS
BEEN DISCUSSED AT SOME LENGTH
ALREADY TODAY WE NEED TO COME
TO AGREEMENT ON HOW TO
CAPTURING COLLECT THAT DATA AND
ANALYZE IT. AND FINALLY WE NEED
TO DO WITH THE SYSTEM DOES BEST.
WE NEED TO INNOVATE AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL LEVEL EVALUATE THE
EFFECTIVENESS OF OUR EFFORTS.
AND CONTINUE TO REFINE THEM
OVER TIME. IN SHORT OUR SYSTEM
IS DOING A LOT OF GOOD WORK NOW
THAT PEOPLE RELY UPON. WHICH IS
IN NEED OF STABILIZATION AS WE
HEARD IN THE LAST PANEL. WE
NEED STABILIZATION IN THE REALM
OF SERVICE COORDINATION AND
PROVIDER SUFFICIENCY AND MISS
PATRICK NOTED THIS IN HER
COMMENTS A LITTLE BIT EARLIER
AS WELL. BUT WE CAN'T THINK
ABOUT THIS MOMENT IN TIME AS AN
EITHER OR PROPOSITION WE MUST
WE MUST BOTH SUPPORT THE
CRITICAL WORK OF TODAY BUT
ALSO. LOOK AT SETTING A COURSE
FOR THE FUTURE OF THE SYSTEM
AND SUPPORTING IT TO MEET THE
DYNAMIC AND MERGING NEEDS
BEFORE US. THE PROPOSED
PERFORMANCE INCENTIVE PROGRAM
PRESENTS US WITH AN OPPORTUNITY
TO ENHANCE SERVICES FOR PEOPLE
WITH DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES
AS WE COLLECTIVELY IDENTIFY
WHERE WE WANT TO GO IN THE NEXT
FIVE TEN AND EVEN FIFTY YEARS
WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
THE ADMINISTRATION AND
STAKEHOLDERS AS THIS PROGRAM
TAKE SHAPE. THANK YOU MA'AM WE
WILL NOW TAKE PUBLIC COMMENT ON
ISSUE THREE. SIX PEOPLE. HELLO
I'M I'M KAREN COLE I LIVE IN
REDONDO BEACH- A MY SON DIDN'T
WANT TO COME WITH ME HIS NAME
IS MAGNUS AND HE'S FIFTEEN- HE
THOUGHT IT BE BORING BUT I
BROUGHT HIS PICTURE INSTEAD. WE
HAVE A REALLY FUN LIFE- BUT I
WANT TO SAY ABOUT THE BOUT THE
REGIONAL CENTER THAT WE BELONG
TO HELP REGIONAL CENTER. REALLY
DOESN'T HAVE A GREAT IMPACT IN
OUR LIFE A TOLL AND WHEN I TALK
TO PEOPLE IN OTHER PARTS OF
CALIFORNIA I REALIZE THAT
THAT'S NOT TRUE FOR EVERYBODY.
I WENT ONLINE TO ALL OF THE
DIFFERENT REGIONAL CENTERS TO
THAT DISPARITY- TO A DATA IS
POSTED ONLINE. AND I PLUGGED IN
THE LONG GRASS AND I CAN SEE
THAT WITH THE SECOND BOTTOM THE
SPENDING ON CHILDREN. AS THREE
TO TWELVE AND THE BOTTOM FOR
SPENDING ON A ZERO TO SAY THE
REGIONAL CENTER. BUT WE HAVE TO
BE WITH DOESN'T SPEND VERY MUCH
MONEY ON CHILDREN A TOLL- THEY
DO BEST FOR ADULTS A LEAVE THIS
FOR YOU IF YOU WANT. SO WHEN I
TALK TO OTHER PARENTS IN THE IN
THE AREA THEY- TELL ME I DON'T
REALLY HAVE MUCH TO DO WITH THE
REGIONAL CENTER- WHEN I ASK
THEM ABOUT. ADVOCATING FOR
FUNDING FOR THE REGIONAL CENTER
THEY SAY WELL THEY DON'T REALLY
DO ANYTHING FOR US I'VE I'VE
GIVEN UP ON THE REGIONAL CENTER
IT'S TOO HARD WE HAVE TO GO TO
FAT HEARING TO GET ANYTHING
FROM THEM. IS WHAT THEY SAY-
THE SERVICES WE GET. ARE EITHER
THE WRONG SERVICES ALL OF THAT
USELESS FOR EXAMPLE REST BY THE
SERVICE MOST PEOPLE DO GET. AT
A REST BY IS JUST UP AND ON
TRACK- THEY HAVE US CPR
CERTIFICATE. UP THE RUN TRYING
THE NOT IN DEALING WITH PEOPLE
WITH THE- BILL ITSELF. AND THAT
THE ROCK BECAUSE THIS IS TO
YOUR HOUSE. HI OUT NOT. YOUR
MINIMUM WAGE ISSUE WHERE I LIVE.
A REGULAR BABY SO. PROFESSIONAL
BABY SITTER COST TWENTY TO
TWENTY FIVE DOLLARS AND THAT'S
NOT WAT THEY PAY THE REST BY
WORKERS. SO IT'S ALMOST
IMPOSSIBLE TO GET ONE YOU CALL
THE SERVICE THEY CALL IN THE
MORNING AND SAY SORRY WE
COUNSEL WE COULDN'T GET AND-
THE- A WELCOME. WELL YOU CAN
PROVIDE YOUR OWN RIGHT I WORK
AT I CAN'T FIND ONE- BUT THE-
THING IS IT LONG. THIS IS GOING
TO BE IN THE HOME I WANT MY
FACE YEAR OLD. YEAH THE BEACH
AT THE CORE OF THE ME WITH HIS
FOR. AND I CAN'T DO THAT WITH
REST THANKS PARTLY THE REGIONAL
SERVICES WE CAN'T DO THAT- I
ASKED THEM. TO HAVE SOMEONE
TAKE MY AND TO SCOUT SO THEY
DIDN'T HAVE TO HAVE IS MOM
WITH HIM NO FIFTY YEAR OLD BOY
WANTS THEM MOM WITH THEM THAT
SCOUTS RIGHT. IT REALLY IS NOT
A GOOD THING FOR A SOCIAL
SKILLS THEY SAID OH NO BECAUSE
IT WOULD JUST BE IMPRESSED BUT
WORKER. UNTRAINED WON'T DO THEM
ANY GOOD. SEND THEM IN TO
SOCIALS. THAT WAS TO YEARS AGO
STILL HAVEN'T FOUND THE SOCIAL
SKILLS PROGRAM HE CAN JOIN
WE'VE BEEN TO THREE INTERVIEWS
BUT APPARENTLY HE CAUGHT THE
SOCIAL SKILLS CLASS. IF YOU
COME FILL OUT A QUESTIONNAIRE
BY HIMSELF. I ACTUALLY DO YOU
KNOW WHAT HE'S GOT A
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITY. THAT
MAKES IT DIFFICULT FOR HIM TO
FILL OUT THE QUESTIONNAIRE BY
HIMSELF. SO IS THE WRONG
SERVICES AND IT'S- AND THAT
NOBODY IS TAKING ANY ACCOUNT.
OF WHETHER THEY HAPPEN. OF
WHETHER THEY GOOD WHAT THE
QUALITY IS OR WHAT THE OUT COME
FROM MY SON OR ANY OF THE OTHER
CHILDREN IN HARPER. REGION IS
WHAT WHY SHE HAPPENS TO THEM-
BEHAVIOR SERVICES WE'VE HAD
GOOD WE'VE HAD BAD. BUT NOW IT
ALL HAS TO BE AN INSURANCE AND
NOBODY THE REGIONAL CENTER CAN
HELP ME. FIND A NEW PROVIDE A
BECAUSE MY OLD BEHAVIOR
PROVIDED THAT THE REGIONAL
SANTEE USED TO. PAY FOR DOESN'T
INSURANCE SHE THINKS THAT'S TOO
HARD WORK I THINK IT'S TOO HARD
TO. AND NOT BE THE BEACH CENTER
CAN HELP ME WITH DEALING WITH
INSURANCEAND SEE IS A GREAT
IDEA. HOWEVER HAVE INSURANCE
PAY FOR EVERYTHING BUT WE NEED
HELP TO DEAL WITH THE INSURANCE
COMPANIES. THAT'S WHAT I THINK
YOU NEED TO HAVE SOME MEN OTHER
THAN THE ONE I JUST GAVE YOU
WHICH IS. HOW MUCH MONEY. THREE
SENTENCE MEANS WHICH IS HUGE.
BETWEEN THE DIFFERENT REGIONAL
IS FOR NO REASON THE TOLL. AND
THEY NEED TO HAVE A HAVE SOME
WAY TO MEASURE. WHETHER IS THAT
SHE DOING ANYTHING. FOR JUST
HAVING NOT FANCY OFFICE THANK
YOU. YOU. THANK YOU FOR SHARING
COMMITTEE MEMBERS AREA OTHERS
WITH THIS COUNTS ON THE- THIS.
THE QUEST OF. WHAT DO WE
MEASURE TO MAKE SURE THE LIVES
OF PEOPLE WHO ARE SERVED BY THE
SYSTEM ARE IMPROVED BY THE
INVESTMENTS THAT YOU IN THE
LEGISLATION GOVERNOR PUT IN THE
SYSTEM. IS A QUESTION IT CAME
FOR THE COUNCIL LAST YEAR AFTER
SEEING THE RATE STUDY ONE POINT
EIGHT BILLION DOLLARS IS A BIG
NUMBER- IT'S A HEAVY LIFT AND
THE QUESTION THE COUNCIL ASKED
IS. WE BELIEVE THAT WILL RESULT
IN BETTER OUTCOMES BUT HOW DO
WE KNOW PEOPLE'S LIVES WILL BE
IMPROVED. THE COUNCIL ISSUED A
GRANT TO. ANSWER THIS QUESTION-
IT WAS AWARDED TO THE
CALIFORNIA SUPPORTED LIVING
NETWORK AND WHAT'S EXCITING
ABOUT THIS CONVERSATION SOUNDS
ARE THERE MANY PEOPLE WERE
TALKING ABOUT THE SAME THINGS
HOW DO WE MAKE SURE THE SYSTEM
IS PERFORMING. THE WAY IT'S
DESIGNED IN THE WAY IT'S
INTENDED TO WHICH IS TO SUPPORT
PEOPLE OF INTELLECTUAL
DEVELOPMENT DISABILITIES- WHAT
DO A MEASURE. OF THE REGIONAL
CENTER COMES IS A PROVIDER ARE
COMES FROM THE COUNCIL'S
RESPECTIVE IT EXPERIENCE OF
BEING SIR THIS IS. AS WEIGHING
OUT DID PROPOSE ON HOW TO
ANSWER THAT QUESTION IN. THE
RIGHT MEASURES TO LOOK AT I
WANNA MAKE SURE THAT YOU KNOW
THAT THERE'S ALSO A COMMUNITY
EFFORT UNDER WAY. TO PROVIDE-
THE LEGISLATURE AND
ADMINISTRATION- WITH OUR VIEW
ON WHAT THOSE MEASURES WHAT
SHOULD BE MEASURED- BATTLED
IT'S BEING DONE BY. A GROUP F
PEOPLE WITH INTELLECTUAL
DEVELOPING DISABILITIES WITH
FAMILY MEMBERS AND WITH
PROVIDERS IN CONJUNCTION-
TOGETHER AND WILL BE AVAILABLE
LATER THIS YEAR. THANK YOU SIR.
MARK MELISSA FROM CALIFORNIA
SAID PUT IT LIVING NETWORK
RECIPIENT OF THE GRANT FROM
STATE COUNSELING DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES. WE HAVE ASSEMBLED
ARE ADVISORY GROUP TO REALLY
TAKE A LOOK AT WHAT MEASURABLE
OUTCOMES OF SERVICE SERVICES
MIGHT BE- HOW TRAINING MIGHT
LOOK LIKE FOR DIRECT SUPPORT
PROFESSIONALS TO HELP ACHIEVE
THOSE. OUTCOMES AND HOW TO
COLLECT AND REPORT THAT DATA
BACK TO YOU FOLKS- SO WE'VE- WE
WE'VE ALREADY STARTED THE
ADVISORY GROUP WE LOOK FORWARD
TO FINISHING UP. QUICKLY TO-
WORK REALLY HARD ON ON ON
DEFINING WHAT THOSE SERVICE-
COMES MIGHT LOOK LIKE- AND-
MOVE FORWARD WITH THE WITH THE
PROJECT THAT WE HAVE FROM STATE
COUNCIL BUT WE'RE HEARING THAT
OUTCOMES AND MEASURE BILLS AND-
IT'S A VERY. COMMON THEME SO WE
FEEL LIKE IT'S A THREE TIME. ON
A ISSUE- AND YOU'RE GONNA HEAR
MORE ON ISSUE SIX ABOUT FACE TO
WITH THIS PROJECT- SO THANK
YOU. THANK YOU SIR. WELL MISTER
CHAIR MEMBER JORDAN LENDS
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE OUR
COMMUNITY POLLS IN CALIFORNIA
COLLABORATION. IMPROVING
QUALITY IS WHAT EVERY BODY
WANTS. NO QUESTION THERE. ARE
AND WE CAN GET A THREE LEGGED
HORSE TO RUN A LITTLE BIT
FASTER. BUT I WOULD RATHER
PRIORITIZE THE MAJORITY NOT
NEGLECTING TO COMPLETELY BUT
MAJORITY OF OUR FOCUS AND
RESOURCES. ON GETTING A FOR
LIKE A HORSE. CALIFORNIANS WITH
INTELLECTUAL DEVELOP
DISABILITIES IN THEIR FAMILIES.
AND THEIR SERVICES AND SUPPORTS
ARE ON THREE LEGS RIGHT NOW. AS
WE HEARD FROM THE FIRST BECAUSE
THE MOTHER WHEN YOU'RE RESPITE
PROVIDER. WHEN YOUR REST WORK
IT DOESN'T SHOW UP WHICH
HAPPENS. EVERY DAY TO THOUSANDS
OF FAMILIES BECAUSE THEY QUIT
OR WE CAN'T HIRE ENOUGH. THAT'S
THE CRISIS THAT'S WHAT WE NEED
TO FIX. AND WHEN GOVERNOR
NEWSOME INCLUDED A SIZEABLE
BUDGET ITEM FOR A RATHER
NEBULOUS PERFORMANCE INCENTIVE
ITEM. AND NOTHING TO ADDRESS
THE MEDIA CRISIS. IT WAS FELT
LIKE THE COMMUNITY AND THE
REALITY. WASN'T BEING HEARD. MY
CONCERN MORE THAN ANYTHING IS
THAT THE NARRATIVE AND THE
CONVERSATION IS MOVING TOWARDS
AND IS SOLELY BEING CONSUMED BY
THIS IDEA PERFORMANCE INCENTIVE
INSTEAD OF ADDRESSING THE ONE
POINT FOUR BILLION DOLLAR UNDER
FUNDING AND THEN THE DEVELOPER
SERVICES TASK FORCE REPORT
THAT'LL BE THAT THE PRIORITY
AND IT'S IT IN IT'S IMPORTANT
TOPIC BUT WE CANNOT NEGLECT THE
CRISIS IN THE MEETING NEED
HAPPY RIGHT NOW MISTER
FRASIER'S PLAN WITH WHICH WE
HOPE TO SHARE WITH YOU VERY
SOON. WILL INCLUDE ITEMS OF
INCENTIVES AND DATA GATHERING
AND WE'RE EXCITED TO SHARE THAT
WITH YOU BUT IT DOESN'T LOSE
SIGHT OF THE BIGGER ISSUE AT
HAND THANK YOU. THANK YOU SIR.
MY NAME IS BONNIE GAIL AND I'M
IN THE PARENT OF A CHILD WHO IS
A REGIONAL CENTER CLIENTS I'M
HERE REPRESENTING EDUCATE
ADVOCATE AS STATEWIDE
GRASSROOTS ORGAN ORGANIZATION
AND WE SERVE FAMILIES WITH
CHILDREN WITH SPECIAL NEEDS I'M
HERE TO SHARE STORY THAT IS
RELEVANT TO ISSUE THREE THIS
INVOLVES A DENIAL OF A REQUEST
OF WHITE FOR WIPES FOR A FAMILY
THAT WE SIR WHAT WAS WRITTEN
FROM THE REGIONAL CENTER DOES
NOT ON. THE DIGNITY OF THE
PERSON THAT WE PURPORT THAT YOU
PURPORT TO SERVE THEY WROTE
PERSONAL CLEANSING WIPES ARE A
CONVENIENCE ITEM AND REPLACE
EITHER THE NEED TO LAUNDER A
WASH CLOTH OR WHAT A PAPER
TOWEL OR SIMILAR ITEM TO
CLEANSE A PERSON. ONE OF THE
GOALS OF THIS ITEM AS DESCRIBED
IS DESCRIBED AS TO DEVELOPING
SERVICES THAT MEET CONSUMER
NEEDS IN A PERSON CENTERED WAY
THIS POLICY DOES NOT ADDRESS
THE PERSON AS A PERSON AT ALL.
IT DOES NOT HONOR THEIR DIGNITY
WHAT A PARENT OF A BABY BE
ASKED TO YOU. TO WIPE THEIR
BABY WITH A PAPER TOWEL OR
WASHCLOTH. LET ALONE THAT THIS
REQUEST INVOLVES A YOUNG ADULT.
UNDER THE ADVOCACY FEEDBACK ON
THIS ITEM IT IS LISTED TO
DETERMINE IF SERVICES ARE BEING
DELIVERED IN A WAY THAT REDUCED
RACIAL OR ETHNIC DISPARITIES
ACROSS THE DEVELOPMENTAL
SERVICES SYSTEM. ONE OF THE
THINGS TO ALSO CONSIDER IS IF
THE SERVICES ARE BEING
DELIVERED DIRECT DIFFERENTLY
ACROSS REGIONAL CENTERS PERIOD
THERE ARE REGIONAL CENTER
CLIENTS. IN REGIONAL CENTERS
THAT HAVE NO ISSUE GETTING A
SERVICE LIKE WIPES AND
OBVIOUSLY THERE ARE OTHERS THAT
DOWNS WE HOPE YOU'LL CONSIDER
THIS PERSONAL NARRATIVE AS YOU
DELIBERATE THE NEXT STEPS AND
REMEMBER THAT WE VALUE THE
HONOR AND DIGNITY OF THE PERSON
THAT WE ULTIMATELY ADDRESS HERE.
JAMIE DAVIS EXECUTIVE MARIN BUT
DIRECTOR FOR MORE ADVENTURES IN
CENTER FELL- THE MICROPHONE
SEEM SHORT SO I HOPE EVERYONE
CAN HEAR ME HER I'M SHORT. I
CAME HERE BEFORE SPEAKING IN
SUPPORT OF MY- EMPLOYEES. ON AN
EARLIER ISSUE THE REASON I CARE
SO MUCH ABOUT MY EMPLOYEES IS I
CARE SO MUCH ABOUT THE PEOPLE
WE SERVE. SOME OF THEM I'VE
KNOWN MY ENTIRE CAREER IN THE
FIELD I'VE KNOWN THEIR FAMILIES
I COULD DO A LITTLE FAMILY TREE
CHART FOR USE FOR SOME OF THEIR
FAMILIES. THAT'S HOW WELL I
KNOW THEM. AND I CARE ABOUT
THEM AS IF THEY WERE MY OWN
FAMILY. I DON'T UNDERSTAND HOW
PERFORMANCE INDICATORS ARE
GOING TO IMPROVE THEIR LIVES IT
FEELS LIKE WE'RE STARTING IN
THE MIDDLE. AND I'M IN SUPPORT
OF THE LA OWES REPORT THAT
SAYS. WE'RE STARTING IN THE
MIDDLE OF SENSUALLY WE DON'T
HAVE THE MEANS. TO GET TO THESE
OUTCOMES. ONE OF THE ISSUES I
FACE IS I CANNOT AFFORD TO
INNOVATE. I CANNOT PARTICIPATE
IN THE C. I. E. OR PIPP
PROGRAMS MEANT TO INCENTIVIZE
US TO INNOVATE. I MANAGED TO
GET AN H. C. B. S. GRANT WHICH
I FOUND TO BE A BURDEN IN THE
ADMINISTRATIVE SIDE. AND A BIG
PAIN IN THE **** FRANKLY SORRY.
I'M GLAD WE GOT IT AND IT HAS
HELPED US BUT- YOU KNOW I
DIDN'T REALIZE IT WOULD BE SUCH
ADMINISTRATIVE BURDEN AND I
DON'T REALLY HAVE THE
ADMINISTRATION TO YOU KNOW
TRACK ALL THIS THESE THINGS AND
SO IT'S ACTUALLY. WELL IT HAS
IMPROVED OUR CULTURE TO BE MORE
PERSON CENTERED AND I'M GLAD WE
GOT IT AND I'M GLAD IT WAS
AVAILABLE I DON'T THINK WE'LL
APPLY FOR ANOTHER ONE. AND LIKE
WAYS WITH PIPPEN C. I. E. AND
ANY OTHER ENHANCEMENTS TO OUR
PROGRAM WE CAN'T AFFORD TO DO
THAT. BECAUSE ALL OF OUR MONEY
IS GOING TO PAY FOR OUR STAFF
TO GET GOOD STAFF. TO WORK WITH
OUR CLIENTS THANK YOU. HELLO MY
NAME IS THERE WE GO. MY NAME IS
KEVIN ROUTE FROM MANOS AND I'M
ALSO WORKING WITH C. ESALEN
ESPECIALLY ON THE- A PROJECT
THAT. THAT COUNSEL JUST
MENTIONED. I WANNA MAKE JUST
ONE POINT. FOR TALKING ABOUT
OPERATIONAL DEFINITIONS FOR
CASE MANAGEMENT THAT IS GOING
TO BE A HOUSE BUILT ON SAND. IF
WE DO NOT HAVE OPERATIONAL
DEFINITIONS FOR SERVICE
DELIVERY OUTCOMES. A CASE
MANAGER AND NOT PROPERLY
EXECUTE THEIR RESPONSIBILITIES
IF THEY DON'T KNOW WHAT
SERVICES DO WHAT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. I AM JUDY MARK I AM A
PARENT OF A TWENTY THRILLED
WITH AUTISM I'M FROM LOS
ANGELES- I STANDING HERE TOO I
AM ALSO THE PRESIDENT OF
DISABILITY VOICES UNITED IN AND
ISTRONGLY SUPPORT THE IDEA OF
PERFORMANCE INCENTIVES. THIS
SYSTEM CURRENTLY IS NOT WORKING
IT'S NOT WORKING FOR A WHOLE
LOT OF PEOPLE THERE ARE I AM
THE RECIPIENT OF MANY EMAILS.
AND MANY PHONE CALLS AND MANY
STORIES FOR PARENTS TO TELL ME
THAT THEY ARE NOT RESPECTED BY
REGIONAL CENTER STAFF THEY'RE
NOT RESPECTED BY SERVICE
PROVIDERS THEY FEEL INTIMIDATED
WHEN THEY COMPLAINED. I'M AND
WE HAVE TO CHANGE THAT AND WE
CAN ONLY CHANGE THAT BY
INCENTIVIZING GOOD BEHAVIOR WE
HAVE TO JUST LIKE WE DO WITH
CLIENTS WERE YOU WE INCENTIVIZE
GOOD BEHAVIOR BY GIVING THEM
AWARDS WE NEED TO REWARD. THOSE
GOOD PROVIDERS AND WE NEED TO
REWARD GOOD STAFF AT REGIONAL
CENTERS AND WE AND WE CAN ONLY
DO THAT THROUGH A PROGRAM LIKE
THIS WE CAN'T CONTINUE TO
INVEST IN A SYSTEM. BY GIVING
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS AND NOT
EXPECTING ANYTHING IN RETURN.
THAT'S NOT THE WAY THE WORLD
WORKS AND THIS IS NOT PERFECT
WE KNOW THIS IS NOT PERFECT AND
WE CAN WORK ON CAN MAY I SIT ON
THE COMMITTEE TO TRY TO HELP
IMPROVE IT. AND I THINK THERE'S
ENOUGH STAKEHOLDERS TO HELP
MAKE IT BETTER. BUT FOR US TO
ABANDON THE IDEA OF
INCENTIVIZING GOOD WORK BY
REGIONAL CENTERS MAKES NO SENSE
AND I REALLY STRONGLY HOPE THEY
THAT YOU WILL SUPPORT THIS
MEASURE THANK YOU. WE'LL
SANFORD- COMMUNICANTS HOLDS AS
FOLLOWS INTERESTING THINGS
ABOUT OUTCOMES WE NEED OUT
COMES AT THE STATE CAN LOOK AND
SAY WE'VE BEEN SUCCESSFUL.
THERE'S OUTCOMES OF THE LANHAM
ACT TALKS ABOUT FOR EVERY
INDIVIDUAL ALL THREE HUNDRED
EIGHTY THOUSAND OF THEM WILL
SERVE NEXT YEAR. WHAT'S
IMPORTANT TO THEM IN THEIR LIFE
THOSE TWO MEASUREMENTS ARE NOT
OFTEN GOING TO BE THE SAME AND
SO WE HAVE TO BE CAREFUL AND
THAT. REALLY APPLY THE YOU KNOW
BECAUSE OF FROM D. R. C. AND
LA- AS IT IS THE LIMITED AT THE
STATE LEVEL WE SHOULD MADE
MAYBE MEASURE FIVE THINGS. IN
MEASURE THEM READ THE READ THE
WELL. ON THE OUTCOME LEVEL FOR
THE INDIVIDUALS WE CLEARLY HAVE
TO FIND A WAY TO IMPROVE STOP.
VERY SMART EDS IMPORT IS
RETIRED A NUMBER OF YEARS TOLD
ME. YOU CAN NOT IN CENTS. A
YEAR. AS MUCH AS LIKE. TO
CHANGES THAT WAY NOT WHAT
HAPPENS. YOU CAN REWARD THINGS
YOU CAN MAKE THINGS HAPPEN BUT
AT SOME POINT YOU HAVE TO SEE
AT THE END THE DAY AFTER GO ON
DO IT. FORMER ASSEMBLYMEMBER IF
SAID TO ME ALSO. POINT YOU
DON'T. LOG BY WAYNE IT MORE
OFTEN. SO INCREASING THIS YEAR
NUMBER OF VOLUME OF
MEASUREMENTS IS GOING IMPROVE
IT. CA IS A GREAT EXAMPLE. WE
SHOULD BE CELEBRATING. TODAY
THERE ARE TWENTY SIX HUNDRED
PEOPLE IN COMPETITOR
EMPLOYMENT. OVER THE LAST THREE
YEARS. THAT'S THE BASE IS A 50%
INCREASE. IT'S NOT TALKED
ABOUT. IT'S ALMOST HIDDEN DATA.
WE'VE DONE THAT IT'S BEEN A
GREAT PROGRAM IS A GREAT
INCENTIVE. WE DON'T CELEBRATE
THAT SO IF WE DON'T CELEBRATED
MAKE A BIG DEAL OF IT. PEOPLE
NOT TO UNDERSTAND IT MAKES DE.
AND USE IT. THE OTHER ONE IS A
BUREAUCRACY WE ACTUALLY MORE
PEOPLE EMPLOYED. BUT THE
REQUIREMENT THE DATA
REQUIREMENTS TO GET THE
PAYMENT. FOR TEN OR FIFTEEN
ITEMS OF PEOPLE HAVE CONTROL
OVER. THEY CAN'T DO IT SO MAKE
IT AS SIMPLE AS POSSIBLE KEEP
IT SIMPLE YOU WANT TO BE
TRANSPARENT. THREE TO FIVE
ITEMS. AS MANY MORE THAN THAT
NO ONE WILL FOLLOW. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SIR. GOOD EVENING
ALMOST A VERY GOOD ANY
CALIFORNIA DISABILITY SERVICES
ASSOCIATION YOU KNOW WE HAVEN'T
REALLY QUITE SEEN ENOUGH TO-
SAY WHAT THIS PROGRAM
ULTIMATELY YIELD IN TERMS OF
PERFORMANCE OUTCOMES TO FORMED
AN OPINION BUT I DID WANT TO
RECOGNIZE THAT THE- LA DOES
WORK ON THIS AND SAYING THAT
UNTIL WE PROVIDE A STRUCTURE.
HAVE A HAVING MEASURING
OUTCOMES IS GOING TO BE
PROBLEMATIC IN THE LONG RUN I
THINK WE REPRESENT NINETY
PROVIDERS THROUGHOUT THE STATE
I HAVE NO DOUBT THAT IF YOU
STARTED MEASURE THEM FOR
OUTCOMES AND LOOK AT THAT
PERFORMANCE WOULD DELIVER ON
THOSE METRICS WE AND WE ARE NOT
OPPOSED TO OUTCOMES MEASURES
AND QUALITY METRICS BUT I DO
SEE THAT WE- DO THAT WITHOUT.
UNDER DEBATE FUNDING TO SUPPORT
STAFF I'M AND PEOPLE NOT HAVING
THEIR ACCESS CUT WILL YOU ONLY
GET SERVICES ON MONDAY AND
TUESDAY BECAUSE WE DON'T HAVE
SOMEONE TAKE CARE PROVIDE
SERVICES. THEY WERE REALLY
GONNA MISS THE- I TELL AT.
THANK YOU SIR. HI AND MY NAME
IS LYNN WHERE I'M HERE WITH
ARCS FRAN AND WITH SOME OF MY
CLIENTS FROM THERE- WE ARE
PROGRAM FUNDED THROUGH THE
REGIONAL CENTER GOLDEN GATE
REGIONAL CENTER AND I'M WITH
THE HEALTH AND WELLNESS
DEPARTMENT WHERE WE COORDINATE
ALL THE HEALTH CARE NEEDS OF
SOME OF OUR CLIENTS I HAVE A
PRETTY LARGE CASELOAD THAT AND
GROWING SINCE I STARTED- BASIC
BUT I WANT TO SAY IT'S KIND OF
LIKE AT THE HUMAN LEVEL FROM
FOR. AS WHERE FIELD FOR BECAUSE
IF ERRORS WHAT I SEE IS THAT
ALL OF US AE SEVERELY
UNDERPAID. ARE STARTING WAGES
EIGHTEEN FIFTY AN HOUR AND
THAT'S FOR A VERY HIGH VOLUME-
COMPLEX SOCIAL WORK JOB THAT'S
VERY STRESSFUL- THE PEOPLE WHO
STAY IN THE FIELD ARE THERE
BECAUSE WE ARE. BASICALLY
INTERNALLY SENT TO FIVE IS THAT
IS WHAT I WOULD SAY WE- WE CARE
DEEPLY ABOUT OUR CLIENTS HEALTH
AND WELL BEING. I COULD SAY
THERE ARE QUITE A FEW PEOPLE
HAVE COME THROUGH MY PROGRAMS
THAT. COULD POSSIBLY BE DEAD OR
SEVERELY ILL IF WE WERE NOT
SUPPORTING THEM. AND WE CARE-
AND WHEN PEOPLE DO LEAVE THIS
POSITION THEY LEAVE BECAUSE
THAT WAGE IS NOT ENOUGH- TO PAY
RENT. MOST PEOPLE HAVE SECOND
AND THIRD JOBS JUST TO PAY RENT
WHILE DOING THIS WORK IN SAN
FRANCISCO- AND AT SOME POINT
THEY BURN OUT. AND THEY'RE VERY
SAD TO LEAVE THEIR CLIENTS. SO
BASICALLY WHAT I'M SAYING BUT I
DON'T THINK IT'S A REWARD TO. I
WOULDN'T CALL IT A REWARD TO
GIVE SOMEONE A LIVING WAGE. I
THINK THAT WE FIND THE RIGHT
WORDS. DOING VERY HUMAN WORK
THAT IS SO NECESSARY. TO HAVE
MORE MONEY TO LIVE AND TO BE
ABLE TO CONTINUE DOING WHAT
WE'RE DOING THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. DORGAN TURRETS GRANDMOTHER
TO- DISABLED IN INTELLECTUALLY
DISABLED INDIVIDUAL. I WOULD
JUST LIKE TO SAY THAT I REALLY
DO SUPPORT THAT REGIONAL
CENTERS. BE REQUIRED TO MEET
CERTAIN GOALS BEFORE THEY GET
MORE MONEY. I HAVE MY IDEA IS
WHY DON'T YOU ASK FOR FAMILIES.
IN THE TWENTY SIX YEARS THAT MY
GRANDSON HAS BEEN. A CLIENT OF
A REGIONAL CENTER I HAVE YET TO
RECEIVE SOME KIND OF A
QUESTIONNAIRE A SURVEY TO ASK
ME HOW I FEEL ABOUT THE
SERVICES THAT ARE BEING
PROVIDED BY THE PARTICULAR OR
LACK UP SERVICES BEING PROVIDED
BY MY PARTICULAR REGIONAL
CENTER. I THINK IT'S TIME I
THINK IT'S TIME TO REALLY LOOK
AT THEM WITH A MICROSCOPE FOR A-
AND LOOK TO SEE I WORK WITH A
LOT OF FAMILIES AS PART OF THE
I CC ORGANIZATION. AND AS PART
OF DISPARITIES I SEE A LOT OF
OUR LATINO FAMILY IT'S NOT
GETTING THE SERVICES THAT THEY
NEED NUMBER ONE AND THE
REGIONAL STAFF CENTER TAKING
MUCH TOO LONG TO GET THE
SERVICES IT PLACE. FOR FAMILIES
THAT ARE IN DIRE NEED THANK YOU
THANK YOU. HI MY NAME IS DONNA
FINE GOLD AND I'M THE DIRECTOR
OF THE ADAPTIVE LEARNING CENTER
ONE CONTRA COSTA COUNTY. AND
I'M NOT OPPOSED TO PERFORMANCE
MEASURES I THINK MOST
ORGANIZATIONS ARE MEASURING
THEIR PERFORMANCE I KNOW WE DO.
A SELF A SURVEY OF ALL THE
PEOPLE WE SERVE THEIR FAMILIES
STAFF EVERY TWO YEARS WE USE AN
OUTSIDE AGENCY WE KNOW AND WE
WANT OUR FOLKS TO BE- HAVE HIGH
QUALITY SERVICES. I'VE BEEN
DOING THIS ALL REALLY LONG
TIME. AND I COULD PROBABLY
GOING TO ALMOST ANY
ORGANIZATION AND TELL YOU WITH
QUALITY SERVICE IS A BEING
PROVIDED BY ASSESSING THE STAFF
FOR PROVIDING THE SERVICES. WE
ARE TAKING CARE OF VULNERABLE
FOLKS AND THE QUALITY OF OUR
STAFF. AND THE SKILLS
OVERSTAFFED WHAT MAKES THE
DIFFERENCE. SO BEFORE WE LOOK
AT PERFORMANCE I THINK IT'S
ALREADY BEEN TALK ABOUT THE LA-
TALKED ABOUT IT WE HAVE TO LOOK
AT WAGES. WE ARE LOOKING AT A
MINIMUM WAGE. MINIMUM WAGES FOR
A PROFESSIONAL WORKFORCE THAT
DESERVE SO MUCH MORE. AS YOU
JUST HEARD FROM THE LAST
SPEAKER IT'S A COMPLEX JOB
WORKING WITH COMPLEX PEOPLE. WE
NEED TO INVEST IN OUR WORKFORCE
THEY DESERVE IT THE PEOPLE WE
SERVE DESERVE IT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MA'AM. SEEING NO
FURTHER PUBLIC COMMENT ON ISSUE
THREE I WILL BRING IT UP TO THE
SUBCOMMITTEE- WE WILL START
WITH ASSEMBLYMEMBER WOULD
FOLLOWED BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
PATTERSON. FIRST OF ALL IT WAS
A THANK YOU TO. ALL THE PEOPLE
WHO CAME TO TESTIFY TODAY I
THINK WHAT- JUMPS OUT AT ME IS
THERE'S- AND IT'S TO BE
EXPECTED I MEAN WE HAVE A
REGIONAL CENTERS IN ALL PARTS
OF THE STATE WOULD EXPECT THAT
THE LEVEL OF SERVICES AND
THINGS. ARE DIFFERENT- AS BASED
ON GEOGRAPHIC SEN- SOCIO
ECONOMICS OF THE AREA. BUT I'D
SAY LOOK AT THE PROPOSAL AYE
AYE AYE I'M PUZZLED I'M A DATE
I'M A DATA PERSON BY BY NATURE-
AN OPT IN- I THINK IS
UNACCEPTABLE IF YOU WANT DATA
YOU WANT DATA FROM EVERYONE.
AND I DON'T SEE HOW YOU HOW YOU
COULD POSSIBLY. WANT PEOPLE TO
OPT OUT- YOU WOULD MAKE ME
WONDER OR MAYBE WONDER WHY
PEOPLE WORK OPTING IN. BUT I'LL
TELL YOU PROBABLY ONE REASON
WHY SOME MIGHT MIGHT NOT OFTEN.
IS YOU HEAR THAT REGIONAL
CENTERS ARE STRUGGLING TO KEEP
HIGHER IN KEEP EMPLOYEES IT
MAKES ME WONDER HOW YOU'RE
GONNA HIRING KEEP THE PEOPLE.
TO DO THE PROGRAMS HERE BECAUSE
I DON'T I DON'T KNOW WHAT THOSE
WAGES ARE GOING TO BE I DON'T
KNOW WHAT THEIR WHAT THEIR
SKILL LEVELS ARE GOING TO BE
THERE AS WELL. THE OTHER THING
THAT ALWAYS BUT IT BOTHERS ME
AND IT'S A TREND WE'VE SEE
WE'RE SEEN AS- THAT HERE THIS
THE LINE THE PROGRAM WILL BE
SUBJECT. TO POTENTIAL
SUSPENSION ON JULY ONE TWELVE
ONE TWENTY TWENTY THREE. AND WE
SEE WERE SEEN THIS OVER AND
OVER AGAIN WEARE THE COMMITTED
TO QUALITY AND IN FORT FOR THIS
PROGRAM OR WE'RE NOT. AND SO
THE IDEA THAT WE'RE DOING TO DO
THIS ON A TEMPORARY BASIS AND
SEE HOW IT GOES- BOTHERS ME
BECAUSE- I THINK QUALITY- IS IT
IS AN ONGOING AN ON GOING
PROCESS AND IT JUST. IT BOTHERS
ME SO HOW YOU HIRE PEOPLE TO
SAY YOU KNOW YEAH WE WANT YOU
FOR THIS JOB YOU'RE GOING TO DO
THIS BUT YET YOU YOU MAY NOT
HAVE A JOB IN A YEAR OR TWO OR
YOU DO YOU JUST NOT TELL. AND
THAT WOULD BE THAT WOULD BE
DISHONEST AND SO. SO I
APPRECIATE WHERE THAT THE LA IT
WAS COMING FROM- I THINK OFTEN
IS UNACCEPTABLE AND- WE NEED TO
WE NEED TO BE REALLY BE LOOKING
AT. FOR A CALL LONG TERM
COMMITMENT IF THAT'S IF THAT'S
THE GOAL HERE. THANK YOU
ASSEMBLYMEMBER. UP OUR FIRST OF
ALL THANK. THE RQ NOTICEABLE
PALSY A COMMUNITY VOCATIONAL
SERVICES A LOT OF FOLKS FROM
OUR FROM OUR AREA- I HAD
PRIVILEGES SERVING AS A MAYOR
FRESNO FOR EIGHT YEARS AND HAD
A GREAT DEAL OF PERSONAL
INVOLVEMENT WITH THOSE WHO ARE
PROVIDING THAT CARE FOR THOSE
WHO NEED IT THE MOST. AND
BROUGHT ATTENTION PURPOSES THE
JOY OF THAT JOB WAS TO SEE OF
THESE PEOPLE FLOURISH AND TO DO
GOOD THINGS- NUMBER ONE NUMBER
TWO I WANT TO SAY SOMETHING
ABOUT. ACCOUNTABILITY WE ALL
WANT ACCOUNTABILITY.
ACCOUNTABILITY IS FUNDAMENTAL
IN FACT I THINK THE REGIONAL
CENTERS ONE ACCOUNTABILITY I
THINK THAT DOES IT- THAT
PROVIDE THE SERVICES- EXPECT
THE ACCOUNTABILITY. BUT I HAVE
TO TELL YOU THAT MY BIG BASIC
CONCERN HERE IS THAT WE HAVE A
SYSTEM LITERALLY FALLING APART
IN FRONT OF OUR VERY OWN. PACE
WE ARE EXPECTING THESE
INDIVIDUALS TO GET QUALITY
MEASURABLE CARE. AND YET WE'RE
DOING IT FOR MINIMUM WAGE. WE
EXPECT THESE ASSOCIATIONS IN
THESE ORGANIZATIONS TO BE ABLE
TO DO THE KINDS OF THINGS THAT
WE EXPECT THEM TO DO. AND YET
THEIR RATES. ARE POVERTY RATES.
THIS IS THE REAL PLACE THAT WE
FIND. OF SO MANY WHO RECEIVE
THESE SERVICES. I UNDERSTAND
THAT IT CAN BE FRUSTRATING FOR
FAMILIES- TO ACCESS A SYSTEM.
IN WHICH- WHAT WE DON'T
ADEQUATE. NUMBERS OF
INDIVIDUALS WERE NOT
COMPENSATING THESE
PROFESSIONALS. THERE'S A
TURNOVER RATE. MY CONCERN IS WE
GET THE CART BEFORE THE HORSE.
AT THE FIRST THING WE HAVE GOT
TO DO. IS SETTLE OUT ON THIS
ONE POINT EIGHT. BILLION
DOLLAR. PROBLEM WE SPENT. WHAT
THREE MILLION DOLLARS TO DO A
RATES THAT. AND AS BEST I CAN
TELL. STATE ACCOUNT IS IGNORING
THAT RATE STUDY. UP AND I
REALLY THINK THAT BEFORE UP.
OUT WE CAN GET ACT ATTIC QUICK
MEASUREMENT. FROM A SYSTEM
UNDER HUGE STRESS IS TO HELP
THEM RELIEVE THAT STRESS TO BE
ABLE TO HIGHER UP IN AFFORD
QUALITY PEOPLE THAT WILL STAY
THE COURSE WITH THEM. ANDGIVE
THEM AN OPPORTUNITY TO
DEMONSTRATE WHAT THEY CAN
REALLY DO. IF WE ARE COMMITTING
TO THEM THE KIND OF RESOURCES
NECESSARY FOR THEM TO DO IT SO
LET'S FIRST. GET THE SYSTEM
STABILIZE LET'S GET PEOPLE
EMPLOYED WITH PAYCHECKS THEY
CAN LIVE ON LET'S GIVE THESE-
ORGANIZATIONS THE OPERATIONAL
MONEY SO THAT THEY'RE NOT
MAKING A DECISION. ABOUT
WHETHER THEY CAN KEEP THIS
PARTICULAR UP A PERSON HANDLE
BUREAUCRACY- BECAUSE OF A
GRANT. OR FIND SOMEBODY THAT
CAN DO ACCOUNTING- FIRST THINGS
FIRST THE SERVICES TO THESE
DEAR PEOPLE I THINK IS UNDER A
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF STRESS.
IN DO LARGE PART BECAUSE WE'RE
SIMPLY EXPECTING IT TO PERFORM
AT. FIFTY DOLLARS ON A HUNDRED
DOLLARS AN HOUR AND WE'RE
GIVING A FIFTEEN DOLLARS AN
HOUR IT DOESN'T WORK THAT WAY
FOLKS AND WE'D BETTER FIX THIS
FIRST OR THE QUALITY. IS GOING
TO BE CONTINUING. UNFORTUNATE
TO DECLINE BECAUSE WE'RE LOSING
THE BEST PEOPLE AND WE'RE
HAVING A HARD TIME REPLACING
THEM AND FINDING FOR THE SYSTEM
IF WE CARE ABOUT THE FAMILIES
IN THESE. A PEOPLE IN IN THE
CIRCUMSTANCES THAT FOR GOODNESS
SAKES COMPENSATE THEM ENOUGH
AND MAKE SURE THAT THESE
ORGANIZATIONS HAVE THE
NECESSARY THAT RATES AND AT AND
PAYMENTS SO THAT CAN DO IT WITH
A EVERYTHING. THE MAN OF AND
THAT THEY DO. THANK. IF I COULD
I WANTED TO QUOTE THE TOP OF
PAGE TWENTY TWO WHERE THE
ELLIE- STATES. THAT THEY FIND
THAT THE SYSTEM'S CURRENT
CONDITIONS PARTICULARLY THE
FUNDING CHALLENGES WOULD
SIGNIFICANT CAN ONLY YOU
CONSTRAIN THE ABILITY OF
REGIONAL CENTERS AND SERVICE
PROVIDERS. TO RESPOND TO
INCENTIVES IN A WAY THAT WOULD
LEAD TO THE INTENDED GOALS.
FURTHER ON IT SAYS THE LA-
NOTES THAT THIS PROPOSAL
APPEARS TO MOVE THE SYSTEM AWAY
FROM IMPLEMENTING RATE REFORM.
AND SO WITH THAT I JUST WANTED
TO ENGAGE THE ADMINISTRATION
AGAIN. HELP US TO UNDERSTAND
HOW THIS WILL MOVE US TOWARDS.
OR AWAY FROM RATE REFORM. I
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND I
ALSO WANT TO THANK THE- PUBLIC
COMMENTS AND THE COMMITTEE'S
COMMENTS BECAUSE THESE ARE. IT
THAT THE CONVERSATIONS ARE SO
IMPORTANT THAT WE HAVE TOGETHER
I'D LIKE TO JUST KIND OF
CLARIFY SOMETHING ON THE
PERFORMANCE INCENTIVE PROGRAM.
IS THAT THE PERFORMANCE
INCENTIVE PROGRAM. IS IDENTIFY.
FOR THE OPERATIONS OF THE
REASON REGIONAL CENTER AND IT
GIVES THE OPPORTUNITY FOR THE
REGIONAL CENTER TO WORK ON HOW
DO THEY DELIVER SERVICES AS A
SERVICE COORDINATION EIGHT-
ORGANIZATION. SO LET ME JUST TO
GIVE A LITTLE BIT MORE DETAIL
BECAUSE I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT
TO JUST ADD A LITTLE BIT OF
CLARITY AND IT'S NOT MINIMIZING
THE IMPORTANCE OF THE
CONVERSATION. ON SYSTEM. OUR
PATH FORWARD WITH RATES YOU
KNOW I'M NOT MINIMIZING THAT
SO. AT CONVERSATION IS AN
IMPORTANT CONVERSATION BUT I DO
WANT TO TAKE A LOOK AT THE CORE
TENET OF WHAT THE LATTER MANAK
IS AND WHAT KIND OF THE CORE
SERVICE THAT THEIR SERVICE
COORDINATORS DO. AND WHAT THE
REGIONAL CENTERS- KIND OF
OBLIGATION AS- AS A SYSTEM AND
THAT IS REALLY HELPING
FAMILIES- CONNECT TO SERVICES
SOME OF THOSE SERVICES ARE
FUNDED BY THE REGIONAL CENTER.
SOME OF THOSE SERVICE CSUS ARE
NOT A KIND OF HAD A TALK ABOUT
EARLIER. THE IT PARTICULARLY
FOR THE THAT ARE UNDER THE AGE
OF TWENTY TWO WE REALLY HAVE
SEEN CHANGES INTO HAVING
MULTIPLE SYSTEMS SUPPORT THE
INDIVIDUALS WHO WERE RECEIVING
SERVICES THROUGH THE REGIONAL
CENTERS SO THE INDIVIDUALS HAVE
AN INTELLECTUAL OR DEVELOP THE
DISABILITY. BUT THEY MAY ALSO
THEN BE RECEIVING OBVIOUSLY
EDUCATION SERVICES YOU KNOW IF
THEY'RE RECEIVING AS IT AS IT
HAD BEEN TALKED ABOUT ABA FOR
AUTISM OR NEEDING SERVICES IN
OTHER AREAS. SOME OF THOSE
SERVICES ARE NOT FUNDED BY THE
REGIONAL CENTER BUT THERE
REALLY IMPORTANT OF THE
FAMILIES WE HAVE TALKED TO A
LOT OF FAMILIESAND OVER THE
LAST COUPLE YEARS IN THE
CONVERSATIONS THAT WE'VE HAD IN
STAKEHOLDER DISCUSSIONS ONE OF
THE ELEMENTS THAT HAS BEEN SO
PASSIONATE. IS HOW FAMILIES
HAVE TALKED ABOUT THE CHALLENGE
OF ACCESSING SERVICES WITHIN
DIFFERENT SYSTEMS AND SO A GOOD
EXAMPLE OF THIS THERE'S AB
TWENTY EIGHTY THREE AND ITS
FOCUSES ON THAT SYSTEM KIND OF
COORDINATION FOR CHILDREN HER
IN FOSTER CARE AND SO
PARTICULARLY YOU KNOW I'M
PARTICULARLY SENSITIVE TO THOSE
THAT ARE IN FOSTER CARE IN OUR
SYSTEM. AND HOW DO THEY
NAVIGATE YOU KNOW BEING ABLE TO
ACCESS MULTIPLE SYSTEMS BECAUSE
WE HAVE TO HELP THAT CARE
COORDINATION SIDE WE CAN
IDENTIFY A VERY SPECIFIC GOAL
IN PERFORMANCE MEASURE THAT IS
TIED TO THE SERVICE
COORDINATION THAT DOESN'T HAVE.
ALL THE RELIANCE ON SAY
COMPETITIVE INTEGRATED
EMPLOYMENT OR SOME OTHER AREAS
WE CAN IDENTIFY THOSE THINGS IN
WHICH THE SERVICE COORDINATORS
AND THE REGIONAL CENTERS HAVE
CONTROL OF THAT THEY HAVE THAT
ABILITY TO BE ABLE TO AFFECT
CHANGE AND SO IF THEY HAVE THE
ABILITY TO AFFECT CHANGE WE
HAVE THE ABILITY TO MEASURE
THAT CHANGE. THEN WE HAVE THE
ABILITY TO BE ABLE TO PROVIDE
THOSE INCENTIVES TIED TO THAT
CHANGE SO THAT'S WHERE I YOU
KNOW I KNOW THAT WITHOUT
FURTHER MORE DETAIL IT'S HARD
TO KINDA CONCEPTUAL I IS AN AND
WE CAN PROVIDE. ADDITIONAL
CLARITY- WE'RE GONNA BE ABLE TO
DO THAT- OVER THE THAT THAT
SHORT WHILE HERE BUT WE'RE ALSO
GOING TO BE ABLE TO GET FURTHER
COMMENTS BACK ON FROM OUR
STAKEHOLDERS SO I TRULY
UNDERSTAND WHY SOME OF THE
STRUGGLE IS HERE. IN KIND
UNDERSTANDING THIS PART AND I
ACTUALLY AND I ALSO REALLY
RECOGNIZE THE IMPORTANCE OF THE
DATA INTEGRITY WE HAVE ALREADY
STARTED LOOKING AT WAYS THAT WE
CAN MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE
THOSE RESOURCES TO MEASURE THAT
ACROSS THE STATE BETWEEN EACH
OF THE REGIONAL CENTERS.
INCREASING THE NATIONAL CORE
INDICATORS WE KNOW THAT IF WE
TAKE A LOOK AT TRAINING WITHIN
THE CEDAR WHICH IS OUR ONE OF
THE CLIENT- SYSTEMS THAT WE CAN
CAN MONITOR THAT WE CAN AFFECT
CONSISTENCY ACROSS THE STATE.
SO THOSE ARE THE THINGS THAT AS
WE HAVE CONVERSATIONS AND WILL
BE MORE THAN HAPPY TO SHARE
THAT WITH THIS COMMITTEE AND
OBVIOUSLY WITH OUR COMMUNITY AS
WELL SO WE CAN. REALLY MAKE
SURE THAT WE HAVE A
COLLABORATIVE CONVERSATION SO
WE HAVE A PROGRAM THAT WORKS
FOR ON THE INDIVIDUALS WE SERVE
AND TO THE REGIONAL CENTERS AND
IT IS TRANSPARENT TO EVERYBODY.
WELL I HOPE WHAT YOU'RE HEARING
FROM ASSEMBLYMEMBER PATTERSON
AND SORRY TO USE THE HEALTH
ANALOGY BUT- SEEMS LIKE THERE
IS SOME HEMORRHAGING WITHIN THE
SYSTEM AND- IS THIS. PROVIDING
PRESSURE VERSES ACTUALLY
SOLVING WHAT IS UNDERLYING AND
I WOULD JUST- HAVE SOME URGENCY
AS WE HAVE THOSE. CONVERSATION
YES THANK YOU AND I DO I WANT
TO ACKNOWLEDGE- THE COMMENTS
THAT WERE MADE THANK YOU- IF I
COULD I DID WANT TO ALSO A CO-
DOCTOR WOULD AS WELL AS
DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA
AND DISABILITY VOICES UNITED-
IS THE ADMINISTRATION AMENABLE.
TO A MANDATORY PARTICIPATION BY
THE REGIONAL EARNERS. I'M A HE
PERFORMED INCENTIVE PROGRAMS IN
DOING KNOW. ARCA IS A MAN OF O
THIS AS WELL. AS I'M AS WE
CONTINUE TO HAVE CON. WITH OPEN
TO A PUT WHAT MAKES THE PER
MORE WE ARE VERY. OF LOOKING
STATE MEASURE SAID EACH RIDGE
CENTER IS. MEASURE TO SO WE CAN
MAKE SURE WE CAN LOOK AT NOT
ONLY HOW EACH REGIONAL CENTERS
FUNCTIONING THAT HOW DOES THAT
COMPARE TO THE REST OF THE
STATE. SO OPEN TO THOSE
CONVERSATIONS AS WELL AS WE
MOVE FORWARD. SO IF I CAN JUST
BECAUSE OUR NEXT HEARING IS
AGAIN ON APRIL TWENTY SECOND
FOR THIS I'D LIKE TO ASK FOR
STAFF TO WORK WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION AND
STAKEHOLDERS. TO REVISE THE
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE TO CREATE
FURTHER SPECIFICITY ON HOW THIS
PROGRAM WOULD WORK. AND THE
GOALS IT WOULD REASONABLY BE
EXPECTED TO ACHIEVE TOWARDS
CREATING A VIABLE OPTION. IF
THIS PROPOSAL IS ULTIMATELY
ADOPTED BY THE SUBCOMMITTEE.
I'M I'D ALSO LIKE TO ASK FOR A
REDUCTION IN RACIAL. ETHNIC
DISPARITIES IN SYSTEM
PERFORMANCE TO BE A CENTRAL
GOAL. FOR THIS PROPOSAL AS IT
MOVES FORWARD. AND BEFORE WE
CLOSE OUT THIS ISSUE I MAY WANT
TO ASK OUR CODE IF THEY'RE
AMENABLE TO THE MANDATORY
PARTICIPATION AS WELL. YEAH
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR THE
QUESTION AND I THINK WHERE WE
WOULD LAND ON THIS IS REALLY
JUST NEEDING TO BETTER
UNDERSTAND WHAT THOSE
PERFORMANCE SCHOOLS WERE WILL
BE- AND IT SOUNDS LIKE WE'RE
GONNA HAVE A LOT OF
CONVERSATIONS I HAD OF APRIL
TWENTY SECOND TO HAVE A BETTER
SENSE OF WHAT THOSE GOALS WOULD
BE AND THAT WOULD GIVE US. THE
FRAMEWORK WITH WITHIN WHICH TO
ANSWER THAT QUESTION PERFECT
WITH THAT WE WILL HOLD ISSUE
THREE OPEN AND MOVE ON TO ISSUE
FOR. OKAY THANK YOU- FINE ISSUE
FOR- THE AGENDA- CORRECTLY
NOTES THE PROPOSAL- IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET THAT
INCLUDES- SIXTEEN POINT FIVE
MILLION TOLD OF FUN IN LEVIN
POINT TWO MILLION GENERAL FUND
TO REDUCE- REGIONAL CENTER
SERVICE- COORDINATOR RATIOS-
FOR. INDIVIDUALS AGES THREE.
FOUR AND FIVE YEARS OLD. AND IN
IN AGAIN TALKING TO FAMILIES
AND TALKING TO- THOSE THAT ARE
REALLY LOOKING AT HOW TO
NAVIGATE THE SYSTEM AT SUCH AN
EARLY AGE. THERE'S A COUPLE OF
POINTS I JUST WANT TO MAKE THAT
THAT REALLY DROVE TO OF FOCUS-
ON THIS PARTICULAR AGE GROUP.
IS THAT THIS IS REALLY THE
FIRST TIME THAT ANY FAMILIES
ARE HAVING TO NAVIGATE MULTIPLE
SYSTEMS AS I HAVE TALKED ABOUT
ENTERING INTO THE EDUCATION.
GOING TO E. IS. YEAH BUT WE'RE
ALSO FINDING NEW WHEN WE TALKED
TO- FAMILY. THAT ARE REALLY
IDENTIFIED HOW DO THEY NAVIGATE
MULTIPLE SYSTEMS. MANY TIMES IT
IS OUR COMMUNITIES OF COLOR.
AND WHEN WE LOOK AT THE AGE
GROUP OF THIS BAND. THAT THIS
IS A PARTICULAR AGE GROUP
THERE'S A HIGH PERCENTAGE OF
OUR COMMUNITIES OF COLOR. AND
THEN WE'RE ALSO SEEING THAT
THIS IS AN AGE GROUP THAT WE'RE
STARTING TO SEE. INDIVIDUALS%
THAT ARE BEING DIAGNOSED WITH
AUTISM. SO YOU HAVE ALL THESE
MULTIPLE AREAS IN WHICH ARE
IMPACTING FAMILIES AND REALLY
HAVING TO SAY. HOW DO WE TAKE A
LOOK AT. YOU KNOW NAVIGATING
AND RECOGNIZE THE VALUE OF
HAVING. SERVICE COORDINATORS
WORK VERY CLOSELY WITH THE
FAMILIES TO BE ABLE TO- BE
SENSITIVE TO THE ISSUES. THAT
THE FAMILIES ARE FACING DURING
THIS THIS REALLY REALLY
CRITICAL. TIME IT IS. PRETTY
EVIDENT WE YOU TAKE A LOOK AT
HELPING A FAMILY- IN THESE
EARLY AGES THAT HELPS THEM.
BUILD THEIR SKILL SET EVEN
THROUGHOUT THE LIFESPAN OF
THEIR CHILD AS THEY NAVIGATE
THEN I'M GOING FORWARD SO THIS
IS A CRITICAL TIME AND THUS WE
HAD IDENTIFIED THE NEED FOR.
FOR PUTTING THIS IN THE
PROPOSED BUDGET THIS YEAR.
THANK YOU DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
SURE THANK YOU I WOULD JUST
NOTE THAT THE PROPOSAL FOR
ENHANCE CASE THE RATIOS FOR
YOUNG CHILDREN REFLECTS ABOUT A
HUNDRED AND EIGHTY SEVEN
SERVICE COORDINATORS AND
EIGHTEEN POINT SEVEN
SUPERVISING COUNSELORS TO
SUPERVISE THE ADDITIONAL-
SERVICE COORDINATORS IN
ADDITION TO BUILDING ON THE
LAST ISSUE WITH THE PERFORMANCE
INCENTIVE PROGRAM ALSO HAS A
TENANT ON SERVICE COORDINATION
SO THIS ALSO WELL THIS IS MORE
FOCUSED ON THIS SPECIFIC AGE
GROUP THERE ARE OTHER EFFORTS
BEING MADE LOOKING AT SERVICE
COORDINATOR RATIOS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU HELLO. SENATE
PETTITTE LA. WITHOUT PREJUDICE
TO THE MERITS OF THIS PROPOSAL
WERE WITHHOLDING RECOMMENDATION
BECAUSE WE DO NOT FULLY
UNDERSTAND THE ANALYTIC BASIS
FOR THIS PROPOSAL SPECIFICALLY
OF THE ADMINISTRATION HAS NOTED
THAT THIS PROPOSAL IS BASED ON
THE CASELOAD RATIOS IN THE
EARLY START PROGRAM FOR INFANTS
AND TODDLERS UNDER AGE THREE-
HOWEVER THOSE RATIOS ARE
CURRENTLY NOT AT ONE TO FORTY
FIVE THEIR MUCH HIGHER THAN
THAT. A IN FACT THEY'RE THEY'RE
CLOSER TO THEIR OVER SIXTY-
INFANTS AND TODDLERS- PER
SERVICE COORDINATOR IN ADDITION
MANY OTHERS CASELOAD RATIOS ARE
FOR OTHER AGE GROUPS AND OTHER
TYPES OF CONSUMERS ARE OUT OF
COMPLIANCE WITH STATE LAW AND
WITH FEDERAL AGREEMENTS. MORE
THAN 90% OF CONSUMERS ARE
CURRENTLY SERVED AT REGIONAL
CENTERS WITH CASELOADS THAT ARE
OUT OF COMPLIANCE- WE DO HAVE
SOME CONCERNS THAT THIS COULD
PUT OUR FEDERAL MEDICAID WAIVER
FUNDING AT RISK. I'M NEXT WE
WOULD NOTE THAT ALTHOUGH EARLY
CHILDHOOD IT IS A VERY
IMPORTANT AGENT IMPORTANT
MILESTONE IN A CONSUMER'S LIFE
IT'S NOT CLEAR. A SPECIFICALLY
WHY AGES THREE FOUR AND FIVE
SHOULD BE PRIORITIZED OVER-
INFANTS AND TODDLERS IN EARLY
START- OR OVER OTHER KEY AGE
GROUPS SUCH AS THE TRANSITION
AGE GROUP- FROM WHEN A CHILD IS
BETWEEN THE AGES OF SIXTEEN AND
TWENTY TWO AND IT'S SORT OF
TRANSITIONING FROM. THE SCHOOLS
TO THE REGIONAL CENTER SYSTEM-
AND- WE WOULD ALSO KNOW THAT
IT'S UNCLEAR IF THIS IS THE
MOST URGENT NEED ACROSS EVERY
SINGLE REGIONAL CENTER THERE
MAY BE- SPECIFIC NEEDS AT AT
DIFFERENT REGIONAL CENTERS. I'M
FINALLY WE WOULD JUST NOTE THAT
EACH YEAR THE REGIONAL CENTERS
ARE REQUIRED TO REPORT
INFORMATION ABOUT THEIR
CASELOAD RATIOS TO THE
DEPARTMENT WE WOULD RECOMMEND
THIS- THE REPORTS ARE DUE TO
THE DEPARTMENT IN MARCH. SO WE
WOULD RECOMMEND THAT THE-
MEMBERS REQUEST THAT UPDATED
INFORMATION FROM THE DEPARTMENT
IN A TIMELY MANNER. THANK YOU.
SEEN THEM WE HAVE WAR THERE
SOME LIMóN MAIENSCHEIN IS NOT
JOINING US BUT WANTED TO
RECOGNIZE TIFFANY WHEN. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF
TIFFANY OR WITH THAT THE ARE
YOU CAL WE HAVE OF OVER SEVEN
THOUSAND HERE IN CALIFORNIA AND
IN PARTICULAR OUR DIRECT
SUPPORT AND REGIONAL CENTER
WORKERS AT TEN REGIONAL CENTERS
AND VARIOUS PROVIDER AGENCIES.
TODAY I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
SUPPORT ON ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MAIENSCHEIN PROPOSAL ALONG WITH
ARCA- AND SCA CALIFORNIA TO
FIND EIGHT HUNDRED SERVICE
COORDINATORS IN ORDER TO
PROVIDE INDIVIDUALIZED PERSON
CENTERED PLANNING THAT THE
CLIENTS OF REGIONAL CENTERS
NEED AND DESERVE. CURRENTLY WE
HAVE MEMBERS- OF REGIONAL
CENTERS WE CASELOADS UPWARDS OF
NINETY- CASES AND SOME OF THEM
REACHING AND THE HIGH HUNDREDS.
OF LEAVING THEM UNABLE TO GIVE
TIME AND ATTENTION TO EACH
FAMILY AND STEP THERE
OFTENTIMES LEFT TO TRIAGE AND
DO CRISIS MANAGEMENT WE LIKE TO
THINK THE LA- FOR INCLUDING IN
THE ANALYSIS THE CHART. IN THE
CHART YOU WILL SEE THAT THE TOP
TWO- REGIONAL CENTER SAN
ANDREAS AND NORTHERN LA COUNTY
REGIONAL CENTERS BOTH OF WHICH
WE REPRESENT SERVICE
COORDINATOR THAT HAVE AN
AVERAGE RATIO OF ONE TO EIGHTY
TWO- THESE HIGH CASELOADS ARE
CAUSES ARE CAUSING DELAYS AND
SERVICES. MISTAKES ARE BEING
MADE AND AT TIMES PEOPLE ARE
FALLING THROUGH THE CRACKS IT'S
IMPERATIVE THAT THE STATE
RECOGNIZES THE DIRE NEED TO
HIRE MORE SERVICE COORDINATORS
BECAUSE ULTIMATELY AS THE
STATE'S MOST VULNERABLE THAT
CONTINUE TO SUFFER. NOT ME TO
THE CURRENT STATE. REQUIRED
VOTE RATIO PUTS STATE AT RISK
OF LOSING FEDERAL FUNDING
BECAUSE THE STATE MADE A
PROMISE TO MEET THE RATIOS. IN
NINETEEN NINETY EIGHT THAT
PROMISE WAS NOT MET IN THE
STATE LOST NEARLY ONE BILLION
DOLLARS AFTER PROMISING AGAIN
TO MEET THE RATIOS THEY ARE
STILL ON MET AND TWENTY TWENTY.
THERE HAVE BEEN DISCUSSIONS
RELATED TO POTENTIALLY A LINE
IN THIS CASE WHAT RATIO AS WE
HEARD EARLIER POTENTIALLY WITH
THE PROPOSED- INCENTIVE PROGRAM
AND WE WOULD HIGHLY URGE
AGAINST THIS. AS IT WOULD ONLY
EXACERBATE THE CURRENT PROBLEM
AND CREATE INSTABILITY AND
FUNDING IN THE OUT YEARS. WHAT
WE SUPPORT THE DEPARTMENT'S
GOAL OF VALUE IN CONSUMER
OUTCOMES IN CREATING A QUALITY
SYSTEM FOR INDIVIDUALS WITH
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES WE
WOULD REMAIN THAT YOU CAN'T DO
THAT WITHOUT ACKNOWLEDGING THE
CURRENT WORK FORCE AND
ADDRESSING THEIR NEEDS-
DIRECTOR BARGE MEN MENTIONED.
BEING ABLE TO SERVICE
COORDINATORS BEING ABLE TO
AFFECT CHANGE I WOULD ARGUE
THAT YES THEY ARE ABLE TO
AFFECT CHANGE. IF THEY HAVE
REASONABLE CASELOAD THAT
RESPECT THAT REFLECT THE
CURRENT STATUTE- AND OUR
PROMISE TO THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT. IN CONCLUSION- WE
WOULD JUST LIKE TO AGAIN- SAY
THAT THIS MEASURE THIS PROPOSAL
SUPPORTED BY THE LETTERMAN
COALITION AND IS INCLUDED IN
THE OVERALL LETTERMAN COALITION
ASK. AND THINK ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MAIENSCHEIN HOLDEN AND FRAZIER-
FOR THEIR SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. NEXT WE WILL HAVE-
PUBLIC COMMENT ON ISSUE FOR.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBER JORDAN LINDSAY ON BEHALF
OF THE LIMóN COALITION IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THE S. YEAH
YOU AN ARC A PROPOSAL TO
INCREASE HIS MENTOR BRING ME
INTO COMPLIANCE I'M WITH
FEDERAL GUIDELINES- EARLY TODAY
I MENTIONED ABOUT A MOTHER WHO
JUST WAS ON THE PHONE WITH
EARLIER IN HER EIGHT YEAR OLD
SON WHO WERE JUST SAID TWO DAYS
AGO EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS.
REGIONAL SON WITH AUTISM THEY
WERE TRYING SHE KNEW THIS WAS
COMING THE DAVE COMING EXPERTS
IN HOLMES SO SHE WAS TRYING TO
SET SOMETHING UP FOR HER SON IN
THE LAST SIX MONTHS SHE SAID
SHE'S GONE THROUGH THREE
SERVICE COORDINATORS AT THE
REGIONAL CENTER BEEN STARTING
ALL OVER EACH TIME AND NOW THAT
THERE HOMELESS THERE IS
NOTHING. FOR HER SON RIGHT NOW
THAT'S A CONSEQUENCE OF HAVING
THE TURN OVER IN- SERVICE
CORNERS OFFICIALS CENTERS THANK
YOU. THANK YOU SIR. HI ERIC
SIGNIN AGAIN EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
GOLDEN GATE REGIONAL CENTER-
SPEAKING IN. SUPPORT OF THE ARC
SEIU PROPOSAL FOR THE EIGHT
HUNDRED SERVICE COORDINATORS SO
AS DIRECTOR MARTIN POINTED OUT
IN THE FIRST PANEL THE SERVICE
COORDINATION REALLY IS A CORE
FUNCTION A CORE PART OF THE
LANHAM ACT. AND IT'S WHEN IT
WORKS WELL IT'S REALLY
BREATHTAKING IN ITS IMPACT IN
TERMS OF CONNECTING PEOPLE WITH
SERVICES IN TERMS OF
UNDERSTANDING THEIR NEEDS AND
ASPIRATIONS AND HELPING THEM.
REALIZE THOSE WHEN IT DOESN'T
WORK WHEN SERVICE CORNERS
AREN'T ABLE TO BE RESPONSIVE
WHEN THEIR CASELOADS ARE THIS
HIGH- IT IS HEARTBREAKING AND
FRUSTRATING DEEPLY TO
INDIVIDUALS AND FAMILIES- EVEN
WHEN THEY CAN RESPOND IF THERE
AREN'T THE SERVICES TO BE ABLE
TO OF AND- YOU KNOW CONNECT THE
PERSON WITH IT IS EQUALLY HEART
BREAKING AND FRUSTRATING. SO
GOLDEN GATE REGIONAL CENTER
WELL- WE ARE AT TWO HUNDRED AND
50% OF THE NATIONAL AVERAGE OF
THE COST OF LIVING SO WE ARE
REALLY THE CANARY IN THE MINE
IN THIS THE NEXT REGIONAL
CENTER NEXT HIGHEST. COST OF
LIVING REGIONAL CENTER IS SAN
ANDREAS A HUNDRED AND 70% OF
THE NATIONAL AVERAGE COST OF
LIVING HOW THAT TRANSLATES TO
US AND SERVICE COORDINATION IS
THAT WE RECEIVED AN ALLOCATION
TO THE POOR STAFFING FORMULA OF
50% OF WHAT ARE AT BRIDGE THE
RACIAL WORKER SERVICE HERE
MAKES WHICH MEANS WE HAVE A-
SERVICE COORDINATORS. WHICH
PROCESS ON NUMBER THREE ON
SONYA'S LIST OF HIGH CASELOADS
AT AND EIGHTY PER PERSON.
WHAT'S HARD TO PORTRAY IN A IN
A HEARING OR AN OFFICE BUILDING
IS THE IMPACT THAT THE WORKERS
THE SOCIAL THE SURF CORNERS
THEMSELVES HAVEN'T. WE TO
CONVERT ON OF MONTHS AGO
LEGISLATIVE STAFF AROUND THIS
AND BILINGUAL SOCIAL WORKERS A
BILINGUAL BICULTURAL SOCIAL
WORKERS A WELDING GATEWAY VERY
COMPELLING IN THE WAY THEY
TALKED ABOUT. HOW OUR DAILY
LIVES. ACTED BY HAVING EIGHTY
FIVE OR NINETY FIVE CASES AND
THE WAY THAT HAPPENS IS THEY'RE
DEALING WITH A NUMBER OF CRISES
AT ANY GIVEN MOMENT THEY HAVE
FAMILIES WHO NEED HELP WITH AND
SLIP IN I. P. IN THE SCHOOL
DISTRICT THEY HAVE ALL THESE
CAN. PRESS WHICH- THEY HAVE TO
TAKE CARE OF THE- INTENSE NEEDS
FIRST. WHICH MEANS THAT THEY
ARE. RECOGNIZE THAT THERE CAN
PEOPLE A SERVER. BEFORE THEY
GET IN THAT CRISIS STATE SO IT
IS JUST. I FEEL LIKE IT THE
GOAL GATE IS OUT THE- THE MOST
INTENSELY- IMPACTED BY THIS
BECAUSE OF THE DIFFICULTY IN
BEING ABLE TO. RETAIN OUR
AVERAGE SOCIAL WORKER MAKES. AT
LEAST TEN THOUSAND BUT PROBABLY.
DOLLARS AT THE CAN MAKE WHEN
THEY WORK FOR THE COUNT IS AN
AND WE LOSE PEOPLE TO- OTHER
SYSTEMS IN THAT WAY. AND SO I
URGE SUPPORT OF THAT. THANK YOU
SIR. HI KATIE HERBERGER
DISABILITY RIGHTS BECAUSE
EVERYONE ELSE WAS SO SOFT
SPOKEN EXCEPT ME. UP BUT THAT
COULD GO WITH MY- POINT THAT
I'M A FORMER EARLY INTERVENTION
TEACHER SO THE LITTLE ONES ARE
CLOSE TO MY HEART AND SO I
ACTUALLY UNDERSTAND. HOW OLD
THEY WERE PICKED AS SORT OF THE
GROUP TO PRIORITIZE IN REDUCING
CASELOADS OF BECAUSE THAT IS A
PARTICULARLY CHALLENGING TIME
THAT IS NOT TO SAY THAT OTHER
TIMES OF LIFE FOR NOT
CHALLENGING. BUT I DO THINK
THAT THERE ARE SOME CHALLENGES
THAT ARE UNIQUE TO THAT AGE
GROUP. IN REGARDS TO THE EIGHT
HUNDRED SERVICE COORDINATORS- I
THINK WE DEFINITELY HAVE A
SERVICE COORDINATOR SHORTAGE WE
DEFINITELY HAVE CASELOADS THAT
ARE RIDICULOUSLY HIGH AND I
WILL TELL YOU MY ADVOCATES.
OFTEN COMPLAIN TO ME ABOUT
THEIR INABILITY TO WORK WITH
SERVICE COORDINATORS BECAUSE OF
UNCOVERED CASELOADS AND OTHER
PROBLEMS HOWEVER I THINK THAT
THERE MAY BE MORE OF A
DISCUSSION TO BE HAD RATHER
THAN JUST HIRING EIGHT HUNDRED
SERVICE COORDINATORS. AND THAT
COULD INCLUDE A ONE TIME ON
EXPENDITURES RELATED TO
TECHNOLOGY THAT COULD MAKE
SERVICE COORDINATORS MORE
EFFICIENT IT COULD BE LOOKING
AT OTHER PRIORITIZE CASELOADS
SUCH AS BILINGUAL CASELOADS. ON
SO THEM I THINK THAT IS WE NEED
A LARGER DISCUSSION ABOUT WHAT
IT MEANS TO BE A SERVICE
COORDINATOR WE NEED TO LOOK AT
THE H. CBS RULES AND SEE IF
THERE ARE DIFFERENT CATEGORIES
OF SERVICE COORDINATOR THAT MAY
BE RESEARCHED. AND SO I THINK
THAT THERE IS AN OPPORTUNITY
HERE FOR A LARGER DISCUSSION
INSTEAD OF JUST EIGHT HUNDRED
SQUARE METERS THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. REVENUE AT GETTING BURIED
IN QUE. JUST SERVICE
ASSOCIATION JUST OF BOYS HARSH.
FOR THE ARE AND AS YOU FOR TO.
FILL THE EIGHT HUNDRED FOR THE
CASEMENT OKAY. OUR SYSTEM WORKS
BEST WHEN WE'RE OFF. ON SIR THE
PEOPLE THAT WE CARE ABOUT
INDIVIDUAL WITHIN LESS DEVELOP
DISABILITIES AND THE REGIONAL
CENTERS NEED. THE ADEQUATE
NUMBERS TO GET THEM INTO THE
SERVICES THAT THESE PEOPLE
NEED- SO THAT WE CAN DELIVER
SERVICES TO THE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. GOOD EVENING AMY
WESLEY ASSOCIATION OF REGIONAL
CENTER AGENCIES- APPRECIATE YOU
HEARING THIS ISSUE THIS
EVENING. WANT TO THANK. THE
ADMINISTRATION PARTICULARLY
NANCY FOR SPEAKING SO MUCH
ABOUT THE VALUE OF SERVICE
COORDINATION. WHEN PEOPLE HAVE
A CHILD WITH A DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITY THERE ARE SO MANY.
PROFESSIONALS THAT ENTER THEIR
LIVES AND THEY NEVER
ANTICIPATED THAT THEY REALLY
NEED HELP WORKING THEIR WAY
THROUGH THOSE SYSTEMS AYE
MINIMUM THE OTHER NIGHT WHO
SAID. MY DAUGHTER'S HEALTH IS
FINALLY STABLE SHOWING HAS FIVE
DOCTORS BUT SHE SEES NW. AND I
CAN'T IMAGINE WEARING THAT WITH
AYE HSS MEDIC HOW. THE SCHOOL
SYSTEM CAO FRESH HEARD ALL THE
SERVICES THAT PEOPLE ARE
WORKING WITH AND THAT'S REALLY
THE VALUE OF SERVICE
COORDINATION BUT HAD HIGH
CASELOADS CHALLENGE THIS WORK
AND MAKE THE WORK OFTENTIMES
LESS ABOUT RELATIONSHIPS AND
TRUST ABOUT CHECKING BOXES AND
GETTING WORK DONE- AND REALLY
THE VALUE IS IN. THOSE
RELATIONSHIPS. THERE'S BEEN
REFERENCE TO THE CASELOAD
RATIOS THAT WERE ESTABLISHED
ABOUT TWENTY YEARS AGO I WENT
BACK ON THE DEPARTMENT'S
WEBSITE AND LOOKED AT WHAT WERE
THE CHARACTERISTICS OF PEOPLE
WE WERE SUPPORTING AT THAT
TIME- PARTICULARLY AROUND THOSE
CHARACTERISTICS THAT MAKE.
PEOPLE REQUIRE A GREATER DEGREE
OF SERVICE COORDINATION AT THAT
TIME WE HAD AN AUTISM RATE OF
12% TODAY IT'S FORTY ONE. WE
HAD 7% OF THE INDIVIDUALS BEING
SUPPORTED WITH SEVERE BEHAVIOR
IS NOW IT'S TWENTY. OUR ELDERLY
POPULATION SIXTY TWO AND OVER
WAS LESS THAN 3% NOW IT'S
APPROACHING FIVE AND THE PEOPLE
LIVING IN DEVELOPMENTAL CENTERS
WERE OVER 2% TWENTY YEARS AGO
AND NOW THOSE PEOPLE ARE BEING
SUPPORTED IN THE COMMUNITY
THERE'S LESS THAN POINT 1% LEFT
IN. DEVELOPMENTAL CENTERS.
REGIONAL CENTER SPEND MORE IN
SERVICE COORDINATION THAN THEY
WERE FUNDED WHAT FOR. AND WE
STILL HAVE THE SHORTFALL. IN
TERMS OF THE DEPARTMENTS OF OR
THE ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL
RELATED TO THAT ENHANCE SERVICE
COORDINATION FOR THREE FOUR AND
FIVE YEAR OLDS WE BELIEVE THAT
WE SHOULD BE ABLE TO PROVIDE
THIS LEVEL OF SERVICE
COORDINATION FOR ALL YOUNG
CHILDREN- BUT AS THE LA- NOTES
IN ITS REPORT THE- REDUCED
RATIOS FOR EARLY START YOU
AREN'T EVEN POSSIBLE TODAY. WE
ALSO DO WANT TO NOTE THAT- IN
TERMS OF THE FISCAL THAT'S
ATTACHED TO THIS PROPOSAL OF
BEING BORED BY THE
ADMINISTRATION. IT'S
ESSENTIALLY BUILDING A GOOD
DIFFERENTIAL ON TOP OF A BAD
BASS AND SO THE PROPOSAL ITSELF
IS UNDER FUNDED BY BY OUR
CALCULATIONS ABOUT FOURTEEN
MILLION DOLLARS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MA'AM. JUDY MARK
PARENT AND DISABILITY VOICES
UNITED MY SIGN IN HIS TWENTY
THREE YEARS OR TWENTY YEARS
WITH THE REGIONAL CENTER HAS
HAD AMAZING SERVICE
COORDINATORS AND HE'S HAD VERY
MEDIOCRE SERVICE COORDINATORS.
AND THEY'RE ALL THE SAME RATIO.
IT TO ME IT'S THERE ARE SOME
REALLY TERRIFIC PEOPLE IN THE
SYSTEM. AND THERE'S SOME FOLKS
WHO WANT TO CLOCK IN AND CLOCK
OUT AND I THINK THAT. TO ONCE
AGAIN I KNOW I FEEL LIKE I'M A
BROKEN RECORD ON THIS FOR ONCE
AGAIN ONCE AGAIN TO ADD MORE
MONEY TO THE SYSTEM WITHOUT
ASKING FOR ANYTHING IN RETURN.
SEEMS TO MAKE NO SENSE. AND I
THINK THAT WE HAVE TO HAVE SOME
STANDARDS THE PERFORMANCE
MEASURES THAT IF WE WANT TO.
LOWER CASE THREE SHOWS THAT
THERE HAS TO BE EXPECTATIONS
MADE OF SERVICE COORDINATORS I
HEAR THE STORIES PARTICULARLY
FROM PARENTS WERE IMMIGRANTS
WHO DO CORN MONOLINGUAL SPANISH
SPEAKERS WHO ARE SAYING THAT
THEY ARE INTIMIDATED BY THE
SYSTEM AND BY THEIR SERVICE
COORDINATORS. SO WE HAVE TO
HAVE WE HAVE TO CHANGE THE
CULTURE WE HAVE TO HAVE
DIFFERENT EXPECTATIONS AND BY
JUST SAYING POINT BLANK YES
LET'S THROWING MORE MONEY AT
THIS WITHOUT A CLEAR
EXPECTATION MAKES NO SENSE TO
ME. THANK YOU. THANK YOU MA'AM.
IT IS EVENING AS AN ACTOR MY
NAME IS MARK CLAUS I AM THE
PRESIDENCY- FROM OF GUIDING
HANDS IN SAN DIEGO WE SUPPORT
ABOUT FOUR THOUSAND INDIVIDUALS
CHILDREN ADOLESCENTS AND ADULTS.
WITH INTELLECTUAL DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES I'M HERE TO SPEAK.
IN FAVOR OF THIS PROPOSAL-
HIRING THE ADDITIONAL- SERVICE
COORDINATORS- THIS IS MY FORTY
IF YOU'RE WORKING IN THE
SYSTEM- A COUPLE YEARS AGO MY
GRANDSON WAS. MOVED IN WITH US
AT TWO. I'M THE EXPERT I KNOW
EVERYTHING ABOUT THE SYSTEM- HE
HAD THREE SERVICE COORDINATORS-
IN A YEAR AND A HALF- THEY WERE
LEAVING FOR MORE MONEY- MY WIFE
AND I ARE VERY ACTIVE. IN THIS
SYSTEM- AND- WE STRUGGLED
TRYING TO FIND OUR WAY THROUGH
THE SYSTEM- WITHOUT GOOD
SERVICE COORDINATORS GOOD
ADEQUATE SERVICE COORDINATORS
AND THE RIGHT NUMBER SERVICE
COORDINATORS. WHEN I CAN SEE
GOOD BUT GOOD VALUE WERE GOOD
OUTCOME SO I WANT TO OFFER MY
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SIR SEEING NO FURTHER PUBLIC
COMMENT I'LL BRING IT UP TO THE
SUBCOMMITTEE TO SEE IF YOU HAVE
ANY QUESTIONS- I'D LIKE TO
BEGIN WITH THE ADMINISTRATION
IF I MAY AND- THE LA- HAD.
BROUGHT UP THAT THERE IS A RISK
OF. FEDERAL FUNDING OF BEING
OUT OF COMPLIANCE WITH THE
CASELOAD RATIO STANDARDS AND
WAS HOPING YOU COULD COMMENT ON
THAT. YES THANK YOU- I'M I'LL
GO AHEAD AND PROVIDED OF
RESPONSE AND THEN I HAVE MY
TECHNICAL EXPERT WHO JUST JOIN
ME HERE. DEPUTY DIRECTOR- BUT
AS I DO WANT TO JUST MAKE NOTE
THAT THERE HAS BEEN SOME SHIFT
AS FAR AS HOW CMS EVALUATES AND
MEASURES COMPLIANCE WITH THE
FEDERAL WAIVER. AND THERE WAS A
TIME WHEN AND CERTAINLY IT THE
MISS WOULDN'T HAD OUTLINED THE
TIME WHEN WE HAD A FINDING AND
THAT THE PLAN OF CORRECTION AND
THE RESPONSE THAT ULTIMATELY
LED INTO STATUTE IS TO KEESLER
RATIOS. BUT RIGHT NOW- CMS IS
USING DATA THAT AS I SAID
THERE'S A CHANGE THAT'S
OCCURRING NATIONALLY AND CMS IS
ALSO MAKING THAT SHIFT AS WELL.
AND SO THE MEASURE THEY USE
PERFORMANCE MEASURES TO ASSESS
COMPLIANCE WITH H. CBS WAIVER
ONE OF THE MEASURES IS NOT
RATIOS- HOWEVER THEY DO TAKE A
LOOK AT WHAT OF THOSE OUTCOMES
AND SO THERE'S- JUST A KIND OF
LINK THE TWO PROPOSALS TOGETHER
BETWEEN. THE CASELOAD RATIO
HERE BUT THEN ALSO THE QUESTION
IS TO COMPLIANCE SO WE TAKE A
LOOK AT THE PERFORMANCE AND
SAID TO PROGRAM IN BEING ABLE
TO USE THE RESOURCES THAT WE
HAVE WITHIN STATUTE TO HAVE THE
ALTERNATIVE STAFFING MODEL THAT
COULD BE PRESENTED. BY STILL
HAVING REGIONAL CENTERS USE SO
STRATEGIES THAT THEY IDENTIFIED
TO MEET THE NEEDS OF THE
INDIVIDUALS. BUT SHE
PERFORMANCE MEASURES THAT GETS
TO THOSE OUTCOMES ACTUALLY IS A
TIED TO COMPLIANCE WITH THE H.
CBS FEDERAL FUNDING- SO IT AND
ALL IF MISTER KNIGHT HAS ANY
ADDITIONAL TECHNICAL ELEMENTS
OF IT THAT MIGHT BE HELP. MANY
YES THANK YOU JIM WITH THAT. OF
THE SERVICES SO JUST TO ADD A
BIT MORE. UNDER OF THE PER
MEASURES THAT CMS REQUIRES NOW
HE REALLY IS DIRECTOR BARGE MEN
SAID LOOKING AT SOME OF THE
RESULTS IF YOU WILL OF CASE
MANAGEMENT AS OPPOSED TO- A
RATIO SO FOR INSTANCE- CASE
MANAGERS ARE REQUIRED IN IN IN
TO DO A TINY REVIEW OF
INDIVIDUAL PROGRAM PLANS MAKING
SURE THEY'RE UPDATED WHEN.
NEEDS CHANGE AND THE LIKE AND
ALSO IF THEY REFLECT-
INDIVIDUALS HEALTH AND SAFETY
NEEDS SO IT'S THOSE KIND OF
MEASURES NOW THAT CMS LOOKS TO
AND THAT WE REPORT ON. EVERY
FIVE YEARS TO AND TO SEE A
MASS. AND IN THAT THOSE
PERFORMANCE MEASURES WHAT'S
USED IN TO EVALUATE OUR
COMPLIANCE WITH THE WAIVER. IS
IT POSSIBLE THAT THOSE ARE
DIRECTLY RELATED TO WORKLOAD.
THE PERFORMANCE OF. THE THOSE
WHO ARE ACTUALLY DOING THE
TIMELY REVIEWS. THIS THIS IS
NANCY SO WITH THERE'S ALWAYS
TIES TO WHAT ARE THE OUTCOMES
YOU KNOW AND YOU TO BE ABLE TO
SAY EXACTLY WHAT ARE THOSE
OUTCOMES AND- CLEARLY WITHIN
THE PERFORMANCE INCENTIVE
PROGRAM WE'RE IDENTIFYING A
NEED. THAT HAS TO DEVELOP A
READINESS TO ACHIEVE
PERFORMANCE MEASURES AND SO THE
FIRST YEAR OF BEING ABLE TO
IDENTIFY THERE IS A COMMENT
THAT ALSO TALKED ABOUT YOU KNOW
WHAT IS THE TECHNOLOGY AND ITS
ITS TECHNOLOGY IS NOT GOING TO
REPLACE PEOPLE. YOU KNOW SO YOU
HAVE TO REALLY TAKE A LOOK AT
WHAT ARE THE KIND OF THE
DIFFERENT STRATEGIES TO BE ABLE
TO ACHIEVE THE OUTCOMES FOR THE
INDIVIDUALS WE SERVE. AND WITH
THE REDUCE THAT THE CASE LOW
FOR THE THREE FOUR AND FIVE
YEAR OLDS WITH THE PERFORMANCE
INCENTIVE PROGRAM WHERE
REGIONAL CENTERS. COULD
IDENTIFY THAT THEIR PRIORITY OR
THE WAY THAT THEY'RE GOING TO
BE ABLE TO ACHIEVE THOSE AREAS
BECAUSE THEY'RE- THEY'RE NOT
ACHIEVING THEM TODAY MAYBE TO
HIRE EX NUMBER SERVICE
COORDINATORS OR IT MAY BE EX
NUMBER SERVICE COORDINATORS
PLUS EMPLOYMENT SPECIALIST
PUSHED. PLUS THE HEALTH PLANS
SPECIALISTS PLUS SO THEY THEY
CAN REALLY USE. THE FLEXIBILITY
AND TO NAVIGATING IT AS OPPOSED
TO A PRESCRIPTIVE. BECAUSE A
PRESCRIPTIVE APPROACH MAY NOT
BE A ONE SIZE FITS ALL FOR
EVERY COMMUNITY AND WE HAVE
TWENTY ONE DIFFERENT REGIONAL
CENTERS THAT RUBRIC REPRESENT.
A MULTIPLE MULTIPLE DIFFERENT
COMMUNITIES. I THINK MY CONCERN
IF I CAN JUST VOICE OUT LOUD
IS- THE RISK REALLY HERE TO
FEDERAL FUNDING AND SO I JUST
HIM. BRINGING IT UP AS A WAY
FOR ME TO ENGAGE WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION TO FIGURE OUT A
PLAN AND- YOU KNOW IF WE WERE
TO DO THE THREE FOURS AND FIVES
THAT YOU SPEAK OF. I THINK MY
NEXT QUESTION IS WHAT'S OUR
PLAN TO ADDRESS THE REMAINING
CASELOAD RATIOS THAT WOULD BE
OUT OF COMPLIANCE. THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL- OUTLINES A
PERFORMANCE INCENTIVE PROGRAM
AND TYING THAT BACK TO- WHAT
WE'RE MEASURING AND PERFORMANCE
MEASURES AND TO WHAT IS-
REPORTABLE TO EIGHT CBS WHICH
IS THE FEDERAL DOLLARS. SO WE
ARE LOOKING AT THE FEDERAL
DOLLARS IT'S IMPORTANT ELEMENT
AND COMPLIANCE WITH THAT. AND
USING THE ABILITY TO- IDENTIFY
PERFORMANCE MEASURES THAT ARE
IN LINE MEANT WITH WHAT THE
EXPECTATION OF OUR PERFORMANCE
THAT WE HAVE TO. DELIVER TO THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT ARE ARE IS
THAT LANDS THAT WE WOULD BE
USING AND THE PERFORMANCE AND
SAID TO PROGRAM- IF I MAY AND-
IT'S THE FINAL THING WILL HAVE
FOR THIS- IS TO ASK FOR SOME
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE IF I MAY
REGARDING THE- ADVOCATES
PROPOSAL ASSEMBLY MEMBER MAIN
SHINES PROPOSAL- I'D LIKE TO.
GET SOME RENDON CONVERT
CONFIRMATION IF I CAN FROM THE
DEPARTMENT- REGARDING THE
ADVOCATES ESTIMATE OF FIFTY
POINT SEVEN MILLION GENERAL
FUND FOR RECTIFYING THE
CASELOAD RATIOS. IF I CAN AS
WELL AS ASKING FOR UPDATED
RATIO INFORMATION- THAT HELPS
US TO UNDERSTAND IF THEY'RE THE
RIGHT RATIOS WE SHOULD BE
LOOKING AT ALL- IF WE COULD
PROVIDE THAT BY MARCH
FOURTEENTH I DON'T KNOW IF
THAT'S TOO EARLY BUT- I KNOW
WERE. PUSHING UP AND ARE TRYING
HARD TO GET INFORMATION SO WITH
THAT WE WILL OKAY WE'RE HAPPY
TO PROVIDE TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
OF COURSE FIXED AND IT'S A
PRIORITY FOR THE LEGISLATURE
HAPPY TO PROVIDE THAT SUPPORT
NO ONE I'M QUITE SENSITIVE TO
THE FRONTLINE WORKERS AND THE
STORIES OF NAVIGATION AND THE
DIFFICULTIES THAT THEY HAVE
FROM. BEING RUNNING TOO FAST ON
A TREADMILL AND SO- JUST WOULD
LIKE TO BE ABLE TO SEE WHAT AN
ACCURATE. ANALYSIS WOULD BE SO
THAT WE CAN MAKE THE
APPROPRIATE DECISION ONE THING
I WOULD KNOW MISTER CHAIR IS
THAT IF USING THE BASELINE OF
THE TWENTY NINETEEN SURVEY IS
THAT THE NEW SURVEY WITH THE
UPDATED CASELOAD RATIOS IS ALSO
COMING OUT IN MARCH TWENTY
TWENTY WHICH WILL REFLECT.
UPDATED RATIOS THAT WAS
PROVIDED AS AN INVESTMENT THIS
BUDGET ACT FOR THE SPECIALIZED
CASELOAD- SPECIALIZED
BEHAVIORAL NEEDS WE REDUCE
CASELOAD FOR ONE TO TWENTY FIVE
AND THIS BUDGET AXES COULD BE
SOME CHANGES IN THE DATA SO
WALL DEPENDING ON THE TIMING
WHEN THAT COMES OUT MAY OR MAY
NOT. HAVE THAT TO OUR DISPOSAL
AS WELL ROOM THREE. WITH THAT
WE WILL HOLD ISSUE FOR OPEN AND
MOVE ON THIS. TWO FIVE. THANK
YOU SO AS THE AGENDA- CORRECTLY
NOTES- THERE'S A NUMBER OF
PROPOSALS THAT WE HAVE BEEN
ABLE TO PUT FORWARD THAT'S BEEN
CONSISTENT WITH OUR SAFETY NET-
AS A REMINDER THAT WE- FIRST
RELEASE OUR SAFETY NET PLAN IN
MAY OF TWENTY SEVENTEEN- OUR
SAFETY NET PLAN HAD BEEN-
INFORMED THROUGH STAKEHOLDER
PROCESS AND THEN DURING THAT
TIME WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO DEVELOP
MULTIPLE DIFFERENT TO DIFFERENT
RESOURCES IN THE COMMUNITY TO
SUPPORT THE INDIVIDUALS WITH
THE MOST COMPLEX NEEDS SO WE
CONTINUE TO EVALUATE TAKE A
LOOK AT THE- THE INFORMATION-
AVAILABLE TO US- TO BE ABLE TO
IDENTIFY WHERE DO WE NEED TO
MOVE TOWARDS. TO CONTINUE TO
DEVELOP THROUGHOUT THE STATE IN
A DIFFERENT REGIONAL CENTERS-
THE AGENDA NOTES A NUMBER OF
THE DIFFERENT SERVICE MODELS
AND WE ALSO HAVE BEEN-PROVIDING- LET STEP ON A
QUARTERLY BASIS AN UPDATE ON
WHAT WE'RE DOING AND OUR SAFETY
NET AND THE PROGRESS IN THE
DEVELOPMENT OF THE SPECIALIZED
RESOURCES- THAT WE'VE BEEN
DEVELOPING I DO WANT TO NOTE-
AND AGAIN IT'S CORRECTLY NOTED
AND THE- THE AGENDA THAT WE'RE
PROPOSING TWENTY POINT NINE
MILLION DOLLARS TOTAL FUN
NINETEEN. MILLION AS GENERAL
FUND AND RELATED- TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE- FOR A COUPLE OF THOSE
ITEMS THERE ARE TWENTY-
ADDITIONAL INDIVIDUALS THAT
WERE IDENTIFYING TO INCREASE
OUR CENSUS OVER AT PORTER BILL
SECURE TREATMENT PROGRAM SO IT
WOULD TEMPORARILY INCREASE OUR
CENSUS- TO RELIEVE THE NUMBER
OF INDIVIDUALS THAT ARE IN JAIL
THAT HAD BEEN CHARGED WITH A
FELONY AND- ON- NEED TO BE ABLE
TO HAVE COMPETENCY DETERMINED-
SO BECAUSE WE ARE SEEINGLONGER
WAIT LIST- AND LONGER WAIT
TIME- FOR INDIVIDUALS IN JAIL
THAT WERE WERE PROPOSING TO
TEMPORARILY- INCREASE TO THE-
ADDITIONAL TWENTY BEDS BUT AT
THE SAME TIME THEN WE ARE
PROPOSING TO DEVELOP ADDITIONAL
EBS H. HOMES- THERE ARE THE AND
HAS BEEN HERE REAL SUPPORTS
HOMES THAT WERE ONE OF THE NEW.
THROUGH THE SAFETY NETWORK THAT
WE'VE BEEN DOING- AND BE ABLE
TO BUILD THAT CAPACITY SO THE
INDIVIDUALS THAT ARE AT PORTER
BILL SECURE TREATMENT PROGRAM.
THAT REALLY CAN'T TRANSITION TO
THE COMMUNITY WITH SUPPORTS
THAT WE CAN REDUCE THE
POPULATION AND SO- DURING THAT
TIME IS WERE. REDUCING THAT
POPULATION AND THEN PROVIDING
ADDITIONAL SUPPORTS AND WRAP
AROUND. TO THE INDIVIDUALS THAT
WE WOULD BE ABLE TO ADDRESS
THIS ISSUE I'M IN A SHORT
PERIOD OF TIME AND SO WE WOULD
NOT RELY ON THAT INCREASED
CENSUS. BE IT BEYOND THAT THE
END DATE THAT WE HAD
IDENTIFIED. THERE'S A AN
ADDITIONAL ITEM THAT I'D LIKE
TO MAKE NOTE OF- WHICH HAS
PROVEN TO BE VERY SUCCESSFUL-
WE HAD DEVELOPED AT WHAT'S
CALLED THE START PROGRAM. AND
IT'S CALLED A SYSTEMIC
THERAPEUTIC ASSESSMENT
RESOURCES AND TREATMENT- IT IS
AN EVIDENCE BASED ON PERSON
CENTERED INFORMED IT TRAUMA
INFORMED- MODEL. THAT IS-
SOMETHING THAT WE BROUGHT INTO
CALIFORNIA WE PILOTED IF YOU
WILL- WITH TO REGIONAL CENTERS
SAN DIEGO REGIONAL CENTER IN
SAN ANDREAS REGIONAL CENTER-
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT WE HAVE
HEARD IS AND WE'VE- IDENTIFIED
IN OUR SAFETY KNOWS THAT WE
REALLY HAVE TO INSTEAD OF JUST
DEVELOPING THE RESOURCES. ON
THE ACUTE SIDE TO WEAR WERE
STABILIZING WHEN SOMEBODY IS
KIND OF GETTING TO THAT ACUTE-
STAGE AND HAVING TO GET
STABILITY OUTSIDE OF THE FAMILY
HOME. IN DOING MORE THE
PREVENTATIVE WORK AND MAKING
pTHE EARLY KIND IDENTIFICATION
AND SUPPORTS. SO THIS WAS ONE
MODEL THAT- WE WERE ABLE TO
IDENTIFY IT PROVIDES A LIFESPAN
SUPPORT TO INDIVIDUALS- IT
REALLY IS ABOUT STABILIZING THE
INDIVIDUAL AND THE HOME. I'M IS
TWENTY FOUR HOUR CASE
COORDINATION AND IT'S
CONNECTING INDIVIDUALS THE
FAMILY AND ON THE INDIVIDUAL
WITH OTHER SYSTEMS TO BE ABLE
TO HELP KIND OF WRAP THAT.
SUPPORT SERVICES OF VERY
HOLISTIC WRAPAROUND SUPPORT
MODEL THAT- WE HAVE SEEN TO
PROVE SOME- ALREADY POSITIVE
OUTCOMES AND I'D LIKE TO SHARE
THAT WITH YOU TODAY. SO WE
CURRENTLY HAVE ABOUT A HUNDRED
AND SIXTY THREE PARTICIPANTS-
AS I SAID IT SAN ANDREAS AND
SAN DIEGO REGIONAL CENTER.
SEVENTY OUR CHILDREN'S NINETY
THREE ADULTS- 85% OF THE
CHILDREN 50% OF ADULTS ACTUALLY
LIVE IN THEIR FAMILY HOME. WE
ARE WE'RE SEEN A DECLINE IN THE
HOSPITALIZATIONS SO SINCE-
SEPTEMBER TWENTY NINETEEN FOR
THOSE PARTICIPANTS WE'VE SEEN A
DECLINE BY. 92% OF THE COST
PSYCHIATRIC HOSPITALS STATIONS
ON A- THESE AND WE'VE ALSO SEEN
A REDUCTION OF EMERGENCY
DEPARTMENT VISITS EMERGENCY
ROOMS AT THE HOSPITAL'S.
DECLINED AT 87% FOR CHILDREN IN
92% FOR ADULTS- OF THOSE THAT
ARE LIVING AT THE HOME. SO OUR
PROPOSAL INCLUDES- FOR
ADDITIONAL PROGRAMS THAT WE
WOULD LIKE TO START UP IN OTHER
PARTS OF THE STATE- AND I KNOW
THE AGENDA. HAD NOTED THE AND
THE LA ALWAYS ASK SOME
QUESTIONS AS TO WHERE WOULD WE
IDENTIFY THOSE- OUR STRATEGY TO
IDENTIFY. THOSE AREAS IN WHICH
WE WOULD PRIORITIZE IS LOOKING
IN AND THE THERE'S A MAP IN THE
AGENDA THAT GIVES YOU A
REFERENCE TO WHERE WE HAVE OUR-
CRISIS- A Q. CRISIS SERVICES
BOTH ON THE RESIDENTIAL SIDE
AND THEN OUR CAST WHICH IS
STATE OPERATED. WHICH IS A
MOBILE TEAM AND THEN ALSO
IDENTIFYING WHERE WE HAVE
OTHERS THE START SERVICES SO WE
WOULD BE LOOKING AT THOSE
REGIONAL CENTER CATCHMENT AREAS
THAT DON'T HAVE EITHER OF THOSE
RESOURCES. SO WE CAN REALLY DO
A COMPLIMENT THROUGHOUT THE
STATE AND START BALANCING SOME
OF THOSE RESOURCES WHAT'S NICE
ABOUT HAVING A MULTIPLE
APPROACH WE CAN START SEEN WHAT
IS THIS. WHAT IS THE EVIDENCE
TELLING US AND SOME BEST
PRACTICES- TO BE ABLE TO
COMPARE ACROSS THE STATE. THANK
YOU. APARTMENT FINANCE. I JUST
TO SUMMARIZE A COUPLE OF THAT
DIRECTOR BY IN MAY IN REAL TO
THE BUILDING I OF COULD PASS A
POOR SO TREAT PROGRAM NOTING
THE SENSE OF BUILDING OUT
CAPACITY- AT THE DEVELOPMENTAL
CENTER HOWEVER WE DO FEEL THAT
FOLKS WOULD BE BETTER SERVED AT
PORTER BILL RATHER THAN COUNTY
JAIL IS THE RATIONALE BEHIND
THAT AND THE TEMPORARY NATURE
OF BUILDING OUT THE TWENTY BET
UNIT AND SECONDARILY JUST THE
WITH THE SAFETY NET PLAN IN THE
CRISIS INTERVENTION TRAINING
NOTING THAT THE SAFETY NET PLAN
TRADITIONALLY AS REFLECTED MORE
BUILDING OUT CAPACITY- THIS IS
REALLY FOCUSED ON A
PREVENTATIVE ASPECT WHICH IS A
POSITIVE STEP FORWARD THANK
YOU. THANK YOU SIR. SO YOU PICK
FROM THE LA. WE WANT TO. A FEW.
A THIS NET. PLAN THAT HAS BEEN
PUT FORWARD BY THE DEPARTMENT
AND THEN TALK ABOUT THE TO-
SPECIFIC PROPOSALS. SO WE KNOW
WHAT A SEVERAL THINGS THAT WE
FOUND- VERY HELPFUL ABOUT THE
PLAN THAT WAS DELIVERED ON
JANUARY TENTH- FIRST IT
PROVIDED HELPFUL UPDATES ABOUT
THE PROJECTS THAT HAVE ALREADY
BEEN FUNDED- IT PROVIDED AS-
SORT OF HOLISTIC LOOK AT THE
VARIOUS SERVICES. AND SUPPORTS
ACROSS THE CONTINUUM OF CARE-
IT PROVIDED A DESCRIPTION OF IT
THE NEW FOCUS ON PREVENTION AS
MY COLLEAGUE FROM FINANCE JUST
MENTIONED- YOU KNOW AS WE KNOW
PREVENTION PREVENTION OF CRISES
IS BETTER FOR THE INDIVIDUAL
BETTER FOR THE FAMILY BETTER
FOR THE SERVICE PROVIDERS AND
IT'S LESS COSTLY- IT ALSO
PROVIDES GREAT CONTEXT ON THE
CHANGING DEMOGRAPHICS OF THE
PERSON'S SERVED INCLUDING THE
GROWING RATES OF AUTISM AND CO
OCCURRING. MENTAL HEALTH.
ATTACHED ISSUES- IT ALSO
PRESENTS SOME OF THE GOALS THAT
WERE DEVELOPED IN COLLABORATION
WITH STAKEHOLDERS WHICH IS
IMPORTANT. BUT WE DO FIND THAT
THE PLAN DOES- LACKS CERTAIN
SPACES SPECIFICITY IN A FEW
AREAS- PRIMARILY IT DOESN'T
REALLY PROVIDE A PLAN THAT
LOOKS FORWARD IT'S AS SOMEWHAT
MORE OF A STATUS UPDATE- IT
WOULD BE GREAT. IF THE PLAN HAD
SOME HAD. OF NOT ONLY THE OVER
ARCHING GOALS THAT ARE IN THE
PLAN BUT BUT SPECIFIC GOALS
WITH MEASURABLE TARGETS- THAT
THE DEPARTMENT HOPES TO
ACHIEVE- THE ACTIVITIES THAT
THE DEPARTMENT WOULD UNDERTAKE
TO ACHIEVE THOSE GOALS AND HOW
THEY WILL KNOW THAT THOSE
VARIOUS EFFORTS ARE SUCCESSFUL.
OR WHETHER THEY NEED REFINEMENT.
IT WOULD BE HELPFUL TO HAVE A
DISK OF HOW DATA IS USED TO
MAKE THESE DECISIONS- THE
DEPARTMENT PROVIDES A LOT OF
GREAT DATA ABOUT THIS
POPULATION- AND THEIR VARIOUS
NEEDS BUT WE DON'T QUITE KNOW
HOW THOSE- THAT INFORMATION
TRANSLATES INTO THESE REQUESTS
THAT COME FORWARD EACH YEAR-
AND THEN IT WOULD BE GREAT TO
HAVE AN EXPLANATION OF HOW
CERTAIN PROJECTS ARE
PRIORITIZED OVER OTHERS AND SO
WITHOUT SORT OF KNOWING HOW
THOSE DECISIONS ARE MADE IT'S
DIFFICULT ON A YEAR BY YEAR
BASIS TO ASSESS- THE PARTICULAR
PROPOSALS THAT COME FORWARD
EACH YEAR- SO WE WOULD JUST
RECOMMEND THAT THE DEPARTMENT
OF SORRY THAT THE LEGISLATURE
CONTINUE TO PRESS THE
DEPARTMENT FOR THOSE TYPES OF.
DETAILS IT WOULD BE IN YOU KNOW
ALONG THE LINES OF HAVING A
ROAD MAP ABOUT WERE WE'RE THE
DEPARTMENT INTENDS TO GO IN
TERMS OF SAFETY NET PLANNING ON
THE TO SPECIFIC PROPOSALS THAT
ARE PART OF THE TWENTY TWENTY
TWENTY ONE BUDGET PROPOSAL WE
RECOMMEND APPROVAL OF THE
TEMPORARY CAPACITY ADDITIONAL
CAPACITY OF TWENTY BEDS AT
PORTER BILL OF COUPLED WITH THE
DEVELOPMENT OF FIVE NEW ENHANCE
BEHAVIORAL SUPPORTS HOMES- THAT
INCLUDE DELAYED EGRESS AND
SECURED PERIMETER THE
DEPARTMENT PROVIDED SOME GREAT
BACKUP INFORMATION TO. SUPPORT
WHY THIS WOULD- SERVES THE
CONSUMER POPULATION WELL. WE
ALSO RECOMMEND APPROVAL OF THE
START PREVENTION SERVICES THAT
TO- DIRECTOR BARGE MEN
DESCRIBED. I'M TYPICALLY YOU
KNOW SHE MENTIONED THAT THIS
PROGRAM IS BEING PILOTED IT
INTO REGIONAL CENTER AREAS. AND
TYPICALLY YOU WOULD AWAIT THE
RESULTS OF A PILOT PROGRAM
BEFORE USE YOUR RAMPS IT UPPER
SCALE THAT UP. A BIT WE WOULD
NOTED IN THIS CASE IT MIGHT BE
JUSTIFIED TO MOVE FORWARD
ANYWAY BECAUSE- PREVENTION
AGAIN OF CRISES ARE IS VERY
KEY. WE ALSO KNOW THAT THIS
PARTICULAR MODEL HAS BEEN
TESTED IN OTHER STATES IT'S IT
IS AN EVIDENCE BASED PROGRAM-
WE ALSO KNOW THAT. USING THAT
PART OF THE PROGRAM IS THAT
DATA HAS TO BE COLLECTED-
THAT'S A REQUIREMENT OF USING
THIS MODEL. WHICH IS A GOOD
THING- IT ALSO TRAINS SORT OF
EVERYBODY INVOLVED A TRAINS THE
DIRECT SERVICE PROVIDERS THE
FAMILY MEMBERS THE REGIONAL
CENTERS- DIRECTOR BRIDGMAN
PROVIDED SOME INFORMATION
ABOUT- WHICH REGIONAL CENTERS
WILL BE SELECTED FOR THIS-
EXPANSION AND SO. I GUESS THE
ONE REMAINING QUESTION THEN
WOULD BE WHEN WILL THEY DECIDE
WHICH- REGIONAL CENTERS AND
WHEN WITH THE LEGISLATURE KNOW.
WHICH SPECIFIC REGIONAL CENTERS.
THANK YOU. AT THIS TIME WE WILL
A COUPLE COMMENT ISSUE FOR.
HELLO JORDAN'S ON BEHALF OF THE
ARK OF CALIFORNIA I'M WE ARE
VERY HAPPY TO SEE IN VERY MUCH
IN SUPPORT OF THE MISTRESS
PROPOSAL TO EXPAND CAPACITY
PORTABLE- IT'S UNFORTUNATE THAT
WE HAVE TO- GET. EXPAND
CAPACITY AVAILABLE CENTER BUT
WHEN PEOPLE ARE IN CRISIS IN A
COUNTY JAIL OR IN A JAIL THAT
THERE IS SO MUCH MORE
COLLABORATION IN THAT IS NEEDED
BETWEEN CRIMINAL JUSTICE AND
OUR SYSTEM IN EVERY LOTS OF IN
THIS ROOM AND EVERYBODY IS
WORKING TO MAKE THAT HAPPEN.
BUT RIGHT NOW THIS IS-
IMPORTANT CRITICAL NEED FOR THE
COMMUNION SO IN STRONG SUPPORT.
HELLO I'M JACQUI BELL ACOSTA
THE CALIFORNIA'S PARTY LIVING
NETWORK. WHAT IS THIS A COUPLE
OF POINTS ON THE SAFETY NET. IS
A REALLY THINK THAT WE CONTINUE
TO NEED TO LOOK OUTSIDE THE
SYSTEM OF JUSTICE THE HOUSE.
BECAUSE OF THE LACK OF. GOOD
MEDICAL SERVICES AVAILABLE TO
FOLKS THAT GO INTO CRISIS
THAT'S ONE THE OTHER ONE IS I'M
HOPING THAT. THE CONVERSATION
BEGINS TO HAPPEN AROUND
SUPPORTED LIVING AND THE SAFETY
NET SUPPORT SERVICES. MANY
SUPPORT OF LIVING PROVIDERS
PRIOR TO THE SAFETY NET OR THE
SAFETY NET. ARE YOU I MYSELF
AND MY AGENCIES OR FORTY FIVE
INDIVIDUALS THAT WERE
PREVIOUSLY IN DEVELOPMENTAL
CENTERS. I CURRENTLY SERVE
FOLKS IN SUPPORT OF LIVING THAT
LEFT THE COMMUNITY CRISIS HOME.
SO I THINK WE NEED TO START
HAVING THIS CONVERSATION
BECAUSE WHAT'S GOING TO SUIT
SUPPORTED LIVING. AND YOU
PROVIDE THAT SUPPORT THERE'S NO
NEED TO MOVE ON. THE SUPPORT
STAYS WHERE IT'S AT I AM IN
SUPPORT OF HAVING THE PARENTS
AND THE FAMILIES GET THE
SUPPORT IN THE HOME. YOU BEGIN
TO MITIGATE A LOT OF THOSE WHEN
FAMILIES CAN HAVE THAT ENHANCE
SUPPORT AND SERVICES. IN A
CRISIS SITUATION I JUST THINK
THE SAME THING NEEDS TO HAPPEN
IN OUR ADULT COMMUNITY SO THEY
DON'T END UP NEEDING. THE
SERVICES OF A C. C. H. S. OR
AND B. S. C. H. BUT IF WE CAN
FOR. A WHOLE. A TO PEOPLE IN.
WHERE THEY LIVE. THAT MAYBE WE
BEGIN TO MOVE THE SYSTEM FOR IN
A MUCH. MORE PROGRESSIVE. THANK
YOU MA'AM. I'M ALISON MARIE
DISABILITY YOU KNOW. I SO I
THINK ALL THREE INCH COME ARE
INTEREST AND THE FIRST TWO I A
WHOLE AGREE WITH LA- THAT IF
THE ALTERNATIVE IS JAIL- WHICH
IT OFTEN IS- THIS IS AN
ABSOLUTELY NECESSARY CRITICAL
AN OVERDUE STEP- PEOPLE WITH ID
DE HAVE NO BUSINESS BEING IN
REGULAR JAILS IT'S A HORRIBLE
PLACE TO BE- THEY ARE
VULNERABLE THEIR RISK IN THOSE
SETTINGS AND SO I THINK
ALTHOUGH CLEARLY I WHOLE
HEARTEDLY WITH THE LAST YOU
KNOW THE LAST COM IS IMPORTANT
I MEAN WE WANT TO PROVIDE
PREVENTION IS CRITICAL. BUT TO
THE EXTENT THAT PEOPLE ARE
READY CRIMINAL JUSTICE INVOLVED.
YOU KNOW TEMPORARILY MAKING
ADDITIONAL SPACE AVAILABLE IN
PORTER VEIL AND BUILDING OUT
THE CAPACITY IN THE COMMUNITY.
MAKES TOTAL SENSE AND IS SO
IMPORTANT- SO I THINK THOSE TWO
PIECES ARE OURS AGIN LONG
OVERDUE. I THINK ON THE START
PROGRAM- IT IT CERTAINLY SEEMS
VERY PROMISING- AND IT HAS BEEN
TRIED IN OTHER STATES WHICH IS
A GOOD THING- BUT I DO THINK
THIS IS A REALLY GREAT EXAMPLE
OF WHY INDEPENDENT EVALUATION
IS SO IMPORTANT- BECAUSE AFTER
ALL CALIFORNIA'S DIFFERENT IN
SO MANY WAYS SOME OF WHICH
WE'VE DISCUSSED IN THIS
HEARING. ON THE FACT THAT IT'S
WORKED IN OTHER STATES WELL IS
VERY ENCOURAGING AND I THINK
THE STATISTICS- THAT DIRECTOR
BIRDMAN CITED ARE ALSO
ENCOURAGING BUT MY CONCERN IS
THAT THOSE ARE NOT REALLY A
SUBSTITUTE FOR INDEPENDENT
EVALUATION WHY- WELL IN PART
BECAUSE WE DON'T KNOW WHAT
OTHER THINGS ARE GOING ON WITH
THESE FAMILIES THAT ARE
INCLUDED. RIGHT EVEN IF THEIR
RATES ARE GOING DOWN IT COULD
BE THAT AS A RESULT OF THIS
INTERVENTION THEY'RE GETTING
OTHER KINDS OF INTERVENTION
THEY'RE ACCESSING GENERIC
RESOURCES THEY'RE ACCESSING
BETTER MEDICAL CARE. AND THAT
IT'S NOT ACTUALLY THIS
INTERVENTION PER SE THAT'S
HELPING THEM BUT THE OTHER
THINGS THAT ARE COMING TO THEM
AT THE SAME TIME- I DON'T KNOW
I DON'T KNOW EITHER WAY BUT I
THINK IT THIS IS A PERFECT
EXAMPLE OF WHY. SORT OF
ENABLING AND THERE'S DIFFERENT
WAYS TO ENABLE INDEPENDENT
EVALUATION IT COULD BE MAKING
THE DATA AVAILABLE AND DE
IDENTIFIED FORM SO THAT THE
RESEARCH COMMUNITY WHICH IS
ROBUST IN LARGE IN CALIFORNIA-
YOU KNOW CAN ANALYZE AND SEE IS
IT REALLY THIS INTERVENTION OR
OTHER THINGS ARE HAPPENING AND
SAME TIME. BUT I THINK WE NEED
TO KNOW BECAUSE OF THIS IS
GONNA BE REPLICATED IN OTHER-
REGIONAL CENTERS IS IT SEEMS IT
WILL BE. WE NEED TO KNOW
WHETHER THERE'S A CAUSAL
RELATIONSHIP WHETHER IT'S
CORRELATIONAL AND WHETHER WHAT
WE'VE ENCOURAGING THINGS WE'VE
SEEN IN OTHER STATES ARE
ACTUALLY HAPPENING IN HERE IN
CALIFORNIA AS WELL. THANK YOU.
YOU KATIE HARDER DISABILITY CAL.
ON WE HAVE A CONCERN THAT THERE.
OF THE BED CAP THAT PORTER FELL.
ON NEED UP BE NASA. AND
CERTAINLY MAY NOT BE NECESSARY
FOR THE DURATION. OF THE
WRITTEN IN THE TRAILER BILL
CURRENTLY. AND THAT'S BECAUSE
IT'S OUR UNDERSTANDING THAT
THERE ARE PEOPLE AT.
PORTERFIELD DEVELOPMENTAL
CENTER WHO MAY BE READY TO
TRANSITION TO THE COMMUNITY.
AND NEED A COMMUNITY PLACEMENT.
ON FOUND FOR THEM. BOB WE ALSO-
BELIEVE THAT IF WE WERE TO LOOK
AT ALIGNING THE I. D. D.
DIVERSION STATUTES TO THE
MENTAL HEALTH DIVERSION STATUTE
THAT COULD REDUCE OUR JAIL
POPULATION. M. M. ALSO IN TERMS
OF. THE RESOURCES FOR OUR I. S.
TEAS- IN PREVIOUS YEARS THE
LEGISLATURE HAD. INCLUDED
COMMUNITY BED SPECIFICALLY FOR
PEOPLE IN THE I. S. T.
SITUATION AND UNFORTUNATELY-
GIVEN COMPETING DEMANDS ON
THEIR ATTENTION THE DEPARTMENT
DIDN'T PRIORITIZE THAT
DEVELOPMENT. AND SO
PRIORITIZING THAT DEVELOPMENT
COULD ALSO REDUCE THE AMOUNT OF
TIME THAT THE EXPANSION
IMPORTER BILL MIGHT WELL BE
NECESSARY. THE OTHER THING IN
REGARDS TO THE- FIVE ADDITIONAL
EBS AGES THE STAFF AT THE
OFFICE OF CLIENTS RIGHTS
ADVOCACY ARE HEAVILY INVOLVED.
ON BECAUSE THEY'RE PART OF THE
INDIVIDUAL BEHAVIOR SUPPORT
TEAMS AND REALLY SUPPORT THOSE
PLACEMENTS AND FIND THEM TO BE
VERY EFFECTIVE FOR OUR CLIENTS.
HOWEVER WE HAVE TO CAPS RUNNING
AND WE REALLY NEED TO ALIGN
THOSE CAPS PARTICULARLY IF
WE'RE LOOKING AT INCREASING ON
THOSE THOSE BEDS IN THIS YEAR.
THANK YOU GIVE. AMY WESTLING
THE ASSOCIATION OF REGIONAL
CENTER AGENCIES WE APPRECIATE
THE ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL
IN THIS AREA WE UNDERSTAND THAT
THERE ARE ACTUALLY IN EXCESS OF
TWENTY PEOPLE CURRENTLY WAITING
TO GET INTO A PORTABLE
DEVELOPMENTAL CENTER SO WE VIEW
THIS AS- UNNECESSARY START TO
MEETING THEIR NEEDS OF COURSE
WANT TO TRANSITION PEOPLE. FROM
PORTER BILL INTO THE COMMUNITY
AS IT'S SAFE AND APPROPRIATE
BUT RECOGNIZE THAT AS THE
POPULATION GROWS AND CONTINUES
TO GET MORE COMPLEX. THAT THIS
MAY BE A NECESSARY STEP AGAIN
ALSO APPRECIATE THE PROPOSAL
AND SUPPORTED FOR THE EXPANSION.
OF THE CAST SERVICES- I'M SORRY
THE START. AS WE HAVE WAY TOO
MANY ACRONYMS IN OUR SYSTEM AND
I TRY TO KEEP THEM ALL STRAIGHT
AND SOMETIMES FAIL BUT THE
START SERVICES AS- MANY BEFORE
ME HAVE NOTED THE- IMPORTANCE
OF INTERVENING AHEAD OF CRISIS
IS REALLY WHERE WE'RE ALL
TRYING TO GET TO IS A SYSTEM
BUT AS- I SAID A MINUTE AGO.
WHEN SOMEONE'S INVOLVED IN THE
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM WE
REALLY DO NEED TO DO EVERYTHING
WE CAN TO MOVE THEM OUT OF
COUNTY JAILS THANK YOU. THANK
YOU SEING NO FURTHER PUBLIC
COMMENT ALL BRING IT BACK UP TO
THE SUBCOMMITTEE- AND I'D LIKE
TO ECHO THAT LAST COMMENT IF I
COULD AS WELL AS WHAT THE LA
HAD SAID LAST YEAR. WHICH IS
THAT MOVING THE SYSTEM MORE
TOWARDS PREVENTION OF CRISES
AND AWAY FROM HAVING TO RESPOND
TO CRISES IS IMPORTANT. AND I
WOULD JUST. ALSO WANTS TO AGREE
THAT ESTABLISHING PORTERVILLE
AND TAKING OUR DD POPULATION
OUT OF JAILS WILL HELP US TO
PREVENT SOME OF THOSE CRISES
FROM OCCURRING IN THE FIRST
PLACE AS WELL IF I COULD.
REGARDING WE HAD RECEIVED A
PLAN AND- FOR THE SAFETY NET
SERVICES AND- TO BE FAIR IT
SEEMED MORE LIKE A TIME LINE
FOR HOW WE GOT TO TODAY WITHOUT
A- PLAN LOOKING FORWARD WITH
REGARDS TO WHAT WE WERE TRYING
TO ACCOMPLISH AND SO. HOW DOES
THE DEPARTMENT PLANNED FOR
SAFETY NET SERVICES AND HOME
DEVELOPMENT MOVING FORWARD.
THANK YOU WANT- AS WE'VE TALKED
ABOUT OUR DEVELOPMENTAL
SERVICES TASK FORCE AND THE
RELATED WORK GROUPS- REALLY
IMPORTANT WORK GROUPS- ONE OF
THEM- DEFINITELY FOCUSES ON
SAFETY NET AND ALSO A FOCUS ON
COMMUNITY RESOURCES AND
DEVELOPMENT- WE HAVE- THE- THE-
GIMME PLACEMENT PLAN WHICH IS
ALSO PART COMMUNITY RESOURCE
DEVELOPMENT AND ANNUALLY E
HAVE APPROXIMATELY. TWENTY
SEVEN MILLION THAT REGIONAL
CENTERS HAVE ACCESS TO DEVELOP
RESOURCES PART OF THE ELEMENTS
THAT IT'S REQUIRED AND THAT IS
TO IDENTIFY YOU KNOW WHAT ARE
THE NEEDS OF THE INDIVIDUALS TO
SUPPORT THE REQUEST THAT'S
COMING TO THE DEPARTMENT. SO A
NUMBER OF THOSE AREAS IN WHICH
WE'RE ABLE TO DO IS TO BRING
THAT INFORMATION- TICKET TO
ASSESS THE SAFETY NET AND- WORK
WITH THE DS TASK FORCE TO
IDENTIFY THOSE DATA POINTS IN
THOSE DATA ELEMENTS THAT ARE
GOING TO INFORM US TO WHAT ARE
SOME OF THE FUTURE NEEDS- WE DO
KNOW THAT WE CAN- TAKE A LOOK
AT TRENDS. I'M INFORMATION TO
PROJECT YOU KNOW WHAT ARE KIND
OF THE PLANS THAT WE'RE GONNA
NEED TO WHAT SOMETIMES WE DON'T
KNOW BENEFIT OF WORKING WITH
OTHER STATES AND GET AN IDEA AS
TO WHAT THEIR STRATEGIES ARE OR
WHAT ARE SOME OF THE THINGS
THAT MAY BE EMERGING THAT WERE
NOT AS AWARE OF- AND THOSE ARE
THE THINGS WE HAVE TO CONTINUE
TO BE SENSITIVE TO AND- AND
WANT TO BE- OPEN TO AND HAVE
TO. REACT TO AS OPPOSED TO
ALWAYS PLANNED BUT WE DO
APPRECIATE AND LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH OUR TASK FORCE TO
DO THAT. IF I MAY I'D COME LIKE
TO END WITH THE REQUEST AGAIN
AND THAT WOULD BE TO ASK THE
DEPARTMENT TO PROVIDE A
DETAILED APPROACH IN WRITING OF
THIS STRATEGIC. PLAN PROCESS IT
USES FOR THE SAFETY NET
SERVICES IN THE FUTURE. TO
INFORM OUR ASSESSMENT REGARDING
THE GOVERNOR SAFETY NET
SPENDING. PRIORITIES AND IF I.
COULD ECHO WHAT THE LA- HAD
SAID. TO ASK FOR YOU TO INCLUDE
THE SPECIFIC REGIONS THAT
REMAIN WITHOUT SAFETY NET
SERVICES ON THE MAP- I WOULD BE
REMISS NOT TO. LOOK AT THE
GREAT CENTRAL VALLEY AS WELL AS
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA- ASSIST
SOMETHING THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION CAN PROVIDE AND
ON WHAT TIME FOR AN- THIS
FEATURE ONLY NOTE THAT WE DO
HAVE QUARTERLY LEGISLATIVE
BRIEFINGS WHICH MAY SERVE AS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO PROVIDE UPDATES
ON THESE TYPES OF TOPICS TO THE
EXTENT THAT WORKS FOR YOU THAT.
MIGHT BE THE APPROPRIATE FORM
TO PROVIDE UPDATES ON THE
SAFETY NET PLAN. MOVING FORWARD.
WOULD BE NICE IF WE COULD HAVE
IT PRIOR TO MAY REVISE AS WE
WILL THEN BE MAKING A DECISION
REGARDING THE- SAFETY NET-
PROPOSAL AND SO. IT WOULD BE
HELPFUL FOR US TO KNOW BY THAT
TIME FRAME IF THAT WORKED
WITHIN THE QUARTERLY MEETINGS.
THAT WOULD BE ACCEPTABLE SO.
WITH THAT WE WILL HOLD ISSUE
FIVE OPEN IN THE BOND ISSUE SIX.
HI. CAN RECORD FOR ME. DO.
GOOD
EVENING. CHAIRMAN ARAMBULA AND
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS OF MY NAME IS
KEVIN ROTH AND I AM THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF MODELS.
THAT MINUS WE EMPLOY OVER
SIXTEEN HUNDRED DIRECT SUPPORT
PROFESSIONALS THAT SERVE MORE
THAN SIXTEEN HUNDRED
INDIVIDUALS WITH DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES IN THE SAN
FRANCISCO EAST BAY. I'M ALSO
THE VICE PRESIDENT OF THE
SUPPORTED LIVING NETWORKS. AND
AMMAN TO THE DISABILITY
WORKGROUP TASK FORCE FOR GROUPS
ON THE STRUCTURAL ON IN EQUITY
ONE. SO FROM THE STATE
CONTINUES TO INCREASE
EXPENDITURES AND DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES SERVICES TO
ADDRESS THE LARGE NUMBER OF NEW
INDIVIDUALS. AND RECEIVING
SERVICES AND THE RISING STATE
MINIMUM WAGE EVEN SO THE STATE
READ STUDY CONCLUDES THAT THE
SYSTEM IS UNDERFUNDED BY ONE
POINT EIGHT BILLION DOLLARS OF
WE'VE ALL BEEN TALKING ABOUT.
ON THE STATE'S RESOURCES MUST
BE USED MORE EFFECTIVELY THAN
THEY HAVE BEEN IN THE PAST.
THAT'S WHY WE ARE HERE.
SUPPORTING THE SERVICE AN
OUTCOME INITIATIVE. THIS UNIQUE
INITIATIVE IS DESIGNED TO
ENSURE THE EFFECTIVE TARGETING
OF THE STATE'S RESOURCES. BY
DEFINING DELIVERING AND
MEASURING QUALITY SERVICES.
IT'S HARD TO BELIEVE BUT THOSE
DEFINITIONS DO NOT CURRENTLY
EXIST AT THE STATE OR NATIONAL
LEVEL. MUCH LESS THE TOOLS TO
MEASURE AND IMPROVE THE QUALITY.
IT THESE DEFINITIONS IN
MEASUREMENTS OF QUALITY
SERVICES ARE NEEDED TO FORM A
SYSTEM THAT HELPS THE STATE
TARGET RESOURCES TOWARDS
QUALITY PROGRAMS WITH PROVEN
OUTCOMES. THE METHOD FOR
DEVELOPING THESE QUALITY
SERVICES HAS BEEN DELIVERED TO
THE ASSEMBLY SUBCOMMITTEE. THE
METHOD WAS DEVELOPED TO THAT
CALIFORNIA'S BORDER LIVING
NETWORK PAY PROJECT PERSON
CENTERED ADVOCACY VISION AND
EDUCATION. PROJECTS PRIMARY
FUNDER IS THE STATE COUNCIL ON
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES. AS
WE DEVELOP THE BLUEPRINT FOR
QUALITY SERVICES INCREASING
INTEREST ABOUT THE APPROACH
LEAD ASSEMBLY MEMBERS SPEAKER
PRO TEM KEVIN MULLIN TO SPONSOR
THE SERVICE OUT COMMISSION OF
WOULD LIKE TO THANK ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MULLIN FOR HIS SUPPORT.
AND HIS VISION. EXPERTS FROM
AROUND THE NATION HAVE
EXPRESSED INTEREST IN CS
ISLANDS APPROACH TO QUALITY
SERVICES. DOCTOR DIDN'T CHEN
DISTINGUISHED PROFESSOR AND
DIRECTOR OF STATISTICAL
DEVELOPMENT AT THE UNIVERSITY
OF NORTH CAROLINA AT CHAPEL
CHAPEL HILL ALSO PRESIDENT OF
THE AMERICAN STATISTICAL
ASSOCIATION HAS THIS TO SAY
ABOUT THE OUTCOME INITIATIVE.
FROM OUR DISCUSSIONS I'M EVEN
MORE CONVINCED THAT THIS
INITIATIVE WILL HELP STATE OF
CALIFORNIA SIGNIFICANTLY
QUANTIFY THE SERVICES NEEDED TO
SUPPORT CALIFORNIA'S
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITY
COMMUNITY WORKING TOGETHER. I'M
SURE WE CAN CREATE EVIDENCE
BASED SERVICE OUTCOME TOOL
BOXES TO MEASURE SERVICE
IMPROVE SERVICE IMPROVEMENTS
FOR THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
WE'RE ALSO CONTACT WITH-
NATIONALLY AND INTERNATIONALLY
KNOWN EXPERTS SUCH AS DR JULIE
BEAT. BEAD BROWN AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF KENT ENGLAND. THE
NATIONAL QUALITY FORUM WHICH
CREATED THE DISABILITY SERVICE
RESEARCH THE DOMAINS TO THE
GUIDE TO GUIDE FEDERAL FUNDING-
IS MEETING WITH CL AND IN TWO
WEEKS IN WASHINGTON. THE FORM
HAS STATED THAT IF WE ARE
SUCCESSFUL IN OUR APPROACH
CALIFORNIA WILL LEAD THE WAY.
IN DEVELOPING TOOLS FOR
EFFECTIVELY DELIVERING QUALITY
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITY
SERVICES. TO THESE
CONVERSATIONS RECENT
CONVERSATIONS AND OTHERS WE OWE
FORMING AND NETWORK EXPERTS
THAT WILL BRING NEW INSIGHTS
AND TOOLS INTO THE CALIFORNIA
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITY
SERVICE SYSTEM. IN ORDER TO
BUILD ON THESE RESULTS ON A HEY
AND MAINTAIN A CONTINUED EFFORT
TO CREATE QUALITY SERVICES THE
OUTCOME INITIATIVE NEEDS TO BE
FUNDED THIS YEAR. WE NEED TO
CONTINUE DEVELOPING THE
FRAMEWORK ON A LARGER SCALE AND
CREATE A PILOT PROJECT TO TEST
THE SOFTWARE DATA COLLECTION
STAFF TRAINING. QUALITY
DEFINITIONS AND MEASUREMENTS.
THE TWO MILLION BUDGET PROPOSAL
WILL ALLOW US TO PLAN PILOT AND
PROVE THAT THE STATE CAN
PROVIDE EFFECTIVE QUALITY
SERVICE TO CALIFORNIANS WITH
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES.
OVERCOMING THE CURRENT OUTCOME
RATE IMPASSE. WORKING WITH YOU
AND THE STATE WE BELIEVE WE CAN
JUMP START THIS PROCESS THANK
YOU. THANK YOU SIR DIRECTOR
PARCHMAN ANY COMMENTS SORRY.
NEXT ON OUR AGENDA NO SAVE IT
TO LATER THAT'S OKAY TOO NO
THANK YOU I- APPRECIATED-
MISTER AT JOINING AND COMING TO
OUR OFFICE AND GET PROVIDING US
AN OVERVIEW- BUT- NO COMMENTS
ON ON THE PROPOSAL IS NOT OURS
THANK YOU. BERMAN FINANCE LA.
ECHOING DIRECTOR BARGES
COMMENTS WE APPRECIATED THE
TIME TO LEARN MORE ABOUT THE
PROPOSAL WERE AWARE OF IT BUT
YOU'RE NOT A POSITION AT THIS
TIME THANK YOU. PUBLIC COMMENT
ON ISSUE SIX. I AM NOT GOING TO
SAY GOOD AFTERNOON. GOOD
EVENING. THE STRONG WILLED WILL
SURVIVE I'M JACKI BUILT FOR US
ONCE AGAIN I AM OBVIOUSLY SAID
IN AND- SUPPORT OF THE DEATH OF
DISABILITY SERVICE OUTCOME
INITIATIVE I THINK IT'S BEEN A
MISSION OF ME IN MY AGENCY THE
LAST TWENTY SIX YEARS OF DOING
THIS. I'M HOPING THAT BY THE
TIME I RETIRE I LOOK IN THE
DISTANT FUTURE THAT WILL HAVE
REALLY GOOD QUALITY DSP
TRAINING THAT LEAD TO DATA THAT
LEAD TO OUTCOMES BUT RIGHT NOW
I THINK WHEN I TALK TO MY TEAM
AND SAY WHAT ARE THE SERVICE
OUTCOMES WHAT ARE WE EXPECTED
TO DO I THINK WHAT THEY THINK
THAT WE HAVE TO DO EVERY SINGLE
YEAR IT'S COME BACK TO THE
CAPITAL AND CONTINUE TO TALK
ABOUT RATES AND WAGES THAT IS A
CRITICAL CONVERSATION. IT'S
CRITICAL BUT A PERSON WITH A
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITY HAVING
QUALITY SERVICES LIFE OUTCOMES
THAT ARE THEY'RE CHOOSING CAN'T
BE DELAYED BECAUSE WE CONTINUE
TO HAVE A RATE CONVERSATION I'M
ASSUMING ON THE DAY I RETIRE
WILL BE COMING BACK TO THE
CAPITAL AND I WILL HAVE BEEN
RETIRED AND STILL TALK ABOUT
RATES I'M I'M PRETTY MUCH
PREDICTING THAT FUTURE FOR ME
BUT I ALSO THINK THAT I HOPE
THAT WE KNOW THAT WE HAVE
DISABILITY SERVICES TRAINING
THAT ACTUALLY MATTERS. CAN WE
DECIDE THAT A DIRECT SUPPORT
PROFESSIONAL IS THAT I WAS THAT
THE WORK FORCE CRISIS SUMMIT
WAY MISSOURI AND A TORNADO
WARNING TALK ABOUT THE WORK
FORCE CRISIS NATIONALLY THERE
ARE THE SAME CONVERSATIONS
WATER OUTCOMES WE DON'T KNOW
WHAT OUTCOMES ARE WE KNOW WE'RE
UNDER FUNDED WE DON'T KNOW WHAT
OUTCOMES ARE IT'S NOT ABOUT.
TASK ANALYSIS THAT'S NOT THE
QUESTION THE QUESTION IS HOW DO
YOU CHIEF HEALTH AND WELLNESS
WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT
HOSPITALIZATION TO THE
REDUCTION OF HOSPITALIZATIONS
FOR THAT PILOT PROJECT WHEN I
HEARD DIRECTOR BARS WE TALK
ABOUT THAT ON LIKE THAT WOULD
BE REALLY GREAT INFORMATION FOR
US TO TRACK IN OUR SYSTEM AS A
WHOLE BECAUSE RIGHT NOW YOU
COULDN'T SAY HOW MANY PEOPLE
BASED ON THE TRAINING THEY
RECEIVE IN THE PROGRAM THERE IN
REDUCE THEIR HOSPITALIZATIONS
BECAUSE OF THE HEALTH AND
WELLNESS RATED THEY RECEIVE. WE
DON'T KNOW WE KNOW THIS FROM
THIS PILOT. BUT THERE'S THREE
AND THIRTY THOUSAND PEOPLE WITH
INTELLECTUAL AND DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. THAT WE DON'T KNOW
THE ANSWER THAT QUESTION FOR SO
LET'S START BEGINNING TO HAVE
THAT HARD CONVERSATION. THANK
YOU. MY PLANTS AND EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA
SUPPORTED LIVING NETWORK I
OBVIOUSLY I RISE IN SUPPORT OF
THE- BUDGET REQUEST- YOU KNOW
AS MENTIONED IN PREVIOUS PUBLIC
COMMEN- WE ARE IN PHASE ONE
RIGHT NOW- WE ARE WORKING WITH
ON THE STATE COUNCIL GRANTS ON
THE PAVE PROJECT PERSON
CENTERED ADVOCACY VISION AND
EDUCATION- WE DANCE. ASSEMBLED
AN AMAZING ADVISORY GROUP OF
STAKEHOLDERS FROM OUR
COMMUNITY- PEOPLE SERVED
PARENTS PROVIDERS- AND- JUST
STAKEHOLDERS. ON THIS PROPOSAL
WILL ALLOW THE STATE COUNCIL TO
IMMEDIATELY BAD BE READY TO
MOVE FORWARD ON. ON TO PHASE
TWO- I'M AT THE COMPLETION OF
THE GRANTS- IT'S A NECESSARY
STEP IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION-
WITH ALL DUE RESPECT I CONTEND
THAT THIS NO EXCUSE NOT TO
ADDRESS IMPROVED QUALITY OF
SERVICES IN AN UNDER FUNDED
SYSTEM- THAT. CAN BE ACHIEVED
BY DEFINING NATURALS MEASURABLE%
SERVICE OUTCOMES COLLECTING AND
REPORTING DATA AND COURSE
CORRECTING ALONG THE WAY. WE
ASK THE BUDGET PROPOSAL BE
FUNDED IN THIS BUDGET WE ASK
FOR YOUR SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SIR. HELLO GOOD
EVENING I MY NAME IS GINNY WAS
THE ARE AND I'M THE DIRECTOR OF
OPERATIONS FOR MONO SOME CARE.
AND I'M ALSO SERVING AS A
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA PRESIDENT
OF THE CALIFORNIA RESTAURANT
ASSOCIATION- AS YOU HEARD FROM
EARLIER APPARENT FROM CAL TASH
SPOKE ABOUT THE CHALLENGES. OF
SECURING A QUALITY STAFFING FOR
RESPITE SERVICES AND I JUST
WANTED TO EXPRESS MY SUPPORT IN
SUPPORT OF OUR ORGANIZATION FOR
THIS BUDGET REQUEST. I REALLY
DO HOPE THAT YOU HOLD A
CONSIDERATION AND THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME. THANK YOU MA'AM.
SEEING NO FURTHER PUBLIC
COMMENT I WILL BRING IT BACK UP
TO THE SUBCOMMITTEE. YES I
COULD SAY ONE THING. IT I- IT
WAS VERY TOUCHING HERE THE
PARENTS BECAUSE WE DO RESPITE
TOUGH. AND I ALSO UNDERSTAND
THAT THE SYSTEM IS UNDERFUNDED
BELIEVE ME WE JUST HAD AN
EMERGENCY MEETING AT OUR AGENCY
BECAUSE WE LOST MONEY- SO THIS
CRISIS GOES ON AND ON. SO AND I
UNDERSTAND THE SENTIMENT OF
SOME SERVICE PROVIDERS IT SAY.
WE IT'S CHANGED IT'S RIDICULOUS
TO TALK ABOUT SERVICE OUTCOMES-
WHEN WE CAN'T EVEN GET STAFF I
UNDERSTAND THAT SENTIMENT. BUT
I THINK THAT THAT'S A
MISPERCEPTION OF OUR PROPOSAL.
WE WERE TALKING ABOUT SERVICE
OUTCOMES SERVICE DELIVERY
OUTCOMES RIGHT- WE TALK ABOUT
MEASURING THEM WE'RE NOT
TALKING ABOUT BEATING UP
SERVICE PROVIDERS A CAN'T MAKE
THEM THE SERVICING THAT'S
THAT'S NOT THE ISSUE WE SHOULD
BE MEASURING HOW THE IMPACT OF
THE UNDER FUNDED SYSTEM AFFECTS
QUALITY WE CAN'T DO THAT.
WITHOUT DETERMINING SERVICE
DELIVER QUALITY SO. A WEEK WE
CAN'T EVEN IF WE DON'T EVEN
KNOW WHAT THAT MEANS HOW CAN WE
TALK ABOUT THE EFFECT ON PEOPLE
WITH DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES%
IN AN UNDERFUNDED SYSTEM AND
THAT'S ONE OF THE PROBLEMS SO
THAT WHEN THERE'S OF WHEN
THERE'S A CRISIS IN FUNDING-
IT'S EASY TO CUT. THIS THE
BUDGET LIKE IT HAPPENED IN THE
LAST GREAT RECESSION RIGHT
WHERE THEY JUST CUT IT BY FOUR
POINT TWO FIVE PERCENT-
BECAUSE- WE COULDN'T
DEMONSTRATE. WHAT THE IMPACT OF
THAT WAS AND SO I THINK IT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT TO UNDERSTAND
THAT THIS INITIATIVE IS NOT
ABOUT. A IGNORING THE RATE
STUDY OR IGNORING UNDERFUNDED-
NATURE OF OUR SYSTEM. THANK YOU
SIR- AND WITH THAT WE WILL HOLD
THIS ISSUE OPEN AND MOVE ON TO
ISSUE SEVEN. WE'RE GETTING PAST
A CERTAIN HOUR I MADE JUST- ASK
THAT WE PREPARE FOR PUBLIC
COMMENT ON EACH OF THESE
REMAINING ISSUES SO. IF YOU'RE
GOING TO SPEAK YOU MAY WANT TO
START WINDING UP NOW. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR- BERRY JOURNEY
FROM THE CALIFORNIA DISABILITY
SERVICES ASSOCIATION AND I AND
I PRESENT TONIGHT ON A PROPOSAL
THAT WE HAVE FOR TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE. TWO MEN TO PROGRAMS
THAT HAVE BEEN IN EXISTENCE
SINCE TWENTY SIXTEEN SEVENTEEN-
THE PAID INTERNSHIP PROGRAM IN
THE CA INCENTIVES PROGRAM THAT
WERE BOTH DESIGNED TO INCREASE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR EMPLOYMENT
AND COMPETITIVE IN A GREAT
EMPLOYMENT OUTCOMES FOR
INDIVIDUALS WITH DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES. SINCE THOSE
PROGRAMS HAVE BEEN IN PLACE
WE'VE APPROPRIATED TWENTY NINE
MILLION DOLLARS PER YEAR- WE'RE
IN THE FOURTH YEAR NOW IT'S
PROPOSED TO CONTINUE NEXT YEAR-
TO FUND THOSE PROGRAMS TO. TO
ACHIEVE MORE CHAU COMES WHICH
IS IN LINE WITH STATE POLICY IN
THE APPOINT FIRST POLICY AND
CONSISTENT WITH SOME OF THE
OUTCOMES GOALS THAT WE'VE HEARD
ABOUT TONIGHT- UNFORTUNATELY
THE RAMP UP ON THIS PROGRAMS
HIS IS. TAKEN IT'S TAKEN A
WHILE THE FIRST YEAR WE SPENT
ONE POINT TWO MILLION DOLLARS
OF THE TWENTY NINE WE SEND
FOUR POINT SIX AND THEN SEVEN
POINT SEVEN IN THE LAST FISCAL
YEAR FOR WHICH WE HAVE FULL
DATA. WE ARE PROPOSING A COUPLE
OF FIXES TO THE PAID INTERNSHIP
PROGRAM SIDE THAT WOULD MAKE
SURE THAT WERE OPTIMIZING THE
LEVEL OF OPPORTUNITY CURRENTLY
PROVIDE IN CONSUMERS WITH
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES HAVE
AN EARNINGS CAP OF TEN THOUSAND
FOUR HUNDRED DOLLARS A YEAR IN
THE PROGRAM. WHEN THIS WENT
INTO. EFFECT IN TWENTY SIXTEEN
THE MINIMUM WAGE IN THE STATE
WAS TEN DOLLARS AN HOUR- AS THE
MINIMUM WAGE IS INCREASED THE
ACTUAL OPPORTUNITY UNDER THAT
EARNINGS CAP HAS DECREASED
BECAUSE YOU'RE GONNA HIT THAT
EARNINGS CAP FASTER SO WE'RE
PROPOSING TO SWITCH FROM
ATTORNEYS CAPTAIN HOURS CAP.
WHICH REFLECTS THE LEVEL OF
OPPORTUNITY THAT WAS IN PLACE
WHEN THE PROGRAM WENT INTO
PLACE AT ONE THOUSAND FORTY
HOURS. PER YEAR AND WE'RE ALSO
PROPOSING THAT PROVIDERS WOULD
BE ABLE TO- GET AN
ADMINISTRATIVE FEE FOR
FACILITATING THE PAID
INTERNSHIP PROGRAM CURRENTLY.
MOST PROVIDERS WHO WHO DO THESE
THINGS DON'T GET ANY SORT OF
RECOGNITION OR REIMBURSEMENT
FOR FACILITATING DOING THE
PAPERWORK THOSE TYPES OF THINGS
FOR THE PAID INTERNSHIP PROGRAM
SO WE WOULD PUT A FIFTEEN
PERCENT- ADMINISTRATIVE FEE ON
THAT WHICH IS IN LINE WITH THE
ADMINISTRATIVE FEE FOR OTHER
SERVICES THE OTHER. THE OTHER
SIDE OF THIS IS THE COMPETITIVE
INTEGRATED EMPLOYMENT
INCENTIVES PROGRAM. WE ARE
PROPOSING TO DOUBLE THE LEVEL
OF THE INCENTIVES FOR BOTH THE
THIRTY DAY SIX MONTH AND ONE
YEAR MARKS. I'M FROM THEIR
CURRENT EXISTING AMOUNTS IN
STATUTE WE BELIEVE THAT THIS
WILL FACILITATE MORE JOB
DEVELOPMENT EMPLOYMENT
EXPLORATION JOB DISCOVERY.
THERE'S CURRENTLY A NOT
SYSTEMATIC SYSTEMATICALLY
FUNDED FOR PROVIDERS. I THINK
THERE'S A LOT OF AGREEMENT THEY
COMPETITIVE INTEGRATED
EMPLOYMENT IS AN OUTCOME THAT
WE WANT TO DRIVE TOWARDS FOR
THOSE CONSUMERS WHO WHO ARE
INTERESTED IN PURSUING IT. AND
WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO IS
FACILITATE A LANDSCAPE THAT-
PROVIDES ADEQUATE FUNDING FOR-
PROVIDERS TO. TO MAKE THAT A
REALITY THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SIR DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE ELIO.
OF WE HAVE A NO POSITION AT
THIS TIME WE ARE AWARE OF IT
WITH THE OF THE PROPOSED AND
HAVE BEEN WORKING WITH MR
TARTINI ON PROVIDING SOME
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE. THANK YOU.
THANK SONY PARTICULARLY- I JUST
HOPE TO MAKE SORT OF A LARGER
POINT- GOING BACK TO THE
EARLIER DISCUSSION ABOUT THE
PERFORMANCE INCENTIVE PROGRAM
AND THAT IS IF THE LEGISLATURE
WERE TO REJECTED THAT PROPOSAL
OR AT LEAST REJECTED IN SOME
SOME FORM THIS- SOURCE OF
FUNDING FOR THE INTERNSHIP
PROGRAM IN COMPETITIVE
INTEGRATED EMPLOYMENT
INCENTIVES- COULD BE USED TO
TEST. INCENTIVE PAYMENTS AND I
REALIZE THAT- PART OF THIS
ALREADY IS AN INCENTIVE PAYMENT
OF PROGRAM HOWEVER THE RULES
THE RESULT IN TERMS OF DOLLARS
SPENT HAVE BEEN PRETTY MODEST
AND THIS MIGHT BE AN
OPPORTUNITY- TO REQUEST THAT
THE DEPARTMENT THINK ABOUT HOW
TO RESTRUCTURE THE PROGRAM TO
ACHIEVE THE RESULTS- RETRIEVE
THE GOALS THAT IT HOPES TO
ACHIEVE AND SO SOME OF THE
RESTRUCTURING COULD INCLUDE THE
OPTIONS THAT MISTER JOURNEY-
PRESENTED- COULD INCLUDE SOME
OTHER OPTIONS BUT IT MIGHT BE-
A WAY TO SORT OF. EASE INTO
PERFORMANCE INCENTIVES- AS A
PILOT THANK YOU WANT TO PROVIDE
THE DEPARTMENT TIME TO ADDRESS
THIS PROPOSAL IF YOU SO WISH.
WE ALSO SIMILAR TO FINANCE
DON'T HAVE A POSITION ON THIS
PROPOSAL THANK YOU. WE WILL NOW
TAKE PUBLIC COMMENT ON ISSUE
SEVEN. HI THANK YOU HARRY PEARL
WITH PATH POINT- JUST WANT TO
GIVE STRONG SUPPORT TO IT I
THINK AS WE THINK ABOUT
SUSTAINABILITY IN THE SYSTEM
THE MORE PEOPLE THAT ARE
WORKING. REALLY HELP
SUSTAINABILITY THAT RETURN
FOLKS AND THE TAXPAYERS AND
BEING INVOLVED IN THE COMMUNITY
AND THIS IS A JUST A MAYORAL
COMMONSENSE WAY NO ADDITIONAL
DOLLARS BUT A WAY TO REALLY
INCENTIVIZE PEOPLE GETTING OUT
WORKING BEING PART OF THE
COMMUNITY OUR SOCIETY
UNFORTUNATELY IS A LOT TIMES
<c.magenta>EASURE BY SELF WORTH. AND</c>
WORTH IN TERMS OF A JOB IN A
PAYCHECK AND THIS PURCHASE MORE
MORE PEOPLE TO HAVE THOSE
OPPORTUNITIES REDUCING HUGE
BENEFITS PAID INTERNSHIP
PROGRAM SEE A PAYMENT SO I
APPRECIATE THE DEVELOPMENT OF
THE PROPOSAL AND THE WORK THAT
THE DEPARTMENT AGENCIES STERN
ON IT. SO THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SIR. WELL CENTER COMMUNITY
CONSULTANTS I'VE BEEN WORKING
ON TRYING TO EXPAND EMPLOYMENT
FOR FOLKS LADY DI FOR FORTY
YEARS. THIS IS ACTUALLY THREE
YEARS AGO WHEN THIS CAME IN
PLACES ACSI OPEN DOORSTHAT
WOULD BE AVAILABLE TO OUR FOLKS
OF THE PAID INTERNSHIP PROGRAM.
REALLY IS A WAY FOR US TO HAVE
PEOPLE BYPASS- THE INTERVIEW
PROCESS- THE CASE IN POINT IS A
STATE INTERNSHIP PROGRAM THAT
SAID TEN PEOPLE IN IT. SEVEN
WHICH ARE NOW STATE EMPLOYEES.
THAT SOMETHING THE DEPARTMENT
REHAB IS NEVER BEEN ABLE TO
PULL OFF THE CONVEYOR HAD
EXPANDED. BUT HAVING A PULL UP
IT WAS AVAIL BECAUSE OF THAT
PROGRAM. ALSO COMING EARLY THE
TWENTY SIX HUNDRED PEOPLE. HAVE
COMPETITIVE GRATED JOBS TODAY
THE THREE AGO THREE YEARS AGO
DIDN'T. THAT DOUBLE THE DOUBLE
THAT 50% MORE PEOPLE WE HAD IN
CA NINETY FOUR. THOSE ARE HUGE
NUMBERS AND I AGREE THAT IT'S
AN OPPORTUNITY FOR US TO DO
THAT. I WOULD ARGUE ON THE FLIP
SIDE IS. WE HAVE TO TAKE OUT
SOME OF THE BUREAUCRACY SO CAN
HAPPEN QUICKER. IN AND SET UP
PAYMENTS CAN BE MADE IN A
TIMELY MANNER AND ASKING THE-
INTERNSHIP PROGRAM SO I THINK
OURS IS A MUCH EASIER THING TO
TRACK THEM DOLLARS FOR OUR
SYSTEM. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SIR. MY NAME'S ERIC KERRISON
WITH DISABILITY RIGHTS
CALIFORNIA AND WE'RE IN SUPPORT
OF A MORE OPPORTUNITIES FOR
COMPETITIVE INTEGRATED
EMPLOYMENT ARE VERY IMPORTANT
TO DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA
FOR. A PEOPLE WITH INTELLECTUAL
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES. SIR.
OTHERS WITH A STAKE COUNSELING
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES WE
HAVE- EMPLOYED THREE PEOPLE IN
THE STATE COUNCIL FOR OFFICES
TO THIS PROGRAM WE FIND AGREED
INDIVIDUALS GREAT SKILLS AND IF
YOU'RE LOOKING FOR WAYS TO
TINKER TO IMPROVE THIS PROGRAM
TO MAKE IT BETTER I'M PLEASE
CONSIDER THE ONE YOUR TIME
FRAME. EXPANDING IT TO TWO
YEARS AND WE FIND THE PEOPLE
ARE JUST NEED A LITTLE BIT MORE
TIME TO MAKE THAT LINK WHICH
LINK INTO THEIR CAREER WITH AN
INTERNSHIP PROGRAM- THE PEACE
RELATED TO WHAT HAPPENS AFTER
THE INTERNSHIP OVER IS OVER IS
A BIG QUESTION- I'M- CHAIRING
THE GOVERNOR HAS A TASK FORCE
ON. DIVERSITY IN CALIFORNIA
EMPLOYMENT I'M CHAIRING THE SUB
WORKGROUP ON DISABILITY WE'RE
LOOKING SPECIFICALLY AT THIS
PROGRAM AS TO HOW IT CREATES A
PATHWAY INTO CIVIL SERVICE TO.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SIR. I'LL
SOME RANTS DISABILITY VOICES
UNITED I JUST WANT TO PICK UP
ON A POINT THAT ERIN JUST MADE
FROM THE STATE COUNCIL- I THINK
WHAT WE ULTIMATELY WANT TO SEE
IS PEOPLE WHO ARE EMPLOYED OR
PART OF THE LABOR FORCE. OVER
THE LONG TERM. RIGHT I MEAN
THAT'S WHAT COMPETITIVE
INTEGRATING PLAN IS ABOUT. I
CAN TELL YOU THAT IN OTHER
CONTEXTS- BUT NOT IN THIS
PARTICULAR ONE BUT- SOME OF THE
PROGRAMS OF THE SIMILAR
STRUCTURE HAVE FOUND THAT THERE
ARE INCENTIVES- TO HIRE PEOPLE
KIND OF FOR. ME TO TURN ONE TO
TWO YEAR PERIODS TO GET THE
BENEFIT OF THE PROGRAM. THAT
DOESN'T NECESSARILY PARLAY INTO
A YOU KNOW LONG TERM SORT OF-
ATTACHMENT TO THE LABOR MARKET-
SO I THINK THIS IS AGAIN
ANOTHER CONTEXT IN WHICH WE
NEED TO COLLECT DATA.
LONGITUDINAL DATA SO WE CAN
TRACK PEOPLE OVER TIME. OUR
HOPE OF COURSE IS THAT THIS
WILL BE THE SPRINGBOARD FOR
LONG TERM YOU KNOW EMPLOYMENT.
BUT WE CAN'T ASSUME THAT YOU
KNOW AS ERIN JUST MENTION SO I
THINK AGAIN HERE WE NEED A
GOOD. LONG TERM DATA ON
INDIVIDUAL PARTICIPANTS TO
PROVE THE CONCEPT. SO WE CAN
ENSURE THAT IT'S SERVING IT'S
YOU KNOW LONG TERM INTENDED
GOAL AND THEN AND THEN INCREASE
THAT IF THAT'S WHAT IMPACT WE
FIND. THANK YOU THANK YOU
MA'AM. SEEING NO FURTHER PUBLIC
COMMENT- I WILL JUST MAKE A
COMMENT. IN FRESNO WE HAVE A
KID'S CAFE WHICH IS OPERATED BY
THE FRESNO COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION. AND THE INTERNSHIPS
THAT THEY PROVIDE FOR THE ID DE
COMMUNITY ARE TREMENDOUS AND-
ARE WONDERFUL FOR THEM TO BE
ABLE TO. BOTH GAIN SO FORTH
CONFIDENCE AND ABILITY TO FEEL
LIKE THEY'RE PARTICIPATING IN
COMMUNITY AND- IT'S A WONDERFUL
WAY FOR THEM TO- START TO SEE
THEIR LIFE AFTER. EDUCATION AND
SO. WITH THAT I JUST WANTED TO-
ASK THE DEPARTMENT AND DEAL
LEFT TO HELP US TO PLEASE
CONFIRM- THAT THE ADVOCATES
PROPOSAL IS COSTS NEUTRAL- IF
YOU CAN COMMUNICATE WITH US IN
THE ADVOCATES- HOPEFULLY BY.
MARCH FOURTEENTH AND I WOULD
SOON. THAT WOULD JUST BE
HELPFUL IF THAT'S POSSIBLE.
SURE WE'VE BEEN IN
COMMUNICATION SO HAPPY TO
PROVIDE TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE.
THANK YOU WITH THAT WE WILL
HOLD ISSUE SEVEN OPEN AND MOVE
ON TO ISSUE EIGHT.
WHEN YOU'RE
READY GOOD EVENING MY NAME IS
ERIC HARRIS I'M A LEGISLATIVE
ADVOCATE A DISABILITY RIGHTS
CALIFORNIA. WE'RE ASKING IN
THIS PROPOSAL FOR APPROXIMATELY
NINE HUNDRED AND TWENTY FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS TO AND THE
ATROCIOUS PRACTICE OF PAYING
PATIENT WORKERS SO MINIMUM WAGE
IN STATE DEVELOPMENTAL CENTERS.
THIS AMOUNT WAS BASED ON
INFORMATION PUT TOGETHER BY THE
DEPARTMENT OF DEVELOPMENTAL
SERVICES AND THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. THIS BUDGET ASK
COINCIDES WITH SB TEN SIXTY TWO.
THE FAIR LABOR STANDARDS ACT
WHICH WAS PASSED IN NINETEEN
THIRTY EIGHT CREATED STANDARDS
AND PRACTICES FOR THE EMPLOYER
EMPLOYEE RELATIONSHIP. THIS
INCLUDES CREATING MET
LIMITATIONS ON HOURS WORKED
SAFE WORKING CONDITIONS WORKING
CONDITIONS CHILD LABOR LAWS
OVERTIME PAY IN MINIMUM WAGE.
MINIMUM WAGE LAWS ENSURE THAT
EMPLOYEES CAN EARN A STANDARD
MINIMUM WAGE TO PROVIDE FOR
THEMSELVES AND THEIR FAMILIES.
FOURTEEN C. WHICH IS AN
EXCEPTION TO MINIMUM WAGE WAS
ESTABLISHED TO ALLOW EMPLOYERS
EMPLOYERS TO BE ABLE TO PAY.
EMPLOYEES WITH DISABILITIES
LESS THAN MINIMUM WAGE.
PORTERFIELD DEVELOPMENTAL
CENTER AND CANYON SPRINGS
COMMUNITY FACILITY USE FOURTEEN
C. CERTIFICATES. PORTER BILL
HAS ONE HUNDRED AND THIRTY
SEVEN CONSUMER WORKERS AND
CANYON SPRINGS HAS FORTY NINE
CONSUMER WORKERS ALL UNDER
FOURTEEN C. CERTIFICATES MAKING
SUB MINIMUM WAGE. THE JOBS THAT
THESE INDIVIDUALS HAVE INCLUDE
WORK LIFE SKILLS GRAPHIC ARTS
CULINARY WORK LANDSCAPE WORK
JANITORIAL WORK. DELIVERING
CLOTHING AND MOPPING. THESE
CONSUMER WORKERS AT PORTER WILL.
AT PORT OF RULES VOCATIONAL
PROGRAM EARN BETWEEN A DOLLAR
AND FIFTY EIGHT CENTS PER HOUR
AND SIX DOLLARS AND NINETY SIX
CENTS PER HOUR ON AVERAGE THEY
EARN ABOUT FOUR DOLLARS AND
TWENTY SEVEN CENTS PER HOUR.
THE CONSUMER WORKERS AT CANYON
SPRINGS VOCATIONAL PROGRAM EARN
ABOUT A EARNED BETWEEN A DOLLAR
AND FOUR CENTS PER HOUR AND SIX
DOLLARS AND NINE CENTS PER
HOUR. ON AVERAGE THEY EARNED
THREE DOLLARS AND TWENTY SIX
CENTS PER HOUR. SEVERAL STATES
HAVE PASSED LAWS TO ADDRESS A
MINIMUM WAGE FOR PERSONS WITH
DISABILITIES. IN TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN THE STATE OF
WASHINGTON PASSED A BILL TO
PROHIBIT THE USE OF SUB MINIMUM
WAGE CERTIFICATES BY STATE
AGENCIES. THIS PROPOSAL WOULD
BE ON PAR WITH STATE AND
NATIONAL TRENDS THAT SUPPORT
THE COMMUNITY INTEGRATION AND
COMPETITIVE INTEGRATED
EMPLOYMENT FOR PERSONS WITH
INTELLECTUAL DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES. DISABILITY RIGHTS
CALIFORNIA BELIEVES THAT THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA SHOULD NOT
PAY PERSONS WITH DISABILITIES
SUB MINIMUM WAGES IN ITS STATE
DEVELOPMENTAL CENTERS. BY
PROHIBITING SUB MINIMUM WAGE IN
DEVELOPMENTAL CENTERS
CALIFORNIA WOULD SUPPORT A
POLICY THAT PROVOKED PROVIDES A
FAIR AND EQUITABLE WAGE TO
PERSONS FOUR PERF FOR WORK
PERFORMED REGARDLESS OF THEIR
DISABILITIES. CALIFORNIA WOULD
ALSO PROVIDE DIGNITY FOR
INDIVIDUALS CORD OF WHO ARE
DEVELOPING SOCIAL SKILLS
OCCUPATIONAL SKILLS LIFE SKILLS
AND CONFIDENCE. I ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT. THANK YOU SIR.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE LA YOU.
WE'RE AWARE OF THIS PROPOSAL WE
DON'T HAVE A POSITION AT THIS
TIME HOWEVER HAVE WORKED WITH
MISTER MISTER HARRIS TO
UNDERSTAND THE METHODOLOGY TO
COME UP WITH THE COST
IMPLICATIONS I WOULD NOTE THAT
WE HAVE ANY VALUE WAITED IT
FROM THE SENSE IF THERE WOULD
BE ANY STATE OPERATIONS COSTS
SO WE WOULD HAVE TO DO THAT TO
FULLY VALIDATE THE COST. THANK
YOU. YOU SENATE PARTICULARLY-
AGAIN WE BELIEVE THAT THIS
PROPOSAL RAISES A BIGGER- ISSUE
IN THE SYSTEM AND THAT IS THE
ISSUE OF SUB MINIMUM WAGE
ACROSS- THE ENTIRE DDS SYSTEM-
AS MISTER HARRIS NOTED SEVERAL
STATES HAVE BANNED THE USE OF
SUB MINIMUM WAGE OR PARTIALLY
BANDIT BY PROHIBITING ITS USE
FOR STATE AGENCIES SOME THERE
ARE ADDITIONAL STATES THAT
DON'T USE IT IN PRACTICE- AND
THERE HAVE BEEN PROPOSALS AT
THE FEDERAL LEVEL TO BAN SUB
MINIMUM WAGE FOR PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES- FOR CONTEXT. I
WOULD NOTE THAT THE PRISON
INDUSTRY AUTHORITY STILL USE A
SUB MINIMUM WAGE AMONG-
INDIVIDUALS WHO AE
INCARCERATED HOWEVER THEY ALSO
HAVE A PROJECT CALLED THE JOINT
VENTURE- PROGRAM- WHICH MUST
PAY A MINIMUM WAGE OR THE
MARKET WAGE FOR THAT FOR
WHATEVER WORK IS BEING DONE SO
ULTIMATELY THIS COMES DOWN TO-
SORT OF THE PHILOSOPHICAL
BELIEFS BELIEFS OF THE MEMBERS
ABOUT WHETHER OR NOT SUB
MINIMUM WAGE IS- APPROPRIATE
FOR PEOPLE WITH DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES. AND IF THEY DO
YOU WISH TO CHANGE WHAT
CONSUMERS ARE PAID OUT
PORTERFIELD DEVELOPMENTAL
CENTER IN CANYON SPRINGS
COMMUNITY FACILITY. WE WOULD
ALSO ASK WELL WHAT ABOUT THE-
SHELTERED WORKSHOPS THAT ARE
OUT IN THE COMMUNITY- IF THE
LEGISLATURE ULTIMATELY WENT
DOWN THE PATH OF BANNING A SUB
MINIMUM WAGE WORK FOR
INDIVIDUALS WITH DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES- WE WOULD ALSO
RECOMMEND THAT THE- LEGISLATURE
ASK THE DEPARTMENT TO
CAREFULLY. PLAN FOR HOW THIS
TRANSITION WOULD TAKE PLACE SO
THAT INDIVIDUALS ARE ALL THE
SUDDEN UNEMPLOYED OR ONLY YOU
KNOW GETTING A JOB THAT MAKES
MINIMUM WAGE BUT ONLY GETTING A
COUPLE HOURS A WEEK- THERE
SHOULD BE A TRANSITIONAL PHASE-
THAT SHOULD BE CAREFULLY
PLANNED. YOU WE WILL NOW TAKE
PUBLIC COMMENT ON ISSUE EIGHT.
RATHER CITY COUNCIL ON
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES- HAS
ERIC HARRIS TESTIFIED THE RATES
FOR EACH INDIVIDUAL'S PAID
VARIES FROM UNDER TWO DOLLARS
TO UNDER SEVEN DOLLARS PER HOUR
AND THAT. THAT RATE IS
DETERMINED BY ACTUALLY
MEASURING SOMEONE'S
PRODUCTIVITY SO EVERYONE'S PAID
MINIMUM WAGE INTO THIS
ASSESSMENT CAN COME IN AND THEN
BASED ON WHAT I AM AS A PERSON
ABLE TO PRODUCE EACH HOUR MY
RATES THAN. HEY ISN'T THAN
LOWER DOWN- SO THERE'S
LITERALLY A PROCESS OF
DEVELOPING HUMANS THAT GOES
INTO THIS PROCESS- I'LL SAY FOR
MYSELF I HOPE NO ONE ACTUALLY
MONITORS MY EVERY HOUR BECAUSE
I'M NOT ALWAYS PRODUCTIVE-
EVERY MOMENT OF EVERY DAY BUT
THIS PROPOSAL ACTUALLY.
EMBRACES THE LEGISLATURE'S
VIEWS THAT EVERY HUMAN SHOULD
BE PAID THEIR VALUE THEY'RE
WORTH FOR THEIR LABOR THANK YOU
FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION THANK
YOU SIR. JORDAN'S WITH THE ARK
OF CALIFORNIA- WITHOUT SPEAKING
SPECIFICALLY TO THIS PROPOSAL
THERE'S COMMENTS MADE ABOUT THE
LARGER ISSUE OF SUB MINIMUM
WAGE AND SO I JUST WANTED
EXPRESS YOUR CALIFORNIA'S
POSITION WHICH HAS BEEN
DISCUSSED PROBABLY IN MORE THAN
ANY OTHER FORM AT OUR NATIONAL
LEVEL. WHICH IS THAT THEY ARE
CALIFORNIA DOES SUPPORT THE
ELIMINATION OF SOME MINIMUM
WAGE IF THERE IS ADEQUATE
TRANSITION FOR INDIVIDUALS WHO
ARE IN THAT PROGRAM RIGHT NOW
TO SOMETHING ELSE AND WE ARE
UNFORTUNATELY FAR FROM BEING
ABLE TO DO THAT- WHICH
HOPEFULLY SOME OF WHAT WE'VE
BEEN DISCUSSING ALL DAY TODAY
WOULD HELP TO DO THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SIR SEEING NO FURTHER
PUBLIC COMMENT. WE WILL HOLD
THIS ISSUE OPEN AND MOVE ON TO
ISSUE NINE. THANK. SORRY.
IT
MISTER CHAIRMAN FOR ISSUE NINE
BEEN GIVEN UPDATE ON OUR-
PROGRESS TOWARDS HOME AND
COMMUNITY SERVICES MEETING
THOSE REQUIREMENTS FROM THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT SO THE
AGENDA DOES A GOOD JOB OF
PROVIDING A HIGH LEVEL TIMELINE
OF THE ACTIVITIES THAT WERE
PLANNING TO DO IS WE- MOVE
TOWARDS MARCH OF TWENTY TWENTY
TWO AND SO JUST A LITTLE BIT
MORE SPECIFICITY AND WHAT'S
GOING ON SO CURRENTLY-
PROVIDERS IN CONJUNCTION WITH
THE FOLKS THAT THEY SERVE OUR-
COMPLETING OR ASSESSING THEIR
OWN COMPLIANCE TOWARDS WHERE
THERE WHERE THEY ARE AS IN
RELATION TO THE FEDERAL
REQUIREMENTS. IT'S REALLY A AND
M. AN IMPORTANT FIRST STEP- TO
GET A BASS LINE AND THEN
DETERMINE THEN WHAT IS THE NEXT
STEP FOR EACH OF THOSE
PROVIDERS AND THE FOLKS THAT
THEY SERVE SO THOSE ASSESSMENTS
AS WHAT WE'RE REFERRING TO
THERE BEING COMPLETED ONLINE IN
A PROGRAM THAT WAS DEVELOPED
IT'S A ONLINE SURVEY DEVELOPED
BY A COMPANY THAT DEVELOPED A
SURVEYS THE PROVIDERS DID A FEW
YEARS AGO AS WELL- AND AGAIN
THOSE SURVEYS NEED TO BE
COMPLETED WITH INPUT FROM FOLKS
WHO RECEIVE SERVICES ONE OF THE
TENANTS OF THESE RULES AS NOTED
IN THE AGENDA IS THAT. THESE
ARE THESE REQUIREMENTS ARE
REALLY ABOUT THAT THE OUTCOME
AND EXPERIENCE OF FOLKS RECEIVE
SERVICES IT. SAYS THAT. THERE
INPUT AND- RESPONSE NEEDS TO BE
CONSIDERED AS WE MOVE FORWARD
JUST GOING BACK TO THE SURVEY
THAT FOLKS ARE COMPLY OR
COMPLETING I DO NEED TO KNOW
THAT THERE HAVE BEEN SOME
TECHNICAL ISSUES WITH THE
SURVEY- IN IN PARTICULAR WITH-
EMAIL ADDRESSES AND MAKING SURE
THOSE ARE UPDATED CORRECTLY.
WILL WE HAVE ASKED FOR THE
SURVEYS TO BE DONE- THE
ASSESSMENTS TO BE DONE BY THE
END OF THIS MONTH. WILL MONITOR
THAT AS WE GO ALONG- TO SEE IF
THE TECHNICAL ISSUES HAVE BEEN
ADDRESSED AND IF WE NEED TO
EXTEND THAT TIME FRAME- TODAY
TOO I JUST WANT TO NOTE THAT WE
HAVE WE DO HAVE FOURTEEN
HUNDRED- SURVEYS THAT ARE
COMPLETED OR NEAR COMPLETION
OUT OF ABOUT NINE THOUSAND THAT
ARE REQUIRED. SO WE USE THESE
RESULTS AS WE GET YOUR-
LANGUAGE IN STATUTE TO VISIT.
ENACTED THIS YEAR THE REQUIRES
US TO REPORT ON. OUR PROGRESS
TOWARDS MEANING THESE RICK
DIVERT WIRE MINTS WILL USE THAT
INITIAL REPORT- FOR THE APRIL
FIRST POSTING. OF THE RESULTS
OF THE SELF ASSESSMENTS AND
THAT THAT'LL BE UPDATED AS WE
GO GO ALONG. EITHER THE NEXT
STEP- ONE OF THE NEXT STEPS IN
AND- DETERMINING WHERE WE ARE
AND WHAT NEEDS TO BE DONE GOING
FORWARD IS THAT THERE'S GOING
TO BE A RANDOM SAMPLE OF THE
PROVIDERS THAT SO- COMPLETED
THESE ASSESSMENTS THEY WILL DO
AN ON SITE VISIT WITH THOSE.
AND SO WE- JUST RECENTLY- A
POSTED A NOTICE OF INTENT TO
AWARD A CONTRACT WITH THEM
PUBLIC CONSULTING GROUP THEIR
CONTRACTOR THAT'S ALSO BEEN
DOING SOME WORK WITH US- IN IN
RELATION TO THE HOME AND
COMMUNITY SERVICES RULES WITH
SOME TRAINING- AND SO WE'RE-
LOOKING FORWARD TO CONTRACTING
WITH THEM TO DO SOME OF THIS
ONSITE ASSESSMENT WORK. IT WILL
BE WORKING WITH STAKEHOLDERS-
AS WELL TO HELP INFORM WHAT
THAT PROCESS TO LOOK LIKE
BECAUSE AGAIN AS I MENTIONED
BEFORE WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT FOLKS WHO RECEIVE SERVICES
ARE INVOLVED IN THE ASSESSMENT
IN THE ON SITES AS WELL. YEAH
THE OTHER THING THAT YOU KNOW
IT'S IMPERATIVE IN A BIG PIECE
OF HOME AND COMMUNITY SERVICES
AND ALSO SELF DETERMINATION OF
WILL TALK ABOUT NEXT AND REALLY
THE ENTIRE REGIONAL CENTER
SYSTEM IS THE IMPORTANCE OF
PERSON CENTERED PLANNING AND
SO- WE ALSO WILL BE STARTING
SOME TRAINING THAT'S GOING TO
BE FOCUSED NOT ONLY FOR
REGIONAL CENTERS BUT ALSO FOLKS
WHO RECEIVE SERVICES AND
PROVIDERS AS WELL ABOUT PERSON
CENTERED THINKING PRACTICES AND
THE LIKE AND HOW THAT NORMALLY
AGAIN RELATES TO HOME AND
COMMUNITY SERVICES BUT JUST-
THE SERVICE SYSTEM AT LARGE.
AND YOU KNOW JUST AS WELL WE
ARE MOVING FOUR WE'VE LEARNED A
LOT EVEN NOT JUST FROM THESE
ASSESSMENTS BUT FROM THE
FUNDING THAT'S BEEN AVAILABLE
OVER THE LAST FOUR YEARS FOR
PROVIDERS TO ACCESS- TO MOVE
TOWARDS MEETING THE
REQUIREMENTS. YOU KNOW. ONE OF
THE TO MOST OFTEN THAT
PROVIDERS HAVE HAD INDICATED
WHERE THEIR- HAVING SOME
STRUGGLES OR NEED SOME
ASSISTANCE. IS THEN- PROVIDING
GREATER ACCESS TO THE COMMUNITY
AT LARGE AND THEN ALSO BEING
ABLE TO. DO SO- MAKE MORE
INDIVIDUALIZED CHOICES AND FOR
INDIVIDUALS THAT THEY SERVE AND
TO SOME OF THE THINGS THAT
PEOPLE HAVE USED THE FUNDING
FOR IS TO ACCESS AND GET SOME
TRAINING IN PERSON CENTERED
THINKING- SOME PROVIDERS IS
ACTUALLY MADE THEMSELVES A
RESOURCE TO OTHER PROVIDERS. TO
HELP WORK WITH THINKING AND
MAKE SOME CHANGES AS WELL- AND
SO WITH THAT OF WILL LEAVE IT.
THANK YOU SIR QUESTIONS
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. AS
MISTER KNIGHT ALLUDED TO A JUST
NOTE THAT THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
TWENTY TWENTY ONE ALSO INCLUDES
CONSISTENT WITH PRIOR YEARS
FIFTEEN MILLION DOLLARS TO HELP
PROVIDERS GET TO H. CBS
COMPLIANCE THANK YOU CAN LIVE.
UP PUBLIC COMMENT ON ISSUE NINE.
CHIU MARK OF DISABILITY VOICES
UNITED I JUST WANT TO POINT OUT
THAT IN THAT- WHAT WAS PUT IN
THE AGENDA. I DOESN'T REALLY
REFLECT WHAT THE FAMILIES NEED
AN INDIVIDUAL SERVED SO THERE'S
BEEN A LOT OF EFFORT DOING
OUTREACH TO PROVIDERS- AND
REGIONAL CENTERS BUT- MOST
FAMILIES HAVE NO IDEA THIS IS
COMING. THEY HAVE NEVER HEARD
THIS TERM H. BUT CBS- THERE
HAVEN'T BEEN MATERIALS PUT OUT.
PLAIN LANGUAGE THAT PEOPLE NOW
AND WE'RE TALKING ABOUT WERE
THE ONES THAT ARE GOING TO BE
IMPACTED WE HAVE KIDS AND HE'S
REALLY SEGREGATED SETTINGS THAT
MAY CLOSE DOWN OR THAT MAY HAVE
TO DRAMATICALLY SHIFT WHAT
THEY'RE DOING. AND WE HAVE NO
IDEA THAT IN TWO YEARS FROM
THIS MONTH THAT THINGS WILL
HAVE TO HAVE CHANGED AND SO I
JUST. REQUEST THAT DDS AND THAT
THE LEGISLATURE TO PROVIDE
OVERSIGHT REALLY NOW PRIORITIZE
FAMILY MEMBERS AND INDIVIDUALS
SERVED TO GET THAT
COMMUNICATION TEMAS SOON AS
POSSIBLE. THANK YOU. ERIC
RATHER STICK COUNSELING
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES
WANTED TO RISE TO CONTINUE TO
EXTEND OUR OFFER TO THE
ADMINISTRATION TO BE A PARTNER
IN REACHING AT CBS COMPLIANCE.
IT IS A IT IT'S AN AGGRESSIVE
TIMELINE THERE'S A LOT TO WORK
TO DO IN THE COUNCILS-
INDEPENDENT AND REGIONAL
PRESENCE THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
CAN BE HELPFUL IN REACHING A
DOING THESE ASSESSMENTS
ADDITIONALLY NOTICE THE COMMENT
FROM. THE STAFF COMMON AS IT
RELATES TO WHETHER OR NOT THERE
ARE SPECIFIC CODES THAT COULD
BE INCENTIVIZED OR PRIORITIZE-
TO REACH H. B. AS COMPLAINTS
FASTER WE HAVE A LIST WE THINK
WITH THAT PROVIDE THAT TO YOU.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. SING ONE
MORE PUBLIC COMMENT IS COMING.
I APOLOGIZE SHOULD BE NEARLY
JORDAN'S WITHOUT TO CALIFORNIA
JUST ALSO WANT TO MENTION THAT-
MISTER FRIDGES PLAN DOES HOPE
TO INCENTIVIZE AS IN THE
STAFF'S COMMENTS INCENTIVIZE
TOWARDS EACH CBS COMPLAINT IN
YOUR ONE IMMEDIATELY WITH THE
FIRST YEAR IMPLEMENTATION IN
YOUR TWO AND THREE- FOLLOWING
WITH THE RATE STUDY. THANK YOU
THANK YOU. IF I MAY I WANTED TO
START WITH THE DEPARTMENT
SAYING NO FOR THE PUBLIC
COMMENT ON NOW WILL BRING IT
BACK TO THE SUBCOMMITTEE- IF I
COULD START WITH THE DEPARTMENT
AND ASK ARE THERE ANY CONCERNS
OR- RED FLAGS THAT YOU
CURRENTLY HAVE ABOUT- H. C. B.
S. COMPLIANCE. YOU KNOW
OBVIOUSLY WHEN IT COMES TO
FEDERAL FUNDING WE'RE WE'RE
ALWAYS CONCERNED IN AND WANTING
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE MEETING
THE FEDERAL REQUIREMENTS- YOU
KNOW WE'RE WE LIKE I SAID WE'VE
LEARNED A LOT THROUGH THE
ASSESSMENTS THAT HAVE BEEN
DONE. WHEN FOR THE FUNDING OF
THE LAST FOUR YEARS WE THINK
THAT THAT HAS LED TO A LOT OF
PROGRESS- AND AS WE GO THROUGH
THESE ASSESSMENTS NOW IT WOULD
NOT ONLY THE SELF ASSESSMENT
BUT ALSO THE ON SITE. THAT
THAT'S GONNA HELP INFORM MORE.
IF I CAN I- WOULD ECHO- TWO
COMMENTS AGO AS WELL AND PUBLIC
COMMENT. ABOUT THE NEXUS- AND
I'M HOPING THAT. WE CAN TALK
ABOUT- OR CONSIDER WHICH RATES.
WOULD BE CANDIDATES FOR AN
INCREASE THAT WOULD ALSO ASSIST
WITH H. C. B. S. COMPLIANCE AND
SO- OUR REQUEST WOULD BE IF THE
DEPARTMENT CAN PROVIDE IT'S
FEEDBACK ON THIS NEXUS QUESTION
IN WRITING TO THE SUB
COMMITTEE- AND THEN WOULD JUST
ASK WHAT IS A REASONABLE DATE.
HAVING TO DO THAT SO IF YOU
JUST FOLLOW UP WITH WHAT A
REASONABLE DATE IS WE WILL HOLD
ISSUE NINE OPEN AND- MOVE ON TO
ISSUE TEN. I JUST WANNA OF.
CAMANCHE. SO JUST GIVE A BRIEF
UPDATE ON- SELF DETERMINATION
AND ALSO THERE ARE A FEW
QUESTIONS IN THE AGENDA THAT I
CAN ADDRESS- A FEW OF THOSE AND
I KNOW THERE WAS ALSO REQUEST
TO FOLLOW UP IN WRITING WHICH
WE WILL DO AS WELL- SO. JUST AS
JUST LAST YEAR IN NOVEMBER WE
DID DO A SELECTION OF SOME
ADDITIONAL INDIVIDUALS AND THE
REASON WE DID THAT THE FIRST
TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED FOLKS SO WE
CHOSE THERE WERE A NUMBER ABOUT
FIVE HUNDRED AND SEVENTY OF
THOSE INITIAL TWENTY FIVE
HUNDRED HAD CHOSEN NOT TO
CONTINUOUS SELF DETERMINATION
SO WE DID SELECT SOME
ADDITIONAL FOLKS- TO CONTINUE.
TO REPLACE THOSE FOLKS. AS OF
MARCH SECOND SO JUST THIS
MONDAY- WE HAVE A HUNDRED FIFTY
FOLKS THAT OF IT THAT HAVE
ACTUALLY NOW STARTED WITH SELF
DETERMINATION MOVING HAVE A
BUDGET IN IRAQ AND- PURCHASING
THEIR SERVICES- THROUGH THAT-
SOME OTHER- THINGS TO NOTE. YOU
KNOW ONE OF THE THINGS THAT IS
HAS- BEEN A CONCERN. IS THE
DELAY IN THE TIME BETWEEN THE
SELECTION AND WHEN PEOPLE ARE
GETTING STARTED. WHAT ONE OF
THE ISSUES HAS BEEN BROUGHT UP
IS THAT THERE'S A TREMENDOUS
AMOUNT OF SUPPORT THAT MAY BE-NEEDED IN BETWEEN THE TIME TO
REALLY GET STARTED. I MEAN IF
WE THINK ABOUT IT WE TALKED
ABOUT IT BEFORE THAT IN SOME
CASES IT'S ALMOST LIKE SETTING
UP A BUSINESS FOR SOME FOLKS.
NEED TO FIGURE OUT A HIGHER
FOLKS WHO TO HIRE HOW MUCH TO
PAY THEM HOW DO I USE ALL THIS
MONEY- AND THAT'S JUST. A MAN.
THE SMALL PART OF IT. RIGHT SO
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT THAT-
THE STATUE DID ALLOW FOR WAS TO
USE SOME OF THE- THE SAVINGS
THAT W- WE- REALIZED. BECAUSE
OF THE FOLKS AROUND THE OLD
PILOT PROJECT HAVE NOW MOVED
INTO SELF DETERMINATION. SOME
OF THAT FUNDING COULD BE USED
TO HELP SUPPORT FOLKS IN THEIR
TRANSITION AND HELP THE
IMPLEMENTATION. OF SELF
DETERMINATION TO THOSE FUNDS
HAVE BEEN ALLOCATED. TO BE USED
BY- WITH THE- COLLABORATION AND
JUST DECIDING IN COLLABORATION
WITH THE LOCAL ADVISORY
COMMITTEES IN THE REGIONAL
CENTERS. ON HOW TO USE THAT
FUNDING TO HELP SUPPORT THAT
IMPLEMENTATION IN TRANSITION.
SO HOPEFULLY THAT WILL HELP-
SUPPORT FOLKS TO TRANSITION AND
DO ALL THAT UP FRONT WORK THAT
THAT REALLY NEEDS TO HAPPEN IN
BECAUSE IN. WE REALLY WANT TO
RECOGNIZE AND IS AGAIN THE
FUNDING THAT WENT OUT IN THE
GUIDANCE TO WIN OUT. STRESSES
THAT THAT THE DECISION ON THE
USE OF THOSE FUNDS NEED TO BE
IN COLLABORATION WITH THE LOCAL
ADVISORY COMMITTEES. BECAUSE
IT'S- THE WORK OF THOSE CAN'T
THE LOCAL COMMITTEE AS WELL AS
THE STATE RIGHT ADVISORY
COMMITTEE IS GOING TO BE VERY
IMPORTANT. AS WE MOVE FORWARD
THE OVERSIGHT AND- PROGRESS IN
THE PROGRAM. SO THERE ARE A
NUMBER OF QUESTIONS AS I
MENTIONED THAT WERE PRESENTED
IN THE AGENDA AND I'LL GO
THROUGH A FEW OF THOSE- INTO
ONE OF THE QUESTIONS WAS ABOUT
THE NUMBER OF FOLKS WHO CHOSE
NOT TO CONTINUE AS I MENTIONED
IT'S ABOUT FIVE HUNDRED SEVENTY
WHICH IS ABOUT 23% OVERALL. ONE
THING THAT WE DID WHEN WE
LOOKED AT THOSE FOLKS WHO CHOSE
NOT TO CONTINUE- BLACKS IN TO
TAKE A STEP BACK WHEN WE DID
THE INITIAL SELECTION OF TWENTY
FIVE HUNDRED FOLKS AS WELL AS
THE- WHEN WE FILLED IN BEHIND
WE WANTED TO BE MINDFUL OF THE
REPRESENTATION OF THE STATE NOT
ONLY WHERE FOLKS LIVE BUT
CERTAINLY- ALONG WITH-
ETHNICITY AND RACIAL GROUPS. SO
WHEN WE LOOK TO THE FOLKS WHO
HAD CHOSEN NOT TO CONTINUE THE
ETHNICITY AND RACIAL MAKE UP OF
THAT GROUP THAT CHOSE NOT TO
CONTINUE ACTUALLY MIRRORS THE
POPULATION AT LARGE SO WE
DIDN'T SEE ANY DIFFERENCES ARE
OUTSTANDING- YOU KNOW WARRANTED
MORE IN ONE AREA THAN ANOTHER
SO THAT THAT WAS ONE THING THAT
WE WANTED TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
TOOK A LOOK AT. IT WITHIN EACH
REGIONAL CENTER THERE CERTAINLY
WAS A VARIANCE IN THAT THE
PERCENTAGE OF FOLKS WHO CHOSE
NOT TO CONTINUE ITS GET THE TO
RANGE OF BETWEEN 11% OF THE
FOLKS SELECTED UP 253% AND
THERE'S SOME REASONS FOR SOME
OF THAT SOME OF THE REGIONAL
CENTERS. IN THE- THE
INFORMATIONAL MEETINGS THAT
FOLKS WERE REQUIRED TO GET SOME
INFORMATION ABOUT SELF
DETERMINATION BEFORE THEY- GOT
ON THE LIST TO BE CONSIDERED
FOR SELECTION. SOME OF THAT WAS
DONE IN A IN A MUCH BROADER
WAY- AND- IN SO SOME OF THE
FOLKS AND THAT WERE SELECTED IN
THOSE REGIONAL CENTERS- MAYBE
WORKED AS QUOTE. THE MAYBE
WEREN'T AS INTERESTED IN IN
GOING FORWARD AT LEAST AT THIS
TIME. IN SELF DETERMINATION AS
MAYBE IN SOME OF THE OTHERS
WHERE THERE IS MORE ROBUST-
INFORMATION THAT WAS SHARED AND
FOLKS THAT THAT HAD MORE
INFORMATION BUT WE ALSO THEN
WANT TO LEARN THOUGH- ABOUT.
WHY IT IS THAT THOSE FOLKS-
CHOSE NOT TO CONTINUE THEIR-
AND SO WE DID SEND OUT A SURVEY
THAT WAS HELPED- DEVELOPED BY-
OR IN CONJUNCTION WITH
STAKEHOLDERS INCLUDING ADVISORY
GROUP. WE SENT THAT OUT TO ALL
FIVE HUNDRED SEVENTY FOLKS. WHO
CHOSE NOT TO CONTINUE SO FAR
WE'VE RECEIVED EIGHTY EIGHT
RESPONSES BACK WE'RE OBVIOUSLY
HOPING TO GET SOME MORE WE'RE
GOING TO CONTINUE TO SEND THOSE
OUT- AS- OTHER FOLKS- CHOOSE
NOT TO CONTINUE AS WELL. AND WE
pIF THERE'S SOME THINGS THAT WE
CAN LEARN FROM FOLKS WHO HAVE
BEEN- WHO HAVE BEEN SELECTED IN
CHOSEN NOT TO CONTINUE. IS
THERE SOME WAY THAT WE CAN HELP
MAKE IT EASIER FOR FOLKS TO
UNDERSTAND OR WHATEVER IT IS
THAT WE CAN LEARN. TO HELP-
PROGRESS TO THE PROGRAM. ALSO
ANOTHER COUPLE OF QUESTIONS AND
ABOUT PERSON CENTER PLANS AN
OBVIOUS AS I MENTIONED IN THE
LAST ISSUE PERSON CENTERED
PLANNING AND THINKING IS
OBVIOUSLY INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT
THERE HAVE BEEN TWO HUNDRED
NINETY ONE INDIVIDUALS THAT
HAVE BEEN REPORTED TO HAVE GONE
TO THAT PERSON CENTERED
PLANNING PROCESS SO FAR AND
AGAIN WE'LL KEEP- DATED AND BE
ABLE TO COLLECT DATA ON THAT
MONTHLY IS BEING REPORTED BY
THE REGIONAL CENTERS AND THEN
ALSO WE CAN- VERIFY IN SOME
CASES THAT SOME OF THOSE THAT
THAT PERSON CENTERED PLANNING
SERVICE WAS ACTUALLY PURCHASED-
OUTSIDE OF. THE REGIONAL CENTER
AS WELL. ONE OF THE THINGS YOU
KNOW WE TALKED ABOUT- ONE AND
MAKE SURE THIS OVERSIGHT AND
THE PROGRAM IS SUCCESSFUL. WE
ARE- LOOKING TO AND I THINK
DIRECTOR BARS REMAIN- MENTION
IT TO NOT ONLY IS THAT THERE A
REQUIREMENT IN THE STATUTE TO
DO AN EVALUATION OF THE
PROGRAM. FOR ALSO GOING TO WITH
THE NATIONAL CORE INDICATORS
MAKE FOLKS WERE SELECTED AND
SELF DETERMINATION AS A AS A AS
A SUBSET IF YOU WILL OR- SO WE
CAN JUST ANOTHER SET A AWAY IS
ANOTHER MAJOR. AND IN LOOKING
AT THE EFFECTIVENESS OF THE
PROGRAM. LASTLY I WANT TO TALK
ABOUT SOME OF THE BUMPS IF YOU
WELL AND WHILE WE I THINK WE
ALL KNEW THAT THERE WOULD BE
ANY WORK WE'RE CREATING
SOMETHING THAT'S NEW. EVEN
THOUGH WE'VE HAD PILOTS- WE
THIS IS NEW STATEWIDE- AND
THERE HAVE BEEN SOME- SOME OF
THOSE HAVE BEEN AS A RESULT OF-
THAT THAT. THE TIME THAT IT
TOOK QUITE HONESTLY TO GET.
THIS APPROVED FOR FEDERAL
FUNDING. SEVERAL YEARS AGO IT
WAS NOT UNFORTUNATELY UNUSUAL.
FOR THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TO
TAKE SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF TIME
TO GO AFTER AN APPLICATION FOR
FUNDING WAS- PRESENTED TO THEM
TO DO SOME APPROVALS THAT DID
TAKE A SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF
TIME. FOR US TO DO THAT. AND
THEN THERE WAS A DELAY-
ACTUALLY AFTER WE DID OUR
SELECTION. UNTIL WE ACTUALLY
START WE'RE ABLE TO START THE
ORIENTATION SO THAT FOLKS CAN
GET STARTED- YOU KNOW IN
HINDSIGHT. WE WEREN'T QUITE
READY FOR THE ORIENTATIONS WHEN
WE DID THE SELECTION AND I
THINK THAT DID CREATE SOME.
SOME SOME ANGST AMONGST FOLKS
AND SO YOU KNOW. IF WE WERE TO
HAVE A CHANCE TO DO IT AGAIN WE
WOULD DO THINGS A LITTLE BIT
DIFFERENTLY- AND- SO THERE'S
ALSO. YOU KNOW INFORMATION I
THINK IS BETTER ARE A REQUEST
FOR THAT. IN A LOT OF THAT I
THINK IS NOT ONLY FROM THE
DEPARTMENT BUT I THINK
INFORMATION ON NOT ONLY WHEN.
THINGS MAYBE ARE GOING RIGHT
BUT ALSO LEARNING FROM FOLKS
THAT WHAT'S WEIRD IS WORKING.
AND SO WERE REALLY HELPFUL WITH
THE FUNDING THAT WE TALKED
ABOUT TWO IS TO CREATE SOME
SHARED TRAINING AND LEARNING
EXPERIENCES IN FOCUS GROUPS. TO
SO THAT WE CAN ALL AS AS WE
TALKED ABOUT A LOT LEARN
TOGETHER ON WHAT'S GOING TO
MAKE THIS SUCCESSFUL. THANK YOU
SIR DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
NOTHING FURTHER ADMIXTURE THANK
YOU- NEXT WE HAVE JUDY MARK.
GAIL JUDY MARK PRESIDENT
DISABILITY VOICES UNITED A
STATEWIDE ADVOCACY ORGANIZATION
DIRECTED EXCLUSIVELY BY
INDIVIDUALS WITH DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES AND FAMILY MEMBERS
I'M ALSO PROFESSOR DISABILITY
STUDIES AT UCLA BUT MOST
IMPORTANTLY I'M A PARENT OF
JOSHUA A TWENTY THREE YEAR OLD
WITH AUTISM WHO IS PROUDLY PART
OF THE SELF DETERMINATION
PROGRAM. SO TODAY WE ARE
HEARING ABOUT THE MANY CONCERNS
THE DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITY
SYSTEM BUT I HAVE A SOLUTION
FOR ALMOST ALL OF THE PROBLEMS
AND THAT IS THE SELF
DETERMINATION PROGRAM. WORRIED
ABOUT OUTCOMES SELF
DETERMINATION PARTICIPANTS GET
TO CHOOSE THE OUTCOMES THAT
MATTER TO THEM AND SELECT THE
PEOPLE AND ACTIVITIES THAT HELP
THEM ACHIEVE THEM RATES TOO LOW
THERE ARE NO RATES IN SELF
DETERMINATION YOU CAN PAY YOUR
STAFF WHAT YOU DESERVE. DD
SYSTEM COSTS RISING WILL BASED
ON A TWENTY YEAR PILOT PROJECT
OF SELF DETERMINATION FIVE
REGIONAL CENTERS THE COSTS DO
NOT RISE AS MUCH AS IN THE
TRADITIONAL SYSTEM BECAUSE
OUTCOMES AND SATISFACTION ARE
BETTER SERVICE COORDINATOR
CASELOAD RATIOS TOO HIGH THE
SELF DETERMINATION PROGRAM ADDS
ADDITIONAL ASSISTANCE FROM
INDEPENDENT FACILITATORS.
RACIAL AND ETHNIC DISPARITIES
NOT IMPROVING SELF
DETERMINATION AS A WAY FOR
FAMILIES TO CHOOSE CULTURALLY
AND GEOGRAPHICALLY ACCESSIBLE
SERVICE SO WHAT IS THIS MAGICAL
PROGRAM CALLED SELF
DETERMINATION. IT'S A LAW
PASSED IN TWENTY THIRTEEN WHICH
ALLOWS PEOPLE SERVED BY
REGIONAL CENTERS TO HAVE CHOICE
AND CONTROL OVER THE SERVICES
THEY RECEIVED BASED ON A PERSON
CENTER PLAN IT IS THAT SIMPLE
BUT WITH THIS GREAT PROMISE ONE
WOULD THINK THAT EVERYONE IN
THE DD SYSTEM WOULD JOIN
TOGETHER TO WORK HARD TO MOVE
THIS PROGRAM FORWARD. BUT THE
SELF DETERMINATION PROGRAM HAS
TAKEN LONGER TO IMPLEMENT THE
AFFORDABLE CARE ACT. THIS SIX
AND A HALF YEAR DELAY HAS TAKEN
A TOLL ON THE ORIGINAL
ENTHUSIASM AND MOMENTUM OF THE
PROGRAM. IT IS LEAD TO VERY
HIGH ATTRITION RATES
MISINFORMATION FEAR AND
DISCONTENT. THE PROGRAM IS
BEING IMPLEMENTED
INCONSISTENTLY IT REGIONAL
CENTERS WELL SUMMER WORKING
HARD TO MAKE IT SUCCESSFUL WE
HEAR STORIES OF OTHERS
DISCOURAGING INDIVIDUALS AND
FAMILIES FROM PARTICIPATING AND
SAYING IT'S NOT FOR YOU. SADLY
WE HEAR THIS MORE FROM LATINO
ASIAN AND AFRICAN AMERICAN
FAMILIES WHO ALREADY FACE
DISPARITIES. THE BARRIERS TO
SUCCESSFUL SELF DETERMINATION
PROGRAM ARE SIGNIFICANT AND
HAVE BEEN DETAILED IN A REPORT
SOON TO BE RELEASED BY THE
STATE WIDE SELF DETERMINATION
ADVISORY COMMITTEE ON WHICH I
SET. THIS COMMITTEE IS MADE UP
OF REPRESENTATIVES FROM LOCAL
COMMITTEES AT ALL TWENTY ONE
REGIONAL CENTERS. WE HAVE
IDENTIFIED THE TOP TEN BARRIERS
TO PARTICIPATION FROM OVERLY
COMPLEX ORIENTATIONS TO POORLY
TRAINED REGIONAL CENTER STAFF
TO AN UNWILLINGNESS OF MANY
PROFESSIONALS TO SHIFT THE
PARADIGM. FROM THE EXPERTS KNOW
BEST TO THE PERSON IS IN CHARGE
OF THEIR OWN LIFE. UNLESS THESE
BARRIERS ARE ADDRESSED AND
OVERSIGHT IS INCREASED WE WILL
SEE PEOPLE LOSE THIS INCREDIBLE
OPPORTUNITY WE KNOW WE CAN TURN
THIS AROUND AND MAKE THIS
MAGICAL PROGRAM A SUCCESS. AND
HELP IMPROVE THE WHOLE DO YOU
SYSTEM WHILE WE'RE AT IT. BUT
ONLY IF WE REQUIRE
IMPLEMENTATION DEADLINES FOR
REGIONAL CENTERS AND BETTER
OVERSIGHT BY DDS WE HAVE
APPRECIATED WORKING CLOSELY
WITH THE DEPARTMENT BUT WE ARE
AT A CRITICAL JUNCTURE WHEN THE
LEGISLATURE NTDS MUST ENSURE.
THE REGIONAL CENTERS ARE
IMPLEMENTING THE PROGRAM IS
REQUIRED SO THAT MY SON AND
THOUSANDS OF OTHERS CAN ACHIEVE
THEIR DREAMS THANK YOU. THANK
YOU HELLO. SONNY PEDICLE A. O.
M. WE WOULD JUST HAVE A FEW
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS TO ADD TO
THE ONES THAT WERE- IN THE
AGENDA IN WHICH THE DEPARTMENT
OF MOSTLY ADDRESSED- FIRST. WE
ARE WONDERING ABOUT THE STATUS
OF THE EVALUATION AND WHETHER
THAT'S ON TRACK- TO GET FINISH
ARE THEY DO THEY HAVE ENOUGH
INFORMATION UP FRONT- TO DO A
SUCCESSFUL OUT EVALUATION-
SECONDS. THE SELF DETERMINATION
PROGRAM AS MISTER KNIGHT
MENTIONED MUST BE MADE
AVAILABLE TO ALL DDS- PERSON
SERVED AS OF JUNE TWENTY TWENTY
ONE. AND WE'RE WONDERING IF THE
DEPARTMENT FEELS THAT IT'S-
READY ESPECIALLY IN LIGHT OF
SOME OF THE DELAYS AND
CHALLENGES THAT HAVE. BEEN
IDENTIFIED AND I GUESS THE A
GREATER QUESTION MIGHT BE- ARE
ANY MODIFICATIONS NEEDED IN IN
THE STATUTE THAT WOULD HELP
FACILITATE. THE RATE AT WHICH
THE THAT CAN BE ROLLED OUT. AND
THEN- FINELY. OUR OFFICE WAS-
pDEPARTMENT TO- PROVIDE MORE
INFORMATION ABOUT THE COSTS OF
THE INDIVIDUAL BUDGETS THAT
HAVE BEEN APPROVED. AND WHETHER.
ANY OF THE INDIVIDUAL OR
WHETHER THERE BEEN ANY
REQUESTS- TO INCREASE THE BUT
THE INDIVIDUAL BUDGETS OVER THE
INITIAL AMOUNT APPROVED THE
SELF DETERMINATION PROGRAM IS
WRITTEN INTO STATUE TO BE
BUDGET NEUTRAL INTEREST
WONDERING HOW THOSE COSTS ARE
PLAYING OUT OF THE COMING IN
LOWER HIGHER. JUST THANK YOU WE
WILL NOW TAKE PUBLIC COMMENT ON
ISSUE TEN. WILL SEVERED
COMMITTEE CONSULTANTS ONE OF
THINGS I DO IS HELP PEOPLE GET
INTO THE PROGRAM BY HELPING THE
PERSON CENTER PLANS WHICH IS
ACTUALLY EXPANDED TO HELP THEM
UNDERSTAND WHAT THE BUDGET
SHOULD BE THAT THEY'RE SORT OF
FIND AND HOW TO GET THERE
SPENDING PLAN IN PLACE. THAT
GAP AS. AT THE DOLLARS THEY
HAVE AVAILABLE TO AND THEN GET
IT INTO ANOTHER INDIVIDUAL
PROGRAM PLAN SO CAN ACTUALLY
GET FUNDED TO BE RUN. AND
THAT'S ACTUALLY BEEN A HUGE
THING I THINK RIGHT NOW THE
DEPARTMENT AND THE STATE Y.
WORKGROUP HAVE ARE PLAYING
CATCH UP LIKE WE JUST NOW
REVISING THE BUDGET DOCUMENTS%
TO HELP MAKE THAT MORE CLEAR WE
HAVEN'T DEVELOPED THE SPENDING
PLAN DOCTOR TO PEOPLE REALLY
KNOW. HOW TO DO IT I THINK IT'S
PRETTY SIMPLE SERVICE CODE
HERE'S YOUR MIND WAS SPEND THE
BILL ASK THEM TO DETAIL OUT IN
VERY DETAILED THING WHAT THEY
HAVE WHAT THEY WANT TO SPEND
THE MONEY ON IT'S LIKE. IS MY
BUDGET HERE'S WHERE I THINK I
NEED TO DO IT I DON'T KNOW
EXACTLY HOW IT'S GOING TO PLAY
THAT IS SLOWS THE WHOLE PROCESS
DOWN THE NUMBER OF PEOPLE THAT
I'VE DNE. COMPLETED WHO ARE
STILL WAITING FOR THE SPENDING
PLAN IS QUITE A FEW TO GET
APPROVED BECAUSE THAT'S AGAIN
THE BUREAUCRATIC PROCESS OF
THIS WHICH IS I UNDERSTAND IS
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT. THERE'S
NO FREE LUNCH WE HAVE TO REPORT
ON IT BUT WE HAVE TO FIGURE OUT
A WAY TO MAKE THAT MUCH MORE
STREAMLINED I THINK IT IS I
AGREE WITH JUDY THAT IT HAS THE
OPPORTUNITY. TO REALLY FOR A
LOT OF FOLKS REALLY YOU KNOW
OPEN UP OPPORTUNITIES TO WRITE
SEEM TO WANT TO SPEND SO PHONE
LIKE. THAT'S GOING TO BE WHAT
THEY WANT THEIR NEEDS THAT'S
WHAT THEY WANT TO DO WE CAN'T
DO THAT THE TRADITIONAL SYSTEM
BECAUSE IT'S NOT HOW WE VENDORS
SERVICES TO DO IT SO. IT HAS
POTENTIAL BUT I AGREE HAS A LOT
OF BARRIERS AT THE SAME TIME.
THANK YOU SIR. HI KAREN CALL
FROM REDONDO BEACH AND I
APPLIED TO BE PART OF THE
INITIAL PROGRAM AND DIDN'T GET
PICKED AND A LOT OF FAMILIES
WHERE I LIVE A VERY EXCITED AS
WELL ABOUT BEING PART OF IT
WHAT I SAID BEFORE ABOUT.
HAVING SERVICES THAT WITH THE
WRONG SERVICES AND I COULDN'T
ACCESS THAT COULD ALL BE
CHANGED BY SELF DETERMINATION I
COULD DO USE THE MONEY
AUTHORIZED BY THE REGIONAL
CENTER THE SERVICES I DON'T.
AND I CONTACT SAYS FOR SERVICES
I DO NEED AND I CAN ACCESS AND
I THINK THAT WOULD BE A MUCH
BETTER USE OF. THE MONEY THANK
YOU THANK YOU. HELLO MISTER
CHAIR ANKARA THIS MISTAKE
COUNCIL ON DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES AS SELF
DETERMINATION IS A CRITICAL
VALUE FOR THE STATE COUNCILS IN
OUR MISSION STATEMENT TO HELP
INDIVIDUALS LEAD SELF DETERMINE
LIVES THE STATURE GIVES THE
STATE COUNCIL TO SIGNIFICANT
OVERSIGHT ROLES FOR THIS
PROGRAM ONE IS THE EVALUATION
WHICH LA- SPEAK SPOKE ABOUT.
THE OTHER IS COVENING IN
SHARING THE STATEWIDE SELF
DETERMINATION OF VISOR
COMMITTEE- WHICH THAT A DUTY
MARK SPOKE ABOUT REGARDING
EVALUATION THERE IS A DUE DATE
FOR US TO DELIVER TO THE
LEGISLATURE A REPORT. ON ON THE
IMPLEMENTATION AND MOST
SIGNIFICANTLY THE SATISFACTION
OF PARTICIPANTS- IN THE NEW
PROGRAM VERSUS THE PRIOR
PROGRAM THAT'S DUE JUNE OF
TWENTY TWENTY ONE. THAT'S A
VERY SHORT TIME FROM NOW WHEN
WE ONLY HAVE A HUNDRED AND
FIFTY PEOPLE- IN THE PROGRAM SO
THAT SOMETHING A TO CONSIDER
THAT THAT THE DEADLINE ON THAT
pSTATEWIDE SELF DETERMINATION
VISOR COMMITTEE. THEY HAVE THEY
ARE WORKING ON AND VERY CLOSE
TO DELIVERING PRODUCING A
DOCUMENT IDENTIFYING THE TEN
TOP BARRIERS- FOR THIS PROGRAM
IT RANGES FROM- DELAYS OF
GETTING THE PROGRAM OUT LACK OF
STANDARD TRAINING REGIONAL
CENTERS. KIND OF A LACK OF EACH
STEP OF THE PROCESS WE'RE GONNA
BE SCRAMBLING TO FIND WHO'S
GONNA BE MY INDEPENDENT
FACILITATOR WHO WILL BE MY FMS
WHO WILL PROVIDE THE SERVICES
SO BE RECREATING THE SYSTEM. AS
WE ROLLED OUT- ONE OF THE MOST
SIGNIFICANT ONES IS A SLOW
CHANGE OF POINT OF VIEW-
BECAUSE OF THE TERMINATORS A
COMPLETE DIFFERENT WAY TO THINK
ABOUT HOW TO RECEIVE SERVICES.
I'M MORE IMPORTANT IN LAYING
OUT TEN BARRIERS THIS DOCUMENT
LAYS OUT SOLUTIONS OF
RECOMMENDATIONS- SO THAT'S
THAT'S I'M READY WILL PROVIDED
TO THE COMMITTEE AS WELL AS TO
THE MINISTRATION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SIR. GOOD EVENING AMY
WESTLING ASSOCIATION OF
REGIONAL CENTER AGENCIES I WANT
TO THANK THE PANEL FOR HEARING
THIS CONCERN IN HEARING THE
ISSUES AROUND THE SELF
DETERMINATION PROGRAM. REGIONAL
CENTERS ARE EX EXCITED AS
ANYBODY ELSE TO SEE THIS WORK.
AND THE STAFF AT THE REGIONAL
CENTERS THAT ARE WORKING TO
IMPLEMENT THIS. OUR STAFF THAT
ARE DEDICATED AND THAT HAVE
VOLUNTEERED AT MOST CENTERS TO
BE PART OF THIS EXCITING
PROJECT WE'RE LOOKING FORWARD
TO WHAT ARE SOME CREATIVE IDEAS
THAT FAMILIES AND INDIVIDUALS
SERVED IN THE SYSTEM CAN BRING
TO US. THAT WE CAN PERHAPS WRAP
INTO THE BIGGER SYSTEM AS WELL.
BUT AS BOTH MISTER PRATHER'S MR
SANFORD NOTED. THERE ARE
CHALLENGES AND A LOT OF THEM
COME FROM THE COMPLEXITY OF
GETTING MONEY FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT WE ARE JUST AS
FRUSTRATED AS EVERYBODY ELSE BY
THAT COMPLEXITY- AND IF. YOU
KNOW HE IF THERE WERE AN EASY
WAY TO DO IT WE WOULD LOVE TO
FIND IT. PART OF THE CHALLENGE
IS WITH CALCULATING EACH
PERSON'S INDIVIDUAL BUDGET THE
AMOUNT OF MONEY THEY HAVE TO
SPEND. THERE IS A VERY EASY WAY
TO DO IT LOOK AT WHAT WE SPENT
LAST YEAR AND CALL IT A DAY BUT
THAT'S NOT THE WAY THE- SYSTEM
WAS SET UP BECAUSE IT REALLY
WAS INTENDED. TO CORRECT SOME
ISSUES IN THE SYSTEM RELATED TO
SERVICE ACCESS RELATED TO UNMET
NEEDS. AND RELATED TO MAKING
SURE THAT WE ARE PROVIDING
PEOPLE WITH THE FULL
OPPORTUNITY TO ACCESS AN ARRAY
OF SERVICES THAT THEY'RE
ENTITLED TO. AND THAT'S A
COMPLICATED PROCESS AND WE
HAVEN'T BEEN ABLE TO FIND A
SHORT CUT AROUND IT- IT WOULD
BE GREAT IF THERE WAS A BUTTON
WE COULD PUSH IN A NUMBER WOULD
POP OUT BUT THAT'S NOT HOW IT
WORKS BECAUSE IT'S ALL
INDIVIDUALLY BASED AND IT'S
TIME CONSUMING AND I.
APPRECIATE THAT IT'S SLOW AND
IT'S FRUSTRATING BUT AT THE END
OF THE DAY WE BELIEVE THAT
THERE WILL BE AMAZING OUTCOMES
FOR PEOPLE AND THAT'LL ALL HAVE
BEEN WORTH IT. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. YES STARK CONTRAST
GRANDMOTHER AND I JUST WANTED
TO SAY THAT THE SELF
DETERMINATION PROGRAM FOR ME AS
A GRANDMOTHER IS A DREAM COME
TRUE. YOU CAN WORK OUT THE
COMPLEXITIES BUT I TELL YOU
WHAT I'VE BEEN DREAMING ABOUT
SOMETHING LIKE THIS FOR A LONG
LONG TIME AND I'LL TELL YOU
WHY. I HAD TO GIVE MY GRANTS
HIM UP TO A CARE FACILITY
BECAUSE OF BY EIGHTEEN AND NOT
BEING ABLE TO CARE FOR HIM AND
HAVE ALL OF THE SERVICES. THAT
THESE CARE HOMES HAVE IN ORDER
TO KEEP HIM TWENTY FOUR SEVEN.
SO YES I SUPPORT SELF
DETERMINATION I WORK HARD. NOW
TO THINK OF WAYS THAT I CAN
HAVE MY GROUND SOME HOME. WITH
ME THE KID OUT OF THE BOX IS A
DREAM COME TRUE. THANK YOU JUDY
MARK AND WHOEVER ELSE WROTE
SELF DETERMINATION. KAMALA. NOT
BY YOUR AB ONE S. NOT JUST AT
THE LOS. IN THE MEAN NUMBER
EIGHTY SEVEN ESTRADA. HIS OWN
MOTHER THAT ALSO BECAUSE ONE OF
THESE MORE SHE IS MOM TO TWO
AUTISTIC CHILDREN. I'M DOES NOT
BE YEAH THE BAILIFF. FEDERAL
OUR ORDER SELECT THE SET OUT OF
WILL JOIN A MENTAL IS AVAILABLE.
IT USED TO BE THAT THERE
WEREN'T LEVELS OF AUTISM BUT
NOW THEY'RE CALLED EITHER
SEVERE ARTISTIC OR LIGHT TO
STICK. AN IMPOSSIBLE NINGUNA DE
LAS DOS. FOR LA HE RELATE BUT I
SAID RESEAL THE CENTER
RECOGNIZE IN THE PAST NEITHER
ONE OF MY TWO YOUNG CHILDREN
WERE ELIGIBLE FOR PMR SHE
SERVICES NEARLY AS STAR. NOT
EARLY START NOT NOTED UP
INSTILLING WALKING NOT THAT I'M
A LITTLE LESS UNITED NO
OCCUPATIONAL THEY'RE NOT IN A
MEDICAL EACH OTHER. PLEAD NO
BEHAVIOR THERAPY. A LETTER IF
THEY AYE YOURS IS IN A
COMPORTAMIENTO IS MORE MOST OF
IT WAS MY THIRTEEN YEAR OLD SON
HAS VERY SEVERE BEHAVIORS.
CUANDO BEING ALTHOUGH IT
THURMOND ASEAN WHEN I HEARD
ABOUT SELF DETERMINATION. AT
THE GALLUP WHAT ON ME GUSTA AND
KNOCKED AT MY DOOR. IS IT
BLONDE AB THAT BUT ON THE WHOLE
IS A PLAN FOR LIFE FOR HIS FOR
HER CHILDREN BUT A ONE FOR ONE
THE- MAKE UNFINISHED WE'VE GOT
A QUARTER A. B. SEALS SHE TIRED
OUT ASKING FOR SERVICES I SENT
TO RECKON I'LL TO THE- IBM TO
THIS REGIONAL CENTER. ID THREE
TO SCORE LACKEY TO THE DISTRICT
SCHOOL DISTRICT YEAH LAST
SECOND FIELD LOCAL RICA. AND
NON PUBLIC AGENCIES. THEY GIVE
IT ME CALL ME GAS TAX SO I TOOK
MY SON HOME. EN MI CASA. YOUR
LANSING ELDERLY AND- AS A HOME
SHE HAS HOME SCHOOLED HIM. AND
SHE HAS TAUGHT HIM TO READ AND
WRITE OUT ACCORDING TO PROGRAM
A WITH THIS PROGRAM YOU'LL
THINK I'LL OPPOSED TO ME THAT I
HAVE THE POSSIBILITY WITH THIS
PROGRAM THIS DIET IS SAID TO BE
SOON TO BE LOTTERY. ALONE IN
THE VILLAGE JULY SIR- SERVICE
TO GET GO BUT I LEARNED THIS IF
YOU THAT THEIR COVER MY CHILD'S
NECESSITY. ELLEN IF THE SEA
BASS I LEAD A LOCK ON JUANITA
HE NEEDS TO GO OUT INTO THE
COMMUNITY YEP AND THERE ARE
LEVELS LET THE RENTALS. SELECT
ID AND LEARN TO READ THE SAFETY
SIGNS ACROSS THE STREET SENATE
HE THOUGHT THEN THEY DON'T KNOW
ME WHAT HE NEEDS A FRIEND AND
THIS IS THE TACKLE MONIQUE OUR
CITY NEEDS TO COMMUNICATE. IT
ALTHOUGH IT SORT OF UPPER RIVER
WHATEVER ME HOPE AND HE WILL BE
ABLE TO DO ALL OF THAT BACK
WITH THEIR PROGRAM MESSED WITH
SELF DETERMINATION. WHAT DID
YOUR WAY UP IN THERE BECAUSE I
WILL HAVE LOCKED ALREADY THAT
YOU. SEE THAT ALREADY AND THE
CAPACITY THEY LEFT THE ONLY
TEACHER THAT SEVENTIES SHOW ME
ELECT WHO WILL GIVE MY SON
SERVICES. YEAH OKAY OKAY TO
PICK UP FOR I DON'T SEVENTY
SHE'LL TRY DISTRICT JUST
COLLECT I DON'T HAVE TO BEG FOR
SERVICES. FROM THE SCHOOL
DISTRICT. NEAR CENTER A- OR TO
THE REGIONAL. YEAH THAT'S A
HAVE NOT RICA. FOR THE NON.
AGENCIES IF THE- I SAID BOB.
THIS PRO IS. A LASSEN THIS IS
THE DODD THE ON THE NECESSITY.
LIKE GOT ON THE YOU. OF EACH
THE- TILE YES. MOTO LOWEST
STAFF A LOT OF PEOPLE LIKE. TO
FOR. WILL PUT IT ON MY LAST DAY
BECAUSE IT'S A- MORE LIBERAL
PROGRAM WHAT CAN LIGHT. IS
CALIFORNIA'S BECAUSE THERE
AREN'T SCAFFOLDS NOT THE NEWS
YOU STAND OUT THERE'S NOT A
SINGLE TRAVEL ORGANIZED AN
ORGANIZED SYSTEM. BATTLE FOR
BUT DS SIGN YOURS BUT FOR TEN
YEARS ME CUESTA WHEN THIS IS
THE SPAMMER MY SON WAS IN THAT
SYSTEM IN OCALA YOU'LL GO
ANOTHER AND NO ONE HELPED TO.
YOUR ANKLE RATHER PERSONAS WHEN
US ARE HAVE FOUND GOOD PEOPLE
GALLUP WEATHER AND THAT THAT UP
YEAH THAT A WALK HIM ME HOLD
THAT CAN GIVE HIM OR HAVE HIM
GIVE HIM SPEECH THERAPY. IN A
SEAT WITHOUT A SAY AND THEY
DON'T NEED TO THEN CENTER I CAN
THAT NEITHER THE THREE PRESS
CORPS LAB THEY DON'T NEED TO
WATCH OUT FOR THE REGIONAL
CENTER OR THE SCHOOL DISTRICT
BUT UP AND NURSES CONTRACT TO
SCORE AY YOU. TO LOSE THEIR
CONTRACTS. ESTO ES. LLAMAR
ESTE. PROGRAM THIS IS ALMOST
BROADBAND OR- THIS IS THE BEST
OF THIS PROGRAM WE ARE TRYING.
YES STARTUP DANDO DAMPEN THEM
OUT. WHERE THAT MORE AND MORE
AS MUCH AS I CAN INSTALL YOU
KNOW CALL ME DAY SHE IS I AM ON
THE OUR SELF DETERMINATION
COMMITTEE THEY MAY CENTER HERE
LAST AT MY REGIONAL CENTER AND
MOST IMPORTANT BATTLE MORE
TRUST DIFFICULT THAT IS WE HAVE
CONFRONTED MANY. ISSUES BUT A
POOR THERE SO THAT WE CALL
MONIQUE THAT. THEN WE CAN GET
OUT ON A LIMB WHEN YOU THAT AND
TELL ARNOLD WENT ON THIS THE
PROGRAM OF THE GOOD OF THIS
PROGRAM. YOUR SECOND
KNOWLEDGEABLE STAFF. AND THEY
KNOW I KNOW THAT. BETTER LUCK
MONEY NINE THIS TO SEE THE OF
IT HELLO THAT I WAS IN THE
RECORD DON'T I THIS THE
REGIONAL CENTER DOESN'T LIKE IT
BUT OUR COMMUNITY NEEDS. THIS
THE LAST SERVICE HERE. CAN
ASSIST RUSSIA JUST WANTED TO
SAY IN. JUST SICK OF MY FRIEND
IF YOU WALK INTO HER LITTLE
HOME HER HOME LOOKS LIKE THE
SCHOOL LITERALLY. POSTERS
BULLETIN BOARDS EVERYTHING. YES
OUR SYSTEM NOT. ALISON RANTS
TVO. WOW. I THINK THE PREVIOUS
COMMENT REALLY- IT PICKED UP ON
A REALITY THAT NOBODY'S REALLY
EXPLICITLY MENTIONS- I WISH
THAT THE EARLIER COMMENT OF AS
OF ANY WESTLING FOR ARCA I WISH
HER ATTITUDE WAS UNIVERSALLY
SHARED AMONG REGIONAL CENTERS-
SADLY I DON'T THINK THAT'S A
REALITY- SOME REGIONAL CENTERS
HAVE BEEN QUITE SUPPORTIVE
ABSOLUTELY MIND FOR EXAMPLE-
BUT NOT ALL HAVE- AND SO PEOPLE
UNFORTUNATELY ARE NOT EQUALLY
POSITION AND I THINK YOU KNOW
WITH THE CAN THAT'S COME OUT
SOME OF OUR TESTIMONY SO I
THINK. IF WE'RE STRIVING FOR
UNIFORM SYSTEM WE MIGHT WANT TO
CONSIDER THE POSSIBILITY AS
LONG AS WE'RE HAVING A
CONVERSATION ALREADY ABOUT
OUTCOMES MEASURING OUTCOMES- I
THINK SELF DETERMINATION IS AN
EXCELLENT CANDIDATE FOR AN
OUTCOME MEASURE. NOW OF COURSE
THAT NEEDS TO BE THOUGHTFULLY
CONSIDERED WE CAN HAVE THE
OUTCOME BE HOW MANY PEOPLE
CHOOSE TO GO INTO SELF DID IT
RIGHT I MEAN THERE'S AN OUTCOME
MEASURES THE WOULDN'T ACTUALLY
BE- ILLUSTRATIVE OR REGULATORY
OF THE REGIONAL CENTERS ROLE
IN. MAXIMIZING THE OPPORTUNITY
FOR PEOPLE TAKE ADVANTAGE OF
SELF DETERMINATION BUT THERE'S
CONSIDERABLE VARIATION ALONG
THAT DIMENSION ACROSS THE STATE
NO QUESTION ABOUT IT. I THINK
WE SHOULD RECOGNIZE THAT WE
SHOULD THINK ABOUT AGAIN HOW TO
MEASURE IT AND HOW TO
INCENTIVIZE IT. SO THAT WE
REALLY EQUALIZE OPPORTUNITY FOR
EVERYBODY NOT JUST IN CERTAIN
REGIONAL CENTERS THAT ARE
ACTUALLY TRYING TO PROMOTE THE
PROGRAM THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
SEEING NO FURTHER PUBLIC
COMMENT ON ISSUE TEN I WILL
BRING IT BACK TO THE SUB
COMMITTEE. I WAS ALSO QUITE
MOVED BY THE TESTIMONY OF THE
MOTHER AND YOU CAN ALWAYS. TELL
WHEN SONS ARE LUCKY TO HAVE
ADVOCATES WHO ARE MOTHERS AS
WELL WHO ARE FIGHTING FOR THEIR
KIDS SOME JUST WANTED TO
COMMENT IF I COULD REGARDING
WHAT THE LA BROUGHT UP AND
WANTED TO SEE IF THERE WERE ANY
MODIFICATIONS. THAT WERE NEEDED
IN THE STATUTE- FOR US TO BE
ABLE TO HELP TO ASSIST- MORE
PEOPLE ENTERING INTO SELF
DETERMINATION. M. CERTAINLY WE
HEARD THE QUESTIONS FROM THE LA
ON WILL WORK AND CAN GET SOME
RESPONSES FOR YOU ON THOSE-
ALONG WITH THAT JUST THE STATUS
OF THE EVALUATION WHEN IT'S
COMING OUT WOULD BE IMPORTANT
FOR US AND- WE LOOK FORWARD TO
RECEIVING THE REPORT- THAT YOU
MENTIONED AND WOULD LIKE TO.
MAKE SURE THE TIMELINE WORKS- I
DO HAVE SOME CONCERNS REGARDING
THE SLOW IMPLEMENTATION OF THIS
AND- JUST WANT TO. HIGHLIGHT
THIS MAY BE ONE OF THE TOOLS
THAT HELPS US TO DEAL WITH
DISPARITIES AS WELL. AND SO WE
JUST ASK THE DEPARTMENT TO. SEE
WHAT WE CAN DO TO HELP TO
FACILITATE THIS AS WE GO
FORWARD SOME. WITH THAT WE WILL
HOLD ISSUE TEN OPEN AND MOVE ON
TO ISSUE ELEVEN. THANK YOU. THE
ISSUE 11-3- GUARDIAN ARE-
REORGANIZATION AN UPDATE AND
THE AGENDA CORRECTLY NOTES-
THE- OPPORTUNITY THAT WE HAD TO
BE ABLE TO MOVE FORWARD WITH
THE- A REORGANIZATION OF
HEADQUARTERS- SOME OF THE
DISCUSSIONS THAT THAT WE'RE
HAVING TODAY AND- WITH THE NEXT
ISSUE- WAS REALLY PART OF THE
DRIVERS YOU KNOW WHEN WE TAKE A
LOOK AT ACCOUNTABILITY AND
OVERSIGHT OF THE REGIONAL
CENTER SYSTEM. AND WHEN WE WERE
LOOKING AT HOW DO WE MAKE SURE
THAT WE AS A DEPARTMENT ARE
AWARE OF THE ISSUES THAT ARE
BEING IMPACTED AT THE AT THE
COMMUNITY LEVEL AND THEN HOW DO
WE HELP YOU KNOW WORK IN
COLLABORATION WITH REGIONAL
CENTERS TO BE ABLE TO AFFECT
CHANGES AND TO BE ABLE TO-
PROVIDE THEM THE SUPPORT TO
MAKE SURE THAT WERE RESPONSIVE
AND THE THINGS THAT WE NEED TO
GET OUT TO THEM IN A TIMELY WAY
TO BE ABLE TO HELP THEM DO.
THAT INITIATIVES IN THE WORK
THAT THEY NEED TO DO WHETHER IT
WAS SELF DETERMINATION WITH THE
COMMITTEE PLACEMENT PLANS WITH
THE NUMBER OF THINGS THAT THAT
IT THEY SUBMIT TO US AND RATE
REACT TO IT SO WE'RE HAPPY TO
SAY THAT WE ARE- VERY FAR ALONG
AND ON THE IMPLEMENTATION OF
OUR REORGANIZATION OF THE
POSITIONS IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA WE ACTUALLY HAVE-
HIRED EVERYBODY THAT WAS
IDENTIFIED TO WORK IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA THAT WAS ONE OF THE
ELEMENTS THAT WAS IMPORTANT IN
THE REORGANIZATION- AND- WE
WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO MOVE
FORWARD- WITH- DEVELOPING THE
DIFFERENT TO- STRUCTURE WITHIN-
THE REGIONAL CENTER- SYSTEM BUT
ALSO AT THE SAME TIME TAKING A
LOOK AT HOW WE- HAVE BEEN ABLE
TO EXPAND SOME OF THE OTHER-
DEPARTMENTS. OR ARE DIVISIONS
AND OUR DEPARTMENT AS WELL- BUT
MISTER WINFIELD THE- CHIEF
DEPUTY DIRECTOR IS HERE TO BE
ABLE TO PROVIDE YOU I'M SOME
EXAMPLES OF THE OUTCOMES OF THE
BENEFITS OF SOME THE RE
ORGANIZATION AND- THAT THAT WE
HAD IDENTIFIED AS A BENEFIT.
THANK YOU SO- AS DIRECTOR BARGE
MEN INDICATED WE ARE- PRETTY
FAR ALONG IN THAT THE
REORGANIZATION AND SO WE'VE-
DEVELOPED OUR LIAISON TEAMS FOR
THE TWENTY ONE REGIONAL
CENTERS. AND MOST OF THE STAFF
OF BEEN HIRED FOR THOSE LIAISON
TEAMSTERS THREE STAFF FOR EVERY
THREE REGIONAL CENTERS- WE HAVE
THAT BEGAN MEETING WITH EACH OF
THE REGIONAL CENTERS TO.
INTRODUCE THE NEW STAFF AND
MAKE THOSE CONNECTIONS WITH THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR AND THEY'RE-
EXECUTIVE STAFF FOR OTHER TEAM
MEMBERS. WE HAVE ALSO- BEEN
MUCH MORE INVOLVED WITH A
REGIONAL CENTERS IN THEIR
COMMUNITY MEDIAN SO IN THE PAST
WE WOULD GO TO- BOARD MEETINGS
EVERY QUARTER WAS SORT OF OUR
STANDARD UNLESS A REGIONAL
CENTER. WAS REALLY STRUGGLING
AND THEN WE WOULD GO TO EVERY
BOARD MEETING. THAT WE NOW ARE
ATTENDING EVERY BOARD MEETING
OF THE REGIONAL CENTERS. AND
MAKING OUR PRESENCE MORE KNOWN
SAID THAT THE BOARD MEMBERS
KNOW. AND I RECOGNIZE MORE SO
WHO THE DEPARTMENT IS THAT WE
HOLD THEIR CONTRACT AND THAT WE
ARE RESOURCE TO THOSE THOSE
BOARD MEMBERS- WE'VE ALSO-
INCREASED. OUR RESPONSE TIMES
HAVE DECREASED SO THAT WITH
COMPLAINTS AND WITH ISSUES THAT
COME UP WE FOUND THAT WITH THE
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES. IT'S BEEN
MUCH MORE MUCH EASIER TO
RESPOND MORE TIMELY TO THE
PUBLIC- WE ARE ALSO ATTENDING
OTHER REGIONAL CENTER PUBLIC
MEETINGS SUCH TO FOR EXAMPLE.
THERE PURCHASE OF SERVICE-
DISPARITY MEETINGS- THEY'RE
HAVING MEETINGS ON PERFORMANCE
CONTRACTS ALL THESE DIFFERENT
PUBLIC MEETINGS WE'RE MAKING
SURE THAT WE HAVE STAFF THERE
AND- AVAILABLE TO THE PUBLIC.
SO THESE ARE JUST A FEW OF THE
WAYS THAT WE- BECAUSE WE OBTAIN
INPUT FROM HAVE FAMILIES AT THE
OUTSET OF ALL OF THIS. AND
HEARD FROM THEM WHAT WAS SOME
OF THE IMPORTANT PARTS WERE FOR
THE REORGANIZATION WERE TRYING
REALLY HARD TO MAKE SURE. THAT
FAMILIES AND CONSUMER OUR FIND
US TO EXCESS. AND THAT WE ARE
MORE AVAILABLE TO HELP REGIONAL
CENTERS- IN TERMS OF THEIR
ORGANIZATION AND THERE THERE'S
THERE DAILY WORK. DEPARTMENT OF
NUMBER. AND IF I COULD I
APOLOGIZE TO JUST GO AHEAD AND
ADD- ONE- NOTE IN CONSISTENT
WITH WHAT'S OUTLINED IN THE
AGENDA IS THE GOVERNOR'S- IN
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED BUDGET
IS A REQUEST FOR TWO MILLION
DOLLARS TOTAL FUN ONE POINT SIX
MILLION GENERAL FUND- FOR-
FISCAL YEAR TWENTY TWENTY ONE
FOR APPROXIMATELY TWENTY
THOUSAND SQUARE FEET. OF NEW
LEASE SPACE AND SO CURRENTLY WE
HAVE THE SOUTHERN CALIFONIA
OFFICE THAT IS HOUSED OVER AT
FAIRVIEW AT THE ADMINISTRATION
BUILDING AND SO THIS WOULD.
THEN BE IN ALIGNMENT WITH OUR
CLOSURE AND- HAVE OFFICE SPACE
ADMINISTRATIVE OFFICE SPACE FOR
THE STAFF THAT WE HAVE LOCATED
IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA AND THE
AGENDA OUTLINE SOME OF THE
POSITIONS AND- AND RECONCILES
TO OUR REQUEST. THANK YOU
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. I
NOTHING FURTHER TED IT'S TIME
THANK YOU HELLO WE HAVE
REVIEWED THE PROPOSAL FOR THE
SET THE EXPENSES RELATED TO THE
NEW SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA OFFICE
IN THE BACK UP WHICH WE
RECEIVED IN A TIMELY MANNER.
THANK YOU AND WE DON'T HAVE ANY
CONCERNS WITH THE PROPOSAL AND
RECOMMEND APPROVAL THANK YOU-
PUBLIC COMMENT ON ISSUE ELEVEN.
SEEING NONE I WILL BRING IT
BACK TO THE SUBCOMMITTEE- I
THINK YOU TOUCHED ON A FEW OF
THE ITEMS DECREASED RESPONSE
TIMES. ATTENDING MEETINGS
MAKING YOUR PRESENCE KNOWN- I
THINK OUR QUESTION WOULD BE HOW
WAS QUALITY OF SERVICE BEING
MADE STRONGER WITH THESE
INVESTMENTS AND- FURTHER
CONVERSATIONS IN WAY YOU CAN
HELP WOULD STRENGTHEN THAT SO-
WITH THAT WE WILL HOLD ISSUE
ELEVEN OPEN IN THE BOND ISSUE
TWELVE. THANK. THANK YOU- SO I
AM I'M GOING TO GO AHEAD AND
PROVIDE A IT- UPDATE IN AN
OVERVIEW OF THE OVERSIGHT ITEM
FOR DISPARITIES FUNDING AND- I
DO HAVE A COUPLE OF MY STAFF
THAT IF THERE'S ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS TECHNICAL QUESTIONS
REGARDING SOME OF THE MEASURES-
THAT WE- HAVE THAT HAVE BEEN-
USED TO- DO THE TRACKING OF THE
OUTCOMES OF OUR DISPARITY
FUNDS- I WOULD- SWITCH SEATS
WITH DOCTOR LEVEL TO BE ABLE TO
DO THAT BUT I DO WANT TO JUST
SPEAK TO SOME OF IMPORTANT
ITEMS THAT. WHISPERED I DON'T
MIND WE'VE BEEN WORKING FOR THE
LAST- I'D SAY THE LAST FOUR
YEARS- BUT CERTAINLY IDENTIFIED
IT EARLIER IN REALLY ADDRESSING
THE ISSUE AND RECOGNIZING THAT
THE DIFFERENCE IN THE DISPARITY
BETWEEN FINDING BETWEEN OUR
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR AND THE
WHITE COMMUNITY AND REALLY
UNDERSTANDING THE DATA ONE OF
THE THINGS IT'S BEEN REALLY
IMPORTANT IS NOT ONLY WITH THE
WORK THAT THE REGIONAL CENTERS
IT AND DOING IT AND THAT I YOU
WAITING THAT PURCHASE SERVICE
DATA OF AND WE'VE RECOGNIZED
OVER TIME ONE OF THE THINGS YOU
NEED TO DO IS TO MAKE SURE THAT
THAT THE DATE THAT THE REASON
CENTERS ARE USED AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL. GOOD WERE USING STATE
LAW THAT WE ABLE TO STAND UP
BUT ALSO AN OPEN THAT WE PANTS
THAT ARE CAME ALSO UNDERSTANDS
SO ONE OF THE THINGS THAT WERE
ALSO DOING IN A M<c.cyan> SENT OF</c>
WITH OF OUR THERE'S A WAS SOME
PLACE TO LOOK AT THE DATA IS TO
SAY HOW CAN BE SURE THAT NOT
ONLY IS THAT ABOUT PEOPLE AND
THEIR MACHINE READABLE FORMAT
BUT HOW IS IT EASILY. AND SO
CAN WITH THE TO SEE THAT WOULD
WANT TO DO A MAY SURE EACH WERE
ON SAID IN STATE THAT THE PER A
SURVEY DAY IT IS IT GOING BE
JUST HEARING OTHERS THAT WILL
IN. WITH THE REGIONAL CENTERS
AND IT WENT TO REGIONAL CENTER-
OPERATIONS AND TO BE ABLE TO
CONTRACT OR TO DELIVER
DIFFERENT TYPES OF SERVICES TO
IT TO ADDRESS THE ISSUE WE
PIVOTED OVER TO A GRANT PROGRAM
THE SECOND YEAR AND THAT GRANT
PROGRAM ALLOWED US TO BE ABLE
TO- DISTRIBUTE MONEY TO
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
AND THAT WAS REALLY AN
OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE LOCAL
COMMUNITIES TO BE ABLE TO-
INTRODUCE NEW IDEAS DIFFERENT
PRACTICES AND START EXPANDING
THE DIFFERENT TYPES OF SERVICES
THAT COULD REALLY BREAK DOWN
THOSE BARRIERS AND HELP
FAMILIES NAVIGATE SERVICES. SO
IN DOING THAT WE STARTED SEEING
MUCH OF THE PROGRAMS THAT- HAD
BEEN REPLICATED THAT WE'VE BEEN
ABLE TO SUPPORT WAS THE
INTEREST OF EITHER THE
NAVIGATORS OUR PROMO TORAS TO
BE- HELPING FAMILIES- NAVIGATE
THE REGIONAL CENTER SYSTEM BUT
ALSO OTHER SYSTEMS SO WE'RE IN
A PLACE- WHEN WE STARTED WE
USED- FIFTEEN SIXTEEN DATA-
THAT GAVE US MEASURES THAT WE
HAVE- MEASURES THAT WE'VE
POSTED- FOR A COUPLE YEARS NOW
THAT WE ARE USED AND THEN I
JUST WANT TO WALK YOU THROUGH
THAT A LITTLE BIT BECAUSE WE
ARE NOW IN THE FISCAL YEAR
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN. IN WHICH
WERE ABLE TO START IDENTIFYING
WHAT ARE THE SOME OF THE
OUTCOMES- THAT WERE SEEN AND
OUR OUR DATA SO AND I KNOW- THE
GENDER OF REFLECTS THE
DISABILITY VOICES A UNITE THE
AGGREGATE DATA- RECOGNIZING
THAT THAT IS CERTAINLY ONE
MEASURE THAT WE CAN LOOK AT ON
THE AGGREGATE BUT WE ALSO KNOW
THAT ON THE AGGREGATE THERE'S A
LOT OF INFORMATION WE KNOW
THERE'S A LOT OF RESIDENTIAL
INFORMATION AND THERE WE
RECOGNIZE THAT OUR COMMUNITIES
OF COLOR AND DIFFERENT CULTURES
MAY NOT USE- RESIDENTIAL
SERVICES SO WE REALLY WANTED TO
DO DRILL INTO SOME OF THE MORE.
KIND OF SERVICE BASED- EXAMPLE
SO WE CAN UNDERSTAND WHERE
THOSE BARRIERS WHAT'S OCCURRING
AND HOW DO WE EFFECT CHANGE IN
UNDERSTANDING THAT LEVEL OF
DETAIL AND WHILE WE DON'T HAVE
A POSTED YET ONE OF THE THINGS
WE WANT TO DO IS TO WORK WITH
THIS NEWLY FORMED DISPARITY
WORK GROUP THAT WE HAVE. IS TO
BE ABLE TO TAKE A LOOK AT IT
BUT I'D LIKE TO SHARE A LITTLE
BIT OF THE INFORMATION- WE'RE
FINDING WITH THE- THE- THE
EQUITY MEASURES THAT WE HAVE.
WE HAVE A LEVIN MEASURES- THAT
HAVE MULTIPLE PULP POPULATIONS
ETHNICITIES IF YOU WILL.
THERE'S A TOTAL OF TWENTY ONE
I'M INDIVIDUAL POPULATION
MEASURES THAT INCLUDES WHETHER
IT'S DIAGNOSIS OR OR
ETHNICITIES- BASED ON THOSE
MEASURES WE HAD EIGHT IMPROVED-
AREAS THAT WE'VE IDENTIFIED IN
THOSE MEASURES AS A COMPARISON
FROM FIFTEEN SIXTEEN TO.
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN WE HAVE TEN
THAT SHOW- SHOWED NO OR SLIGHT
CHANGES. AND THEN WE HAVE THREE
THAT SHOWED LARGER GAPS. AND SO
WHAT THIS DOES FOR US IS WERE
ABLE TO NOW TAKE A LOOK INTO
SOME OF THOSE AREAS OF ONE OF
THE AREAS I'LL GIVE YOU AN
EXAMPLE I WAS A LITTLE
SURPRISED BY. IS THAT WE HAVE A
SERVICE CODE THAT'S CALLED
ADAPTIVE SKILLS TRAINING. AND
SO WHEN WE'RE TAKING A LOOK AT
THE AVERAGE COST OF ADAPTIVE
SKILLS TRAINING. WE DON'T HAVE
ALL OF THE UNDERSTANDING AS TO
WHAT TE SERVICES EXACTLY USED
FOR WE'RE GOING TO BE DRILLING
INTO THIS BUT ONE OF THE AREAS
THAT'S USED. IS FOR A. B. A. OR
BEHAVIOR TRAINING FOR
INDIVIDUALS WHO HAVE AUTISM OR
OR HIGH INTENSITY NEEDS. THIS
IS A PARTICULAR AREA IN A
MEASURE. THAT ACTUALLY THE WAS
THE MOST MOST SIGNIFICANT
DIFFERENCE THAT ACTUALLY GOT
WORSE BETWEEN OUR AFRICAN
AMERICAN COMMUNITY AND WHITE.
PER CAPITA SPEND AND THEN THIS
BI ONYX VERSUS WHITES PER
CAPITA SPEND. AND SO WHEN WE
LOOK AT THAT I DON'T HAVE AN
ANSWER TODAY AS TO WHY THAT IS.
BUT I I'M ACTUALLY KIND OF GLAD
THAT WE KNOW THAT LEVEL OF
DETAIL. BECAUSE WE YOU KNOW WE
CAN MAKE SOME SOME ASSUMPTIONS
BUT WE REALLY DO NEED TO DRILL
INTO A BY REGIONAL CENTER TAKE
A LOOK AT SOME OF THE
INFORMATION AND SEE WHAT MAY BE
THOSE DRIVERS. IS IT THAT WE
HAVE. SOME INDIVIDUALS THAT ARE
NOT ABLE TO ACCESS GENERIC
RESOURCES AND REGIONAL CENTERS
MAY NOT BE FUNDING SOME OF THE
A BA SERVICES UNTIL THEY GET
THOSE RESOURCES. AND IS THAT
IMPACT IN THE COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR MORE THAN IT IS OUR WHITE
COMMUNITIES SO. AGAIN I'M I'M-
I DON'T KNOW WHAT IT IS BUT WE
ARE GOING TO BE DRILLING INTO
THOSE THINGS. SO AS WE CONTINUE
TO WORK ON OUR EFFORTS ONE OF
THE IMPORTANT- AREAS IS REALLY
DRILLING INTO THE DATA THAT WE
DO HAVE AVAILABLE TO US. I DO
JUST WANT TO MAKE A COUPLE OF
NOTES TO SOME OTHER INITIATIVE
BECAUSE PART OF WHAT WE WANT TO
DO. IS MAKE SURE THAT ANY
INITIATIVE OR POLICY THAT WERE
LOOKING THROUGH IT THROUGH THE
LENS OF CULTURAL COMPETENCE AND
LINGUISTIC COMPETENCE. WE WORK
WITH GEORGETOWN WE- CALIFORNIA
WAS SELECTED AS ONE OF THE
STATE'S TO WORK WITH GEORGETOWN
UNIVERSITY. AND WE WORK WITH
THE YOU SAID SINCE STATE
COUNCIL AND D. R. C. YOU KNOW
TO SAY HOW DO WE KIND OF BUILD
OUR LEADERSHIP. AND SO THAT'S
ONE OF THE AREAS THAT WE
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH. I DO
KNOW THAT PART OF WORKING WITH
THE DS TASK FORCE AND THE WORK
GROUPS AND TRYING TO BRING
FORWARD APPLICATIONS THAT
REPRESENTS OUR COMMUNITY. I
HAVE COMMUNITIES OF COLOR THAT
ARE NOT REPRESENTED ON THE TASK
FORCE. SO ONE OF THE AREAS THAT
I REALLY WANT TO WORK WITH OUR
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
AND THE REGIONAL CENTERS. IS
THAT WHAT ARE THOSE INITIATIVES
THAT WE CAN START DEVELOPING
THE SELF ADVOCATES IN THE- THE-
DIFFERENT COMMUNITY LEADERS
THAT WILL PARTICIPATE SO WE
CAN'T HAVE A BROADER
pTHAN IT WAS. BUT IT'S NOT
REPRESENTATIVE OF OUR COMMUNITY
AND WE HAVE SIGNIFICANT- GAPS
IN THE REPRESENTATION OF THE
VOICES THAT ARE AT THE TABLE
AND THAT'S AN AREA THAT WERE.
I'M GOING TO BE PRIORITIZING.
THE REORGANIZATION IS AN AREA
THAT HELPS US SO ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO
DO THIS YEAR'S ATTEND- ALL OF
THE COMMUNITY MEETINGS THAT
REGIONAL CENTERS HAD. IN THEIR
COMMUNITY ON THE PURCHASE A
SERVICE THERE SEVENTY FIVE
DIFFERENT MEETINGS WE WERE ABLE
TO HAVE STAFF SO NOW IS WE'RE
KINDA LINKING SOME OF THAT
INFORMATION. WERE WERE THERE TO
LISTEN TO THAT DIALOGUE IN THAT
CONVERSATION. TALKED ABOUT
TRANSPARENCY OF INFORMATION
TAKING A LOOK AT THE DATA SO WE
CAN HAVE THAT AVAILABLE AND-
AND MAKE SURE THAT IT'S USER
FRIENDLY. I WILL JUST MAKE-
LAST NOTE IS THAT ON THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSALS
AGAIN AS ISAID AS WERE PUTTING
FORWARD- PROPOSALS ARE
INITIATIVES WE DO LOOK AT HOW
DOES THIS IMPACT. OUR COMMUNITY
AND REALLY ADDRESS THOSE.
REALLY SIGNIFICANT ISSUES AS TO
DISPARITY AND BARRIERS TO
ACCESS TO SERVICES. THE
ENHANCE- CASELOAD FOR THREE
FOUR AND FIVE I HAD MENTIONED
THAT IN THE EARLIER ISSUE. THE
INCENTIVE PROGRAM YOU KNOW
LOOKING AT WAYS THAT WE CAN USE
PERFORMANCE MEASURES THAT WILL
BE ABLE TO ADDRESS ISSUES OF-
THE INEQUITY OR THE BARRIERS TO
ACCESS TO SERVICES- AND THEN
ALSO MAKING SURE THAT WE HAVE
CROSS SYSTEM COLLABORATION. YOU
KNOW WORKING WITH OUR OTHER
SYSTEMS SO AS WE'RE TRYING TO
HELP OUR FAMILIES THAT ARE
STRUGGLING TO ACCESS. THAT
WE'RE DOING IN A WAY THAT WILL
BE ABLE TO. ADDRESS ISSUES
BROADLY. SO THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SHARE THOSE
THINGS. THANK YOU DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. FOR THAT AT THIS TIME
THANK YOU- FERNANDO GOMEZ FROM
DISABILITY VOICES UNITED. THANK
YOU AND GOOD EVENING TO AND I'M
SHAKING MY HEAD AS I HEAR
REPORT BECAUSE I THINK OUR
SECRET WEAPON IS IN THE PARENTS
LIKE THE TWO THAT YOU SEE THAT
THAT'S WHAT I THINK OUR
SOLUTION IS BUT THE MY NAME IS
FERNANDO GOMES I AM THE FATHER
OF US GOT ANTONIO WAS THIRTEEN
YEARS OLD. AND HAS A DIAGNOSIS
OF DOWN SYNDROME AND I'M ALSO
THE VICE PRESIDENT OF
DISABILITY FORCES UNITED. THEN
THANK YOU FOR YOUR CONTINUED
FOCUS ON THE SIGNIFICANT
SERVICES THE DISPARITIES THAT
LATINOS AFRICAN AMERICANS AND
ASIAN SPACE FOR THE PAST THREE
YEARS THE LEGISLATURE HAS
APPROVED THIRTY THREE MILLION
DOLLARS TO FUND REGIONAL
CENTERS AND COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS TO WORK TO READ
KATE THESE DISPARITIES. LAST
YEAR DISABILITY VOICES UNITED
ISSUED REPORTS SHOWING THAT
DESPITE THE TWENTY TWO MILLION
DOLLARS SPENT DISPARITIES FOR
LATINOS ACTUALLY HAD INCREASED
IN TWENTY OUT OF TWENTY ONE
REGIONAL CENTERS WELL NOW AFTER
THREE YEARS. IN THIRTY THREE
MILLION DOLLARS DISPARITIES FOR
LATINOS HAVE INCREASED IN
NINETEEN OF THE TWENTY ONE
REGIONAL CENTERS THAT HAVE
ACTUALLY STATE THE SAME INTO A
THE TO REGIONAL CENTERS. EVEN
THE LATINOS ARE THE LARGEST
GROUP SERVED BY THE SYSTEM.
THEY CONTINUE TO FACE THE
GREATEST LEVEL OF DISPARITIES.
AT ALMOST EVERY REGIONAL CENTER
LATINOS RECEIVE NO MORE THAN
HALF OF WHAT WHITES GET. AT
FIVE REGIONAL CENTERS LATINOS
ONLY RECEIVE A THIRD. OF WHAT
WHITES RECEIVE AND THINGS SEEM
TO BE WORSE AT REGIONAL CENTERS
WHERE THE LATINO POPULATION IS
THE LARGEST. WE APPRECIATE THAT
THE DIRECTOR BARGE BEEN HAS
MADE THIS ISSUE SUCH A PRIORITY
AND HAS ENGAGE GRASSROOTS
ORGANIZATIONS TO REACH DEEP
INTO THESE COMMUNITIES. TO
BRING TO THE TABLE A VOICE THAT
HAS BEEN SILENT. AND WE'RE
GRATEFUL THAT THE LEGISLATURE
CONTINUES TO FIND COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS TO WORK
WITH AND TRAIN FAMILIES BY
MEETING THEM WHERE THEY'RE APT.
AND HELPING THEM INTEGRATE INTO
A SYSTEM ON THE PEER TO PEER
BASIS. SO WHY HAVE WE NOT SEEN
THE BETTER RESULTS. OUR CONCERN
IS THAT THERE HAS BEEN NO
INDEPENDENT EVALUATIONS OF THE
FUNDED PROGRAMS TO SEE IF THEY
HAD ANY AFFECT. WE NEED TO STOP
ALLOCATING FUNDS FOR PROGRAMS
THAT REALLY DON'T WORK. AND
REPLICATE THOSE THAT ACTUALLY
DO. THE PRIORITY NOW NEEDS TO
BE ON THE ROAD CASA DISPARITIES
WE ARE SEEING THAT THE
ROADBLOCKS MOSTLY HAPPEN WHEN
THESE GROUPS GRASSROOTS
EFFORTS. ENGAGE WITH THE
REGIONAL CENTER SYSTEM. WHEN A
COMMUNITY GROUP IS A SYSTEM A
FAMILY TO GET THE PROPER
SERVICE AS THEY OFTEN
EXPERIENCE RESISTANCE. AT THE
POINT OF ENGAGEMENT WITH THE
REGIONAL CENTER. MANY OF MY
COMMUNITY CONTINUE REPORT
FEELING INTIMIDATED BY THE
SYSTEM AND ARE SOMETIMES AFRAID
TO SPEAK UP IN FEAR OF
RETALIATION AGAINST THEIR
CHILD. YOU MAY HEAR SOME OF
THOSE EXAMPLES AND ACTUALLY
HAVE DURING THE PUBLIC COMMENTS
TODAY. WE NEED TO SEE THE
CULTURAL CHANGE AT THE REGIONAL
CENTER LEVEL. WE NEED TO STOP
DENYING THAT THE REAL BY OF
SUCCESS. WE NEED TO STOP
ATTRIBUTING DISPARITIES TO THE
ETHNIC CULTURE A FAMILIES THE
LACK OF EDUCATION OR THE
PROFICIENCY IN ENGLISH. WE NEED
TO MOVE FROM IT REGIONAL
CENTERS CULTURE OF NO. AND
PASSING THE BUCK TO A CULTURE
OF EMPATHY ACCEPTANCE AND
SUPPORT. THE REGIONAL CENTERS
NEED TO MEET FAMILIES RIGHT
WHERE THEY'RE ACT. THE WAY TO
CHANGE A CULTURE OF NO IS BY
ENGAGING THE COMMUNITIES
IMPACTED BY DISPARITIES TO
ACTUALLY BE PART OF THE
SOLUTION. WE WILL GAS AT THE
PROJECTS THAT ARE PRODUCING THE
BEST RESULTS ARE THOSE LED BY
INDIVIDUALS AND COMMUNITIES OF
DISPARITY. SO WE ALSO REQUEST
THE DDS CREATE A DISPARITY
OMBUDSMAN THAT FAMILIES CAN
CALL DIRECTLY WITH THEIR
CONCERNS AND CAN INTERVIEW
INTERVENE WITH THE REGIONAL
CENTER ON THEIR BEHALF. WE
REQUESTED AN OVERSIGHT BODY
WITH SOME AUTHORITY BE MADE UP
OF FAMILY MEMBERS. INDIVIDUALS
FACING DISPARITIES REGIONAL
CENTER STAFF AND ADVOCATES WHO
CAN FIND COMMON GROUND AND
CONTRIBUTE TO MEANINGFUL
DIALOGUE. TOWARDS LONG TERM
SOLUTIONS THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR YOUR TIME AND SUPPORT THANK
YOU SIR HELLO. CINEMATIC LA- WE
JUST HAD A COUPLE COMMENTS ON
AND THIS- ISSUE ONE- IS TO SAY
THAT GOING BACK TO OUR-
CONVERSATION MUCH EARLIER IN
THE DAY ABOUT THE PERFORMANCE
INCENTIVE PROGRAM THAT THIS.
THE LEGISLATURE DIDN'T CHOOSE
TO GO FOR THE PERFORMANCE
INCENTIVE PROGRAM THIS WOULD BE
ANOTHER SOURCE OF FUNDING THAT
COULD POTENTIALLY BE SHOULD
RESTRUCTURED TO TEST INCENTIVES
TO USE TO ACTUALLY REWARD
REGIONAL CENTERS FOR CLOSING
SOME OF THOSE DISPARITY GAPS-
SAID JUST AN IDEA- AND THEN-
OUR OTHER COMMENT WOULD REFLECT
SOMETHING THAT MISTER GOMEZ
SAID WHICH IS JUST THE NEED FOR
MORE INFORMATION ABOUT WHICH
PER PROJECTS ARE ACTUALLY
SUCCESSFUL. AND THROUGH AN
INDEPENDENT- EVALUATION AS WELL
AS A BETTER UNDERSTANDING OF
THE ROOT CAUSES OF DISPARITY.
PUBLIC COMMENT ON ISSUE TWELVE.
ALISON RANSOM I AM A MEMBER OF
BOARD MEMBER DAVE YOU BUT I
WILL SPEAK WITH THE DIRECTOR OF
THE SAID LIVE ACTUALLY BECAUSE
I ALLUDED TO THIS EARLIER I
THINK THAT INDEPENDENT
EVALUATION REALLY GOES HAND IN
HAND WITH A PERFORMANCE
INCENTIVE PLANS BECAUSE THEY'RE
BOTH ABOUT TAKING AN OUTCOMES
BASED IN DATA DRIVEN APPROACH
TO. DEVELOPING AN EVIDENCE BASE
ABOUT WHAT WORKS AND DOESN'T
WORK AND THEN USING THAT AS A
SPRINGBOARD FROM WHICH TO BUILD
ON SUCCESS AND ALTHOUGH YOU
KNOW IT WE I THINK WE ALL AGREE
THAT THE DISPARITIES OF EVERY
KIND IN THE SYSTEM ARE A
SIGNIFICANT PROBLEM AND
CONTINUE TO BE A SIGNIFICANT
PROBLEM THERE EVEN A MORE
SIGNIFICANT PROBLEM NOW THAN
THEY WERE WHEN WE STARTED TO
ADDRESS THEM THREE FOUR YEARS
AGO- BUT I THINK THIS IS REALLY
A CASE IN POINT FOR WHY WE NEED
TO SHIFT THE MENTALITY TO
REALLY AGAIN COLLECTING
SYSTEMATICALLY DATA THAT CAN BE
TRACKED TO DATA THAT IS
RELIABLE. DATA THIS TRANSPARENT
DATE IS IT IS ACCOUNTABLE TO
THE COMMUNITY. AND THINKING
ABOUT EVERYTHING THAT WE DO IN
THE SYSTEM. ABOUT MEASURING IT
IN SUCH A WAY THEY CAN FIGURE
OUT IF IT'S EFFECTIVE AND SO I
THE INDEPENDENT EVALUATION
PIECE WAS NOT BAKED INTO THE
PERFORMANCE AND SENATE BUT
SORRY WAS CUT BAKED INTO THE
DISPARITIES GRANTS AT THE
OUTSET- MY OWN PERSONAL VIEW IS
THERE'S DIFFERENT WAYS TO
ACCOMPLISH THAT. AND I'VE
MENTIONED THIS BEFORE I DON'T
THINK IT NECESSARILY NEEDS TO
BE A LEGISLATIVE APPROPRIATION-
I THINK THERE AGAIN THAT WE
HAVE A WEALTH OF YOU KNOW OF.
PEOPLE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WAS VERY INTERESTED
IN THIS ISSUE IT'S VERY IT'S
VERY LATE OF ALL. AND I THINK
PEOPLE IN THE UNIVERSITIES
ACROSS THE STATE WILL BE
INTERESTED IN STUDYING THIS
ISSUE IT'S A GREAT OPPORTUNITY.
AND IT'S REALLY SAD THING TO ME
THAT AFTER THE APPROPRIATIONS I
THINK WE'RE ACTUALLY TO FORTY
FOUR MILLION- THAT WE DON'T
ACTUALLY KNOW ANYTHING MORE
THAN WE DID FOUR YEARS AGO- I
THINK THAT ELLIE- SUGGESTION
ABOUT THE IDEA OF KIND OF
SEEING THIS AS AN OPPORTUNITY
TO CONVERT IT INTO A
PERFORMANCE INCENTIVE PLAN IN
WHICH YOU INCENTIVIZE REGIONAL
CENTERS. I UNDERSTAND THE
IMPULSE BUT I RESPECTFULLY
DON'T AGREE AND THAT'S BECAUSE
MY COLLEAGUE FOR UNDERGO MRS
TESTIMONY. ABOUT THE IMPORTANCE
OF HAVING INDIVIDUALS THAT ARE
PIONEERING THESE PROGRAMS COME
FROM COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS. THAT ARE FROM
THE SAME COMMUNITIES THAT ARE
BEING MOST AFFECTED. THAT ARE
BEING UNDERSERVED IS CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT- BUT I THINK THAT
NEEDS TO BE COUPLED AS HE
EXPRESSED SO WELL IN HIS
TESTIMONY. WITH A AGAIN WITH
INDEPENDENT EVALUATION BECAUSE
WE CAN'T ASSUME THAT EVERY
PROGRAM YOU KNOW THAT IS THAT
IS A LEAD. YOU KNOW I'M SURE
WITH THE BEST OF INTENTIONS BY
INDIVIDUALS FROM COMMITTEES
THAT ARE UNDERSERVED IS
NECESSARILY SUCCESSFUL ONE OR
SUCCESSFUL AS IT COULD BE. SO I
THINK REALLY THAT THIS JUST
REALLY MAKES THE CASE FOR
INDEPENDENT EVALUATION BECAUSE
SHORTLY AFTER THIS EXPENDITURE
FORTY FOUR MILLION DOLLARS WE
SHOULD HAVE A RICH EVIDENCE
SPACE. AND I ALSO WANT TO PICK
UP VERY BRIEFLY ON. ON A
DIRECTOR PARCHMENTS POINT IT
YOU WOULDN'T NECESSARILY EXPECT
TO SEE AN EFFECT ON THE OVERALL
YOU KNOW POS DISPARITIES. BUT
THAT'S THE ONLY METRIC WE HAVE
WITHOUT DEFINING AT THE OUTSET
WHAT THE SPECIFIC GOAL OF A
PILOT IS. SOME PILOTS MAY HAVE
A MUCH MORE DISCRETE GOAL OF
SERVING PARTICULAR COMMUNITIES
WE WOULD NECESSARILY EXPECT
THEM TO INCLUDE TWO AT IF
AFFECT THE AGGREGATE NUMBERS.
RIGHT THAT MIGHT NOT BE THE
RIGHT METRIC I THINK YOU HAVE
TO DEVELOP THE METRIC. IN
CONSIDERATION OF WHAT THE
PARTICULAR PILOT IS TRYING TO
ACHIEVE AGAIN ANOTHER FACET THE
ONE CAN ACCOMPLISH WITH
INDEPENDENT EVALUATION. THAT WE
DON'T HAVE A BILL TO CAPACITY
TO ACCOMPLISH SO FAR THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. DOOR CONTRAIRE US
AND I'D FIRST OF ALL LIKE TO
SUPPORT EVERYTHING THAT MR
GOMEZ SAID. WHEN HE SPOKE ONE
OF THE THINGS THAT I'D LIKE TO
SAY THAT I AM PART OF A
GRASSROOTS ORGANIZATION CALL
THE ICC. INTEGRATED COMMUNITY
COLLABORATIVE AND OUR
ASSIGNMENT THANKS TO. THE
SUPPORT OF A DIRECTOR
PARCHMENT. WAS TO LOOK FOR
DISPARITIES IN OUR PARTICULAR.
LATINO COMMUNITY. WHAT WE HAVE
DONE IS WE HAVE EDUCATED
FAMILIES ABOUT HOW TO NAVIGATE
THE SYSTEM AND IT WAS QUITE
ASTOUNDING TO FIND. THAT MANY
OF OUR FAMILIES. HAD NO IDEA.
OF WHAT TO DO. EXCEPT THAT
THERE WAS A SERVICE COORDINATOR
COMING. EVERY YEAR TO MEET WITH
THEM. WE ATTENDED I A P.
MEETINGS WE'VE GONE TO FAIR
HEARINGS WITH FAMILIES AS WELL
AS- HELP THEM THROUGH. THE
SYSTEM TO DEVELOP A PLAN OF
ACTION OF HOW WE WOULD ADDRESS
SOME OF THEIR NEEDS. AT FIRST
WHEN WE ENTERED OUR PARTICULAR
OUR PARTICULAR REGIONAL CENTER
WE WERE KIND OF SEEN AS THE
ENEMY. ARE AT AYE PP MEETINGS
SO- WE WERE SAID THAT TO BE
AGGRESSIVE. ARE WE WERE SAID IT
WAS SAID THAT OUR FAMILIES HAD
CHANGED THAT THEY USE THAT THE
BUT FAMILIES SO THAT WE TOOK
INTO THESE MEETINGS HAD CHANGED
THAT THEY WERE NICE AT ONE
POINT AND NOW THEY WERE. VERY
NICE. SO THE PROCESS IN THE
SERVICES IN THE QUESTIONS THAT
ARE PARTICULAR COMMUNITY HAS.
ABOUT THE OUR REGIONAL CENTER
IT IT'S A COMPLEX SYSTEM FOR
ANYONE AND IF YOU CAN IMAGINE A
MOM AT HOME WITH TO US TO STICK
CHILDREN WITHOUT EVEN RESPITE
THEN YOU CAN FIGURE OUT FOR
YOURSELF WHAT IS GOING ON IN
SOME OF THESE- FAMILIES. WE ARE
TAKING UP TO FIVE FAMILIES TO
FAIR HEARINGS ARE ACTUALLY NOT.
BECAUSE THEY WERE DENIED
SERVICES WE ACTUALLY ENCOURAGE
THEM TO GO THROUGH THE APPEAL
PROCESS MANY OF THEM DID NOT
EVEN KNOW WHAT THE APPEAL
PROCESS WAS. OF AND SOMEONE WE
TOOK THEM THROUGH THE ACTUAL
PREPARATION OF GETTING THE
EXHIBITS IN THE EVIDENCE TO
GATHER GOING THROUGH INFORMAL
FIRST MEDIATION NOT REACHING.
ANY KIND OF A SOLUTION THEN
GOING TO FAIR HEARING A FEW OF
THEM SAID ALL KNOW IF THERE'S
GOING TO BE A LAWYER AT THE
OTHER SIDE OF THE TABLE AND A
COMPLIANCE MANAGER IN A CASE
MANAGER AND MY SERVICE
COORDINATOR SHE'S NOT GOING TO
LIKE ME ANYMORE. AND I DON'T
KNOW SOME OF THEM DID DID
REFUSE TO GO TO APPEAL. SO
WE'RE MAKING GRADUAL CHANGES AT
THE REGIONAL CENTER LEVEL I
THINK I THINK THAT- AT THIS
POINT- THE REGIONAL CENTER HAS
REALIZED THAT WE'RE NOT GOING
AWAY. AND THEY KNOW US ON A
FIRST NAME BASIS AND WE'RE
BRINGING IN FAMILIES THAT HAD
NEVER. ACTUALLY ASKED FOR
ANYTHING AND NOW THEY'RE BEING
EMPOWERED BY THE KNOWLEDGE THAT.
THE MONEY IS FOR THEIR CHILD
AND FOR THE SERVICES OF THE
CHILD AND THE CHILD IN THE
FAMILY THERE THE OWNERS OF THAT
REGIONAL CENTER. THERE THAT'S
REGIONAL CENTER EXISTS BECAUSE
OF THE FAMILIES SO WHAT WE SEE
A WHOLE COMMUNITY COMING
TOGETHER I THINK WE HIT A
HUNDRED AND FIFTEEN FAMILIES
THAT WE HAVE TOUCHED IN THE
LAST. TENDED TO TWELVE MONTHS.
OUGHT TO THIS GRANT THAT WE
RECEIVED OUR I THINK THAT ARE
PRESENTLY WE ARE NOW. SEEING
MAYBE IS A RESOURCE THAT THE
REGIONAL CENTER OR LET'S JUST
SAY THIS THAT AT BOARD MEETINGS.
AT THE REGIONAL BOARD MEETINGS
WE ARE THE ONLY ONES IN THERE
AND WE HAVE FAMILIES THAT WE
TAKE TO THESE BOARD MEETINGS.
AND I WERE THERE AND WE'RE
SPEAKING DURING PUBLIC COMMENT
AND WE'RE GETTING SOME OF OUR
FAMILIES AND POWERED ENOUGH TO
SPEAK UP ALSO FOR WHATEVER.
THEIR NEEDS MAY BE SO WE ARE
MAKING INCREMENTAL CHANGES ARE
WE GO TO ALL OF THE COMMITTEE
MEETINGS WE INFORM OURSELVES SO
THAT WE CAN AND FORMER LATINO
COULD POP A COMMUNITY A
CORRECTLY AND WE'RE NOT OUT
THERE GIVING MISINFORMATION.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MA'AM. IT
HAS HAS ONE THE LARGEST WHEN I
WAS MATH IT IS A LIST THAT
EITHER ONCE AGAIN THE SIMPLEST.
YOUR PS OKAY ALLOWED THIS BODY
THAT WHETHER THIS UP BUT HE
SAID. I THINK DISPARITIES WOULD
DISAPPEAR. GAIL CENTER
REGULARLY THEY LAWCENTER BCS IF
THE REGIONAL CENTER WOULD GIVE
SERVICES YOU'RE NOT AVAIL
DRESSEL SEE ON I DON'T SEE ANY
OTHER SOLUTION. BUT A STOCK I
SEE ON FOR THIS OCCASION YES
THE REPRESENTANTES ON MEDIA
SCHEDULE LAMENTABLE ALMOST AS
BY NOON I AM REPRESENTING ALL
FAMILIES THAT SPEAK SPANISH
ONLY. A MAN CONTRA LOCAL MORE
JUST FOR ME YES I HAVE FOUND
MANY FAMILIES GET THE IN AND
MANY FAMILIES THAT HAVE BEEN IS
SETTLED. THEY HAVE THE BUDGET.
BUDGET ORDER ORDER FAMILIAR GET
THEM INTO THE MEAT THEY MAY
FROM MEDIA OR CHEN BY THREE OF
THE LETTUCE FROM HER EYELINER
MALLY SHE HAS A POS BUDGET OF
EIGHTY THREE DOLLARS. LOCAL
MONEY THAT ARE MEANT THAT THE
MORE JIM. THE COMMUNITY HAS
GROWN THERE IS A LOOK AT IT
THIS YEAR CAN ARNOLD AND
SERVICIOS BUT THAT DOES NOT
MEAN THAT WE SHOULD NOT RECEIVE
OKAY MOST A COUPLE OR THAT WE
GET FEW SERVICES. WHAT IS FOR
YOUR STORY. NUMBER LOCAL BOTHER
POR QUE I AM VERY WORRIED EN EL
PASO ALTHOUGH IN THE PAST YOUR
NOTICE TO BE SAID RESEAL I
DIDN'T RECEIVE SERVICES. YOUR
ALSO BONTA THIS ALL THESE BODY
THAT AND ON PART OF THE
DISPARITY. ELECTRIC OUT OF YOUR
STORY AKKI. THE REASON I'M
HERE. IS PUT GAS TO NINE YOUR
NORMAL FOR THIS STAR BECAUSE A
YEAR AGO I WASN'T ABLE TO COME
HERE WHAT IS THAT CALLED ME
HOPE. BECAUSE I WAS WITH MY SON
THIS IS THE ACTUAL NINE ULFA
JOHN. OBERNOLTE I HAVE. MET
LOCAL MONEY THAT I THINK THEY
COULD EITHER. THE INTEGRATED
THE INTEGRATED. COMMUNITY
COLLABORATIVE. IT IS THAT'S MY
MASS THOSE MOMS WHO ARE ALL MEN
IN THREE NOW THE- HAVE A
TRAINED HER AS A MOM I COMO. OF
LATIN ACCORDING TO THE ORDER TO
HOW COMMERCENTRE L'OREAL'S ON
HOW TO SPEAK TO THE SERVICE
COORDINATOR HOW HE GOT MORE
KNOWLEDGE THINKING THE IMPACT
ON THEM AND HOW TO PROGRESS. ON
EVERYTHING. UP GET A GUEST
ALLOW THE NCO. I HAVE GONE TO
FAIR HEARING. FOR PRESS. WITH
THREE SERVICES. ASKING FOR
THREE SERVICES IS A THREAT
SERVICIOS LOVE WHETHER OR NOT
FORGET MELODIOUS FAMILY FEUD ON
MAY THE ASEAN BECAUSE OUR MY
FAIR HERE IN TURNED INTO THE
MEDIATION SO I CAN NOT SPEAK
UNCLE SERVICES. HE LOVE IT
BOTHERS GUESS ALL I MEANT THAT
ONE ON LEGAL. AND THE TRUTH
THOSE I ONLY HAVE ONE SERVICE
OF THE THREE RIGHT NOW. IT IS A
BOY THE WAR STARTED THEY GET
OUT AYE AYE AGAIN THIS START
WITH UNDER ME HOPE A LOOK AT
YOUR STORE YAKKING AND NOW I AM
VERY HAPPY BECAUSE SOMEONE IS
CARING FOR MY SON WHILE I AM
HERE. NEVER NEED OTHERS HERE
BECAUSE MY ALLOWS THOSE
INTEREST YOUR LAND I HAVE NOT
COME TO SPEAK ILL OF THE-
REGIONAL CENTER BUT ALAS I
MEDIA THIS IS THE DOMINOES AND
SENT OVER HERE NOW BECAUSE OUR
FAMILIES NEED THE REGIONAL
CENTER. BROUGHT THEM INTO
CENTER REGULAR LAND BUT THE
REGIONAL CENTER THIS IS THE
BALLOT FOR MEDIA NEEDS ARE
FAMILIES AS WELL. YOUR GET
ORGANIZED THE SYLLABLE YOU'LL
WANT TO APPRECIATE THE SUPPORT.
YES ALTHOUGH RECIBIENDO ME
KAMANI THAT THAT I HAVE
RECEIVED IN THE COMMUNITY I
THOUGHT THAT IT DOES HELP US A
LOT THIS BODY THAT IS IN ORDER
TO ADDRESS DISPARITIES. THIS
ALMOST ON A HONDA WE ARE
WORKING ON A LACK OF MONEY THAT
I THINK THEY COULD EITHER WITH
THE- ICC. BUT ALMOST IMPRINT
OTHER MANY DIFFICULT THAT IS WE
HAVE. A CALM BEFORE SOME
HARDSHIPS. YOGA PICKLE TEAMS NO
GET OTHER THEORY ARMY. CENTER
REGULAR I WANT TO SAY TO MY
REGIONAL CENTER GET BORED
HOBBLED STABILITY THAT. LET US
BE A PRIORITY LIKE ONLY THAT
GUEST ALMOST INDUCED BY THE
THAT THE COMMUNITY THAT IS A
DISPARITY FOUR FIVE FOUR
PLEASE. TELL ME GET OUT OF THIS
SAID AND I WANT TO APPRECIATE
OR GIVE MY APPRECIATION TO US
IN YOUR FERNANDO TO MISTER
GOMEZ YEAH LESSEN YOUR ANANSI
GUEST ON NICKI PRESENT THIS.
NANCY PARCHMENT BOTTLED UP FOR
TONY THURMOND US THE
OPPORTUNITY OUR LAST FROM MEDIA
TO HAVE GIVEN THE OPPORTUNITY
TO THE FAMILY FIND
INTERNATIONALS TO TRAIN US.
EAGLE FIAT AND ALSO THROUGH TO
TRUST US TRUST IN US THE
PINEAPPLE GALA COMMENTATOR. AND
TO. A TO SUB. THE COMMUNITY THE-
COMMUNITY HE CAN NO SEE I LIKE
AROUND THE- AND TO KEEP HELPING.
I ONLY THE NET OKAY CAN THIS IS
ACCESS TO THIRTY WILL EITHER
NEEDS TO BE STRIP THE LA ONLY.
THAT NEEDS TO BE DISTRIBUTED IN
TO THE COMMUNITY. GET A FIFTH
THANK MUST ADDRESS FAMILY
ASSIST ALMOST IN PART THAT THIS
THING COULD HONEST ALTHOUGH
HE'S ON IN PART DANTE PADA.
TOLD US BUT AT THE NET ON BOSS
GET ALL THE SAME CLASS AS THOSE
THAT GET A TELEMEDICINE. THE
DEATH. WELL THAT'S A HARD ACT
TO FOLLOW GOOD EVENING AMY
WESTLING FROM THE ASSOCIATION
OF REGIONAL CENTER AGENCIES
FIRST AND FOREMOST WANT TO SAY
THANK YOU TO THE FAMILIES THAT
WERE HERE TONIGHT THANK YOU FOR
REMINDING US THAT THIS ISSUE IS
CRITICAL AND FOR CONTINUING TO
BRING IT BEFORE AS- DID WANT TO
PIGGY BACK ON A COUPLE OF
THINGS THAT THE SPEAKERS RIGHT
BEFORE ME SAID- THAT FIRST AND
FOREMOST THIS IS A COMPLICATED
SYSTEM THIS. SYSTEM IS
COMPLICATED FOR ANYONE TO
NAVIGATE AND THE ONLY WAY THAT
REGIONAL CENTERS CAN. ADDRESS
THE ISSUES THAT HAVE BEEN
RAISED IS BY PARTNERING WITH
THEIR COMMUNITIES REGIONAL
CENTERS ARE OF AN FOR THEIR
COMMUNITIES. AND THE PREVIOUS
SPEAKER WAS ABSOLUTELY RIGHT
REGIONAL CENTERS EXIST BECAUSE
OF THE PEOPLE THEY SERVE AND
THE FAMILIES AND THEIR FAMILY
MEMBERS. I DID WANT TO- ALSO
EXTEND MY GRATITUDE TO THE
DEPARTMENT FOR PROVIDING- AND
REALLY HIGHLIGHTING THE NEED TO
PROVIDE INFORMATION IN A WAY
THAT'S DIGESTIBLE FOR PEOPLE-
THIS IS A SPACE WHERE WE HAVE A
LOT OF DATA. WE HAVE PAGES AND
PAGES PROBABLY ABOUT SEVENTY
PAGES PER REGIONAL CENTER EVERY
YEAR. AND IT'S GETTING DOWN TO
WHAT IS THE DATA TELLING US AND
IN A RECENT- DEVELOPMENTAL
SERVICES. WORK GROUP ON EQUITY
THE DEPARTMENT PRESENTED SOME
REALLY CRITICAL DATA THEY SAID
THAT- THE SLIDES A PRESENTED
SHOWED THAT- MISTER GOMEZ'S
RIGHT THAT IF YOU JUST LOOK AT
THAT TOP LEVEL FOR THE AVERAGE
PERSON- FOR THE WHITE VERSES
THE- ALL OTHERS. THERE IS ABOUT
A 50% DIFFERENCE BUT WHEN YOU
START TO DRILL DOWN THE STORY
GETS A LITTLE MORE NUANCED AND
A LITTLE MORE COMPLEX. WHEN YOU
LOOK AT INDIVIDUALS WHO WERE
LIVING AT HOME WHO WERE AT
LEAST THREE YEARS OLD. AND IT
YOU'RE REALLY CONTROLLING FOR
WHERE THAT PERSON LIVES
REGARDLESS OF WHY THEY'RE
LIVING AT HOME YOU GET FROM A
50% DIFFERENCE TO YOU NARROW IT
DOWN TO ABOUT A 22% DIFFERENCE
STILL WORK TO BE DONE STILL
CRITICAL TO FOCUS ON. BUT IT
PAINTS A LITTLE BIT OF A
DIFFERENT PICTURE AND IT HELPS
US FOCUS OUR ENERGY IS A LITTLE
MORE. AND THEN WHEN YOU LOK AT
JUST CHILDREN THREE TO TWENTY
ONE LIVING AT HOME SO YOU CARVE
OUT THE ADULT POPULATION SO NOW
YOU'RE CONTROLLING FOR AGE AS
WELL AS PLACE OF RESIDENCE. YOU
GET DOWN 284% IS THE AMOUNT
THAT SPENT ON PER CAPITA FOR
NON WHITES COMPARED TO WHITES.
ABSOLUTELY CRITICAL THAT WE
CONTINUE TO WORK ON THIS. BUT
IT'S ALSO CRITICAL THAT WE LOOK
AT THIS DATA IN ADDITIONAL
DETAIL AND THAT WE THINK ABOUT
SERVICES THAT. AND PLACES OF
STRENGTH IN OUR SYSTEM FOR
INSTANCE AN EARLY START PROGRAM
THERE ARE POPULATIONS THAT ARE
ACTUALLY RECEIVING MORE
SERVICES PER CAPITA. PAID BY
THE REGIONAL CENTER THAN WHITES
SO WHAT'S WORKING THERE WHAT IS
EFFECTIVE THEIR INNER RESPITE
SERVICES FOR- CHILDREN LIVING
AT HOME. THE AVERAGE HISPANIC
CHILD IS RECEIVING MORE THAN
THE AVERAGE WHITE TRIALS SO
AGAIN A PLACE OF STRENGTH IN
THE SYSTEM. IN SHORT IT'S JUST
REALLY COMPLICATED AND THE
REGIONAL CENTERS APPRECIATE THE
EFFORTS OF EVERYONE AND THE
ABILITY TO REALLY FOCUS SOME
COMMITTED ENERGY TO ADDRESSING
THE ISSUES TO MAKING SURE THAT
SERVICES ARE AVAILABLE IN AN
EQUITABLE WAY TO PEOPLE. AND TO
FINDING WAYS TO DRILL INTO THE
DATA AND ALSO TO RECOGNIZE AS
WE'VE TALKED ABOUT SO MUCH THIS
EVENING ALREADY. THOSE THINGS
THAT ARE NOT DIRECTLY TIED TO
PURCHASE OF SERVICE BECAUSE
REGIONAL CENTERS DO SO MUCH
MORE SO WE HAVE DATA AT OUR
DISPOSAL THAT WE NEED TO USE IN
NEW AND DIFFERENT WAYS. LOOKING
AT SATISFACTION WITH THE
SERVICE SYSTEM LOOKING AT-
SERVICE COORDINATION THE
QUALITY OF THE RELATIONSHIPS
AND- INVESTING TIME AND ENERGY
INTO EVALUATING THAT DATA
ACROSS THE SAME RACIAL AND
ETHNIC LINES BECAUSE ULTIMATELY
THIS NEEDS TO BE A SYSTEM THAT
EVOLVES AND THAT WORKS WELL FOR
EVERYONE BUT IT SERVES THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MA'AM. SEEING NO
FURTHER PUBLIC COMMENT ON ISSUE
TWELVE I WILL BRING IT UP TO
THE SUBCOMMITTEE- IF I COULD I
WANTED A QUOTE. DISABILITY
VOICES UNITED ON PAGE FORTY
NINE. YOU SAID THAT THERE'S
BEEN NO WAS SAYS OF THE GRANTS
OF TARGETED REGIONAL CENTERS
WITH THE GREATEST LEVEL OF
DISPARITIES AND THAT THE
DEPARTMENT HAS NOT TIED THE
RECEIPTS OF FUNDS. TO A
DEMONSTRATION OF PROGRAM
EFFECTIVENESS. I THOUGHT THAT
WAS A VERY POWERFUL STATEMENT
AND SOMETHING THAT- I THINK I
WANTED TO ASK THE DEPARTMENT A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT IF WERE. WHO
WHO WHICH PACIFIC TARGETS FOR
WHAT METRIC ARE WE TRYING TO
FIX. IN REDUCING DISPARITIES.
WHEN WE HAVE SO THE MEASURES
THAT I WAS REFERRING TO SO WE
THAT'S THE METRICS THAT WE'VE
BEEN- I HAD IDENTIFIED SO WHEN
WE FIRST STARTED THE
MEASUREMENTS- AGAIN BACK AND
FIFTEEN SIXTEEN AND THEN THE
FIRST YEAR THAT WE HAD THE
DISPARITY FUNDS- WAS IN TWENTY
SIXTEEN AND SO USING THAT AND
THEN WE JUST CLOSED OUT OUR OUR
FISCAL YEAR OF EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN WITH. SO WE COULD CAN
A POPULATE THAT AND AS I SAID I
KIND OF GAVE YOU EVERYBODY A
SNEAK PEEK OF BECAUSE WE'RE
STILL WORKING THROUGH SOME OF
THE DATA AND THAT THAT'S WHAT
WE'RE DOING AS FAR AS THE
METRICS IT'S GOING TO BE REALLY
IMPORTANT THAT WE- ALSO TAKE A
LOOK AT THE MEASURES THAT WE
HAD IDENTIFIED BACK IN TWO
THOUSAND FIFTEEN SIXTEEN- THE
DISPARITY DATA WORK GROUP AS
WELL AS THE SERVICE- EQUITY
WORKGROUP BUT THE DS TASK
FORCE. IN IN TAKING A LOOK AT
WHAT ARE THE METRICS GOING
FORWARD YOU KNOW THE ONES THAT
WE ARE USING IS THAT WHAT WE
SHOULD BE USING OR SHOULD WE
START IDENTIFYING OTHER WAYS TO
BE ABLE TO- PRIORITIZE THOSE
THOSE MEASURES ON THIS IS THE
TIME THAT THAT WE NEED TO DO
THAT- THERE WAS AN INITIATIVE
THAT HAD HAPPENED THAT WE- HAD
LIFTED THE CAP I CAN'T REMEMBER
WHAT WHAT YEAR IT WAS IT WAS
LAST BUDGET YEAR THE ARTS
COUPLE BUDGET YEARS. AGO AND
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT WE DID
IS THAT WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE WERE MEASURING BECAUSE-ONE AT THAT WAS ONE OF THE
STRATEGIES TO ADDRESS THE
INEQUITY OF SPENDING TO HAVE
THAT IS A RESOURCE AND THE AS-
MISS WESLEY HAD HAD NOTED IS
THAT WE DON'T HAVE WHEN WE TAKE
A LOOK AT JUST ON PER CAPITA
THE COST OF BREAST BUT- IS.
BETWEEN WHITES AND NON WHITES-
WE DO SEE THAT AS A PER CAPITA
EQUAL COST- SO WHEN WE LIFTED
THE CAP WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT IT WASN'T GOING TO ALL THE
SAID NOW CREATE A AN INEQUITY A
SPENDING- I SAY AND PEOPLE I'VE
HEARD. ME SAID AND IN DIFFERENT
MEETINGS THAT WE'VE HAD YEAH WE
HAVE THAT DATA BUT WE STILL
HAVE TO TAKE A LOOK AT THE
QUALITATIVE PIECE OF IT AS
WELL. SO THAT IS THAT'S THE
QUANTITATIVE WE KNOW THAT'S THE
DOLLAR TO DOLLAR. BUT THEN-
WHAT IS IT THAT THE FAMILIES
ARE SAYING WAS THE EXPERIENCE
OF THE RESPITE SERVICES THAT
THEY'RE RECEIVING. ARE WE
REALLY DELIVERING IT NO WAY
THAT IS LINGUISTICALLY
APPROPRIATE IS SAID YEAH THOSE
ARE THE THINGS THAT WE REALLY
WANT TO DO. SO IT'S A LITTLE
BIT LONGER WINDED- ANSWER THAN-
MAYBE YOU'RE ASKING BUT I EIGHT
THOSE ARE THE THINGS RIGHT NOW
WE HAVE THE INFORMATION TODAY
THAT. WE'RE CLOSING OUT THOSE
MEASURES AND NOW BEING ABLE TO
TAKE A LOOK AT THOSE NEXT STEPS
AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING-
WITH THE WORK GROUPS- TO- HELP
US IDENTIFY THOSE. YEAH I WOULD
ECHO WE'VE HEARD TO ENGAGE
COMMUNITIES OF DISPARITY ON
THIS ISSUE AND- I THOUGHT WE
ALSO HEARD. PRETTY CLEARLY THAT
WE NEED TO HELP PARENTS TO BE
ABLE TO SPEAK AND FOLLOW UP
WITH REGIONAL CENTERS TO BE
ABLE TO. ACCESS SERVICES AND AS
A MECHANISM FOR THAT- I WOULD
BE REMISS NOT TO MENTION THAT
ON PAGE FORTY NINE YOU GAVE US
A COMPLETED PROJECTS- FOR
DISPARITY FUNDS PROGRAM. AND I
STRUGGLED TO SEE ANY IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY. AND JUST
THOUGHT I'D MENTIONED THAT
THERE WERE NINETEEN OF TWENTY
ONE REGIONAL CENTERS THAT. HAD
ENGAGED IN IT AND I'M NT SURE
WHAT ARE DISPARITIES ARE BUT-
SO WHAT I I'D LIKE TO SHARE
WITH YOU ON ON. THIS IS THIS IS
ACTUALLY REFLECTIVE OF. OF
COMPLETED PROJECTS NOT CURRENT
PROJECTS THAT ARE ACTIVE. SO
WHAT WE COULD DO IS SHARE- THAT
WAY YOU COULD SEE THE- THE
PROJECTS THAT ARE ALSO ACTIVE-
SO AGAIN THIS IS JUST WERE
MEASURING THOSE THAT HAVE BEEN
COMPLETED AND- SO THERE'S A
LITTLE BIT MORE TO THE DETAIL
THAT WE WOULD BE HAPPY TO
SHARE. THANK YOU AND- MY FINAL
REQUEST IS FOR THE ADVOCATES
HELP ON THIS ITEM IF I MAY- CAN
I ASK FOR DV YOU TO WORK WITH
BOTH THE DEPARTMENT. THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IN THE
LA- TO HELP US DEVELOP TRAILER.
DRAFT TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE TO
STRENGTHEN THE CODE AROUND THE
DISABILITY FUNDING. PER YOUR
RECOMMENDATIONS- AND SUBMIT
THIS TO THE SUB COMMITTEE- FOR
CONSIDERATION BY THE END OF
MARCH. THAT OKAY ABSOLUTELY
THANK RETURNED. FROM WITH THAT
WE WILL HOLD ISSUE TWELVE OPEN
AND WANT TO THANK DIRECTOR
BARGE MEN FOR MAKING IT THROUGH
A- NEARLY SIX HOUR HEARING AND
SO. ON THANK YOU FOR YOUR
STAMINA ON IT. RIGHT NOW WE ARE
GOING TO MOVE ON TO NON
DISCUSSION ITEMS AND SEE IF
THERE'S ANY PUBLIC COMMENT ON
THOSE ITEMS. SEEING NONE THIS
WILL CONCLUDE TODAY'S SOMEONE
HEARING THANK YOU FOR ATTENDING.